ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
WELL. FOR AGES BRADFORD
CABALLERO CHIANG DALLY. DODD
THE RHIZOME GALGIANI GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROWTH HERTZBERG HILL
HUESO TADO JACKSON JONES LEYVA
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MITCHELL
MONNING. MORE LOCK MORALE.
NIELSEN PAN PORTANTINO ROTH
RUBIO SKINNER STERN I'M BERG
WHAT CASKEY WIENER WELL.
COLLEAGUES A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS CHEN OUR
GUESTS BE ON THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RICE WE WILL
BE LEADING PER THIS MORNING BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WE WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO OUR FLAG BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. THE FOLLOWING
IS AN INDIGENOUS PRAYER FROM
HAWAII. LET US GIVE THANKS FOR
THE WORLD AROUND US THANKS FOR
ALL THE CREATURES STONES IN
PLANTS. LET US LEARN THEIR
LESSONS AND SEEK THEIR TROOPS.
SO THAT THEIR PATH MIGHT BE
HOURS AND WE MIGHT LIVE A
BETTER LIFE IN HARMONY HARMONY
WITH ALL. MAY THE EARTH
CONTINUE TO LIVE ME THE HEAVENS
ABOVE CONTINUE TO LIVE. MAY THE
RAINS CONTINUE TO DAMPEN THE
LAND. MAY THE WHAT FORCE
CONTINUE TO GROW. IN THE
FLOWERS CHAU BLOOM. AND ALL THE
PEOPLE SHALL FLOURISH AGAIN A
MAN. SENATOR PORTANTINO. AND.
FOR ALL. GOOD MORNING
COLLEAGUES. BEFORE WE START
WITH PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
I'D LIKE TO CHOOSE SHARE WITH
YOU WHAT TODAY. IS GOING TO
LOOK LIKE IF I COULD HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION. COLLEAGUES WE HAVE
FIFTY BILLS. TO CONSIDER TODAY
WE HAVE EIGHTEEN TRAILER BILLS
IN ADDITION AND WE HAVE THE
BUDGET BILL AT EIGHT FORTY FIVE
THIS EVENING. WE WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO CONCLUDE PROCEEDINGS
TODAY SO THAT WE CAN ALL GO
HOME TOMORROW MORNING TO BE
BACK ON MONDAY- HOPEFULLY WE
WILL BE ABLE TO MOVE AS QUICKLY
AS WE CAN MAINTAINING OF COURSE
THE DECORUM OF OUR HOUSE. AND
HAVING THE NECESSARY DEBATES SO
THAT WE CAN CONSIDER EACH OF
THESE MEASURES FULLY ARE AND
RECOGNIZE HOWEVER THAT WE HAVE
THE SIXTY EIGHT PLUS THE
TRAILER BILL TO TRY TO DISPENSE
WITH TODAY. SO WITH THAT
COLLEAGUES UNDER PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR THERE ARE NONE. UNDER
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THIS ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED UNDER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
KEEP THE FOLLOWING BILLS
PURSUANT TO RID US SENATE RULE
TWENTY NINE POINT TEN
SUBDIVISIONS CITY ARE REFERRED
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE FILE
ITEM FOR AB. FOURTEEN SEVENTY
TWO. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS NOTICES
SEEING NONE WE WILL MOVE NOW TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
UNDER THE SECOND READING FILE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL. 1-558-406-1560
ONE AND ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
SEVENTY TWO SECOND READING WILL
BE DEEMED READ MOVING ON NOW
TO. A SHIP US SENATE THIRD
READING WE HAVE A NUMBER OF TO
TAKE UP WE WILL START WITH FILE
ITEMS TWENTY. NT FOUR. TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT AND TWENTY NINE SO
IF THE AUTHORS WOULD BE READY
PLEASE FOR THEIR BILLS WHEN
THEY COME UP WE WILL START WITH
FILE ITEM. TWENTY FOUR. SENATOR
DODD. COLLEAGUES IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION TO THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBER TO SENATOR
DODD BEN SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TEN NINETY NINE BY
SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
NON VEHICULAR AIR POLLUTION
SENATOR DODD THE FLORIDA SENATE
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'M GLAD TO
BE LEADING OFF TODAY AND- FIRST
OF A- SEVENTY BILLS SB TEN
NINETY NINE PROTECTS CRITICAL
FACILITIES ABILITIES. TO
OPERATE EMERGENCY BACKUP
GENERATORS DURING PUBLIC'S.
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF OR OTHER
LOSS OF POWER LIKE A WILDFIRE.
CRITICAL FACILITIES LIKE WATER-WASTE WATER AGENCIES AND
HOSPITALS NEED RELIABLE POWER
TO PROTECT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS WITH
PS PSE BEDS WITH. THESE
FACILITIES MUCH USE THEIR
EMERGENCY BACKUP GENERATORS TO
DELIVER SAFE WATER AND PROVIDE
LIFESAVING SERVICES HOWEVER
THERE ARE LIMITATIONS IN
CERTAIN THEIR DISTRICTS THAT
RESTRICT THE RUN TIME OF THESE
GENERATORS EVEN DURING
EMERGENCIES. SB TEN NINETY NINE
ADDS TO EXISTING PROCESS SAID
AIR DISTRICTS CALLED A
STIPULATED ORDER OF ABATEMENT
IT REQUIRES THE AIR DISTRICTS
TO DEVELOP SPECIAL STIPULATION
THAT ALLOWS AN OPERATOR
CRITICAL FACILITY TO RUN THEIR
EMERGENCY BACKUP GENERATORS
DURING A P. S. P. S. EVE THAT.
EVEN IF THEY EXCEED THE TIME
LIMITS. IT EXCEEDS OPERATOR FOR
WORK WITH THE DISTRICTS ON A
REPLACEMENT SCHEDULE FOR THEIR
OLDER GENERATORS WHICH
IMPORTANTLY MUST BE TECHNICALLY
AND ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE A
CONSIDER THE USEFUL LIFE OF THE
EXISTING EMERGENCY BACKUP
GENERATOR. THESE SO WAYS ARE
NEGOTIATED BETWEEN THE TWO
PARTIES BEFORE ANYBODY ELATION
RATHER THAN HAVING THE
OPERATORS OF CRITICAL
FACILITIES UP THAT. APPLY FOR A
VERY IT'S AFTER THE FACT. THE
VARIANCE PROCESS STILL REMAINS
AN OPTION YES- WEIGHTS ARE JUST
ONE VOLUNTARY TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX THE ALLOWS OPERATORS TO
OPERATE THE BACKUP GENERATORS
DURING A PSP US OR WHILE FAR
WITHOUT FEAR OF FINES OR
PENALTIES. SB TEN NINETY NINE
PROVIDE CERTAINTY FOR BOTH-
DISTRICTS AND OPERATORS OF
CRITICAL FACILITIES WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY MOVING TOWARD
CLEANER TECHNOLOGY AND
PROTECTING YOUR QUALITY. I
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACTIVELY TALKING TO THE
OPPOSITION IN ANY PARTY IS-
THAT HAVE COME FORWARD WITH
CONCERNS IT'S SEEKING WAYS WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT
APPROACH THAT WORKS FOR ONE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD IS THERE
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM. SENATOR ALLEN. FULL
PAGE. YES OF I KNOW THE EVEN IN
THE SAME MANNER WITHOUT SENATOR
ALLEN IF YOU WOULD WAIT JUST
SECOND COULD WE PLEASE HAVE HIS
MIKE. HE DOES NOT ADDRESS AND I
WAS LARGELY ASKING A QUESTION
ON BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUE IS
NOW HERE FROM THOUSAND OAKS AND
SO- I'M SURE HE- WOULD PREFER
TO ASK THE QUESTION. WELL HE'S
GETTING READY MADAM CHAIR JUST
ONE FINAL COMMENT I APOLOGIZE
CENTER GLAZER THE GOD PRINCIPLE
CALL AUTHOR ON THIS BILL IN ITS
HAVE TO TRY TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF BILLS. I HE HAD ONE
BILL THAT WAS IN THIS AREA FOR
A HOSPITALS I HAD A BILL FOR
CRITICAL FACILITIES LIKE WATER
DISTRICTS AND SO WE MERGE THOSE
TWO TOGETHER IN A TAPPED TO
HAVE FEWER BILLS ON THE FLOOR
SO. THANK YOU TO. GOOD SENATOR
FROM AROUND THE- THANK YOU FOR
THAT CLARIFICATION SENATOR AND
NOW WE WILL MOVE WE'LL START
WITH SENATOR STERN. UNDER
DEBATE AND DISCUSSION YES THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST WANT-TO THANK THE AUTHORS FOR THEIR
HARD WORK IN DIGGING IN ON.
THIS POWER SHUT OFF ISSUE AND
REALLY ADDRESSING AT- A GAP IN
OUR IN OUR WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
SYSTEM IF WE LOSE WATER DURING
THESE. THESE INCIDENTS- WE LOSE
EVERYTHING WE CAN'T FIGHT FIRES
AND- SOCIETY STARTS TO SLOWLY
BREAK DOWN SO I APPRECIATE THE
URGENCY OF THIS AND I THINK THE
QUESTION I HAVE THE AUTHOR WAS
REALLY. I KNOW THERE'S SOME
ISSUES AROUND- AT THE AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT'S
AND THEIR CONCERNS OF MY
CONCERN WAS PRIMARILY THAT. IN
THE SPACE OF WHAT KIND OF
TECHNOLOGY IS GOING TO BE USED
HERE AND REALLY TO PUSH THE
WATER DISTRICTS TO ADOPT THE
CLEANEST ALTERNATIVES FEASIBLE
AND I KNOW YOU'VE LOOKED AT
THIS ISSUE AND GOING THROUGH
SOME THINKING THERE SO I JUST
WANTED TO POSE A QUESTION AND
ASK- IF THE BILL IS WHEN CLOSER
TO THE ASSEMBLY OF THERE'S AN
INTENT TO- REQUIRE AT LEAST
THESE WATER DISTRICTS TO DO
SOME HOMEWORK AND JUST USE.
THAT ALL THE BILLABLE THING AT
THE ADOPT CLEANER ALTER ISN'T
JUST DEFAULTING TO DIS SENATORS
AT A QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR YES
WOULD YOU ACCEPT THE QUEST YES
THANK. YOU ANY INSTITUTION
PUTTING IN- ANY TYPE OF
GENERATORS TODAY SHOULD DO THE
DUE DILIGENCE. AND DO THE WORK
NECESSARY TO DETERMINE. WHAT
KIND OF CO TWO IS BEING OMITTED
FROM THERE SO- UTILIZING- THE-
CLEANER TECHNOLOGIES AS IS
ALWAYS THE WAY TO GO SO YES
THAT. THE ON THAT THAT
CERTAINLY IS NOT THE ANYTHING
THAT WE WOULD OPPOSE THE MOVING
IN THAT DIRECTION I THINK THAT
THIS BILL ALREADY GIVES THE
OPPORTUNITY- IT DOESN'T
PRECLUDE JUST IT IT IT DOESN'T
PRECLUDE THAT. AND HAPPY TO
LOOK AT THAT. THIS IS. TO LOOK
AT IT I JUST I HATE TO BE A
STICK BURNER BROUGHT UP WITH
THE SENATOR FROM VENTURA COUNTY
ON HER BACK UP GENERATOR BILL
AND- WITH THE SENATE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY AND- I JUST DON'T
WANT IS DEFAULTING TO DIESEL
WE'RE GONNA SOLVE PS PS THIS
FIRE SEASON ALMOST WITH A 100%
DIESEL POWER IN THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AREA AND I DON'T
THINK. THAT'S NOT REALLY A TRUE
CALIFORNIA SOLUTION SO JUST. I
HATE TO BE A STICKLER BUT- THEY
OPEN THIS TO ADOPTING A
REQUIREMENT TO DO THAT
DILIGENCE BEFORE- OPTING INTO
THIS AIR QUALITY EXEMPTION. I
DON'T HAVE ANY BUT I DON'T HAVE
ANY PROBLEM WITH THE WITH. WITH
MOVING IN THAT DIRECTION I WANT
TO BRING EVERYBODY BACK TO
THAT. THE REASON FOR THE BILL.
THE REASON FOR THE BILL IN THE
FIRST PLACE. IS BECAUSE WE'RE
HAVING THESE PSP **** AND- IN
MANY CASES BECAUSE THE P. S. P.
S. IS OUR LONGER THEY MAY
EXCEED THE NUMBER OF HOURS.
THAT THEY'RE ALLOWED TO RUN
THEIR GENERATORS FROM. AND FROM
THE FROM THE AIRPORT AND SO
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS
JUST. LOOK AT THESE PS PS IS
ARE THESE CRITICAL FACILITIES
FAULT. WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
GET YOU KNOW SOME SOME WAVE
PATHWAY FORWARD ONE OF THE
REASONS I TOOK A FIVE YEAR
SUNSET ON THIS BILL. IT'S
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T THINK SHOULD
BE OPEN ENDED AND BECAUSE OF
THAT QUALITY ISSUES. RENEW
ENERGY THAT THEY WOULD HAVE WE
DIDN'T THINK IT SHOULD BE A
LONG TERM SURE THE- SITUATION
WHERE THEY WOULD CONTINUE TO
USE. YOU KNOW WHO DIRTY IF YOU
WILL DIESEL- YELLOW GENERATORS.
SO HAPPY TO CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSION ON THIS IF YOU WANT.
A SPECIFIC- YOU KNOW LIKE WHICH
I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THAT I DON'T THINK I DON'T
THINK ANY OF THE- CRITICAL
FACILITIES WOULD HAVE ANY
PROBLEM WITH THAT BECAUSE I AS
I SAID AT THE ONSET- THEY
SHOULD BE CONSIDERING THAT
ANYWAY. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
INDULGING THE QUESTION A AND MY
SENSE IS IF THAT AMANDA WERE
ADOPTED- THEY'RE ALL
ENVIRONMENTAL OPPOSITION BE
DROPPED AND WE CAN MOVE FOR SO
APPRECIATE YOUR WORKING ON THAT
I THINK. WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
MEASURE WITH THAT COMMITMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SENATOR
GROW FOLLOWED BY SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
QUESTION THE AUTHOR BECAUSE YOU
KNOW WE GET THESE BILLS AND WE
JUST HAVE A BRIEF TIME TO GO
OVER AND- WOULD YOU ACCEPT THE
QUESTION AUTHOR YES WOULD YOU
ACCEPT QUESTIONS VERY GOOD
CENTER GROW PLEASING. SO IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING AND THEN I GOT
A LITTLE CONFUSED WITH THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER BUT IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION UNDER PS PSP
EMERGENCY SHUT OFF FOR FIRES
WERE PEOPLE HAVE N POWER IN
THE WINTER TO KEEP THEIR HOMES
WARM OR NO FACILITIES OR-
COMPANIES THAT HAVE THE POWER
TO KEEP- TO HAVE THE GENERATED
POWER BECAUSE THE ELECTRICITY
SHUT OFF LIKE IT SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES. WERE MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE FOR HANNAH
BARBARA MADE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THAT BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT A
GENERATORS WERE ALLOWED IT
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
AFTER REQUIRED YOUR BILL JUST
SAYS THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO WORK.
WITH NINE THREE THE PSP. BUT
ONLY FOR SHORT OF TIME FIVE
YEARS THAT THEY CAN APPLY FOR
THOSE GRANTS THAT MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THOUSAND OAKS. HAD
MENTIONED DURING THE CONTENT OF
THE DISCUSSION WITH MY
COLLEAGUES BILL FRIEND. A SANTA
BARBARA SO I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS THAT MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
IS ONLY TO ALLOW THESE
GENERATORS TO OPERATE TO
PROVIDE POWER TO PEOPLE WHO
DESPERATELY NEED IT. LIKE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
DURING AN EMERGENCY STATE SHUT
OFF. AND DURING THAT EMERGENCY
STATE SHUT OFF THEY WOULD ONLY
BE ABLE TO USE THE GENERATORS
FOR A PERIOD OF TIME. BEFORE
THEY CAN REPLACE THEM WITH THE
GRANTS THAT ARE AVAILABLE FOR
ENERGY AND YOU KNOW OTHER KIND
OF- GENERATING POWER IS THAT
RIGHT OR WRONG. I WOULD SAY
THAT THE SENATOR FROM
BAKERSFIELD WAS MUCH MORE
ARTICULATE THE DIE WAS- ON THE
DESCRIPTION OF THAT BILL AND I
THANK HER VERY MUCH. OKAY THANK
YOU I'M ON MY OWN TIME. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WITH WHAT
WE FACING CALIFORNIA WITH THESE
PS PS SITUATIONS YOU KNOW MY
DISTRICT IN PARTICULAR AND ALL
AROUND THE STATE NOT JUST IN MY
DISTRICT FROM SOUTHERN. TO
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. WITH SMALL
COMMUNITY TO HAVE TO BE THE
EXPERIENCE PS PS ADVANCE. AND
IT'S AN ELDERLY RETIEMENT
COMMUNITY IT REALLY IS A
MOUNTAIN RETIREMENT COMMUNITY
PEOPLE COME FROM LOS ANGELES
FROM ALL OVER TO RETIRE TO THIS
BEAUTIFUL COMMUNITY. THAT HAS
FOUR SEASONS AT REAL FOUR
SEASONS SUMMER WINTER SPRING
AND FALL IT'S GOT BEAUTIFUL
FLOWERS. ONE OF MOST. AMAZING
SPRING DID UP ON THEM SPRING
FLOWERS ON THE MOUNTAIN TOPS
IT'S GOT SNOW IN THE WINTER
IT'S GOT BEAUTIFUL FOLLIES.
JUST REALLY LETTUCE COMMUNITY.
OUT OF POWER I BELIEVE FOR
TWENTY THREE DAYS. TWENTY THREE
DAYS- THE WAIT WHAT WASTE WATER
TREATMENT PLANT WENT DOWN IT
BECAUSE BACK UP IN THE TOWN
THERE WAS ALL THIS. ISSUE IT
TOOK PLACE AND IF. WE WERE ABLE
TO RUN BACK AND GENERATORS
WITHOUT THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
FINING AS- IT'S UNGODLY THINK
THE EVEN. UPON ME. UPON
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. THOSE
PEOPLE COULD'VE BEEN TAKING
CARE OF IN A MUCH BETTER WAY.
SO IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING BASED
ON THE LIMITED INFORMATION THAT
I HAVE THAT THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES. IT ALLOWS BACKUP
GENERATORS TO RESPOND. TO MATCH
NEEDED POWER SOURCES THAT ARE
NOT AVAILABLE DURING A PS PS.
AND THEY WILL NOT BE FINE BY
THE CALIFORNIA- RESOURCES BOARD
EVEN IF THEY HAVE A PROTECT
WHICH MEANS PER YOU KNOW THAT.
IT'S A PORTABLE TAG A PORTABLE
GENERATOR TAG. SO I. APPLAUD
THE AUTHOR FOR DOING THAT. OF
MY BLOOD THE OTHER FROM FOR
PUTTING A FIVE YEAR SUNSET ON
IT BECAUSE THAT LLOWS THESE
INDUSTRIES. THESE PEOPLE THAT
USE THESE- PORTABLE GENERATORS
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE FIVE YEARS
TO GARNER OTHER. MEANS OF
POWER. AND TECHNOLOGY THAT IS
STARTING TO BECOME AVAILABLE I
THINK IT'S A WELL THOUGHT OUT
BILL. AND JUST THINK GATHERED
FOR PRISON ANY CLEAR I MADE MY-
THANK YOU. HIS TO GROW SENATOR
WE. THANK YOU I'M NOT PRESIDENT
IF I COULD JUST. PUT TO BE ON
PLEASE. I WOULD YOU ACCEPT THE
QUESTION CENTER DOT. WITHOUT OF
TO THE QUESTION TO GO CLARIFY
THE IN THE SAN FROM FROM LOS
ANGELES CAL. QUESTION LANDIS IS
THAT THE SENATOR. HAS PROPOSED
SOME SPECIFIC AMENDMENTS. AND
THE IDEAS OF THOSE WOULD BE
TAKEN- IN THE ASSEMBLY- TO
REQUIRE CONSIDERATION. OF THE
CLEANER ENERGY SO THAT WE DON'T
TO FALL TO THE DIRTY ENERGY-
ARE YOU ARE YOU PREPARED TO
TAKE THOSE IN THE ASSEMBLY.
IT'S JUST THAT WOULD REQUIRE
THE OPERATOR TAKE A
DEMONSTRABLE STEPS SUCH AS A
REQUEST FOR INFORMATION OR
REQUEST FOR. PROPOSAL TOWARDS
IMPLEMENTING THE USE OF BACK
UP. POWER TECHNOLOGIES THAT
MEET OR EXCEED EMISSION
STANDARDS. A BY THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD I WANT TO
MAKE THAT CLEAR AND I'M I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE THAT AMENDED. BUT
I ALSO WANT TO MAKE CLEAR FOR
THOSE THAT PERHAPS MIGHT NOT
LIKE THAT. BUT THAT'S NOT A
REQUIREMENT TO DO SO I JUST
IT'S A IT'S A MIDDLE GROUND
HERE. IN AND- HOPEFULLY PEOPLE
WILL SEE IT ISTHAT THANK YOU
CENTER OUR OUR THANK YOU ON SO
MANY PRESIDENT ARMS I THINK A
NUMBER OF US HAD. CONCERNS
ABOUT HIS BILL THAT IT WOULD BE
A DEFAULT. FIVE TWO GENERATORS
PROPANE OR DIESEL- AND TING
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS- IT WILL-
FROM ALL RIGHT TO HERS AND NOT
FOR THE DIRTY ENERGIES AND TO
TRY TO CLEAN ENERGY. OBVIOUSLY
WE ALL WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
OUR I WAS THE RIGHT BALANCE AND
SO ON BASED ON ASSURING I'LL BE
VOTE ON IT TO THANK YOU SENATOR
WINNER ANY FURTHER TO DISK CHEN
OUT. MEMBERS THERE WE GO HI I
WANTED THINK FRIENDS FROM
THOUSAND OAKS AND MY CALL FROM
SERVICES GO- FOR WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR ON THIS I THINK
THESE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'RE
PROPOSING WILL WILL CERTAINLY
STRENGTH IN THE BILL MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT HARMING THE AIR
MIGHT MY ONLY RESPONSE TODAY
THE COMMENTS ARE MARKET. ALI
FROM BAKERSFIELD IS THAT. IN
THERE WE DID IT WE DID A DEEP
DIVE INTO THIS ONE THIS MEASURE
CAME BEFORE THE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY COMMITTEE AND THERE
HAVE BEEN. NO INCIDENCES OF.
HIGHER BOARDS FINING. HAVE
FOLKS WHO WANTED TO KEEP THE
POWER ON DURING. YES YES
INCIDENCES. AND YOU KNOW IT IN
THE IN THE- IN THE IN THE IN
THE TYPES OF SITUATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP. THEY WERE
TRYING TO IT ALLEVIATE AND AN
ADDRESS AND WITH REGARD TO THIS
BILL. THE AIRPORTS OF SAID IT
VERY CLEARLY THAT THEY WOULDN'T
FIND UNDER THOSE KINDS OF
CIRCUMSTANCES BECAUSE THEY
UNDERSTAND. THE DIFFICULTIES
AND THE- THE- THE- THE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCE OF THE TS TS.
LET'S NOT LET'S NOT KID
OURSELVES THERE'S A LOT OF
POLLUTION ASSOCIATED WITH THE
DIESEL GENERATORS. AND IF
ANYTHING. THE PROBLEM HERE THAT
WE'VE GOT A UTILITY. THAT HAS
NOT DONE THE WORK HAS NOT PUT
IN PLACE THE INFRASTRUCTURE. TO
MITIGATE AND TO MINIMIZE THE
NEED FOR P. S. TS ADVANCE. AND
AS A RESULT WE HAVE HOSPITALS
IN TOWNS LIKE THAT BEAUTIFUL
TOWN THAT THE SENATOR TALKED
ABOUT UP IN THE MOUNTAINS THAT
ARE FORCED TO GO TO HEAVILY
POLLUTING DIESEL GENERATORS
THAT POWER AARON MIGHT MAKE
THAT LITTLE TOWN A LITTLE LESS
PRETTY THAN IT WAS BEFORE AND
THAT'S BECAUSE WE HAVE
UTILITIES HAVE. HI FAILED. TO
DO ITS JOB AND IS RESULT THEY
HAVE THESE MASSIVE POWER SET US
ALL THROUGHOUT NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THAT RESULT IN THE
NEED FOR FOLKS TO POWER AND
DIESEL POLLUTING DIESEL
GENERATORS AND SO THAT'S REALLY
THE HEART OF THIS PROBLEM HERE.
AND WE'RE TRYING OUR BEST TO
THIS BILL TO CRAFTING A
COMPROMISE TO ALLOW. HOSPITALS
AND OTHER VITAL INSTITUTIONS TO
KEEP. RUNNING DURING DIFFICULT
TIMES HOW WE WANT TO ALLOW THE
NETFLIX ABILITY- BUT LET'S NOT
MAKEANY MISTAKE ABOUT WHAT.
WHO WHO THE REAL- VILLIAN IS
HERE. AND LET'S ALSO NOT MAKING
A MISTAKE THAT. THESE DIESEL
GENERATORS ARE HEAVILY POLLUTED.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN SENATOR
DOLLY AB. TO GET THAT MIKE
PLEASE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YES. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT TO I WAS
ANY Q. AS WELL WHEN HIS BILL
CAME THROUGH AND ACTUALLY VOTED
AGAINST THIS BILL NOT BECAUSE-
I THINK IT WE WENT. I'M I'M
WORRIED WE'RE GONNA GO TOO FAR
LOOK. THIS IS THE CHAIR OF THE
EQ BROUGHT UP SOME REALLY GREAT
POINTS. THE FACT OF THE MATTER
IS THAT HOSPITALS AND WATER
DISTRICTS. THEY DIDN'T CAUSE
THIS PROBLEM UNIQUE BECAUSE
THIS PROBLEM BUT I HAVE IN OUR
IN OUR DISTRICT WE'VE HAD.
OUTAGES FOR. TEN TO TWELVE DAYS
AND EVEN LONGER IN SOME AREAS
OF THE DISTRICT WHERE THEY WERE
REQUIRED TO RUN THOSE.
GENERATORS TO PROVIDE. OUR OR
WATER INTO HAVE DEEPER HOSPITAL
RUNNING. THIS BILL COULD ALLOW
THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL IS TO
COME IN AND FORCE THEM TO
BECAUSE THEY'RE RUNNING LONGER
PRISON THEY NORMALLY WOULD RUN
AND THERE IS A PULL BLOOM.
ASSOCIATE WITH THE- SO IF
YOU'RE IF YOU'RE A HOSPITAL.
THAT IS IN THAT SITUATION AND
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICER
COMES IN AND MANDATE YOU
CHANGED OUT BECAUSE YOU'RE
POLLUTANTS. AND THESE ARE
DISTRICT HOSPITALS WE ACTUALLY
ASSESS OURSELVES TO PROPERTY
TAX SO WE CAN HAVE A HOSPITAL.
THAT COULD BE TWO TO THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
THAT DISTRICT HOSPITAL. THAT IS
NOT THEIR FAULT. SO I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT IT GOING TOO
FAR THE OTHER WAY I VOTED
AGAINST THE BILL I'M GONNA LAY
OFF ON THE BILL BECAUSE I
BELIEVE. THE AUTHORS TRYING TO
STRIKE BOTH AUTHORS I SHOULD
SAY ARE TRYING TO STRIKE THE
BALANCE WHERE. LOOK IF THERE'S
AN ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
IMPROVE THE ENVIRONMENT. AND
THE RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE
THEY SHOULD DO IT. IF THERE IS
A HARDSHIP AND THERE IS NOT THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO DO IT
THEY SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
GENERATE AND PROVIDE THE
SERVICES THAT THE COMMUNITY
NEEDS SO. I'M OPTIMIST LEE
WATCHING THE BILL HOPEFULLY THE
AMENDMENTS TO COME BACK. THAT
THE AUTHORS AGREED TO TAKE WILL
WILL STRIKETHAT BALANCE SO
THAT ALL COMMUNITIES CAN
FINANCIALLY GET WHERE THEY NEED
TO BE AND WE CAN ALSO HAVE.
BETTER ENVIRONMENT THE SAME
TIME SO I WANT TO APPLAUD THE
ALL THESE WE HE HAS. WORKED US
BILL VERY HARD AND I'M HOPING
IT'LL GET OUT AND THAT THE
MINUTES WILL BE. WILL BE FAIR
TO ALL OF CALIFORNIA STATE YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION. SIX BATES
BUT MAY I ASK MAY I ASK IT'S
REALLY HARD TO SEE WHO'S GOT
THEIR MIKE SHOP. WE HAVE THESE
LITTLE FLASH. THINGS THAT
PEOPLE CAN. USE I'MI'M FINDING
IT EASIER TO IDENTIFY WORSE
WHEN PEOPLE WANT TO SPEAK IF
YOU'LL HOLD THAT UP BEFOREHAND.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES I
APPRECIATED. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
HOLD ON ONE SECOND PLEASE CAN
WE HAVE. IS THE MICHAEL ON.
SORRY. READY ALL SET THANK YOU
READY CENTER BATES THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I DID OBSCENE
ANY Q. ODD BECAUSE THERE'S A
LOT OF DISCUSSION THAT WE HEARD
HERE ON THE FLOOR- THIS MORNING
BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT THE
AUTHOR IS VERY COMMITTED TO
WORKING ARE WITH THE OPPOSITION
OF WE CAN CALL IT THAT THOSE
WHO HAVE CONCERNS AND I THINK
IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AS
WERE REACHING OUR FINAL
DEADLINES TO GIVE THAT EXTRA
PUSH TO THOSE WHO HAVE
ADDITIONAL TIME- THIS WILL GO
TO THE ASSEMBLY THAT WOULD HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY FLESH
OUT WHAT CAN HAPPEN WITH THE
AMENDMENTS AND HOPEFULLY
RESOLVE. ANY ISSUE THAT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT TO A SITUATION
THAT THE GOOD SENATOR IS TRYING
TO RESOLVE SO I WILL BE
CHANGING OUR BE MOVING TO AN
AYE VOTE TO HELP OF THAT ACCORD
THANK YOU YOU TOO. THANK YOU
SENATOR TING NO ADDITION MICRO.
UP SENATOR DODD YOU MAY CLOSE
YES I WOULD HAVE- SENATOR- THAT
FOR MARANDA- DO THE DO THE
CLOTHES BUT JUST FOR ITS- THE
SENATOR FROM BEAVER. EIGHTY OF
THESE- A GREEN IT'S OUR
VOLUNTARY IN NATURE SO IF YOU
DON'T WANT TO GO DOWN THAT ROAD
OR BOARD OF DIRECTORS DOESN'T
WANT TO DO IT THEY CAN ALWAYS
IT HERE TO THE LAWS THAT ARE
THERE. RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU
SENATOR GLAZER YOU MAY CLOSE.
AT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR DIED IN NINE THE
THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATION TODAY
WE HAVE WORKED HARD ON THIS
BILL I WANT TO- PARTICULARLY
CALL OUT APPRECIATION TO THE
SENATOR FROM THE NORTH COAST
AND THE SENATOR FROM LOS
ANGELES TO HEADED UP OUR
ENERGY- UTILITY FIRE GROUP TO-
HELP STEER AND WORK ON THESE
ISSUES AND AS WELL AS THE PRO
TEM AND THE PRO TEM STAFF SO-
THESE ARE CIRCUMSTANCES NOBODY
WANTS- BUT WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE
THE BEST OF IT FOR THESE
CRITICAL CARE FACILITIES- AS WE
HAVE DISCUSSED WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT OF.
THANK YOU ALL DEBATE HAVING
SEIZED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES I
TELL FIVE FOR JUST HI BRADFORD.
I HAVE A ADAM. I CHIANG HI
DOLLY. DODD I ASSUME. I
GALGIANI I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. I HERTZBERG I HILL AYE
HUESO- HIGH TADO I JACKSON I
JONES. HI HI LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE
AYE MELINDA'S. MITCHELL I
MONNINGHI MORE LOCK HIGH
MORALE. I NIELSEN I PAN I
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. I RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN I AM VERY HIGH
I LIKE HOW SCHEME. WIENER HI
WELL. HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. DALLY
MELENDEZ. WHITE HOUSE SKI. FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES SENATOR GROWTH
FOR WHAT PURPOSE PLEASE THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT TO CALL
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN THE RULES
ROOM IMMEDIATELY THANK YOU
ROOM FOURTH WITH.
IN THE RULES COMMITTEE I THINK
YOU MEAN THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
HOLD ON ONE SECOND COULD WE GET
SENATOR BREAUX BACK HERE TO
GIVE US SOME CLARIFICATION.
ALSO THE ONE. NINETY ONE.
ALRIGHT WOULD ANYONE. PUBLIC IN
CARCASS IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE.
I WAS ASKED TO
REMIND EVERYONE THAT WE MUST
SOCIALLY DISTANCE I KNOW IT'S
HARD. BUT SENATOR DOLLY CENTER
BRADFORD WE'VE GOT TO SAID
WE'VE GOT TO SOCIALLY DISTANCE.
SOCIAL DISTANCING PLEASE THE
GOOD SENATOR NOT FOM THOUSAND
OAKS SOCIAL DISTANCING PLEASE.
SENATOR SKINNER. I'M SORRY
WE'VE GOT A SOCIALLY DISTANCE I
HAVE BEEN GIVEN MY MARCHING
ORDERS. MUCH APPRECIATED BY
CAUCUS REPUBLICAN CAUCUS HAS
CONCLUDED IF I MAY REMIND
EVERYONE ONCE AGAIN WE NOW HAVE
FORTY NINE BILLS. US EIGHTEEN
TRAILER BILLS PLUS THE BUDGET
AT EIGHT FORTY FIVE TONIGHT A
WE ARE GOING TO TRY TO BE DONE
THIS EVENING IF NOT WE WILL
HAVE TO COME BACK TOMORROW SO
IF WE COULD BE MINDFUL AS WE
DEBATE. THAT WE HAVE A VERY
VERY LARGE FILE TODAY TO
ADDRESS SO WITH THAT. WE WILL
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
FIVE. FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ADAM I AM PASSING ON FILE WELL
I'M SORRY OKAY VERY GOOD. NOW
FORTY EIGHT LEFT. ALL RIGHT
FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX SENATOR
HILL ARE YOU PREPARED ON FILE
ITEM TWENTY SIX SENATOR HILL.
SENATOR HILL. ARE YOU PREPARED
TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX
YOU THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE BY SENATOR HILL AN
ACT RELATING TO EXCAVATIONS
THANK YOU SENATOR HILL THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND GOOD MORNING SB
EIGHT SIXTY FIVE MAKES COMMON
SENSE CHANGES TO THE DIG SAFE
WALL. THAT SUPPORTS SAFE
EXCAVATION PRACTICES AND
STRENGTHEN COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN SUBSURFACE
INFRASTRUCTURE STAKEHOLDERS.
THE BIG STATE BOARD WAS
ESTABLISHED TO IMPROVE
ENFORCEMENT OF THE CALL BEFORE
YOU DIG LAW AND EVALUATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR IMPROVING
SAFETY. BUT THEY CANNOT DO
THEIR JOB WITHOUT THE PROPER
DATA SUCH AS HOW MANY DIGGINS
ARE OCCURRING WHERE THEY ARE
HAPPENING HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
CALLING EIGHT ONE ONE WHO IS
COLLEEN AND WHO ISN'T. SB EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE EQUIPS THE DIG SAFE
BOARD WITH THE NECESSARY TOOLS
TO PERFORM THEIR STATUTORY
DUTY. EIGHT SIXTY FIVE ALSO
ENSURES THATEXCAVATORS HAVE
ACCURATE INFORMATION BEFORE A
SHOVEL FULL OF EARTH IS TURNED
BY REQUIRING ALL NEW SUBSURFACE
INSTALLATIONS THE G. I. S. TAG.
SB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE MOVES TO
DIG FOR TO THE OFFICE OF ENERGY
AND INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY WHICH
BETTER ALIGNS WITH THEIR
MISSION WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH THE COPS. WESTERN
AND FARM BUREAU AND WE HAVE
AMENDMENTS THAT THAT WILL GO
BEFORE THE FIRST POLICY
COMMITTEE IN THE ASSEMBLY WE'RE
ALSO WORKING WITH LAND
SURVEYORS- AND- THAT WILL BE
FOR ON THE G. I. S. PROVISIONS
AS WELL AS BIGELOW OR CHILL
WHAT WE WILL HAVE WHATEVER
ISSUES ARE ARE STILL AROUND. IT
WILL BE RESOLVED IN THE
ASSEMBLY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
CENTER HILL DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM I BELIEVE THE
AUTHOR JUST STATED WHAT I
WANTED TO HEAR AND THAT WAS- I
HAVE A LETTER FROM DIG ALERT
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT. THAT
HE WAS- WORKING WITH- THEIR
CONCERN SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM. PRESIDENT THANK YOU
SENATOR MODOC FURTHER DELAY.
DISCUSSION SEEING AND HEARING
NONE SENATOR HILL YOU MAY CLOSE
RECESS RIVAL COLLEAGUES. THANK
YOU ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED IF
YOU GIVE ME A MOMENT. RIGHT
VERY GOOD MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA OR AYE ATKINS I BATES.
I FELL I FORGES AYE BRADFORD. I
HAVE A I CHIANG I DALLY FIVE
DODD. I TORONTO I GALGIANI FIVE
GLAZER I GONZALEZ BY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I HILL HI WITH SO. HI
TANTO. I JACKSON HI I JONES.
LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S
AYE MITCHELL. I MONEY FIVE MORE
LOCK HI MORAL THE SERGEANTS
HIGH NIELSEN I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN. HI I'M BURKE
HI I LIKE HOW SKI. I WIENER I
WILK HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME PLEASE
ALLEN. I GROWTH HI JONES. ICE
THIRTY NINE AT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSAGE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT. SENATOR
GLAZER YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP
THIS ITEM MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL EIGHT
OH ONE BY SENATOR GLAZER AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTRICITY SENATOR
GLAZER THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. TOP POWER IF POWER IS
LIFE WE THINK ABOUT POWER WE
SAY IF THE LIGHTS ON IN THE
ROOM BUT FOR MANY PEOPLE POWER
REALLY IS LIFE. WHEN THE
POWERSHOT OFFICE IT WAS THIS
PAST FALL IT PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF OF ANTS. OVER
TWO MILLION PEOPLE LOST THEIR
POWER IN CALIFORNIA. THE CAMPUS
THE MORE THAN FORTY COUNTIES.
AND WITHIN THOSE COUNTIES.
THERE ARE THIRTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHO ARE BASS LINE
MEDICAL CUSTOMERS TO. FOR THEM
POWER IS LIFE. BUT WHEN THE
LIGHTS GO OUT. THEY'RE IN A
VERY. MORE THAN I'M COMFORTABLE
THERE IN A LIFE THREATENING
SITUATION SO SB EIGHT A ONE IS
A BILL TO TRY TO PROTECT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE CITIZENS OF OUR
STATE. WHEN WE ENTER THE
WILDFIRE SEASON WHICH IS COMING
SOONER IN SOONER WHEN THE POWER
GETS SHUT OFF THROUGH WITH NO
CONTROL OF ANYONE EXCEPT FOR
THE UTILITY COMPANIES AND
NATURE. AND THE QUESTION IS CAN
THOSE PEOPLE GET BACK UP POWER
TO PROTECT THEIR LIVES. AND FOR
THEM IT'S NOT BACK UP POWER TO.
RUN THE XBOX ON THE TV
ENTERTAINMENT IS NOT POWER TO
RUN EVEN THE REFRIGERATOR THE
FREEZER AND OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
GREAT GREAT ECONOMIC IMPACT
WHEN THE POWER GOES OFF. ON THE
REFRIGERATION UNIT FOR THEM THE
POWER IS LIFE IF YOU'RE ON A
DIALYSIS MACHINE POWER IS LIFE.
IF YOU HAVE A BREATHING MACHINE.
OUR IS LIFE A RESPIRATOR AND
IRON LONG. THAT POWER IS
EVERYTHING IN YOUR WORLD. THIS
LEGISLATION DOESN'T SAY THAT
THE UTILITIES HAVE TO PROVIDE
POWER FOR EVERYTHING IN YOUR
HOUSEHOLD IT SAYS THAT FOR
THOSE WHO ARE MEDICAL BASELINE
DOCTOR APPROVED MEDICAL
BASELINE FOR POWER IS LIFE THAT
THE UTILITY NEEDS TO PROVIDE
SOME SORT OF ENERGY SOURCE. TO
KEEP YOU ALIVE AND THAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF EIGHT OH ONE AND
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SENATOR WILK FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR NIELSEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I RISE IS A PROUD
CO AUTHOR OF SB EIGHT OH ONE
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS DIRE
REALLY NEEDED- DURING THE T. S.
P. S. EPISODES LAST YEAR. I HAD
AN EIGHTY TWO YEAR OLD
WHEELCHAIR BOUND VETERAN. THAT
ALSO WAS ON OXYGEN WHO HAD NO
POWER IN HIS HOUSE FOR OVER
THREE DAYS. WHEN HE CALLED THE
I OWE YOU THEY SAID CALL NINE
ONE ONE. FORTUNATELY HE CALLED
MYSELF IN THIS WOMAN LACKEY AND
WE ACTUALLY WENT AND RENTED A
GENERATOR WENT AND INSTALLED IT
AT HIS HOUSE BECAUSE HE WAS
UNABLE TO AS WELL AS HIS WIFE.
THIS IS JUST ON THIS IS JUST
UNACCEPTABLE I THINK THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO PROTECT
THE MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
SOCIETY AND I ENCOURAGE AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER WILL
RETURN NIELSEN. BUT A PRESENT
LAYS DOWN THE SENATE I ALSO
URGE AN AYE VOTE THESE P. S. P.
S. ADVANCE OUR NEW TO US BUT WE
ARE LEARNING ABOUT. BUT I WOULD
ARGUE THE FIRST ONE HERE WAS
PRETTY MUCH A DISASTER. IN MANY
WAYS. AND SERVE SEVERAL OF S
ARE TRYING TO WORK ON DIFFERENT
LEGISLATIVE OPTIONS TO EASE
THAT PROBLEM. SENATOR DODD MOST
RECENTLY FROM NAPA. BUT WHEN WE
HAD THIS LAST EVENT. AS THE
CENTER OF FOR MARANDA HAS SO
WONDERFULLY ARGUED. WE HAD LIFE
AT RISK DESPERATE PEOPLE
CALLING. THERE ARE DIALYSIS.
WHATEVER IT WAS THEY NEEDED
READING YOU NAME IT. AND THEY
HAD NO HOME. THEN I COMMEND MY
COLLEAGUE WHO ACTUALLY WENT OUT
AND RENTED SUBSISTENCE FISH
THINGS TO HELP THEM OUT. IT IS
SO CRITICAL AND THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE GOT TO BE VIGILANT. AND
TRY TO REFINE THIS WHOLE P. S.
P. S. PROCESS. ANY
ACCOMMODATIONS RELATED THERE
ARE TWO WERE MORE BILLS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE FORTHCOMING
RELATED TO THAT THIS CLEARLY IS
A LIFE. HEALTH AND SAFETY ISSUE
I URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR NIELSEN SEEING NO
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
CENTER GLAZER YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FIRST
LET ME- THANK MY JOINT AUTHORED
THE CENTER FROM THE NORTH
COAST- FOR PARTNERING ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL I WANT TO THANK
THE SENATOR FROM SANTA CLARITA
FOR BEING A CO AUTHOR
CERTAINLY. THE SENATOR FROM MY
FOR HIS GOOD WORDS- WE DO A LOT
FLOOR BUT CERTAINLY PROTECTING
LIFE OF OUR RESIDENTS IS
ESSENTIAL PART OF WHAT WE DO AT
THE BILL'S NEARLY CRAFTED TO
TRY TO DEAL WITH THOSE WHO ARE
MOST MEDICALLY VULNERABLE I
KNOW THE ABILITIES ARE EXCITED
ABOUT IT BUT WE HOPE THAT THIS
IS PRUDENT STEP FORWARD THEY
DON'T LIKE PSP. EITHER TRYING
TO GET THEM BUT IN THE MEANTIME
WE PROTECT OUR RESIDENTS AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS DOES IT
CREATING I'VE THANK YOU ALL
DEBATE HAVING SPEECH MAY
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL. THE ROLL.
I OUR JULY. ATKINS AYE BATES.
BELL BY FOR JUST FIVE BRADFORD.
HI COVER ADAM I CHIANG HI DOLLY
I DODD. I THEY'RE AWESOME I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ
I GROWTH I HERTZBERG HI HILL HI
LISTEN. I TADO I JACKSON HI
JONES. LEYVA HI MCGUIRE AYE
MELINDA'S AYE MITCHELL. I MONEY
FIVE MORE LOCK. MORRELL NIELSEN.
I PAN I PORTANTINO AYE ROTH I
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER I STERN HI
I'M BURKE AYE I WHAT KIND OF
SPEED. I WIENER HI WILK HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME. BATES JONES.
MORE LOCK. ZERO WHY IS THIRTY
SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ALONG NOW TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY NINE FILE ITEM TWENTY
NINE SENATOR TO RUSSELL. MADAM
SCHECTER. SENATE BILL ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE BY SENATOR DORADO
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT SENATOR DORADO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR COLLEAGUES GOOD MORNING.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AB ONE
NINETEEN WAS SIGNED INTO LAW.
GRANTED PUBLIC EMPLOYEE OR
GOING TO STATIONS ACCESS TO
NEWLY HIRED STAFF CONTACT
INFORMATION WITHIN THIRTY DAYS
OF THEIR HIRE DATE AND FURTHER
DATA EVERY FOUR MONTHS IS A
VERY SIMPLE LAW. PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE OR THE ASIANS MUST
RECEIVE ACCURATE AND TIMELY
BARGAINING UNIT INFORMATION SO
THAT THEY MAY FULFILL THEIR
LEGAL REPRESENTATION DUTIES
AND- MEET THE NEEDS OF THEIR
BARGAINING UNIT AS A WHOLE. IF
THEY DO NOT MAKE THEIR LEGAL
DUTIES EMPLOYEES OF THAT
BARGAINING UNIT CAN FILE
CHARGES AGAINST THE
ORGANIZATION. DESPITE THIS SOME
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS STILL CHOOSE
TO IGNORE THEIR REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. OR SOME EMPLOYERS
AND INACCURATE OR OUT OF DATE
INFORMATION. SINCE THE MAY
TWENTY TWENTY REPORTING
DEADLINE AT LEAST TWENTY FOUR
EMPLOYERS FAILED TO EVEN
RESPOND TO THE BARGAINING AGENT
WITH NO CONSEQUENCES. THIS BILL
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
ESTABLISHES ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES WITH PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE EMPLOYER TO
CURE THE PROBLEM AND RESPOND.
WE MUST DO A BETTER JOB OF
MAKING SURE THAT PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES AT HERE TO EXISTING
LAW. THERE'S NO DOUBT IN MY
MIND THAT THOSE SAME EMPLOYERS
HAVE TO HAVE THIS INFORMATION
THEY HAVE IT ON LISTS. HAVE TO
HAVE BASIC INFORMATION LIKE THE
NAMES OF THEIR EMPLOYEES WHERE
THEY WORK WITH CLASSIFICATION
THEY WORK AND- LET ME BE CLEAR
THAT THIS MEASURE CREATES KNOLL
NEW REQUIREMENTS FOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES. IT SIMPLY
INCENTIVIZE IS COMPLIANCE WITH
EXISTING LAW. DURING
EMERGENCIES HAVING ACCURATE AND
TIMELY INFORMATION IS ESSENTIAL
WHETHER THE STATE IS FACING
WILDFIRES MASS SHOOTINGS OR
PANDEMIC VIRUSES CALIFORNIA
EXPECTS ITS PUBLIC SERVANTS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE. THE
BARGAINING REPRESENTATIVE HAS
THE MORAL AND A LEGAL DUTY TO
WATCH OUT FOR THE WELFARE OF
THESE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES WHO TURK
WINTER AND WATCH OUT FOR THE
PUBLIC'S WELLBEING. SHORTAGES
AND PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT HAVE LEFT MANY
FRONTLINE WORKERS EXPOSED WELL-SERVING THE PUBLIC. THOSE ARE
BARGAINING AGENTS HAVE BOND
THEMSELVES PROCURING PP TO KEEP
EMPLOYEES AND THE PUBLIC SAFE
WHERE THE PUBLIC EMPLOYERS
LACTOSE SOURCES TO DETERMINE
THE P. B. E. NEEDS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT UP TODAY CON
INFORMATION AND WORKS LOOK. OF
THE BARGAINING UNIT. THIS
CRISIS HAS SHOWN IT IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER THAT
EMPLOYEE REPRESENTATIVES HAVE
THE ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THE ENTIRE BARGAINING UNIT AND
SURE WORKPLACE SAFETY FOR THESE
REASONS COLLEAGUES I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BRING SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE BEFORE
YOU. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN IDOL. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUSSELL DEBATER DISCUSSION
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SENATOR
ALAN. MEMBERS LIKE I SUPPORT
THE BROAD GOALS OF THIS BILL
AND IT'S ABOUT COMPLIANCE WITH
EXISTING LAW- THE AUTHOR AND
I'VE BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS
MIGHT MY MAIN CONCERN IS THAT
THE CURRENT FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR FINE OF PUBLIC AGENCIES
REALLY DOES SEEM PRETTY HIGH TO
ME AT THE CURVE IN SOME HI I'M
HOPING TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH THEM THERE ABOUT- ABOUT
SIGNIFICANTLY DROPPING THAT
NUMBER LET US REMEMBER THIS IS
TAXPAYER DOLLARS AT PLAY HERE
WE OBVIOUSLY WANT THEM TO
COMPLY. AND WE ALSO TO MAKE
SURE THE TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE.
ARE GOING TO THE USES THAT
TAXPAYERS WANTED TO GO SEE
WHICH IS FINDING THE VERY
SERVICES THAT THESE GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES ARE. PROVIDING SO I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
ABOUT. THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR WOULD YOU ACCEPT THE
QUESTION YES WITHOUT OBJECTION
PLEASE PROCEED NGUYEN AND
PRIVATE BUSINESSES ARE FIND-
THE MONEY THAT IS GENERATED
FROM THE PRIVATE BUSINESS GOES
BACK TO THE TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF A DESPERATELY. OR THE CHANCE.
A WIN THESE ARE FINE WHICH IS
TAXPAYER DOLLARS- FOR
MUNICIPALITIES OR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WEIRD IS THAT MANY
GO IS IT JUST FIND IN PAID AND
PUT BACK INTO THE GENERAL FUND
OR DOES IT THIS BILL PROVIDES
FOR IT TO GO SOMEPLACE ELSE.
MAYOR ANSWER. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION PLEASE.
YES THE MONEY WILL BE VOTE ARE
GIVEN TO THE PROBE GENERAL FUND.
AND I'M SORRY THE MONEY WILL GO
TO THE GENERAL FUND. DO YOU
HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OKAY
I'M ON MY OWN TIME JUST TO MAKE
SURE I UNDERSTAND IT'S JUST SO
I UNDERSTAND BILL AND I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE I HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING OF THIS BILL. IT
IS- A PUBLIC ENTITY BUT SAVE.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
DEPARTMENT THE AT T. DOES NOT
PROVIDE THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING UNIT THE PROPER
INFORMATION AT THE PROPER TIME
THE EDT IS GOING TO BE FINE.
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A DAY
FOR SO MANY DAYS IT'S CALLED A
HUNDRED DAYS. THAT TOTAL DOLLAR
AMOUNT THAT THE STATE IS GOING
TO PAY. ON BEHALF OF THE U. D.
D. WE'LL GO BACK TO THE GENERAL
FUND WHERE IT CAME FROM TO
WRITE THE CHECK. THE FIRST
PLACE I GUESS AM I RIGHT OR
WRONG STE SENATOR DORADO DO YOU
WISH TO RESPOND YES- FIRST OF
ALL IT'S NOT AN AUTOMATIC-
PENALTY THAT'S DONE AT FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS WELL WHAT WE
AMENDED IN THIS. THERE MAY BE
SOME EMPLOYERS WHO MADE THE
MISTAKE WEREN'T PAYING
ATTENTION THE WHOLE GOAL IS TO
JUST GET ATTENTION FROM THESE
ENTITIES AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE PROVIDING THE LIST TO
THE BARGAINING AGENT IT'S NOT
TO MAKE MONEY OUT OF IT IT'S
NOT TO LINE ANYBODY'S POCKETS
IT'S JUST TO GET THEIR
ATTENTION. SO THEY'RE GIVEN A
CURE SO THAT THEY COULD FIX THE
PROBLEM. OBVIOUSLY IF IT
CONTINUES- THEN- THE BARGAINING
AGENT WOULD GO BACK TO PER- I
THINK IT YOU KNOW UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. THEY WOULD- TO
LOOK AT THE THIS THE ACTUAL A
PROBLEM SEE HOW SERIOUS IT WAS
IS IT REPETITIVE WHATEVER IT IS
AND THEY HAVE THE OPTION ON THE
DISCRETION OF FINDING THAT
ENTITY THAT ENTITY OF THE FINE
WOULD GO TO THE PURPOSE A
GENERAL FUND NOT THE STATE'S
GENERAL FUND. SOME THE QUESTION
SEVEN ON MY OWN TIME SO- BASED
ON THE UNDERSTANDING THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE JUST
ANSWERED. AND I YOU KNOW I WANT
TO SAY WHAT'S GOOD FOR THE
GOOSE IS GOOD FOR THE GANDER
BECAUSE I MEAN A PRIVATE
BUSINESS IS GOING TO BE FIND AT
HER IN THIS AMOUNT OF MONEY.
FIND OUT WHAT THE STATE BE FINE
TOO. BOTTOM LINE IS THAT IT
MAKES NO SENSE. BUSINESSES FIND
UNDER THE SAME RULES WHICH THEY
ARE FOR NOT COMPLYING WITH. THE
GET A CURE. SO THIS IS LIKE A
GENEROUS BILL TO THE- IF
THEY'RE GOING TO BE FINE. AND
IN THE NOT MANY GOES BACK TO
THE GENERAL FUND. AND YOU KNOW
ISUSED FOR. YOU KNOW WHATEVER
WE DECIDE TO SPEND MONEY ON.
BUT YET THIS BILL. GOING TO
REQUIRE THE GENERAL FUND TO
WRITE A CHECK WHICH IS GOING TO
BE RETURNED TO THE GENERAL
FUND. FOR A FINE GENERAL FRIEND
HAD TO PAY. I JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE CONCEPT OF THE
BILL UNLESS THIS THE LANGUAGE
OF THIS BILL PUTS THAT MANY
SOMEPLACE ELSE IN A UNION
ORGANIZATION OR A- PENSION
FUNDING SENIOR. OR SEVENTEEN
THAT. IT JUST INCREASES COSTS
TO TAXPAYERS FOR THOSE.
OUTSTANDING LIABILITIES I'M
ASSUMING- BUT TO PASS A BILL
THAT REQUIRES THE GENERAL FUND
TO WRITE A CHECK OUT OF THE
GENERAL FUND TO GET MONEY BACK
INTO THE GENERAL FUND. FOR A
PENALTY THAT WAS VIOLATED BY AN
AGENCY OR MUNICIPALITY- MAKES
NO SENSE TO ME AND I WOULD ASK
TO- SAY NO TO THIS BILL AND
THEN REPEAT THE PROCESS AND
WHAT WE'RE DOING. AND THEN MOVE
FORWARD- THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR BORCHERS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT-
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR PLEASE
WOULD YOU ACCEPT A QUESTION
FROM SENATOR BORCHERT'S YES.
CENTER BORDERS PLEASE PROCEED
WHAT IS THE EXISTING
ADMINISTRATIVE- PRACTICE FOR-
BARGAINING UNIT TO. WORK WITH A
PUBLIC ENTITY TO GET THE
INFORMATION THAT THIS BILL
ADDRESSES NAMELY. NEW
EMPLOYEES. WHAT IS THE EXISTING
REMEDY ADMINISTRATIVE REMEDY.
THAT EXIST GET THAT INFORMATION
AND IF IT DOESN'T HAPPEN. WHAT
OCCURRED RIGHT NOW. THE FILE A
CHARGE WITH HERB. AND THEN A
GOES THROUGH WHATEVER THE PER
PROCESSES. SO THE LABOR BOARD
WILL WERE STILL RECEIVE THE
CHARGE YES WHAT THIS DOES IS IT
ADDS DOLLAR AMOUNT TO THAT. YES
AND THE BRING IT BRINGS
ATTENTION BECAUSE IT WILL BE
SPECIFICALLY OUTLINED THAT
THERE'S A PROCESS FOR THEM.
HERB TO REACH OUT TO THAT
ENTITY TO THAT JURISDICTION AND
SAY WHAT'S GOING ON HERE YOU'VE
GOT TO FIX THIS PROBLEM GOT IT
I THINK ON ITS FACE YOU KNOW I
THINK THERE'S HAVING
ENFORCEMENT. IN CERTAIN
SITUATIONS CAN SENATE WHAT I'VE
NOTICED HELLO. IS THAT PER
CHARGES. AND PENALTIES THAT ARE
ATTACHED MAYBE NOT COLLECTED.
BUT SUED AND EVEN ARE
ADJUDICATED IN FAVOR OF ONE
PARTY ARGUES LARGELY FOR PR-PURPOSES AND TO INCREASE
LEVERAGING POWER NGUYEN
RENEGOTIATION OCCURS DURING THE
CYCLE FOR EXAMPLE IF SOMEONE IS
A DAY OR TWO LATE CHARGES ARE
FILED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ARE LEVIED REGARDLESS IF IT
GOES BACK TO THE STATE OR- THAT
SOMEWHERE ALONG THE LINE.
FATHER'S LITERATURE THEY GETS
ELATED POSITION PIECES THAT GET
CIRCULATED THAT SAY- COUNTY TAX
FOR STATE EX HAS FAILED IT'S-
WORKING POPULATION BECAUSE-
THEY'RE VIOLATING ALL THESE
LABOR RULES SO WE CREATES THIS
IN INFLAMMATORY ENVIRONMENT.
THAT GIVES THE WRONG IMPRESSION
TO PEOPLE THAT REALIZE CITY
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN FIND NUMBER
DOLLAR FAILING TO ABIDE BY
LABOR PRACTICES SO I'M IF WE
ALREADY KNOW THE MONEY'S GOING
BACK INTO THE SYSTEM WE ALREADY
KNOW THERE'S ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES IN PLACE THAT
PROVIDE THAT CHECK. I'M CURIOUS
THIS HAS MORE OF A P. R.
COMPONENT IN A REAL FORCE
COMPONENT. THE YOU SENATOR
BORJA NOW SENATOR MULLIN AND
GROWS. IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
SENATOR GROSS DESK CENTER
MELENDEZ THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THE-
AUTHORS AT THE MIKE FRIENDS I
CAN GO OVER THERE I JUST. JUST
A FOLLOW UP QUESTION SO THE
MONEY THAT IS RETURNED TO THE
GENERAL FUND OF HERB. IS THAT-
MINUS ATTORNEY'S FEES. LABOR
HERE. I'M SORRY QUESTION WE ARE
VERY GOOD WOULD YOU ACCEPT THE
QUESTION YES THANK YOU THIRTEEN
DO YOU HAVE A QUESTION A MIND.
COULD YOU REPEAT THE QUESTION
SIR WANT TO SHARE OF THE MONEY
THAT GAME WHEN THE AGENCY OR
ORGANIZATION IS FINDING THAT
MONEY GOES BACK TO- IS AWARDED
TO THE GENERAL FUND. IT'S THAT
MINUS ATTORNEY'S FEES. SHE
ANSWERED. PLEASE PROCEED THE
ATTORNEYS FEES ARE NOT AN
AUTOMATIC PART OF WHATEVER THE
DECISION THE ATTORNEYS FEES IS
ONLY IN THE VERY LAST PART OF
THE PROCESS- IF THERE IS A- AN
APPEAL FROM THE CURB DECISION
TO AN ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE
THAT'S THE ONLY TIME IN THE
WHOLE PROCESS THAT ATTORNEYS
FEES COULD BE CONSIDERED AND
THAT'S ONLY AT THE END OF YOUR
THE PREVAILING PARTY THAT COULD
APPLY TO THE UNION AS JUST A
COULD APPLY. TO THE EMPLOYER.
WE JUST. PERHAPS YOUR CLOTHES
YOU CAN RESPOND. ALL RIGHT I DO
WE ANY OTHER DEBATE DISK.
SITTING IN HEARING NONE THAT
THE SENATE TO RUSH SO YOU MAY
CLOSE. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I THINK THIS IS A VERY SIMPLE
BALL THAT WE HAVE SAID IS THAT
JURISDICTION'S PAY MORE
ATTENTION TO THE LAW THAT
CURRENTLY EXIST. THAT'S IT OF
WHO TRIED TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
IS NOT GONNA HURT THE
JURISDICTIONS IT'S GOING TO GET
THEIR ATTENTION. CURRENTLY IS
ANYWHERE I THINK THEY WERE UP
TO SEE THE ENTITIES THAT HAD
NOT RESPONDED- SO THAT'S ALL WE
WANT TO DO IT VERY WELL AND I
YOUR- ALL PAID HAVING SEE.
MADAM PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES. TELL FIVE FOR JUST THE
NO BRADFORD. I HAVE I ADAM.
CHIANG NO NO DALLY. NO DODD.
THERE ARE SO. I GALGIANI.
GLAZER NO GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG HI HILL NO WAY SO. HI
TADA TADA. NO JACKSON I JONES
NO NO LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I
MELENDEZ NO MITCHELL I MONNNG.
I MORE LOG NO MORALE. NO
NIELSEN NO NO HAN I PORTANTINO
I ROTH. I REVIEW. SKINNER I
STERN HI NUMBER. WHITE HOUSE
SKI I WIENER I WILK NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THERE
IS ALLEN. BATES NO CABALLERO.
DODD GALGIANI. RUBIO I'M BURKE
FIVE LOCALIZED TWENTY ONE THAT
KNOWS FOURTEEN THE MEASURE
PASSED. MOVING ALONG COLLEAGUES
SO WE HAVE NOW COMPLETED FIVE
MEASURES OF WE HAVE FORTY FIVE
TO GO PLUS EIGHTEEN- BILLS AND
BUDGET BILL THE NEXT FIVE ITEMS
ARE FILE ITEMS. THIRTY THIRTY
ONE THIRTY TWO THIRTY THREE AND
THIRTY FOUR. SENATOR ROSS SO
EUROPE NOW WITH FILE ITEM
THIRTY. BEN CHECK JERRY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL ELEVEN NINETY
BY SENATOR DORADO AN ACT
RELATING TO TENNESSEE SENATOR
TO RUSSELL. COLLEAGUES GIVEN
THE ECONOMIC HARDSHIPS CAUSED
BY THE CLOVER NINETEEN CRISIS
THE STATE THE STATE IS FOCUSING
WE'RE TRYING TO FOCUS VERY MUCH
ON KEEPING CALIFORNIANS IN
THEIR HOMES. WHETHER TO OUR PRO
TEM'S HOUSING PRODUCTION
WORKING GROUP OR OTHER WAYS IN
WHICH WE ARE LOOKING AT ALL THE
OUT TO ADDRESS THE HOUSE. BILL
IS BI WHEN CLOSEST TO OF TENANT
STABILIZATION SPECIALLY NEEDED
IN THIS CRISIS. FIRST KEVIN
STABILIZATION PROVISIONS FOR
TENANTS EXPERIENCING THE MOST
VULNERABLE CIRCLE AND THAT IS.
BEING A VICTIM OF A VIOLENT
CRIME. UNFORTUNATELY WE KNOW
THAT NOT EVERY HOME IS SAFE.
THE WORLD HAS SEEN HOW THE
COLBERT NINETEEN SHELTER IN
PLACE PROTECTIONS HAVE LED TO
AN INCREASE IN INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE VICTIMS BY LIVE WITH
OR NEAR THEIR PERPETRATORS.
CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW INSURERS
THAT VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND FAMILY MAY
ELEVENTH. IN THE HOUSEHOLD CAN
TERMINATE A LEASE WITHOUT
PENALTY FOLLOWING THE
VICTIMIZATION. MY BILL WOULD
INCLUDE VICTIMS OF OTHER
VIOLENT CRIMES LIKE GUN
VIOLENCE ARMED HOME INVASION OR
CALL VICTIMS OF HOMICIDE. THE
VICTIMS OF VIOLENT CRIMES AND
THEIR FAMILY HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS
WOULD THEN BE ABLE TO TERMINATE
THE LEASE WITHOUT PENALTY. THIS
BILL ARE EXTENDS THE PROVISIONS
TO MEET ITALIAN FAMILY MEMBERS
OUTSIDE OF THE HOUSEHOLD. I%
WANT TO BE CLEAR THIS TEN AND
STABILIZATION PROVISION HAS AN
EXISTING RIGOROUS CERTIFICATION
AND DOCUMENTATION PROJECT UP
PROCESS. ARE YOU DO TO SUPPORT
OUR OWN BACK OUT OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFE IN JUST
AS A WORKED VERY VERY HARD TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT AND RESOURCES
FOR VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS. WELL
BEFORE AND AFTER HELLO BUT
NINETEEN. HIGHER DUE TO SUPPORT
THE HOW THE SECURITY OF TENANTS
EXPERIENCING THE MOST
VULNERABLE CIRCUMSTANCES.
SECOND I AM PROPOSING LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT OF TENANTS
STABILIZATION PROVISIONS I WANT
TO NOTE THAT IN THIS BILL LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT IS PERMISSIVE NOT
MANDATORY. LAST YEAR OF E
APPROVED AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
WHICHCODIFIED JUST BECAUSE
PROVISIONS AND RENT CAPS
HOWEVER AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
HAS LIMITED ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISMS TENANTS MUST TAKE
THEIR CASES TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. AND THERE HAS BEEN
LITTLE GUIDANCE IN THIS
PROCESS. OUR BILL WOULD ALLOW
ENFORCEMENT BY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THAT THIS MEANS THAT THE CITY
ATTORNEY- DISTRICT ATTORNEY OR
COUNTY COUNCIL CAN ENFORCE THE
TENANT PROTECTIONS. THE
MAJORITY OF THE LEGISLATURE
VOTED FOR AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO IT IS THE LAW WE SIMPLY
WANT TO MAKE IT ACCESSIBLE TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS. AS GEN I'M
FLOOR THE HOUSE PRICES ONLY
GOTTEN WORSE SINCE LAST YEAR
THE REASON HOMELESS COUNT ON
THAT THEIR SIXTY SIX BY. MILES
INDIVIDUALS A COW. NO THAT
HOMELESSNESS IS A SPARE HIS
HEART AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
FOR THIS HOMELESS COUNT TOOK
PLACE BEFORE KOBE NINETEEN AND
THERE ARE CONCERNS THAT MORE
PEOPLE HAVE FALLEN TO
HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE OF LOSING
THEIR JOB AND NOT BEING ABLE TO
PAY THE RENT. EVEN WITH THE
EXISTING STATEWIDE EMERGENCY
MEASURES LOW INCOME TENANTS ARE
STILL AT RISK FOR ILLEGAL
EVICTIONS. A RECENT LA TIMES
ARTICLE SHOWED THAT THE LA
POLICE RESPONDED TO MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED NINETY INSTANCE. A
POTENTIAL ILLEGAL LOCKED OUT
AND UTILITY SHOT OF ACROSS THE
CITY. THE LARGEST SHARE OF
THOSE CALLS WERE PREDOMINANTLY
LOW INCOME WORKING POOR LOS
ANGELES. I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT KEEPING PEOPLE IN THEIR
HOMES AND PREVENTING EVICTIONS
WILL PREVENT TENANTS FROM
BECOMING HOMELESS. TENANT
STABILIZATION MUST BE A
PRIORITY OF OUR STATE. I KNOW
THAT SOME COLLEAGUES HAVE
RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT THE FINES
IN THE LOCAL ENFORCEMENT
PROVISIONS I WANT TO MAKE A
COMMITMENT THAT I WILL WORK TO
TAKE OUT THE FINES IN THE NEXT
HOUSE- AND I HAVE LEDGE COUNCIL
LANGUAGE TO THAT OF. OUR STATE
THE OPPORTUNITY BRING SB ELEVEN
NIGHT BEFORE YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
ALSO DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I'M SORRY EXCUSE ME
EXCUSE ME- CENTER BOARD JUST
SHOWING I'M SORRY I MISSED
MICROPHONE. IS AGAIN STILL
POSSIBLE OR NO IT IS POSSIBLE
IN THIS A MOMENT HERE- CENTER
BOARD JUST BEFORE WE GO AHEAD
AND TAKE THE VOTE- THE FLOOR
SURE SURE. THE MAN PRESENT
APOLOGIZE THAT WAS A TACTICAL
SHOWS CONSULTING WITH THE
SERGEANTS- QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR IF I MAY THROUGH THE
CHAIR WOULD YOU ACCEPT THE
QUESTION SENATOR ALSO. COULD I
ANSWER AT THE END. IF THAT'S
CAN I ANSWER THE AND CERTAINLY
BUT THE QUESTION FROM CENTER
BORCHERS AND YOU CAN ANSWERED
IN YOUR CLOSE. THEIR BORDERS.
WE'LL DEALT WITH THIS IN JUNE.
THERE WERE A COUPLE ISSUES AND
FORGIVE ME I JUST WANT TO KIND
OF REFRESH AND MAKE CERTAIN
THAT. I UNDERSTAND. THE FIRST
WAS A SELF ATTESTATION THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS A TESTING THAT A
CRIME HAD OCCURRED. AND THERE'S
ANOTHER IF I RECALL CORRECTLY
THAT THERE HAD TO HAVE BEEN A
LAW ENFORCEMENT- OUR RECORD.
AND I WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT.
THAT WAS ALL ST STILL ALSO
INCLUDED IN THE LATEST VERSION
OF THIS AND- I THINK THE LAST
POINT WAS. THE CAN YOU IMAGINE
EXAMPLES WHERE THIS COULD BE
MISS YEARS MEANING THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL JUST USES THIS TO
GET OUT OF A LEASE AND TO THE
DETRIMENT OF- A CONTRACTUAL
OBLIGATION. VERY GOOD- ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS ARE DEBATING
IN HEARING ON CHARTER DORADO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO ANSWER THAT IN
YOUR CLOTHES THANK YOU FOR
SURE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AT
YES WITH REGARDS TO THERE IS A
RIGOROUS- ARE RULES ABOUT-
HAVING A THIRD PARTY OF VERIFY
THAT THE CRIME WAS COMMITTED SO
EITHER LAW ENFORCEMENT- A
SOCIAL WORKER THAT IS INVOLVED
IN IN THE- WITH THE FAMILY OR
WHAT THEIR INDIVIDUAL WITH THE
BIG DOWN THE MOST AT THIRD
PARTY. OF VERIFICATION ALONG
WITH A STATEMENT FROM THE
ATTENDANT TO WHAT TOOK PLACE
AND WHAT IS THE RELATIONSHIP ON
BECAUSE OF TWO POINT DOESN'T
FAIL THAT JUST SAYS A CRANK UP
WITH IT AND SO IT'S A
COMBINATION OF BOTH THE TENANT
AS WELL AS THE THIRD PARTY
VERIFICATION. THAT PROVIDED I'M
SORRY I. DIDN'T WRITE DOWN THE
SECOND WHAT WAS THE SECOND ONE.
WELL FIVE SO PEOPLE COULD AVOID
THE CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATION OF
THE RENTAL AGREEMENT THANK YOU
AND I'D LIKE TO REMIND EVERYONE
PLEASE TALK INTO THE MICROPHONE
WITH THE WE'RE HAVING SOME
DIFFICULTY- AND I'M SURE ANYONE
LISTENING IS PROBABLY HAVING
SOME DIFFICULTY OUTSIDE THE
CHAMBER SO PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
SPEAK RIGHT INTO THE MICROPHONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU THE A YOU
KNOW CAN I GUARANTEE THAT A
100% OF EVERYBODY IS GONNA USE
THIS FOR THE RIGHT REASONS I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY COULD WITH
ANY LAW. BUT I MUST SAY IN THIS
TIME OF HOUSING I CAN IMAGINE
THAT IT'S EASY TO JUST GET UP
AND GO AND FIGHT WE HAVE TO PUT
SIX THIRTY IN THE POP THAT IN.
UP TO THE LAN I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE JUST GEN
AND THE LOW FOR ANY TO THIS IS
FROM IT'S VERY TRAUMATIC FOR A
MEMBER OF YOUR FAMILY- TO BE
THE VICTIM OF A CRIME OR FOR
YOU TO BE ACROSS OF A CRIME YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A BILL TO BE ABLE
TO LEAVE BECAUSE IT BE THE H.
FURTHER. AS THEY WANTED TO CARE
OF YOUR FAMILY. SO A LOT. I
CAN'T AND- THAT SOME WOULD DO
THIS LIST IN IN A VERY
FRIVOLOUS WAY. SO WITH THAT.
WAS THAT YOUR CLOTHES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. BY THE VERY GOOD WITH
THAT A DEBATE HAVING SEIZED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SHE WITH ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. ATKINS I BATES WHO
KNOW BELL I FOR JUST. BRADFORD
I CABALLERO. CHIANG VALLEY. NO
DODD I THERE ARE SO. I GALGIANI.
GLAZER GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG. I HILL. WITH SO ONE
OF THE- TADO. JACKSON HI I
JONES. NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL. AYE
MONNING AYE MORLOCK NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN. NO PAN. PORTANTINO
ROTH. RUBIO SKINNER FIVE STERN
I AM BURKE. WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WIENER I WILK NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA
FOR AGES. CUT BY ADAM. CHIANG
NO GALGIANI. GLAZER HILL. HUESO
TADO. PAN PORTANTINO. ROTH
RUBIO. AMBERG SENATOR DORADO
MOVES A CALL MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY ONE CENTER DORADO.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR DORADO AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT SENATOR
RUSSELL THE FLOOR'S YOURS.
THANK YOU MAY CHAIR. I THINK
I'M GONNA PUT A DESK HERE OKAY.
CURRENTLY COLLEAGUES DOMESTIC
WORKERS ARE EXCLUDED FROM BASIC
HEALTH AS A SAFETY PROTECTIONS
AFFORDED ALMOST ALL OTHER
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA SB TWELVE
FIFTY SEVEN REMOVES THAT
DISCRIMINATORY EXCLUSION.
ADDRESSING THIS EXCLUDES IS
PART OF A DRESS IN A LONG
HISTORY OF EXCLUSION OF
DOMESTIC WORKERS FROM BASIC
LABOR PROTECTIONS AND IT IS A
PART OF OUR COUNTRY'S HISTORY.
THIS IS A- IN THE NINETEEN
THIRTIES WHEN DOMESTIC. SLAVES
WILL BE PERFORMED PRIMARILY BY
AFRICAN AMERICANS WE EXCLUDED
THIS WORK FROM THE BASIC
WORKPLACE SAFETY PROTECTIONS
ESTABLISHED FOR OTHER WORKERS
AND THAT EXCLUSION HAS
CONTINUED TO THIS DAY. THE
CURRENT OVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC
AND CALIFORNIA'S DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES HAVE MAGNIFIED THE
VULNERABILITY THAT HOUSEHOLD
DOMESTIC WORKERS FACE ON A
DAILY BASIS BECAUSE THEY ARE
EXCLUDED FROM CAL OSHA. THE
WORKERS WERE PRIMARILY
IMMIGRANT WOMEN ARE ESSENTIAL
TO THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AND
TO THE ABILITY OF US AS
CALIFORNIANS TO LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY. AND THEY DESERVE
DIGNITY AND PROTECTIONS JUST
LIKE OTHER WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN. IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE THE BILL WAS AMENDED
TO ALLOW CAL OSHA TO CREATE AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR INDUSTRY
SPECIFIC REGULATORY GUIDANCE TO
HELP IMPLEMENT THIS BILL. JUST
AS THE RELEVANCE SAFETY ITEMS
PROTECT THE WORKERS IN THE
LABORATORY OR DRY CLEANERS A
SAW MILL IS DIFFERENT SO TOO
WILL THERE BE YOUR
CIRCUMSTANCES THIS INDUSTRY.
ADVISE FOR BY THIS BILL
COMPRISED OF EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES WILL BE TASKED WITH
MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT
THE TYPE OF CARD IS NEEDED FOR
THIS TYPE OF WORK PLEASE. I
KNOW- SEVERAL OF YOU HAVE
RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT EMPLOYER
PRIVACY AND PLEASE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE DUE DUE PROCESS
SAFEGUARDS WITHIN THE BILL. THE
BALANCE THE NEED FOR PRIVACY
WITH COMPLIANCE THE BILL WILL
ONLY. ALLOW FOR ON SITE
INSPECTION IF THE EMPLOYER DOES
NOT ABATE ANY HAZARD CONDITIONS
AFTER BEING CONTACTED BY PHONE
BY LETTER BY OSHA. EVEN AFTER
THAT THE EMPLOYEE. THE GREAT
PERMISSION FOR AN- AND THE
PREMISES FOR THE AGENCY HAS TO
SEEK A COURT ORDER BEFORE
ONSITE INSPECTIONS CAN OCCUR.
MOST WORKPLACE SAFETY CONCERNS
WILL BE ADDRESSED LONG BEFORE
GETTING TO THAT POINT.
COLLEAGUES THE POINT OF THIS IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT BOTH OF.
THOSE WORKPLACES THOSE HOMES
HAVE THE BASIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY ARE. STANDARDS FOR THOSE
DOMESTIC WORKERS IN RECENT
YEARS DOMESTIC WORKERS HAVE
SECURED MINIMUM WAGE OVERTIME
AND WORKERS COMPENSATION
PROTECTIONSNOW WOULD BELIEVE
THEY NEED THEY ARE ASKING THAT
THEY BE TREATED ARE GIVEN THE
DIGNITY OF BASIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROTECTIONS. ONE END BY
SAYING THERE IS NO OPPOSITION
RECORDED ON THIS BILL I ASK FOR
YOUR ARRIVAL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION WE WILL
START WITH SENATORS WIENER. LET
OF A AND CAME. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT BECAUSE I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
FIFTY SEVEN. AS THE TALK OF THE
SEVEN SIX TO RIGHT THE WRONGS
OF HISTORY OF EXCLUSION OF THE
MEXICAN IMMIGRANT WORKERS FROM
BASIC LABOR PROTECTIONS. IT'S
EXCLUSION IS ROOTED IN THE
RACIST OPPRESSION OF BLACK
DOMESTIC WORKERS. AND THE
LEGACY OF SLAVERY ONE BLACK
WORKERS PARTICULARLY DOMESTIC
WORKERS AND FARMWORKERS WERE
FIRST EXCLUDED FROM BASIC LABOR
PROTECTIONS IN THE NINETEEN
THIRTIES. HOUSEHOLD WORKERS
CHILD CARE WORKERS HEALTH
KEEPERS HOME CARE WORKERS DAY
LABOR IS LIKE GARDENERS ARE THE
ONLY GROUP WORKERS. OR EXCLUDE.
ON THE CAL OSHA. DOMESTIC
WORKERS ARE AT THE FOR. OF THE
CURVE IN NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
THEY WORK WITH OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS LIKE THE
ELDERLY AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
IMMUNO OMPROMISED. HOWEVER
MANY DOMESTC WORKERS ARE ALSO
VULNERABLE WORKING WITHOUT
HEALTH AND SAFETY PROTECTIONS
FOR LONG HOURS AND FOR VERY LOW
WAGES MANY LACK ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE AND PAID SICK DAYS.
THAT MIGHT ENABLE THEM TO TAKE
CARE OF THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES DURING THIS HEALTH
CRISIS. DURING THIS TERRIBLE
TIME DOMESTIC WRKERS OFTEN
HAVE TO MAKE IMPOSSIBLE CHOICE
BETWEEN WORKING IN UNSAFE
CONDITIONS. OR GOING WITHOUT
ANY INCOME. IN A TIME OF A
DANGEROUS GLOBAL PANDEMIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY PROTECTIONS
ARE A MATTER OF LIFE AND DEATH
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO
JUSTIFICATION. TO CONTINUE
EXCLUDING HOUSEHOLD DOMESTIC
SERVICE EMPLOYEES FROM BASIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY EXACT-
PROTECTIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR WINNERS- LEYVA THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS I RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN WHICH WILL HELP PROTECT
THE OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOMESTIC WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
THE PROVIDE CARE AND SUPPORT TO
HELP HOLD ACROSS OUR STATE. AS
YOU MAY REMEMBER IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN I AUTHORED AND
THEN GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED SB
TEN FIFTEEN ALSO KNOWN AS A
DOMESTIC FOR DOMESTIC WORKER
BILL OF RIGHTS WHICH
PERMANENTLY PRESERVED OVERTIME
PROTECTIONS FOR CALIFORNIA
PRIVATELY HIRED DOMESTIC
WORKERS. SEN THE SENATE STOOD
THEN AND I HOPE WILL STAND
AGAIN TODAY WITH THESE AMAZING
WORKERS PRIMARILY IMMIGRANT
WOMEN. 98% SO THATTHEY CAN
WORK WITH DIGNITY RESPECT AND
THE SAFETY THAT THEY DESERVE
DOMESTIC WORKERS JUST LIKE ANY
OTHER WORKER IN OUR STATE
SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO FILE A
COMPLAINT IF NEEDED. ABOUT IT
WORKLACE HEALTH OR SAFETY
HAZARD WITH CAL OSHA AFTER ALL
THEY SHOULD KNOW THAT WHEN THEY
GO TO WORK THEY WILL NOT HAVE
TO DEAL WITH ABUSE OR
HARASSMENT AS WELL AS ANY
SUBSTANCES OR CHEMICALS THAT
MIGHT HURT THEM. YES THE
REQUESTED WORK IS UNIQUE IN
THAT WORKERS COME INTO PEOPLE'S
HOMES TO PROVIDE CARE AND
SUPPORT FOR ALL FAMILIES AND
THEIR HOUSEHOLDS. BUT JUST
BECAUSE DOMESTIC WORKERS
PERFORM UNIQUE WORK DOES NOT IN
ANY WAY MEAN THAT THEY SHOULD
BE EXCLUDED FROM BASIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY PROTECTIONS. EVEN
NOW DURING COVERED NINETEEN
DOMESTIC WORKERS ARE DOING
FRONTLIE WORK THAT IF ANYTHING
MAKES IT EVEN MORE CRITICAL
THAT THESE THEY HAVE THESE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS. DOMESTIC
WORKERS EVER HAVE TO RISK THEIR
HEALTH AND SAFETY JUST SO THEY
CAN HELP PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES. SO MEMBERS LUCY AND
RICKY'S HARD WORK PERFORMANCE
TODAY BY IN THIS STORE COAX OF
DOMESTIC WORKERS. AND AS THE
DAYS. THANK YOU. YOU SHOULD
LEAHY CENTER. THANK BETTER
PRESIDENT SENT. TO HI EIGHTY
CERTAINLY THE BILL AND THE AT I
DO HAVE A QUESTION FOR YA AND-
SHE WILLIAMS WOULD YOU ACCEPT
THE QUESTION SENATOR DRAWS. YES
MA'AM. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR- I KNOW WE HAD SOME
THAT EXCELLENT CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THE BILL I THINK THE-
PART AND I KNOW YOU TOUCHED ON
IN YOUR REMARKS BY JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY. IS THAT THE CERTAINLY
I AGREE WITH YOU THAT DOMESTIC
WORKERS DESERVE TO HAVE A
HEALTHY AND SAFE WORK
ENVIRONMENT- AND THAT ANY LACK
OF HEALTH OR SAFETY NETWORK
ENVIRONMENT NOT ONLY OF COURSE-
IS NOT GOOD FOR THE WORKER- IT
ALSO ISN'T THAT PROBABLY ISN'T
A GOOD FOR THE PERSON IS LIVING
IN THAT HOME BUT IT IS A
PERSON'S PERSONAL RESIDENCE AND
SO THERE MIGHT. BE NEED TO BE
SOME SENSITIVITY ABOUT THAT- SO
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS THAT YEAH
AND I KNOW YOU REFERRED TO
SOMETHING'S BUT ARE YOU
COMMITTED TO DO PERHAPS IN THE
ASSEMBLY THINKING ABOUT ADDING
SOME WEIGHING JUST. PRICE OF
THE ATHEA EMPLOYER IT'S A
PERSONAL RESIDENCE SO THAT-
OUTSIDE OF ANY HEALTH OR SAFETY
INSPECTION BECAUSE THEY'RE AND
SOMEONE'S PERSONAL HOME THAT
THERE'S A DUTY OF PRIVACY TO IN
TERMS OF ANYTHING ELSE THAT THE
INSPECTOR MIGHT SEE THEM YOU
KNOW MAY HURT THEIR REPUTATION
OR OTHER TYPES OF THINGS AS
WELL SO I JUST WHY SURE THAT-
WE A BE A SITUATION WHERE
PEOPLE FEAR AN INSPECTOR COMING
TO THE HOME NOT BE HEALTH OR
SAFETY ISSUE BECAUSE OF OTHER
PRIVACY ISSUES AND SURE
PEOPLE'S PRIVACY. RESIDENTS
HE'S DORADO YOU LIKE TO RESPOND
YES ON CENTER I WILL ABSOLUTELY
COMMIT TO THAT- IT IS NOT OUR
INTENTION TO CONFUSE THE LINES
BETWEEN THE PRIVACY OF THE
HOME. AND THE HOME AS THE
WORKPLACE THE PART OF IT THAT'S
A WORKPLACE SO I ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH YOU
AND STRENGTHENING OR CLARIFYING
THAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND-
WITH THAT I WAS CERTAINLY URGE
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR PAN ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SENATOR GROW. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND I'D APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR WOULD ADDRESSES AS A
QUESTION OR JUST RESPOND IN HER
CLOTHES. I AM CONCERNED THAT A
LOT OF THESE DOMESTIC WORKERS
TO WORK IN PRIVATE RESIDENCE.
AND IF OSHA IS NOT ALLOWED TO
ENTER THESE PRIVATE RESIDENCES
IN THE GO GET A COURT ORDER. I
DON'T KNOW I'M THINKING ABOUT
THE FOURTH AMENDMENT I'M
THINKING ABOUT- JUST PRIVATE
RESIDENTS PROP YOU KNOW
PROPERTY RIGHTS AND PRIVATE
RESIDENCE RATES AND I REALIZE
AGAIN THAT WE HAVE TO DO WHAT
WE CAN TO PROTECT THE DOMESTIC
WORKER. AND THERE ARE ABUSES
OUT THERE BUT I JUST THINK THAT
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU START MESSING
WITH SOMEONE'S PRIVATE
RESIDENCE AND THEIR PRIVATE
HOME. THERE'S GOING TO BE A
HUGE ISSUE PERTAINING TO THAT
SO I WOULD ASK AGAIN. FOR BILLS
TO BE THOUGHTFULLY CONSIDERED
BEFORE THE MOVE FORWARD SO
THAT- IT CAN BE THE RIGHT WAY
INSTEAD OF PUTTING A LOT OF OUR
HOMEOWNERS. IN A POSITION WHERE.
YOU KNOW THESE. I'VE SEEN
THINGS LIKE THAT YOU KNOW FOR
BUSINESSES THAT THEY DO SEE
SINCE DISORDERS THAT THEY STOP
PEOPLE FROM OPERATING THEIR
BUSINESS I MEAN IS GONNA FOLLOW
TRUE AND SET PRECEDENTS. FOR
HOMEOWNERS WE NOT BE ALLOWED TO
LIVE THERE AND I KNOW THAT
SEEMS FAR FETCHED BUT- YOU IN
THE BUSINESS WORLD IF THEY
DON'T. COMPLY WITH OSHA THEY
GET A COURT ORDER THE AFTER THE
SEASON'S ASSESS THEY STOP THE
BUSINESS FROM OPERATING PEOPLE
LOSE THEIR JOBS. SO WHAT
HAPPENS IN A HOME SETTING IS A
GOING TO FOLLOW THE SAME PACE.
AS THE PRIVATE BUSINESS SECTOR
OR IS IT GOING TO BE HANDLED
DIFFERENTLY. AND I THINK A
TOUCHY SUBJECT SITUATION THAT
WE HAVE YEARS OF THESE ARE
PRIVATE HOMES THAT. CAL OSHA
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS WILL BE ENTERING SO-
I WOULD REQUEST A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SENATOR
HERTZBERG. YEAH I JUST WANT TO
JOIN IN ON THE- THOUGHT OF THE
SENATOR FROM SACRAMENTO. WITH
RESPECT TO THE CONCERN HERE WE
WRITE THE LAW WE IMPOSE THE
GOVERNMENT'S ABILITY TO FIND
PEOPLE TO TAKE AWAY THEIR
LIBERTY AND WE HAVE TO EXERCISE
THAT IN THE MOST ELEGANT AND
APPROPRIATE WAY. THE GREATEST
CHALLENGES AREN'T THOSE WITH
THE BLINDS OF BRIGHT. THE
GREATEST CHALLENGES OF THOSE
WITH THERE'S DEEPLY CONFLICTING
INTERESTS. PRIVACY AND WHAT
HAPPENS IN YOUR HOME AS WE HAVE
LOOKED AT THROUGHOUT THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY IS
SACROSANCT. THAT MUST BE
BALANCED BY. THE OTHER
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT WE'VE
BEEN ARTICULATED HERE ON THE
FLOOR TODAY. BUT IF YOU HAVE A
FAMILY WHO BRING SOMEBODY IN TO
HELP OUT THE CLEANED OUT
BECAUSE SOMEONE MIGHT HAVE BEEN
ILL OR SOMETHING. AND THEY'RE
USING A DETERGENT THAT THEY
MIGHT NOT HAVE THE ABILITY TO
FORD BECAUSE THEY'RE SAVING
MONEY FOR THEIR KIDS TO BUY A
NEW PRESIDENT OR TO PAY FOR A
KANSEN NEO OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT. BUT WHATEVER THE CASE MAY
BE OR YOU DON'T HAVE THE MONEY
TO PUT A NEW STAIR RAIL ON
SOMETHING THAT MIGHT BILL
RICKETY BUT YOU BEEN WORKING AT
YOUR HOUSE FOR TWENTY YEARS AND
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO NAVIGATE IT.
IT'S A CHALLENGE. AND SALAS
SAYS I WILL VOTE FOR THIS BILL
TODAY. BUT I AM DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT. THE ABILITY TO
DRAFT THIS IN A WAY. THAT
BALANCES THESE CRITICAL
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE. IT IS
EASY TO FIND THE EXAMPLE. BUT
IT IS ALWAYS THE EXAMPLE THAT
FOLKS THAT AFFECTS PEOPLE EVERY
DAY WHERE SOMEBODY COMES IN.
AND THEY'RE TRYING TO DO THE
RIGHT THING. SOMEBODY COMES
ALONG THEY GOT A BEEF. THEY'RE
CALLING OSHA. WE GOT TO FIGURE
THAT OUT SO I'M JUST GOING TO
SAY IS I WILL VOTE FOR IT
BECAUSE I THINK THE CAUSES
RIGHT. BUT I THINK IT REQUIRES
DEEP. HOMEWORK IN DRAFTING THIS
IN A WAY WHERE WE DO NOT STEP
ON THE RIGHTS OF PEOPLE IN
THEIR HOMES. WELL WE STILL
PROTECT FOLKS THAT COME INTO
THOSE HOMES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MAN. THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SENATOR DOLLINGER.
THANK YOU I JUST CAN YOU CAN
ASISTIR BECAUSE THIS WITH THIS
INCLUDE IN HOME SUPPORT OF
WORKERS. RIGHT THAT TO IT THAT
IS A QUESTION WOULD YOU LIKE TO
HAVE THE SENATOR ANSWERED IN
HER CLOTHES VERY GOOD. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. FIGHTING IN
HEARING NONE CENTER DORADO YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU. I
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN PRESENTED BY MY COLLEAGUES
AND I SUPPORT THE ISSUES THAT
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE PRESENTED. I
JUST WANT TO REMIND US THAT
THIS ISN'T A ONE BY ONE IT IS A
ONE BY ONE CASES ARE WHERE
PEOPLE LIVE BUT IT'S REALLY A
WHOLE INDUSTRY. LET'S NOT
FORGET IT'S AN INDUSTRY WHERE
IT IS ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY WOMEN.
AND THE WAY THAT WE MIGHT LOOK
AT WOMEN ONE WOMAN IS THE WAY
THAT ALL WOMEN ARE BEING LOOKED
UPON IN THAT INDUSTRY. THEY
NEED PROTECTIONS. BECAUSE THERE
HAVE BEEN CASE AFTER CASE AFTER
CASE IN SITUATION WHERE THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN AFFORDED THE MOST
MINIMAL BASIC HEALTH STANDARDS-
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS AS A
WHOLE INDUSTRY. WE ALSO ARE
VERY CONCERNED AND WE WILL WORK
VERY VERY HARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE PRIVACY OF THE HOME IS
NOT. A CROSSOVER. WE REALLY
THESE WOMEN REALLY MADE TO HEAR
THEIR STORIES. NO MATTER WHAT
PART OF THE STATE THE RENT WE
HEAR THEIR STORIES ABOUT
SITUATION UP TO SITUATION AND
HOW THEY ARE NOT GIVEN THE MOST
MINIMAL BASIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS. WE JUST HAVE TO AS A
STATE. YOU KNOW RESPOND TO THAT
AND DO AND FIX THAT AND HEP TO
FIX THAT. BUT I AM COMMITTED I
COMMITTED TO THE CENTER TO PAN
WE WILL WORK EVEN HARDER TO
CLARIFY. THE THAT RELATIONSHIP-
THAT ADVISORY COMMITTEE WILL BE
MADE UP OF HOMEOWNERS AND
DOMESTIC WORKERS. THEIR GOAL IS
NOT TO. AT VIOLATE PRIVACY
THEIR GOAL IS JUST TO HAVE THE
TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO DO THE WORK
THAT THEY'RE BEING ASKED TO DO
SO WITH THAT COLLEAGUES I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR ROSS FOR ALL DEBATE
HAVING SEIZED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA OR AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES. NO BELL I FORGES NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A- I CHIANG. NO
DALLY NO DODD. THEY'RE AWESOME.
I GALGIANI. GLAZER GONZALEZ I
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG I HELLO.
HUESO I TADO. I JACKSON HI I
JONES. NO LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL FIVE
MONNING I MORE LOOK NO RURAL.
NO NIELSEN NO PAN I PORTANTINO
HI ROSS. I RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN I NUMBER. WHITE HOUSE SKI
I WIENER AYE WILK NOW PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE
MORE TIME. DODD I GALGIANI I
GLAZER. HELLO NUMBER. HI PRICE
TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS ELEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON NOW TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO. SENATOR
MCGUIRE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
TWELVE THE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
AND AFTER LEAVING THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES SENATOR MCGUIRE THANK
YOU SO MUCH A MATTER PRESENT
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS IN THE
MORNING MATTER PRESIDENT SB
THIRTEEN TWELVE TAKES STEPS TO
ENSURE. THAT UTILITY POWER SHUT
OFF OF INSTEAD OF SMALLER
FOOTPRINTS SHORTER DURATIONS IN
PROPER OVERSIGHT IN DOING SO
THIS BILL REQUIRES INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES TO PRIORITIZE
PUBLIC HEALTH PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY AS WELL AS A PULLED THE
BELIEF THAT CALIFORNIA SHOULD
HAVE THE RIGHT TO RELIABLE
ELECTRICAL SERVICE IN THIS DAY
AND AGE LAST YEAR BROUGHT IN ON
PRESIDENT LEVEL POWER SHUT OFF
OF VINCE BY. I USE CUTTING
CALIFORNIANS WONDER IF THE NEW
NORMAL WILL BE LACK OF POWER
FOR DAYS OR EVEN WEEKS ON END.
BEGINNING SEPTEMBER OVER TWO
MILLION RESIDENTS LOST POWER
ACROSS FORTY COUNTIES P. S. P.
S. VINCE OCCURRED WITH SUCH
FREQUENCY THAT THEY'VE LED INTO
EACH OTHER IN FACT. IN MY NECK
OF THE WOODS AT SOME LOST POWER
FOR TOTAL F FOURTEEN DAYS IN A
ONE MONTH PERIOD. CURRENTLY THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION REQUIRES I- USED TO
FILL OUT REPORTS AFTER POWER
SHUT OFF THE VINCE. THESE
REPORTS HOWEVER OFTEN LACKEY
INFORMATION A PROPER OVERVIEW.
MORE OUT OF THE DOZENS REPORTS
FILED LAST FALL THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION CONDUCTED
ONLY ONE OFFICIAL REVIEW. THIS
IS SIMPLY NOT GOOD ENOUGH IN
OUR STATE LACKS A FORMAL
PROCESS FOR FUTURE REVIEWS OF
SHUT OFF ADVANCING CLEARLY. THE
LEVEL OF REVIEW WITHOUT ONE HAS
BEEN INSUFFICIENT AT BEST
HERE'S WHAT THE BILL DE
THIRTEEN TWELVE PROVIDES THE
NECESSARY FRAMEWORK. TO SHORTEN
DECREASE THE FREQUENCY OF POWER
SHUT OFF EVENTS IN THE OLD
EMILY ELIMINATE THEIR USE BY
REQUIRING INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES. TO GO SHORT OR LONG
TERM STEPS TO HARD RIVER
STRUCTURE. NOW IT WOULD ALLOW
THE WHOLE IN STRATEGIC POINTS
IN YEARS FOR IT TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD ESPECIALLY DURING
HIGH FIRED. SEES REDUCE OUR
TARGET POWER SHOPS LAST THIS
BILL MODIFY THE EXISTING UNDER
RUNNING PROGRAM AT THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION TO ALSO
ALLOW CITIES IN HIGH FIRE RISK
HERE IS. TO USE EXISTING CREDIT
FOR RUNNING TO READ TWELVE
VIRUS WHERE PEACEFUL ANY DITCH.
TO A PURPOSE. THE BILL A THE
STATE TERRACE THE FOR CHEESE.
CITIES I WANT THIS MADAM
PRESIDENT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE I. LOSE AND OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS ON THIS
LANGUAGE THIS BILL TO BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS THEIR- WE DID MAKE A
MINI. TO DRAW SEVERAL THEM MOST
NOTABLY SURE THIS BILL ALIGNS
THE RATE OF RETURN. WITH THE
THIS BILL THAT WE ALL ADDRESS
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FIFTY FOUR.
AND YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT IN
THIS IS A COMMIT WE MADE TODAY
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS ON THE BILL. OUR GOAL
OUR GOAL IS NOT TO THROW OUT
THE EXISTING. PEACE PROCESS
SIMPLY TO BE ON. THE BILL ON AN
AREA WE GAP AS FAR. THERE.
TWELVE PROVIDES WORK TO THAT
OUR OF IN. THE TOOL OF LAST
RESORT. NOT THE DEFAULT
STRAIGHT. WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR PRESIDENT. THANK
YOU SENATOR DEBATE TO. WE WILL
START WITH SENATOR AND THEN GO
TO SENATOR HILL SENATOR DODD
FLOORS YOURS YES THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'M
GONNA BE BRIEF I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. TODAY WE'VE I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH A GOOD CENTER FROM
HEALDSBURG ON THESE TYPE ISSUES
WE'VE SEEN WHAT THESE P. S. P.
S. COULD DO TO OUR COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY IN A TOUGH TIME.
OF THE YEAR AND I THINK THIS
BILL GOES VERY VERY FAR INTO
THE PROCESS AND TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THESE P. SBS'S AS
THE CENTER SAID ARE NOT THE
FIRST RESORT BUT THE LAST
RESORT. FRANKLY AFTER I THE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD SENATOR
HILL. UP PLEASE FROM HEALDSBURG
AS WELL FOR HIS GOOD WORK AND
IS REALLY TIRELESS DEDICATION
ON THIS ISSUE- SB THIRTEEN
TWELVE REPRESENTS ONE OF THE
SIGNATURE MEASURES FROM THE-
WILDFIRE WORKING GROUP A GROUP
CONVENE AFTER THE DISASTROUS
PUBLIC POWER SHUT OFF
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCE LAST YEAR
CALIFORNIA HAS CERTAINLY
EXPERIENCED MANY MORE EMERGENCY
SINCE LAST FALL SO WE MIGHT
HAVE FORGOTTEN JUST HOW BAD THE
POWER SHUT OFF WERE ESPECIALLY
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA I HAD
CONSTITUENTS CALLING AFTER
THREE DAYS IN MANY CASES AFTER
ONE DAY ONE IN PARTICULAR
WORRIED PARENTS WERE WORRIED
THAT THEIR SON WOULD BE TRAPPED
UPSTAIRS BECAUSE IS
ELECTRICALLY. POWERED
WHEELCHAIR LIFT BATTERY ONLY
LASTED SEVENTY TWO HOURS AND
THEY HAD NO WHERE TO RECHARGE
IT AND THEN THERE WERE THE
VOLUMES OF LOCAL OFFICIALS AND
BUSINESSES FOOD BANKS AND
RESEARCH LABS ALL IN THE
LITERAL AND FIGURATIVE DARK
ABOUT WHAT WAS GOING ON THE
COMMUNICATION WASN'T THERE THE
PLANNING WASN'T THERE AND TO BE
HONEST THE C. P. UC'S OVERSIGHT
ROLE WASN'T THERE EITHER PRIOR
TO LAST YEAR'S SHUT OFF SEASON
TO SEE IF YOU SHE TOOK AN ARM'S
LENGTH APPROACH TO THESE EVENTS.
THE POST PS PS OFFENSE THAT HAD
OCCURRED. TO TWENTY NINETEEN.
THE CPU SHE HAD REVIEWED ONLY
ONE. AND WE'VE WRITTEN LETTERS
ABOUT THAT TO TRY AND MOVE IT
FORWARD THIS BILL SEEKS TO PUT
THE LESSONS LEARNED FROM LAST
YEAR SHUT OFF TO PRACTICE. IT
DOESN'T ADVOCATE FOR NO SHUT
OFF WE NEED P. S. P. S. IT JUST
PUTS REPORTING REQUIREMENTS IN
PLACE AND HOLDS THE CPUC
ACCOUNTABLE TO DEVELOP A
STANDARD FOR UTILITIES AND
ENSURE THAT THEY INVESTIGATE
ALL SHUT OFF COLLEAGUES. THIS
IS A GREAT BILL IT IS A THE
SOLUTION IS NOT TO LIMIT THE
UTILITIES ABILITY TO DEPLOY PS
PS AS NEEDED BUT TO ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND PRUDENT SEE
IS USED IN THAT DECISION
MAKING. HI ASHLEY RIVAL. THANK
YOU SENATOR HILL ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING AND
HEARING NONE SENATOR MCGUIRE
YOU MAY CLOSE BETTER PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH I JUST WANT
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
SAN MATTEO. AND A GOOD SENATOR
FROM NAPA BUT THEY'VE BEEN
ABSOLUTE PARTNERS IN THIS
LEGISLATION AND THEY HAVE BEEN
HEATERS IN THIS LAW LATER. ON
ALL ISSUES RELATED TO GAS
RELIABILITY AS WELL AS A LETTER
RIGHT RELIABILITY AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE MOVE FORWARD
PRUDENT LEGISLATION ON CONSUMER
SAFETY THANK YOU. ALL THIS
ENDED HERE. BOTTOM LINE IS THIS
IS GOING TO BE A CHALLENGE FOR
THIS STATE FOR YEARS TO COME.
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO TAKE
ACTION TO BE TO KEEP
CALIFORNIANS SAFE INDIA TO KEEP
THE LIGHTS ON THIS IS EXACTLY
WHAT THIS BILL WILL DO WHEN
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AND I'VE-
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES. BELL FIVE FOR JUST.
BRADFORD CABALLERO I CHIANG.
DALY DODD. HI THERE ARE SO. HI
GALGIANI. I GLAZER. I GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. HERTZBERG I HILL AYE
HUESO I TADO I JACKSON AYE
JONES. JONES YEAH. NO LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ. MITCHELL I
MONEY I MORE LOCK MORRELL.
NIELSEN PAN I PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER. I
STERN HI I'M BURKE HI I MY
CASKEY I WIENER. I WILK HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME. BATES FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I CHIANG. DALLY GROWTH.
MELENDEZ MORE LOCK. MORRELL
NIELSEN. MORRELL.
ZERO SENATOR
BURRELL WHO WOULD LIKE WE CAN'T
HEAR APOLOGIES IS THAT ARE YOU
NOT VOTING OR VOTING NO ON THIS.
OKAY THERE WAS A NOTE. MORRELL
NO. PLEASE CONTINUE WITH THE
ROLL CALL WE HAVE WE HAVE
SENATOR MORALE AS A NO. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT NEXT THE
ITEM PLEASE. VICE THIRTY KNOWS
TO THE MEASURE PASSES. IF YOU
WAIT ONE SECOND PLEASE.
MY
COLLEAGUES WE'RE NOT GOING TO
BREAK FOR TWENTY MINUTES FOR
LUNCH IF YOU WOULD GRAB YOUR
LUNCH TAKE IT UP TO YOUR OFFICE
PLEASE EXERCISE SOCIAL
DISTANCING PLEASE KEEP POURING
YOUR MASKS AND THEN WE WILL
RETURN PROMPTLY AT TWELVE.
TWELVE COLLEAGUES WE HAVE DONE
SEVEN BILLS WE HAVE A TOTAL OF
FIFTY PLUS EIGHTEEN- BUDGET
TRAILER BILLS PLUS THE BUDGET.
SB BACK PROMPTLY AT TWELVE
TWELVE.
COLLEAGUES ARE SESSION
WILL COMMENCE IN ONE MINUTE
SENATOR TO RUSSIA WILL BE
PRESENTING HER ITEM. FILE ITEM
THIRTY THREE ALL SENATORS
PLEASE REPORT TO THE SENATE
FLOOR FOURTH WITH.
COLLEAGUES
IF WE COULD PLEASE HAVE
EVERYONE BACK ON THE SENATE
FLOOR WE'VE DONE SEVEN BILLS.
WE HAVE FORTY THREE MORE DID
TWO PLUS THEN EIGHTEEN TRAILER
BILLS AND THE BUDGET BILL. ALL
SENATORS PLEASE FOURTH WITH TO
THE SENATE FLOOR.
COLLEAGUES WE
ARE NOW HEADED TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY THREE. SENATOR DORADO.
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN NINETY NINE BY
SENATOR DURAZO AN ACT RELATING
TO EMPLOYMENT SENATOR TO ROSS
SO. THE FLOOR IS YOURS. SENATOR
DORADO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
RIGHT NOW PRIMARILY WOMEN IN
THE ARE THE GARMENT INDUSTRY
ARE AT WORK MAKING THE
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT THAN
ENABLES US TO BE HERE TODAY AND
THAT OUR BUSINESSES AND
SERVICES NEED TO RE OPEN AND
REBUILD. GARMENT WORKERS ARE
DOING THIS WORK MOST OF THEM IN
VERY HARSH CONDITIONS AND MANY
OF THEM FOR AN AVERAGE OF FIVE
DOLLARS AN HOUR. THAT'S A THIRD
OF THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE FIVE
DOLLARS AN HOUR. THESE WOMEN
AND MEN ARE DOING ESSENTIAL
WORK FOR OUR HEALTH AND OUR
ECONOMY. AND THEY FINALLY
BECOMING VISIBLE. SB THIRTY
NINETY NINE WOULD PROTECT
GARMENT WORKERS FROM
EXPLOITATION. AND BUSINESSES
FROM UNFAIR COMPETITION MEMBER
THIS IS ABOUT GOOD BUSINESSES
GOOD EMPLOYERS AS MUCH AS IT IS
ABOUT THE GARMENT WORKERS
THEMSELVES. WE LOOK TO
ELIMINATE THE PIECE RATE IN THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY TO MAKE SURE
BORROWER WORKERS ARE BEING PAID
FULLY FOR ALL OF THE TIME SPENT
WORKING. WE'RE GOING TO ENFORCE
THE LIABILITY. FOR WAGE WHILE
ASIANS AND CREATE A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION AS TO THE
IDENTITIES OF THE BRANDS BASED
ON GARMENT WORKERS TESTIMONY.
EXPLICITLY AUTHORIZED THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S BUREAU OF FIELD
ENFORCEMENT TO INVESTIGATE AND
SIDE THE BROWN'S. SB THIRTY
NINETY NINE MAKES CLEAR THAT A
BUSINESS CONTRACTING TO HAVE
GARMENTS MADE IS LIABLE FOR
UNPAID. ON PAY MINIMUM WAGE AND
OVERTIME PAY TO THE WORKERS TO
MANUFACTURE THOSE GARMENTS.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
REGARDLESS OF HOW MANY LAYERS
OF CONTRACTING THAT PERSON MAY
USE. SO CALLED RETAILERS
ACTUALLY CONTRACT WITH A
NETWORK OF MANUFACTURERS AND
SUBCONTRACTORS TO PRODUCE THEIR
GARMENTS AND DICTATE THE
PRICING STRUCTURE. THIS LEADS
TO VICIOUS PRICE COMPETITION
AND GARMENT WORKERS BEANS THAT
PAID A THIRD OF THE STATE
MINIMUM WAGE. AWAY STEPPED
REPORT FROM UCLA DOCUMENTED
THAT LOW WAGE WORKERS IN LA AS
A WHOLE NEWS TWENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. PER WEEK. NOT PER YEAR
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS PER
WEEK AND WAGE THEFT VIOLATIONS
NO INDUSTRY WITHIN. THOSE ARE
OUT WORKERS IS MORE RIGHT WITH
THESE VIOLATIONS THAN GARMENT
MANUFACTURING. THE UNITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
UNCOVERED WAGE VIOLATIONS AT
EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT. OF A
SURVEY OF SEVENTY SEVEN GARMENT
SHOPS THEY INVESTIGATED
RANDOMLY. RESULTED IN ONE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN BACK
PAY FOR EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE WORKERS. GARMENT WORKERS
IN LOS ANGELES OF REGULARLY
WORK MORE THAN TWELVE HOURS PER
DAY. AND IXTY TO SEVENTY HOURS
PER WEEK FOR RECEIVING. SUCH
LOW PAY AND NO OVERTIME. UCLA
FOUND THAT IN ADDITION TO THE
DIRECT THE FACT OF LOST INCOME
TO THOSE MEN AND WOMEN WHO WORK
SO HARD. MONEYTHAT IS LOST TO
OUR STATE AND LOCAL ECONOMIES
BECAUSE OF THE WAY STEPPED IN
LA COUNTY ALONE. THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT TAX LOSSES
ANNUALLY. TWO BILLION DOLLARS
IN LOST EARNINGS ONE POINT
THREE MILLION AND LOST INCOME
TAX. FORTY TWO TO NINETY TWO
MILLION LOST SALES TAX REVENUE.
LAST CONTRIBUTIONS TO
CALIFORNIA'S UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE FUND THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING TAX AND DISABILITY
INSURANCE TOTALING SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS. MANY
MANUFACTURERS HAVE NO INCENTIVE
TO ENSURE SAFE CONDITIONS OR
THE PROPER MINIMUM WAGE AND
OVERTIME PAYMENTS FOR THE
WORKERS PRODUCING THEIR
GARMENTS UNLESS THEY FACE
LIABILITY. WE AT THE STATE HAVE
TO DO MORE TO PROTECT THE LOW
WAGE HARD WORKING MEN AND WOMEN
IN THE GARMENT INDUSTRY OUR
PROTECT RESPONSIBLE BUSINESSES
WHO ARE FOLLOWING THE LAW. YOU
KNOW PROVIDING ETHICAL SAFETY
STANDARDS FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES
ESPECIALLY NOW AS WORKERS RISK
THEIR HEALTH TO MAKE THE
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT LIKE
MASKING DOWN THAT ARE NEEDED TO
GET US THROUGH LOS ANGELES A
GARMENT INDUSTRY HAS A SPECIAL
NICHE. IN THE WORLD OF GARMENT
AND FASHION. AND THAT NAY AGES
FAST FASHION I DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT BUT I'M
LEARNING ABOUT IT FAST FASHION.
WHERE YOU DESIGN IT AND YOU GET
IT TO THE MANUFACTURE AND YOU
GET OUT INTO THOSE STORES AND
IT HAS TO CHANGE CONTINUOUSLY-
SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
THAT PRODUCING SENSIBILITY
GREATER STABILITY IN THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY FOR THE
BUSINESSES AS WELL AS FOR THE
EMPLOYEES. COLLEAGUES I NOTE SB
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE THERE'S
BEEN A LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS PRIORITY AND I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR DORADO DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR LEYVA. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS AS THE CHAIR
OF THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
TODAY AT OF SB THIRTEEN NINETY
NINE THE GARMENT WORKER
PROTECTION ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
THIS IS ACTUALLY A PRIORITY
BILL FOR THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS. AS
WE'VE SEEN DURING THE COVERED
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THERE HAS
BEEN A TREMENDOUS SHORTAGE OF
PROTECTIVE MASKS AND RELATED
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
PP HERE IN CALIFORNIA IN TURN
MANY GOVERNMENT WORKERSWERE
CLASSIFIED AS ESSENTIAL WORKERS
AND JUST LIKE MANY OTHERS
INDUSTRIES A MAJORITY OF
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND IN THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY ARE WOMEN.
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC MANY
GARMENT WORKERS WERE ALREADY
WORKING IN DIFFICULT CONDITIONS
FOR MINIMAL PAY WITH LITTLE
RECOURSE TO RECOVER THEIR
UNPAID WAGES AND LOST OVER TIME
PAID DUE TO THE EXISTING
STRUCTURE. THIS PANDEMIC HAS
SHED A LIGHT ON THE LACK OF
OVERSIGHT WITH IN THIS INDUSTRY
AND IS EXPOSED MANY OF THE POOR
CONDITIONS THAT WORKERS
EXPERIENCE FOR OUR SAFETY AND
FOR OUR COMFORT TO THAT END SB
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE SIX TO
PROVIDE IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS
FOR MANY WOMEN AND MEN. IN THIS
INDUSTRY MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU A SENATOR GROW FALL BY
SENATOR ATKINS. ONE SECOND
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. YES
SENATOR GROW THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
QUESTION THE AUTHOR. WOULD YOU
ACCEPT THE QUESTION. I ANSWERED
THE END. PLEASE FEEL FREE TO DO
THAT GO AHEAD NATIONAL QUESTION
CENTER GROVE SO I AM NOT AWARE
OF ANY TYPE OF INDUSTRY THAT'S
EXCLUDED FROM THE CURRENT LABOR
CODE AND I WAS CURIOUS IF YOU
HAD KNOWLEDGE THAT THE GARMENT
INDUSTRY WAS EXCLUDED. FROM
CURRENT LABOR CODE SET BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
REQUIRES A MINIMUM WAGE SHOULD
BE PAID WORKERS COMP TO BE
PAID. AND YOU EVERYTHING THAT
WERE REQUIRED IS EMPLOYER FIVE
DEFENDER FOR THE CITY TO DO
WORKS POPULAR JUST NAME IT. SO
IS THE GARMENT INDUSTRY EXEMPT
FROM THE LABOUR CODE OR TO THE
LABOR CODE LAWS THAT ARE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA APPLIED TO
THE GARMENT INDUSTRY. THANK YOU
CENTER GROW ANYTHING FURTHER. I
THINK IN PART IT WAS A QUESTION
OF THE AUTHOR. CENTER WOULD YOU
ACCEPT THE QUESTION OUR WHICH
RATHER WAIT TILL YOUR CLOTHES I
LIKE TO WAIT TIMES CLOSE TO
HEAR ALL THE QUESTIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU. I DID NOT HEAR MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES I
SEE THAT SO ON MY OWN TIME TO
MY KNOWLEDGE THERE IS NO
INDUSTRY THAT IS EXEMPT FROM
THE LABOUR CODE IN THESE LABOR
STANDARDS THAT ARE PUT FORTH BY
THIS BODY. ENFORCED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL ASIANS
APPLY TO ALL EMPLOYERS REQUIRED
TO PAY MINIMUM WAGE FOR TO
COVER PEOPLE ON WORKERS COMP-
ALL OF THESE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE TO COMPLY WITH- WITH THIS
LABOR CODE THAT IS SET. WITH
THE EXCEPTION. OF IF THESE
EMPLOYEES ARE UNDER A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT. BECAUSE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT CONTRACT
LAW SUPERSEDES LABOR LAW. SO
NGUYEN SAY FOSTER FARMS OR- A
COMPANY DOWN IN LOS ANGELES
THAT I READ THEY CAN'T REALLY
THINK OF THE NAME OF RIGHT NOW.
ENGAGED IN. A CONTRACT LABOR
AGREEMENT OR FOR. A LABOR
AGREEMENT. THAT PAID THE
EMPLOYEES BELOW MINIMUM WAGE AS
LONG AS THE EMPLOYEE AND THE
EMPLOYER AGREED UPON THAT. AND
THEY COULD SUBSTITUTE THE WAGE
WITH PIECE RATE THAT'S OKAY.
BUT TO MY KNOWLEDGE THERE IS
NOT ONE EMPLOYER THAT IS EXEMPT
FROM THE LABOUR CODE AGAIN
UNLESS YOU'RE UNDER CONTRACT
LABOR AGREEMENT. SAYS
DIFFERENTLY THE TEAM PLAYING
THE PLAYER AGREE UPON. THERE'S
NOT ONE INDUSTRY THAT IS
ALLOWED TO VIOLATE THE LABOR
LAW AND LAWS ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE TO MAKE SURE THAT. LABOR
THAT MANUFACTURING CLOTHING
MANUFACTURING COMPANIES HAVE TO
PAY MINIMUM WAGE. OR THEY HAVE
TO PAY A PIECE RATE- THAT
ALLOWS THE EMPLOYEE TO MAKE A
MINIMUM OF THE MINIMUM WAGE AND
IF THE EMPLOYEE. AT PRODUCES
MORE GARMENTS THE OF THAT
MINIMUM WAGE THEY GET TO EARN
ADDITIONAL MANY AND THEN
PLEASE. DON'T THE GARMENT. IS
MAKE THE MAN PAGE. SO THAT THE
LAW AND THAT'S THE AY IT READS
IT ALSO SAYS THAT THE LAWS
REQUIRED TO- MAKE SURE THE
EMPLOYEES ARE COVERED UNDER
WORKER'S COMP THE PAIN THE WIFE
AND THE PIANO FOR SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT. YOU ARE
PROVIDING YOUR EMPLOYEE WITH
HEALTH AND SAFETY REQUIREMENTS
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT NO
ONE IN THE STATE IS INVOLVED
IS- EXEMPTED FROM CAL OSHA. CAL
OSHA CAN STILL GO INTO THESE
GARMENT MANUFACTURING PLACES
AND MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS A
SAFE WORK ENVIRONMENT. SO THE
CLAIMS ON THE FLOOR I REALIZE
THAT THERE ARE PROBABLY BAD
EMPLOYERS IN EVERY TYPE OF
INDUSTRY. BUT IT DOESN'T STOP
THE LAWS THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE
RIGHT NOW WITH CAL OSHA. END OF
THE LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL LABOR
THE- FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING IT
DOESN'T STOP ANY OF THESE
AGENCIES FROM GOING IN TO
PROTECT THESE EMPLOYEES. AND
FIND THESE EMPLOYERS THAT ARE
DOING THIS BAD THING. WHAT I
DID NOTICE IN THE BILL IS IT
JUST SAYS HERE AND I KNOCKED MY
LITTLE SIGN DOWN. IT'S IS IT
ELIMINATES. THE PIECE RATE PAY
FOR EMPLOYERS WITHOUT A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
SO WHAT THIS DOES IS IF YOUR
PAIN EIGHT PIECE RATE. AND SOME
OF YOUR EMPLOYEES ARE MAKING
FORTY FIFTY DOLLARS AN HOUR
TWENTY DOLLARS AN HOUR YOU WILL
NO LONGER BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
UNLESS YOU JOIN A UNION. SO YOU
WILL NO LONGER BE ABLE TO OFFER
THAT BENEFIT TO YOUR EMPLOYEES
TO MAKE IN EXCESS OF THE
MINIMUM WAGE. UNLESS YOU JOIN A
UNION AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
SAYS THE LANGUAGES RIGHT THERE.
SO I JUST ASK YOU GUYS THAT.
LET'S JUST WE ARE IN A POSITION
ESPECIALLY WITH COVE IN. WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE EVERY
EMPLOYER HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EMPLOY PEOPLE AND LET THOSE
PEOPLE MAKE AS MUCH MONEY AS
POSSIBLE WITHOUT VIOLATING THE
LABOR CODE WHICH SAYS YOU HAVE
TO PAY MINIMUM WAGE. SO IF YOU
HAVE AN EMPLOYER WHO IS A NON
UNION COMPANY AND THEY'RE
PAYING FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR
PLUS PIECE RATE OR FOURTEEN
DOLLARS OR TWELVE DOLLARS AN
HOUR WHATEVER MINIMUM WAGES
NOW. PLUS PIECE RATE SO THAT
THOSE EMPLOYEES CAN BE
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED IN PAY MORE.
FOR THE AND GET EARNED MORE FOR
THEIR FAMILIES AND TO PROVIDE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES. WHAT WHAT
REQUIRED THEM TO BE UNDER
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
IN ORDER TO HAVE THAT BENEFIT.
THERE'S NO THAT MAKES NO SENSE
IF THE IF THE EMPLOYEES WANT TO
WORK FOR AN EMPLOYER. ON A
PIECE RATE BASIS AS LONG AS
EMPLOYERS MAKING SURE THAT THEY
ARE PAID MINIMUM WAGE. WHICH IS
THE JOB OF THE INDUSTRIAL THE
LABOR DEPARTMENT TO. WHICH IS
THE JOB OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS TO HEAR.
US SAFETY PRACTICES AND LABOR
CODE ISSUES. THEN LET THEM DO
IT LET THOSE EMPLOYEES MAKE AS
MUCH MONEY AS POSSIBLE ON PIECE
RATE AND THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
BELONG TO A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT TO DO IT.
ALL THIS DOES IS GIVE ANOTHER
ARM SO THAT UNIONS CAN GO INTO
THESE MEN CLOTHING
MANUFACTURING COMPANIES. AND
THEY CAN GO LOOK IF YOU WANT.
JANE DOE TO CONTINUE OR BECAUSE
THEY'RE PROBABLY WOMEN IN THIS
INDUSTRY IF YOU WANT JANE DOE
AND YOUR EPLOYEES TO MAKE MORE
THAN MINIMUM WAGE THEN YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO JOIN A UNION
YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE A LOT OF
PAIN IN PEACE RATING MORE- OR
YOU CAN SPEND THE AVERAGE RATE
OF TWENTY DOLLARS AN HOUR. AND
THEN THERE'S NO INCENTIVE TO DO
MORE- WHEN YOU HAVE SOMEBODY
WHO IS WORKING REALLY HARD AND
LIKES THEIR JOB IN WANTS TO
PRODUCE MORE AND EARN MORE
MONEY. IT MAKES NO SENSE
ESPECIALLY COMING OUT OF A CODE
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE RESTRICT
PEOPLE. FOR MAKING MONEY UNLESS
ARE BELONG TO. IT THIS. I'M
SORRY BUT IT'S GETTING SO FAR
OVER THE LINE AND I HOPE THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZE THIS. I
URGE A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR ROVES THE SENATOR
MELENDEZ IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- SAID THIS BILL SEEKS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
WORKING IN THE GARMENT INDUSTRY
OR PAY TO FADE A FAIR WAGE- AND
SPECIFICALLY IT WAS MENTIONED
THE PRODUCTION MANUFACTURE OF
PVP. SO DIFFERENT STYLES OF
CLOTHING IN THE MASKS LIKE WERE
ALL WEARING. YET THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- SECURITY CONTRACT
WITH THE COMPANY TO MAKE THESE
VERY ITEMS IN CHINA. WHERE VERY
LIKELY DOES WORKERS WERE NOT
BEING PAID THE WAGES THIS BILL
SEEKS TO IMPOSE ON CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYERS DESPITE THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE A COMPANY IN CALIFORNIA
WHO COULD MANUFACTURE. THOSE
MAPS SO THAT WILL BE SENT AS IN
THIS IS A LEVEL OF HYPOCRISY
THAT EVERYTHING SHOULD EVERYONE
SHOULD TAKE PART ASIDE AND- YOU
KNOW IF YOU'RE GOING TO IMPOSE.
THESE TYPES OF WISE ON
CALIFORNIAN PLOY PLAYER
SHOULDN'T WE WALK THE WALK.
DOESN'T THAT MAKE CENTER FOR
GOING TO IMPOSE THIS ON A POOR
SHOULDN'T WE MAKE SURE THAT THE
CONTRACTS WE ARE- ENGAGING IN
FOLLOW THE SAME RULES BECAUSE
SO FAR WE HAVEN'T AND IT WAS. A
BILLION DOLLAR CONTRACT THAT'S
A LOT OF MONEY SO UNTIL WE CAN
KIND OF BRING DOWN THE LEVEL OF
HYPOCRISY THAT I SEE- IN THIS
BILL. THAT I CAN'T SUPPORT IT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
ATKINS.
WHAT THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES- YOU KNOW
FAMOUS LAST WORDS I ACTUALLY
DIDN'T INTEND TO SPEAK ON THIS
BILL FIVE HOW MANY TIMES ARE WE
GONNA HEAR THAT TODAY BUT YOU
KNOW I FELT COMPELLED TO GET UP
AND SPEAK YOU KNOW AFTER
YESTERDAY IT SEEMS YOU KNOW
YESTERDAY WAS SUCH A TIME OF
REFLECTION. WE ARE. THOUGHT
ABOUT A LOT OF DEEP ISSUES- IN
OUR SOCIETY AND SO MAYBE I'M-
FOLLOWING ONTO YESTERDAY BUT-
YOU KNOW MY MOTHER WAS A
SEAMSTRESS. AND SHE WORKED FOR
SHE WORKED PIECEMEAL. AND I
REMEMBER IN THE EIGHTIES
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR THAT WAS
THIRTY SIX YEARS AGO. COMING
HOME FROM COLLEGE AND SEE MY
MOM AT THE KITCHEN TABLE WITH A
PIECE OF PAPER AND A PENCIL.
AND DOING HER FIGURES AS SHE
WOULD SAY FIGURING OUT WHAT SHE
HAD MADE THAT DAY. AND SHE WAS
VERY GOOD MY MOTHER WAS AN
INCREDIBLE SEAMSTRESS BUT I
WANT TO SAY I YOU KNOW I'M BACK
YOU'RE TALKING WITH THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM RIVERSIDE WHO
UNDERSTANDS THE- WAGE ISSUES
AND HE WAS. AND WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE MINIMUM WAGE AND WHAT
IT TAKES TO GET THE MINIMUM
WAGE AND HOW YOU WOULD HAVE TO
WORK TOWARDS THE MINIMUM WAGE
AND HAVE IT DEDUCTED STILL
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THAT. OVER
FROM A HUMAN PERSPECTIVE. YOU
KNOW I WATCHED MY MOM- DO HER
FIGURES AND FIGURE OUT HOW WELL
SHE HAD DONE THAT DAY AND THEN
THE NEXT DAY AND THEN THE NEXT
DAY. AND THEN FIGURE OUT WHAT
THAT MEANT FOR OUR FAMILY AT
THE END OF THE WEEK. AND YOU
KNOW I ALSO NOTICED AS SHE GOT
OLDER. YEAH I'M NOT SURPRISED
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS ARE WITH THE
IN THE IT'S SUPPORTING THIS
BECAUSE- IT HAS A PARTICULAR
IMPACT ON ON WOMEN NOT THAT IT
DOESN'T IMPACT- AND MEN AS
WELL. BUT A MAJORITY OF THE
PEOPLE WHO WORK IN THIS
INDUSTRY ARE WOMEN. AND I
REMEMBER AS MY MOM GOT OLDER
AND OLDER. AND HOW IT USED TO
JUST REALLY BOTHER HER BECAUSE
SHE GOT SLOWER AND BACK TO HER
MEANT SHE WASN'T. UP TO SNUFF
SHE WASN'T AS GOOD AS SHE WAS.
WHEN SHE WAS- CRANKING OUT.
THOSE INCREDIBLE DRESSES IT HOW
MODE INDUSTRIES IN ROANOKE
VIRGINIA AND WE WOULD GO TO THE
J. C. PENNEY. AND WE WOULD SEE
THOSE DRESSES THAT MY MOTHER
HAD MADE THEY'VE GONE THROUGH
THAT WHOLE PRODUCTION I WORKED
THERE ONE SUMMER IN BETWEEN
COLLEGE. HARSH JOB ALMOST I
EVER HAD AND I THOUGHT I GET TO
GO BACK TO COLLEGE. AND MY MOM
IS GOING TO GO BACK TO THAT
FACTORY EVERY SINGLE DAY AND
SHE'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO TRY
TO MAKE PEACE. PIECE RATE. N.
YOU KNOW I JUST THINK IT'S
BEYOND THE TIME IN WHICH WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THIS AND SAY IS
THIS RIGHT. YOU KNOW WE ARE
TRYING TO BE PROTECTIVE OF
WORKERS AND- AND I TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND THE INDUSTRIES THAT
ARE. STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW AND
TRYING TO CONTINUE TO BE
VIBRANT. ARE FROM THE RETAILERS
AND MANUFACTURERS ALL PEOPLE
THAT I THINK WE NEED TO SUPPORT
AND FIND A WAY. FOR THOSE
INDUSTRIES. TO BE VIABLE AND
ECONOMICALLY SOUND FOR OUR
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FIFTH.
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD. I
JUST THINK IT'S TIME FOR US TO
LOOK AT THIS ISSUE AND REALIZE
THAT GARMENT INDUSTRY WORKERS
HAVE HISTORICALLY AS HAS
ALREADY BEEN STATED. SUFFERED
FROM SUBSTANTIAL WAGE THEFT.
FROM NOT BEING ABLE TO MAKE
ENOUGH- YOU KNOW I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN NINETY
NINE BECAUSE I ACTUALLY
REMEMBER. WHAT IT WAS LIKE
LIVING THROUGH THAT TOM EVEN
THOUGH I WASN'T THE ONE THAT
HAD TO GO IN AND DO THAT WORK.
AND I THINK IT'S TIME WE STAND
UP FOR THOSE WORKERS AND WE
PROTECT THEM FROM WAGE THEFT WE
MAKE SURE. THAT YOU KNOW
THY'RE GOING TO WORK A HARD
DAY BUT THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO OFFSET THAT MINIMUM WAGE AND
GET THERE AND IF YOU KNOW IF
THEY'RE REALLY GOOD DON'T MAKE
MORE THAT'S TRUE. BUT I JUST
THINK WE HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS FROM A PERSPECTIVE OF. ICE
TOM THAT WE WRITE SOMETHING
THAT MAYBE. WE SHOULD OF TAKING
CARE OF A LONG TIME AGO THIRTY
SIX YEARS. THIRTY SIX YEARS AND
SO AND SOME OF THESE FOLKS CAN
MAKE AN AVERAGE OF FIVE FIFTEEN
AN HOUR. I MEAN. MY MOTHER
AIMED FOR FIVE FIFTEEN AN HOUR
AND IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR
THAT WAS SOMETHING. NOT THANK
YOU SENATOR ATKINS SENATOR
GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES- I
ALSO STAND INS VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN NINETY
NINE THE GARMENT WORKER
PROTECTION ACT AND I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AS
ANOTHER MEMBER FROM LOS ANGELES
WAGE THAT VIOLATIONS IN THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY IN OUR AREAS
HAVE BEEN AGREE JUST FOR A VRY
VERY LONG TIME. GARMENT WORKERS
DESERVE A LIVING WAGE THESE ARE
MOSTLY WOMEN SOMETIMES WOMEN OF
COLOR AND THE ABSOLUTELY
DESERVE A LIVING WAGE- BUT THEY
ARE NOW OF COURSE AS WITH A
MENTION PRODUCING MASKS WHICH
ARE CRITICAL TO HELP SPREAD THE
VIRUS BUT TO HELP REDUCE
SPREADING OF THE VIRUS DURING
THIS PANDEMIC AND THE IRONY
TODAY. THAT GARMENT WORKERS ARE
ALSO VULNERABLE IN THIS HEALTH
AND ECONOMIC CRISIS DUE IN
LARGE PART TO THE WIDESPREAD
EXPLOITATION AND LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY BY THESE
BUSINESSES MY DISTRICT IN
PARTICULAR ESPECIALLY THE
SOUTHEAST LOS ANGELES REGION IS
HOME TO MANY GARMENT WORKERS IN
THE VERNON AND HUNTINGTON PARK
IN SOUTH LA REGION OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS WE'VE SEEN
INCREASED AMOUNTS OF FACTORIES
MOVE INTO THESE AREAS AND WITH
LOW PROTECT FOR WORKERS. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO A FEW WORDS
PLEASE I'M A CONSTITUENT TO
RESET GARCIA AND HER STORY TO
RESELL IT MY DISTRICT THIRD FOR
FASHION OVER BUILDING A
SHOCKING RATE AN EXPERT LABOUR
USES NEW YORK TIMES I THOUGHT
AND AS LITTLE AS TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS FOR SIXTY
FIVE HOURS OF WORK. IN A WAY.
QUICKLY OF THREE DOT IS AND
FORTY SIX CENTS AN HOUR FOR IN
TWENTY. THAT'S NOT MINIMUM.
SHOULD THE FACTORIES RECEIVING
ORDERS FROM FASHION OF A FOR UP
TO FIVE THOUSAND PIECES OF
CLOTHING AT A TIME. SHE WAS
PAID BY THE PIECE WE OFTEN HEAR
THAT IF WE WORK HARD WE CAN
MAKE MORE MONEY BUT WORKING
SIXTY FIVE HOURS A WEEK AND
GETTING PAID THREE FORTY SIX AN
HOUR. IS NOT FAIR PAY AND NOT
MINIMUM WAGE FOR HEART WEEKS
WORTH OF WORK. AND CLEAR
VIOLATION OF LABOR LAWS MISS
GARCIA WAS PAID WELL. TO
CONTINUE IN OUR STATE. HOW CAN
WE ALLOW TWENTY DOLLAR SHIRT TO
VALUE MORE THAN SOMEONE'S
PROTECTIONS IN SOMEONE'S HOURLY
WAGE. I JUST WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE AGAIN FROM LOS
ANGELES FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND WE MUST VOTE YES
AND I AND I. AM FOR MY
COLLEAGUES TO DO THE SAME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR GONZALEZ
SENATOR GALGIANI FULL BY
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS UNLIKE MANY
OF YOU I'VE STRUGGLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT I HAD A MASK FROM
MANY MONTHS AGO IN FACT WHEN
THIS BEGAN BECAUSE WE WERE ALL
TRYING TO ORDER THEM AND THERE
WAS A BACKLOG WE COULDN'T GET
THEM FOR SIX OR SEVEN WEEKS. SO
I BORROWED MY MOM'S SEWING
MACHINE AND I STARTED MAKING
SOME FOR MYSELF AND MY WIFE
MARY LOU AND MY FAMILY AND SOME
FRIENDS AND THE FIRST ONE I
MADE TOOK ABOUT TWO HOURS. AND
THEN AFTER ABOUT TEN OF THEM I
GOT A LITTLE FASTER AND WAS
ABLE TO MAKE ONE A LITTLE BIT
OVER AN HOUR ON AT SEA YOU CAN
BUY THESE MASKS FOR THREE
DOLLARS AND FORTY FIVE CENTS.
MADE IN THE USA. WHAT THAT
TELLS ME. IS THAT WHILE WE
DON'T KNOW WHO THESE COMPANIES
ARE. THEY ARE OUT THERE AND
THEY ARE PAYING SUBSTANDARD
WAGES TO THEIR WORKERS. THERE'S
NO WAY THAT SOMEBODY COULD MAKE
A MASK. AT WITH THE MATERIALS
AND WORKERS COMP PRICES AND SO
ON AND SO FORTH. AND BE ABLE TO
MAKE ANY PROFIT. IF THEY'RE
PAYING MINIMUM WAGE. AND
THEY'RE SELLING A MASK FOR
THREE DOLLARS AND FORTY FIVE
CENTS AN HOUR. THANK YOU I RISE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU CENTER
GALGIANI SENATOR RUBIO FOLLOWED
BY A SENATOR GROW. SENATOR
RUBIO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE AND I WANT ALSO
STRAINING COACH MY COLLEAGUES
TO SUPPORT IT AS WELL I MEAN I
THINK MOST OF MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE SPOKEN FROM LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AT WORK THIS IS SO
PREVALENT AND EVIDENT I GREW UP
IN DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES- AND
JOB THAT'S FOR THE GARMENT
INDUSTRY IS. AND IF YOU EVER GO
INTO ANY OF THESE MANUFACTURERS
IT'S REALLY HEARTBREAKING TO
SEE I MEAN THERE'S A REASON WHY
THEY CALL THEM SOMETIMES SWEAT
SHOPS AND THAT IS UNACCEPTABLE
AND I'M VERY MINDFUL THAT IT'S
NOT EVERY SINGLE MANUFACTURE.
BUT IN PARTICULAR I'M SPEAKING
ABOUT THE AREA LOS ANGELES
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES WHICH WE
CALL THE GARMENT INDUSTRY AND
SO I HAVE SEEN THE ABUSES IN
THOSE INDUSTRIES AS I. WAS
GROWING UP I KNOW A LOT OF
FAMILIES THAT DON MADE THEIR
MONEY FROM WORKING IN THESE
INDUSTRIES AND SO I THINK IT'S
AN IMPORTANT MEASURE- JUST
BASIC PROTECTIONS FOR THESE
WORKERS AND AN ADEQUATE LIVING
WAGE IS IMPORTANT STILL I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF IT AND HOPE THAT
YOU SUPPORTED TO THINKING. THAT
A PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SENATOR.
SENATOR GROW AND THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I WHAT I DID
WAS I GOING TO SPEAK ON IT
AGAIN BUT I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU GUYS UNDERSTAND
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR CODE SAYS
THAT PIECE READING COMMISSION
PAID EMPLOYEES MUST RECEIVE AT
LEAST MINIMUM WAGE. PEACE THREE
EMPLOYEES MUST ALSO BE PAID AT
LEAST MINIMUM WAGE FOR ALL THE
TIME SPENT ON TASKS NOT
SPECIFICALLY INCLUDED IN THEIR
PIECE RATE UNDER THE NEW LABOR
LAW EMPLOYERS ARE REQUIRED TO
COMPENSATE EMPLOYEES WHO WERE
PAID BY A PIECE THREE BASIS FOR
THE REFER RESTED WE CAN FREE
PERIODS AND OTHER NON
PRODUCTIVE WORK TIME. SO THE
LAW ALREADY STATES THAT ANYBODY
PAIN PIECE RATE IS REQUIRED TO
MAKE FOR THOSE EMPLOYEES ARE
PAID MINIMUM WAGE. SO THIS BILL.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND BECAUSE- THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT CAN GO INTO THE
GARMENT DISTRICT THREE GUYS ARE
SHARING THESE HORRIFIC STORIES.
OF SOMEBODY WORKING SIXTY FIVE
HOURS A WEEK AND MAKING THREE
DOLLARS AN HOUR. THAT IS
ILLEGAL UNDER CALIFORNIA STATE
LAW ON HIS EMPLOYER I AM JUST.
IT'S REPREHENSIBLE THAT SOMEONE
WOULD TREAT THEIR EMPLOYEES
LIKE THAT. BUT THE LAW ALREADY
EXIST IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS AND LABOR
STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT IS NOT
DOING THEIR JOB BY NEGLECTING.
GOING INTO THOSE FACILITIES
THAT ARE IN THE LOS ANGELES
GARMENT DISTRICT AREA. THEN
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED
TO ADDRESS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT.
BUT TO PASS A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT SAYS YOU CAN
ONLY PAID PIECE RATE. IF IT'S A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT IS
BENEFICIAL EITHER TO THE
MANUFACTURE OR THE EMPLOYEE
THEMSELVES. BECAUSE IF THE IF
THE AGREEMENT ISN'T MADE THEN
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO BE PAID PIECE RATE. AND
THEY WILL NOT BE ABLE TO EXCEED
THE LIMITS OF FIFTEEN DOLLARS
AN ARE THE MINIMUM WAGE. AND SO
I JUST AGAIN IT IS LABOR LAW IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. UNDER
THE LABOR CODE THAT WE PASS
THAT REQUIRE INDIVIDUALS ON P.
ST TO MAKE THE MINIMUM STANDARD
OF MINIMUM WEIGHT. AND THEN
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT IN EXCESS
IS ADDITIONAL DOLLARS IN THE
EMPLOYEE'S POCKET. THE ONLY
THING THAT THIS BILL DOES IS
REQUIRE ONLY- IN OUR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING CONTRACTS TO BE ABLE
TO. AND PEACE SO AGAIN I JUST
NEED TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT IT'S
IN CALIFORNIA LAW. AND LIKE I
SAID THE STATE THAT WERE
TAUGHT. FULLER I DON'T DOUBT.
THAT SHOULD BE ADDRESSED THOSE.
AND IS THE MOST POWER
DELEGATION AS THE LEAD THE LOS
ANGELES DELEGATION. I SUGGEST
YOU MEET WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS AND TELL
THEM TO GET THEIR HAPPY BUT
DOWN THERE AND CORRECT THE
SITUATION. THANK YOU SIR GROVER
SENATOR FURTADO. CHOOSE ME
BEFORE YOU SPEAK HAS JUST BEEN
CLEARED OFF CLEAN DOT. ALRIGHT
VERY GOOD CENTER HER TITLE
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM- PRESIDENT I
WANT TO THANK SENATOR ALSO
FIRST AND FOREMOST AND
APPRECIATE HER EFFORTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR GARMENT WORKERS
ARE PROTECTED FROM WAGE THEFT.
OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW I SUPPORT
THIS THIS BILL IN ITS IN ITS
CONCEPT IT REALLY EASY FOR ME
TO SUPPORT IT HERE TODAY BUT I
WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT MY MOM AND HER STORY
AND HER BACKGROUND IN MY STORY
TO A CERTAIN EXTENT IS WELL.
MANY OF YOU KNOW HER HAVE MET
HER SHE WAS HERE ON THE SENATE
FLOOR OFFER MY SWEARING IN MANY
OF YOU KNOW THAT I REPRESENT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY THE SOUTHERN
VALLEY WHERE- AGRICULTURE IS A
IS A MAJOR PART OF OUR LIFE
WELLA MAJOR PART OF OUR LIFE
HAS ALSO BEEN I MOTHER WORKING
A GARMENT AND VERY MUCH THE
PRETENCE MOTHER AND SO. AS I
MENTIONED. JUST A BIT AGO IT'S
REAL EASY FOR ME TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL BECAUSE- I DON'T WANT
ANY WOMAN. ANY PERSON ARE TO BE
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF. NO I DON'T
THINK ANYONE OF US SHE HAS THAT
VALUE- BUT- WHEN I WAS TALKING
TO MY MOM ABOUT IT. I DIDN'T
REALLY HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL. I REALLY DIDN'T- LIKE I
SAID IT'S VERY EASY FOR ME TO
SERVE SUPPORT THIS BILL BUT-
SHE CAME TO BE A LITTLE BIT OF
AN UNDERSTANDING FROM. HER
BEING IN A BEING A WORKER IN
THE GARMENT INDUSTRY. AND I YOU
KNOW SPECIFICALLY WE SPOKE
ABOUT THE PER PIECE. THE WAVE
OF MAKING THAT YOU KNOW MONEY.
AND SHE TOLD ME THAT HER ALONG
WITH A LOT OF FAMILY FRIENDS
THAT STILL LIVE IN THE SAME
COMMUNITY THAT I LIVE IN-
ACTUALLY MADE MUCH MORE MONEY.
ARE UNDER THE PER PIECE AND YOU
KNOW I THINK ABOUT THOSE TIMES
WHEN I WAS A CHILD AND YES IT'S
HARD WORK I MEAN I WISH THAT.
THAT YOU KNOW THAT MY MOTHER
HAD IN A DIFFERENT OPTION WHICH
SHE DIDN'T HAVE TO WORK IN IN
IN IN THE LABOR INTENSIVE- JOB
BUT BUT THIS IS THE TYPE OF
OPPORTUNITY THAT SHE- WITH
GIVEN AND SHE DID WELL IN IT
THAT PROVIDED TO MY FAMILY. IT
PROVIDED ME WITH. ENOUGH OF
FOOD WITH ENOUGH CLOTHING- TO
GET ME WHERE I AM TODAY. AND
YOU KNOW I JUST WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT YOU KNOW SHAME ON
ANY INDUSTRY. THAT DOES NOT
PROVIDE THE BASIC BENEFIT OF
HEALTH CARE AND IT DOESN'T
PROTECT THE WORKERS I DON'T
SUPPORT THAT. BUT AT THE SAME
TIME IT IS A CHALLENGE. GIVEN
MY BACKGROUND MY HISTORY. AND
MY MOTHER'S HISTORY. KNOWING
THAT- AT A TIME WHERE WERE
FIFTEEN YOU KNOW 15% OR UP
22425% IN SOME COMMUNITIES LIKE
THE ONE THAT I LIVE IN.
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE THAT WE WOULD
JEOPARDIZE- EIGHTY INCOME FOR
ANY WOMAN I'D I I'D IT
TERRIFIES ME AND I DON'T. I
DON'T WANT TO PUT ANY WOMAN AND
THAT KIND OF SITUATION OR ANY
OTHER PERSON REALLY THIS IS A
TIME WHERE WE NEED TO CREEK
FURTHER EXPAND THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS- NOT TO RISK BE
ALREADY LIMITED OPPORTUNITIES
THAT WE HAVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE DO NEED TO MAKE
<c.red>MPROVEMENTS. UPON THE ISSUES</c>
THAT WE HAVE AT HAND- AND SO
TODAY I WILL. NOT SUPPORT THE
BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM BUT I
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
ADDITIONAL OF THIS BILL OUT
WHEN IT COMES BACK SO I CAN
SUPPORT IT BECAUSE THEY DO
BELIEVE THAT WOMEN NEED TO BE
TREATED FAIRLY. A TO BE
PROVIDED WITH CARE- BUT I'M
HOPING TO SEE SOME CHANGES THAT
CAN GET ME TO A POINT WHERE I
CAN SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
CHAIR LET ME START BY SAYING
I'M STANDING IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE WILL
SPROUT THE CO AUTHOR WITH THE
AUTHOR ON A BILL LAST YEAR ON
TO PROTECT WAIT STAFF. I JUST
WANTED TO BRING TO EVERYONE'S
ATTENTION A I SUPPORT THE BILL
LABOR COMMITTEE BUT- THAT IT IS
A- LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
TWENTY TWENTY PRIORITY BAIL-
PROUD THAT MY MAYOR MY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS- GARMENT WORKER
CENTER. LABOR FEDERATION NUMBER
PEOPLE SUPPORT IT- AS I LISTEN
TO THE STORIES ABOUT MOTHERS I
THOUGHT ABOUT MY MOTHER. FLATLY
DIFFERENT VARIATION ON THE
STORY. MOM SHE LIVES AT
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE UNIVERSITY
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GRANT.
AND SHE GOT THERE BECAUSE THE
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL
EARLY. AND IT IS OFTEN THE CASE
KIDS WERE SMART ENOUGH TO
GRADUATE EARLY SOMETIMES A
MOSTLY ARE QUITE READY FOR THE
REAL WORLD. SOLD MY GRANDMOTHER
TOLD HER WHAT YOU SAID ADDING
YEAR TO YOU YOU KNOW. GET A
LITTLE OLDER THEN WE'LL FIGURE
OUT WHAT YOU GONNA DO AND SO
SHE SPENT THAT YOU'RE WORKING
IN A ZIPPER FACTORY IN DOWNTOWN
LA. AND THE STORY THAT I GREW
UP UNDERSTANDING THE PART OF
THE REASON WHY SHE WENT TO YOU
WITH THE AND GOT HER DEGREE IN
SOCIAL WORK WITH BASED ON HER
EXPERIENCE WORKING ALONGSIDE
WOMEN. IN THE ZIPPER FACTORY.
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH BLACK
WOMAN AT USC IN THE FIFTIES
MINORED IN SPANISH SO SHE SPOKE
FLUENT SPANISH- AND SHE TOLD
THE STORY ABOUT THE LAST DAY AT
WORK IN THE ZIPPER FACTORY
FIRST OF ALL THE PIECEMEAL- AND
YOU KNOW THE PIECEMEAL PAYMENT
GOES BACK IN HISTORY. LAW THAT
ALSO IMPACTS YOU KNOW BLACK
WOMEN AND WOMEN OF COLOR AND
WORKING WOMEN IN TERMS OF THE
ONLY WAY YOU COULD GET WORK-
PULSE RECONSTRUCTION IRONING
CLEANING PIECEMEAL. AND IT WAS
A WAY TO YOU KNOW NOT REALLY
PAY YOU FOR YOUR WORK. BUT SHE
TOLD THE STORY THE ZIPPER
FACTORY WHEN THERE WAS A FIRE
IN THE ZIPPER. THERE IS A WERE
ALSO LEAVE THE REAL THE DOOR
HIS BILL THE DOORS BEEN CHAIN
LOCKED FROM THE OUTSIDE. THE
KEEP PEOPLE THEY'RE WORKING
LONG HOURS WITHOUT TAKING MAKES
A REALLY VIOLENT BEING LATE LOS
EVEN BACK IN THE- AND SO YOU
KNOW. I STAND IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY NINETY NINE BECAUSE THIS
IS TWENTY TWENTY. AND THE FACT
THAT WE'RE STILL HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HAVING TO
GO ABOVE AND BEYOND. TO PROVIDE
PROTECTIONS TO CERTAIN ASSETS.
IT REALLY TO ME PERSONALLY
SINCE. I APPRECIATE BUSINESS
NEEDS TO DO BUSINESS PARTICULAR
PULSE CO THE WHICH WE WEIRD TO
TALK ABOUT I'M SURE FOR YEARS
TO COME HOW WE HAVE TO SUPPORT
BUSINESS PULSE CALLED IT AND I
APPRECIATE THAT BUT NO.
BUSINESS OUR SHIP. POWER TO
MAKE A PROFIT ON THE BACKS OF
THEIR WORKERS. PAGE I SHOULDN'T
I'M PROUD TO SUPPORT SB THIRTY
NINETY NINE. THANK YOU- SENATOR
MITCHELL SENATOR DODD.
PRESIDENT SKIS ME. I'LL TELL
YOU THAT THE CENTER FROM LOS
ANGELES JAVED JUST GAVE SOME
COMPELLING REMARKS I WAS NOT
GOING TO VOTE FOR THIS TODAY
AND LISTENING TO THE PRO TEM
AND LISTENING TO OTHERS HAS GOT
ME TO THE POINT WERE. YOU KNOW
I AM A CONSIDERING SUPPORTING
THIS BUT I WANT TO LISTEN. TO
THE CLOSE OF THE BILL'S AUTHOR
HERE. AND I WANT TO UNDERSTAND
HOW IS IT IN TWENTY TWENTY.
WE'VE GOT PEOPLE THAT ARE
MAKING THREE DOLLARS AN HOUR
WITH WHAT THIS BODY HAS BEEN
DOING. WITH WHAT WE WOULD TRY
TO GET DONE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR YEARS. HOW IS
THAT HAPPENING. IN THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY VERY
DISTURBING TO ME THAT WE HAVE
RULES AND REGULATIONS IN PLACE.
THAT WE HAVE A MINIMUM WAGE
THAT WE'VE ALL WORKED VERY VERY
HARD. TO SUPPORT IN THIS
CHAMBERS AND OTHERS. AND YET WE
STILL HAVE VIOLATIONS LAW WHERE
IS THE ENFORCEMENT IT'S SO I'M
THE LIST. WAY THE CALL. SHE
RESPONSE ALL UP IN SUPPORT OF
NOT I WILL LAY OFF TODAY. THANK
YOU SENATOR DODD ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
SENATOR DRAW CHAU YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU. AND I WANNA THANK
ALL MY COLLEAGUES WHOSE- SPOKE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND A
PARTICULAR TEACHER R. PRO TOWN
FOR SHARING THE STORIES. I HAVE
WORKED UNDER PIECE RATE. BOTH
IN THE FEELS. IN AGRICULTURE AS
WELL AS FOR VERY VERY SHORT
TIME IN THE GARMENT INDUSTRY.
AND A WHAT THAT INDUSTRY HAS
DONE AND IT HAPPENS IN OTHER
INDUSTRIES IT IS IT'S CREATED
SUCH A WEB. OF COMPANIES
AVOIDING THEIR RESPONSIBILITY
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE TRIED TO ADDRESS IN
THIS BILL. HE TAKES
RESPONSIBILITY THE CONTRACTOR
WHO IS THE MEDIA YOU KNOW PER-
COMPANY THAT HIRES SOMEBODY ON.
HE CAN CLOSE UP WE ACTUALLY
CLOSES UP SHOP TODAY. WHEN
PAYROLL IS DUE AND IT OPENS UP
UNDER ANOTHER NAME DOWN THE
HALL ON THE SAME FLOOR WHERE
ALL THESE CONTRACTORS ARE IT
OPENS UP UNDER A NEW NAME. TO
MAKE IT MORE MORE DIFFICULT FOR
EVEN A LABOR COMMISSIONER THAT
WANTS TO DO THEIR JOB. TO BE
ABLE TO DO THEIR JOB. THERE WAS
A LOT PASSED IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE WHICH WE THOUGHT WAS GOING
TO BRING. REAL LIABILITY TO
EVERYONE INVOLVED IN THAT. LINE
OF RESPONSIBILITY LINE THE
MANUFACTURING AND IT DID WORK
FOR AWHILE. BUT THE COMPANIES
FOUND ANOTHER WAY OF GETTING
OUT OF PAIN AND ITEM HAVING
LIABILITY AND THAT WAS THROUGH
THEIR BRANDS. THE BRAND'S DO
NOT TAKE RESPONSIBILITY ECAUSE
I HIRE A BUNCH OF COMPANIES
DIFFERENT LAYERS OF CONTRACTORS
SO THAT WHEN THERE IS AN
INVESTIGATION AND BECOME SO
DIFFICULT TO FIND OUT WHO WAS
RESPONSIBLE BUT YOU CAN'T PIN
THEM DOWN AND THAT'S WHY THEY
GET AWAY WITH IT AND THAT'S WHY
IT'S GOTTEN WORSE AND WORSE AND
WORSE. IT'S A RIGHT TO DO WHAT
WE DO IN THIS BILL IS TO FIND
THE BRANDS. LIABLE FOR THE
WAGES AND THE CONDITIONS OF
THOSE EMPLOYEES- AND THAT THE
TESTIMONY. OF THOSE WORKERS.
TOGETHER WHAT ACTUALLY THEY
BRING I THOSE LITTLE LABELS
THAT THEY SOLD ONE. TO SAY THIS
IS WHY WE WORK FOR. CAN YOU
FIND YOU KNOW THIS IS WHO
SHOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
PAYING ME MY MINIMUM MIGHT MY
WAGES. SO IT'S GOTTEN HARDER
AND HARDER TO ENFORCE BECAUSE
THEY FIND WAYS TO GET OUT OF
THAT LIABILITY IN THAT
ENFORCEMENT SO WE'VE GONE FROM
GETTING. YOU KNOW TRYING TO GET
BETTER TO WEAR BACK DOWN A ROCK
BOTTOM AGAIN. YES IT IS THE
LAW. TO BE PAID MINIMUM WAGE IT
IS A LOT OF BE PAID OVERTIME.
BUT IT IS SO DIFFICULT THAT THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S COULD NOT
NAILED DOWN HE IS RESPONSIBLE.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON RIGHT
HERE AND THAT'S WHY THE WORKING
CONDITIONS OF OTTEN WORSE AND
WORSE AND WORKERS ARE. I HAVE
MET WITH DOZENS HUNDREDS OF
THESE WORKERS TO TELL ME THE
SAME THING. THIS IS WHAT WITH
THE CHANGE WE NEED IN ORDER FOR
US TO BE ABLE TO START TO GET
PAID EVEN THE STATE MINIMUM
WAGE. THERE IS NO ELIMINATION
OF INCENTIVES IT'S INCLUDED IN
THIS BILL. THAT THERE ARE WAYS
FOR AN EMPLOYER TO GET BONUSES
AND INCENTIVIZE MORE
PRODUCTIVITY THE THING IS THAT
THE MINIMUM WAGE AND IT'S ABOVE
THAT. SO THERE IS STILL WAY. IN
A AND A AND AN ETHICAL WAY AND
OF FAIR WAY. FOR WORKERS TO GET
MORE. BASED ON THEIR
PRODUCTIVITY THROUGH INCENTIVE
BONUS PROGRAMS SO THAT'S VERY
CLEARLY IN THE BILL. YOU KNOW I
GOT CONNECTED WITH PLEASE OF
WORKERS LAST YEAR. WHEN THEY
CAME BEFORE A SUBCOMMITTEE ON.
TRYING TO GET THEIR WAGES FROM
UP RESTITUTION FUND THAT THE
STATE HAS. THEY WERE ALL WOOD
SEVERAL HUNDRED DOLLARS EACH
AND THERE WASN'T ENOUGH MONEY
IN THAT RESTITUTION FUND TO
TAKE CARE OF THEM SO WE STEPPED
IN TO FILL THE VOID. AND THEY
GOOD FOR HER FROM LOS ANGELES
CENTER MITCHELL AND I WENT TO A
CELEBRATION. WHERE THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF THOSE GARMENT
WORKERS. AND TO THINK THAT THEY
WERE CELEBRATING. BECAUSE THEY
FINALLY GOT SEVERAL YEARS LATER
THEY FINALLY GOT PAID THE
MINIMUM WAGE. THINK ABOUT THAT.
THE FINALLY GOT PAID THE
MINIMUM WAGE. AND THEY AND
THEIR FAMILIES THERE WERE.
WE'RE JUST ECSTATIC AT BEING
ABLE TO DO THAT. COLLEAGUES
PAYING A FAIR WAGE AND GIVING
US GIVING OUR LABOR
COMMISSIONER THE TOOLS TO DO
THAT IS WHAT THESE WORKERS NEED
SOUL I VERY PROBABLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. ATKINS AYE BATES.
BELL FIVE FOR JUST NO BRADFORD.
CABALLERO I CHIANG NO DALLY NO
DODD. THERE ARE SO. I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG I HILL I WAS SO.
HI TADO. JACKSON I JONES NO
LEYVA I MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S
NO MITCHELL. I MONNING I MORE
LOCK NO MORAL. NO NIELSEN NO
PAN I PORTANTINO I ROTH. I
RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER. I STERN I
UMBERG I WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WIENER. I WILK NOW. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME. ARCHULETA BATES NO
BRADFORD I DODD. GLAZER TADO.
VICE TWENTY FIVE KNOWS ELEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES. THANK YOU
SENATOR DORADO WE WILL MOVE NOW
TO SENATOR DODD. FILE ITEM.
THIRTY FOUR. COLLEAGUES WE HAVE
COMPLETED THE EITHER EIGHT OR
NINE ITEMS WE HAVE FORTY ONE
MORE TO GO PLUS EIGHTEEN. OF
BUDGET TRAILER BILLS AND A
BUDGET. SENATOR DODD THE FLOOR
IS YOURS MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL EIGHT EIGHT
SIXTY TWO BY SENATOR DODD AND
ACTUALLY DO THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES SENATOR DON. MEMBERS
IN MADAM PRESIDENT I A AUTHORED
LAST YEAR- SP ONE SIXTY SEVEN
REQUIRING UTILITY PROTOCOLS FOR
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF MEDICAL
BASS LIKE CUSTOMERS DURING A D.
ENERGIES ASIAN OR PS PSP THAT I
KNOW WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
THOSE TODAY. IN IN THIS IN THIS
BODY AND- A LOT OF DIFFERENT
AREAS. BUT I'VE COME TO LEARN
THAT IN ADDITION A MEDICAL BASS
LIKE CUSTOMERS THERE ARE ACCESS
AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS A UP IN
CUSTOMERS REQUIRING ATTENTION-
DURING THESE DIGITIZATION SAYS
WELL. IN THESE A FAN
INDIVIDUALS ARE THOSE HAVING
DEVELOPMENTAL INTELLECTUAL OR
PHYSICAL DISABILITIES LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY OR WHO ARE
NON ENGLISH SPEAKING SENIORS
CHILDREN OR PEOPLE LIVING IN
INSTITUTIONALIZED SETTINGS. SB
AIDS YOU TO REQUIRE YOU TO
DEVELOP DE IMAGES ASIAN QUOTA.
FOR THE BEDROCK THE POPULATION
IN ADDITION A MEDICAL BASS LINE
PROTOCOLS ADDITIONALLY EIGHT
SIXTY TWO CLARIFIES. OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES AT. IT IS A
SHOULD BE BAD WE WILL PERMIT.
ME REPEAT THAT PER QUE TO
RECEIVE. ASSISTANCE FOR THESE
COSTS OF RUNNING THEIR
EMERGENCY OPERATION CENTERS
WHERE THE PSP AS OCCURS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT- THIS COMMUNITY
REALLY NEEDS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I. BUT. THANK YOU
SENATOR DODD DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. ARCHULETA OR AYE ATKINS
I BATES. I FELL FIVE FOR JUST I
BRADFORD I CAN BY ADAM. I
CHIANG HI DOLLY I DODD. HI
THERE ARE SO. I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
FIVE HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE
HUESO I TADO HI JACKSON AYE
JONES I LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE AYE
MELINDA'S I MITCHELL. I MONNING
I WARLOCK I MORAL. I NIELSEN.
NO HAN FIVE PORTANTINO HI ROSS
I RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN HI
NUMBER FIVE MY CASKEY. I WIENER
HI WILK. HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS SENATOR NIELSEN
DID YOU. BUT CENTER NIELSEN
NOTE I'D NIELSEN NIELSEN NOTIFY
NIELSEN NOTE I'D PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN HI
THE VICE FORTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES COLLEAGUES WERE
NOW GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEMS THIRTY FIVE THROUGH FORTY
WE'LL START WITH SENATOR
NIELSEN. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL NINE FIFTY
TWO BY SENATOR NIELSEN AN ACT
RELATING TO TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY
SENATOR NIELSEN MADAM PRESIDENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN THE SENATE
THIS IS A DAY FOR BILLS THAT
ARE DEALING. WITH THE RAVAGES
IT WE'VE HAD TO SUFFER WITH
FIRES. AND PUBLIC SAFETY HAVE
SHUT OFFS. AND STATE A
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL IS AN
ATTEMPT TO HELP OUR- VERY
CHALLENGED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
DEAL WITH THESE PUBLIC SAFETY
SHUT OFF. THE AREA HAVE CERTAIN
OBLIGATIONS TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND THE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE THERE. TO THE DIVIDING
THEM SERVICES REQUIRE THIS
POWER. AND IT'S BEST THAT WE
MAKE IT IS UNINTERRUPTED AS WE
CAN'T. NOW AS WE FOUND OUT
THROUGH THIS CHALLENGING TIME
THERE ARE MANY ESSENTIAL THINGS
THAT THIS POWER PROVIDES. WHAT
THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO DO HELLO
WILL DO FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO ENSURE THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE. SUPPLYING THEIR
OBLIGATIONS TO US. AND NOT GET
THEMSELVES INTO LEGAL
DIFFICULTIES SWITCH SOMEWHERE
DOWN THE WAY WILL HAPPEN IF WE
DO NOT ADDRESS THIS. THIS
ALLOWS THEM TO BE FREE OF THE
SEVEN AND A HALF PERCENT STATE
STATE SALES TAX AND USE TAX.
FOR THE ACQUISITION. A BACKUP
GENERATION EQUIPMENT. THEY'RE
ALL GOING TO BE DOING THIS. BUT
THEY ARE ALL NOW FISCALLY
CHALLENGED. THIS IS A SMALL WAY.
TO HELP EASE THAT BURDEN ON OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES PROTECTORS
FROM NAPA FROM HEALDSBURG SAN
FRANCISCO. AND DEEPER TAKEN
SUCH AN INTEREST IN THIS ISSUE.
AND WE WORK COLLECTIVELY
TOGETHER. NOW PART OF WHAT I'M
REFERRING TO HERE AS TO THIS
PARTICULAR BILL NINE FIFTY TWO
IS IT IT'S STILL REQUIRING SOME
WORK. TO ENSURE I THINK WE'VE
GOT IT COVERED BUT I'M GOING TO
TAKE NO CHANCES ABOUT THAT. AS
WE PROCEED WITH THE BILL. WE'RE
GONNA MAKE IT VERY CLEAR. THE
DISHES ENERGY SOURCE NEUTRAL.
NEUTRAL THAT MEANS THAT OTHER
THINGS THAT ARE IMPORTANT IN
THIS COMPLEX WAY OF PROVIDING
OUR ENERGY SERVICES. ARE GOING
TO BE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT FOR
WHATEVER THAT SOURCE OF POWER
MAY BE OR INCLUDING THE
BATTERIES THE STORE. RESERVES
FOR THOSE NEEDED TIME. WHY IS
IT IMPORTANT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN OVER THE YEARS I'VE
REPRESENTED NINETEEN DIFFERENT
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES. I AM A
VERY SYMPATHETIC WITH THEIR
FLIGHT MORE SO THAN I EVER HAVE
BEEN TO CITY CITIES HAVE FEWER
MANDATES AND MANY MORE OPTIONS.
TO SECURE REVENUE. THE ACCOUNT
X. COUNTIES HAVE THE BLUNT.
MANDATES THAT OF A PRESS THEM
FOREVER AND MUCH FEWER OPTIONS
OPTIONS TO PROVIDE REVENUE. BUT
THIS HELPS SMALL IN TERMS OF
THIS PUBLIC POWER. DOES IT
REQUIRE ANY GIVEN SCHORSCH.
THERE'S ALWAYS CONCERN LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN ABOUT. DIESEL
PETROLEUM SOURCES DOES NOT THIS
IS WHAT I SAY NEUTRAL. THE
LOCAL ENTITY CAN DECIDE WHAT IS
THE BEST TO FIT THEIR
PARTICULAR NEEDS. AND THEN FOR
THAT AND- THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
GAIN A GENERAL. A RELIEF FROM
THE SALES TAX ISSUE. NOW THERE
WAS A QUESTION ABOUT WHY
COULDN'T WE JUST FUND THESE
THINGS DIRECTLY OUT OF THE
BUDGET. WELL WE KNOW LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN THAT THAT'S ALWAYS A
CHALLENGING TIME FOR US. IT IS
NOT MY WANT HERE TO OBLIGE OUR
GENERAL FUND. TOO MUCH NOW YOU
GIVE SOME SALES TAX RELIEF THAT
HURTS JUST A LITTLE BIT BUT I
BELIEVE IT'S THE MOST DIRECT
AND HELPFUL MANNER TO HELP. OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. THERE IS
ALSO A REQUIREMENT IN HERE FOR
MONITORING AND REPORTING. TO
THE LEGISLATURE. HOW THIS IS
PROCEEDING. THE DEPARTMENT OF
TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION
WOULD BE CHARGED WITH REVIEWING
AND REPORTING TO THIS HONORABLE
BODY. OF THE PROGRESS THAT THIS
MAKES THE REVENUE AND HOW IT IS
BEING UTILIZED. SO GETTING BACK
TO. THE ORIGINAL PURPOSE HERE.
YES TO HAVE ANOTHER TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX. FOR US TO ENSURE THAT
THESE PUBLIC POWER.
INTERRUPTIONS SHUT OFFS IS A
HARSH TERM. OUR AS EASILY
MANAGED AS POSSIBLE. I WOULD WE
NOT IN CALIFORNIA EXCEPT THE PS
PS IS A PART OF OUR FUTURE. WE
JUST HAVE TO LEARN TO LIVE WITH.
I EXPECT TO SOME DEGREE IT MAY
WELL BE. BUT ARE NOT NOT BE THE
PREFERRED OPTION. AND WHATEVER
WE DO WE NEED TO PROVIDE SOME
ASSISTANCE. TO THE CITIZENS TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR NEEDS ARE MET.
CONSISTENT WITH THE BEST
INTEREST OF OUR CITIES ARE
COUNTIES ARE SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
THEREFORE I ASK THAT YOU HELP
WITH THIS VOTE I'LL BE HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
MEMBERS. THANK YOU CENTER
NIELSEN DEBATER DISCUSSION
SENATOR STERN. AT THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I WANT TO THANK.
THE DEAN MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM
TO HEMA FOR HIS EFFORTS HERE
AND I KNOW IT'S BEEN- LIFE AND
DEATH CIRCUMSTANCES UP THERE
<c.cyan>OR TOO LONG- OUR POWER WENT</c>
DOWN. HAD SOME OF VERY
HARROWING EXPERIENCES OURSELVES
DURING PS PS SO I GET THE
URGENCY OF THE MEASURE-
UNFORTUNATELY I CAN'T SUPPORT.
THE BILL TODAY. NOT BECAUSE I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT DIESEL
GENERATOR SHOULDN'T BE THERE IS
A SORT OF LAST RESORT BACK UP
AND I THINK AS OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM MARANDA AND NAPA EARLIER
WE MADE EFFORTS TO ACCOMMODATE
THAT SORT A LAST RESORT
EMERGENCY THIS. I RECOGNIZE THE
DIESEL WILL HAVE TO BE IN THE
MIX IN SOME WAY. BUT WHEN IT
COMES USING TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO
INCENTIVIZE BEHAVIOR. AND TO
PUT PROACTIVE MONEY ON THE
TABLE I REALLY THINK WE SHOULD
BE INCENTIVIZING- TECHNOLOGY
THAT ISN'T GOING TO PUT OUR AIR
QUALITY A RISK OR BOTTOM LINES
AT RISK- I APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT ON TRYING TO MAKE THE
BILL TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL. I
GUESS I DON'T I'M NOT NEUTRAL
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS ISSUE IT
I THINK THE ONLY INCENTIVES WE
SHOULD BE PUTTING ON THE LINER
SAY FOR SOLAR STORAGE SYSTEMS
ARE FOR FUEL CELL SYSTEMS ARE
FOR OTHER. CLEAN ENERGY
TECHNOLOGY IN FACT WE HAVE A
GREAT PROGRAM NOW TO SEE IF YOU
SEE THAT ALLOWS THAT AND OUR
OUR BUT IT JUST ALLOCATE
ACTUALLY FIFTEEN DOLLARS FOR.
CUT POWER FOR CAN THIS. THERE
IS FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
CURRENT BUDGET FOR COUNTIES AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DO THEIR
OWN BACK UP. UNFORTUNATELY THE
DEFAULT FOR A LOT OF COUNTIES
FROM THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
THAT WE PUT IN LAST YEAR WAS
ALL THESE. IT'S AN EASY THING
TO DEFAULT TO. I GET THAT IT'S
HARD TO DO THIS DILIGENCE AND
TRY TO FIND THESE NEW SOLUTIONS
BUT- I REALLY THINK WE SHOULD
BE ENCOURAGING WITH OUR
TAXPAYER DOLLARS- THE SORT OF
FUTURE SOLUTIONS THAT TO ME ARE
HERE RIGHT NOW CLEAN ENERGY
MICRO GRADES. ENERGY STORAGE OF
SOLAR STORAGE COMBINATIONS THEY
CAN BE DONE SO- I DEEPLY
RESPECT MIGHT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
DANA BUT- TO GREEN. THANK YOU
SIR STERN CENTER WERE CASKEY
HIGHER RIE RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION OF THE MEASURE
ALTHOUGH I VOTED FOR IN
APPROPRIATIONS YESTERDAY TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THIS DEBATE I TO
WILL CHOI MY OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM- CALABASAS IS SAID THESE
THESE- GOVERNMENT MONEY CEASAR
COUNTIES WE WANT COUNTIES TO BE
LEADERSHIP IN ALTERNATIVE
ENERGY AND HIS NEW TECHNOLOGY
CENTER THAT ARE GOING ON A I
APPRECIATE THE ATTEMPT TO BE
ENERGY NEUTRAL IT'S- IT'S A
OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE NOW TO SEE
A WE WANT YOU TO BUY THESE TYPE
OF THESE HOLSTERS. ON THURS
RENEW ALL ENERGY ALTERNATIVES
TO DIESEL THAT EXIST RIGHT NOW
THAT I'D LIKE TO COURAGE ALL
THE COUNTIES TO BE USING TO
PURCHASE SO WITH THAT I'LL BE.
VOTING NO. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEMS SHIPPING IN HEARING ON
SENATOR NIELSEN YOU MAY CLOSE.
MADAM PRESIDENT LATE IN GENERAL
THE SENATE. I APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTIVENESS THEN THE
SUGGESTIONS OF MY COLLEAGUES AS
WELL. I BELIEVE THAT IN TERMS
OF OUR ENERGY FUTURE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE TO HAVE
MANY OPTIONS. A MARKET BASKET
OF SOURCES AND OPPORTUNITIES
CERTAINLY THE ENCOURAGEMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY WHICH WERE DOING A
MAGNIFICENT JOB OF. IN THE AREA
THAT I REPRESENT HIS. BEEN KIND
OF PIONEERING IN LOCATING A
ONLY AN HOUR WIND POWER.
BECAUSE WE HAVE KIND OF UNIQUE
GEOGRAPHY OF YOUR GRAPHICAL
CONFIGURATIONS THAT PERMIT THAT.
THAT'S BUT ANOTHER SOURCE
FULLER IS EVERYWHERE AND IT'S
GONE A LONG WAYS. WE'VE DONE A
LOT TO ENCOURAGE THAT
PARTICULAR OPTION. I EXPECT TO
WILL CONTINUE TO. IN THE FUTURE.
AND AGAIN I DO NOT OFFER THAT
THIS IS THE OVERALL SUGGESTION.
BUT IT IS A VERY IMPORTANT TOOL
IN THE TOOLBOX. TO ENSURE THAT
OUR CITIZENS DO NOT FACE AND
SUFFER INTERRUPTIONS THAT IN
SOME CASES. COULD BE LIFE
THREATENING AND JEOPARDIZING. I
URGE AND REQUEST A NO VOTE WITH
MY PLEDGE IF WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE
LANGUAGE TO BE EX EXPRESSLY
LEGALLY. MANIFESTING OUR INTENT
THE HAVE A BROAD BASKET.
BROUGHT UP PERTINENTES AND TO
BE VERY SPECIFIC IN THE LEGAL
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL WILL TAKE
THAT THOSE AMENDMENTS AS WE
MOVE ALONG AND WORK WITH THE
INTERESTED PARTIES TO
ACCOMPLISH IT JUST AS WE HAVE
HERE SO FAR DIRE GINGIVAL.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN ALL
DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA SO NO ATKINS. I
BATES I FELL I FORGES I
BRADFORD I HAVE A- I CHIANG I
DALLY. I DODD I TOURISM.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER HI GONZALEZ.
GROWTH. HERTZBERG I PROVIDE
HILL I HUESO. I TADO I JACKSON.
JONES I LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S AYE MITCHELL NO
MONNING. MORE LOCK OR I MARROW.
I NIELSEN. HI PAN FIVE
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO I
SKINNER NO STERN. NO I'M VERY I
Y. CASKEY. NO WIENER NO WILK I.
LEYVA I DON'T KNOW PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN NO.
THEY'RE AWESOME. GONZALEZ NO.
JACKSON MONNING. NO. THERE ARE
OTHER NO. HIGHS TWENTY EIGHT
NOS ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
SIX SENATOR RUBIO. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL ELEVEN FORTY ONE BY
SENATOR RUBIO AN ACT RELATING
TO COERCIVE CONTROL SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES GENTLEMEN
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT SB ELEVEN FORTY
ONE A BILL THAT DEFINES
pCOERCIVE CONTROL AND THE FAMILY
CODE. THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SB
ELEVEN FORTY ONE IS CRITICAL
BECAUSE AS WE KNOW DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS NOT LIMITED TO
PHYSICAL BRUISES AND ABUSE. IT
ALSO INVOLVES A PATTERN OF BOB
CONTROL TO WHICH AN ABUSER
DOMINATES EVERY ASPECT OF THE
VICTIMS LINE LIFE CAUSING
SEVERE EMOTIONAL DISTRESS SOME
EXAMPLES OF. CHORUS OF CONTROL
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
CONSTANT SURVEILLANCE A GRADUAL
ISOLATION AWAY FROM FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. WITHHOLDING FINANCES
AND BASIC NECESSITIES
NECESSITIES INCLUDING USING
THEIR OWN CHILDREN TO
MANIPULATE THE SITUATION AND
KEEP CONTROL. IT MAKES IT
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR ANY
VICTIM TO GET AWAY.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS PANDEMIC HAS
PUT A SPOTLIGHT ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. DATA SHOWS THE
NUMBER OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CALLS TO THE NATIONAL HOTLINE
ARE DRASTICALLY INCREASING AS
VICTIMS ARE LOCKED IN WITH
THEIR ABUSERS. NEARLY TEN
STATES ACROSS THE US HAVE
ALREADY IDENTIFIED THE
IMPORTANCE OF NADINE MAY NEED
THIS TYPE OF ABUSE IN THEIR
STATUTES. THIS BILL SIMPLY
ALLOW THE VICTIM TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. BUT I WANT
TO BE VERY CLEAR THAT A JUDGE
STILL HAS TO REVIEW THE
EVIDENCE. AND DETERMINE IF
THERE IS AN ONGOING PATTERN OF
ABUSE THAT SATISFIES ALL
ELEMENTS OF THE LAW. THIS ALSO
INCLUDES A BUILT IN DEFENSE OF
REASONABLE NOW SO WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THAT CONTACT. UNDER
REASONABLE CIRCUMSTANCES IS
EXCLUDED FROM THIS BILL EXACT.
ONCE AGAIN MEMBERS THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT MEASURE IT IS
TIME THAT WE STRENGTHEN OUR
LOSS FOR SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND ADDRESS THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE. JUST BECAUSE
VICTIMS DON'T WALK AROUND WITH
BRUISES ALL OVER THEIR BODY
DOES NOT MEAN THEY'RE NOT BEING
ABUSED AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR RIFLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR CHAINS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESENT MEMBERS
DURING THE STAY AT HOME ORDER
OTHER CHALLENGES CAME OUT OF
THAT IN PARTICULAR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND ABUSE GREW. BUT AS
WE RE OPEN ECONOMY THESE ISSUES
ARE GOING AWAY THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL THAT RECOGNIZES
ABUSE COMES IN MANY FORMS NOT
JUST PHYSICAL ABUSE. WHEN YOU
CONTROL SOMEONE FINANCES YOU
MONITOR THEM. ISOLATE THEM FROM
FRIENDS AND FAMILY AND
INTIMIDATE THEM THAT IS ABUSE.
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRING THIS BILL TO US AND FOR
BEING A LEADER IN THE SPACE. I
ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU SIR CHIANG SENATOR
BORCHERS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I TOO WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO THE
AUTHOR BRING THIS MATTER
FORWARD I THINK SHE HAS SHOWN
HERSELF TO BE A LEADER IN THIS
AREA OF THE LAW IN THIS AREA
PUBLIC POLICY HAVE YOU DONE A
GREAT JOB AND- HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THIS THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK.
THANK YOU SIR BORDERS ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SITTING IN HEARING NONE CHEN
RUBIO YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES FROM MIAMI TO BRING
THIS FORWARD AND JUST WITH THAT
I URGE ARRIVAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING ARE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ON THIS MEASURE. SEEING
AND HEARING NOT BUT THERE IS
OBJECTION MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE. THERE IS NO OBJECTION.
ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD ICE FORTY
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
SENATOR GROW. FOR WHAT PURPOSE
MAY REQUEST A REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
IN THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE FOR
FIVE MNUTES A SHORT REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE.
BACK TO THE DAILY
FILE STARTING WITH FILE ITEM
THIRTY. YEAH ONE MOMENT.
COLLEAGUES IF WE COULD GO- BACK
INTO SESSION HERE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING BILLS
WILL BE PLACED ON TODAY'S
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR FILE
ITEMS FORTY SIX. FIFTY TO SIXTY
TO SIXTY FOUR SIXTY NINE AND
LET ME GO THROUGH THOSE AGAIN
AND READ THE BILL NUMBERS FILE
ITEM FORTY SIX IS SB NINE
THIRTY TWO FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO
IS SB TEN SIXTY FIVE FILE ITEM
SIXTY TWO IS SB TWELVE THIRTY
TWO FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR IS SB
TWELVE SIXTY FOUR. FILE ITEM
SIXTY NINE IS SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY AND WITH THAT WE WILL
NOW TAKE UP THE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL AT. NINE
THIRTY TO TEN SIXTY FIVE TWELVE
THIRTY TO TWELVE SIXTY FOUR AND
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE AYE AYES FORTY
KNOWS ZERO THE SPECIALS CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. ALRIGHT WE
ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
THE DAILY FILE AND WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH FILE ITEM THIRTY
SEVEN SENATOR LABOR. AND
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THANK.
BOB AT THE SENATE BILL TWELVE
THIRTEEN VICE LEYVA. BEFORE WE
DO THAT SENATOR DOLLY FOR WHAT
PURPOSE SIR. DID WE TAKE A VOTE
ON THE LISTENER RUBIO'S BILL.
YES OKAY WE DID A UNIT I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL OF FORTY TWO ZERO.
VERY GOOD ALL RIGHT NOW OF. BEN
SCHECTER PLEASE READ FILE ITEM
THIRTY SEVEN. SENATE BILL
TWELVE THIRTEEN BY SENATOR
LEYVA AN ACT RELATING TO PEOPLE
INSTRUCTION. SENATOR LABOR THE
FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS SB TWELVE THIRTEEN WILL
ALLOW FOR THE UPDATING OF OUR
STATE'S HISTORY SOCIAL SCIENCE
ACADEMIC CONTENT STANDARDS
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL DIRECTS
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION IN CONSULTATION
WITH VERY STAKEHOLDERS TO
RECOMMEND REVISIONS OF THE
HISTORY SOCIAL SCIENCE CONTENT
STANDARDS. TO THE STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION BY NOVEMBER
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY THREE
UNLIKE CURRICULUM FRAMEWORK
WHICH IS ON AN EIGHT YEAR CYCLE
THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT TO
UPDATE CONTENT STANDARDS OUR
STATE'S HISTORY SOCIAL SCIENCE
STANDARDS HAVE NOT BEEN UPDATED
SINCE THEY WERE ORIGINALLY DOT
ADOPTED. IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT TWENTY TWO YEARS AGO SB
TWELVE THIRTEEN WILL ENSURE
THAT OUR STUDENTS RECEIVE THE
HIGHEST QUALITY INSTRUCTION IN
THE HISTORY SOCIAL SCIENCE
WHICH INCLUDE ECONOMICS CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT IN FINANCIAL
LITERACY THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON FILE
ITEM THIRTY SEVEN. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO SUBSTANCE. OR OKAY
SO FAR WE HAVE A MEMBER OFF THE
FLOOR SO WE CAN'T. THE. THIRTY
NINE ZERO. WHAT DO WE DO THAT
WE'RE GOING TO WITHOUT
pROLL CALL OF THIRTY NINE TWO
ZERO AND THEN WE WILL PLACE A
CALL FOR THAT ABSENT MEMBERS.
UNLESS THERE'S A IS YOUR
OBJECTION THERE'S OBJECTION. IF
THERE'S THE IT. LET'S GO AHEAD
AND CALL THE ROLL. IN PLACE OF
ALL. WE NOW ALL THE ROLE AND
THEN MOVE A CALL PLEASE SIR
PROCEED MADAME SECTOR CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES. I FELL HI
GORGEOUS. BRADFORD I HAVE A
YELLOW I CHIANG I DALLY. I DON.
I TORONTO. I GALGIANI I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ. I GROWTH. FIVE
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO. I
TADO. JACKSON I JONES HI LEYVA.
FIVE MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S.
MITCHELL. HI MONNING. I MORE
LOCK. I RURAL. I NIELSEN I PAN.
I PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO. I
SKINNER. I STERN. I NUMBER NINE
I WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER I
WILK I. LAWCENTER LABOR MOVES A
CALL MOVING ON NOW TO A FILE
ITEM THIRTY EIGHT. SENATOR HILL
IS PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL NOT
SEVEN NINETY THREE BY SENATOR
AN ACTUAL LEADING TO TOBACCO
PRODUCTS SENATOR HILL THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS E. CIGARETTE USE
AMONG PEOPLE SURGED AMONG YOUNG
PEOPLE SEARCH BY ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE PERCENT. AND
THERE ARE NOW FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION YOUNG AMERICANS WHO USE
E. CIGARETTES REGULARLY IT IS
IMPORTANT UNDERSCORE THE
EXPLOSION OF FATE FLAVORED
NICOTINE PRODUCTS AND THE ROLE
THEY PLAY BOTH IN THIS EPIDEMIC
AND IN ADDICTING NEW USERS.
FLAVORS LIKE BUBBLE GUM LIMóN
DROPPING FRUIT LOOPS ARE WIDELY
AVAILABLE AND PERVASIVELY
MARKETED 80% OF YOUTH THAT
EIGHTY PERCENT OF YOUTH THAT
HAVE USED TOBACCO STARTED WITH
THE FLAVORED PRODUCT. THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF TEEN
SMOKERS AND PAPERS REPORT USE
OF POPULAR FRUIT MENTHOL OR
MINT FLAVORS BIG TOBACCO ARGUES
LIKE FLAVORS LIKE BUBBLE GUM
CATER TO ADULT TICKETS BUT THE
DATA SHOWS THE FLAVOR TOBACCO
USE IS SUBSTANTIALLY HIGHER
WITH YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULTS.
MENTHOL CIGARETTES SWEETS
CIGARS CANDIDATES AND OTHER
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS MASS
FOR THE HARMLESS IN HARSHNESS
OF TOBACCO AND GET USERS HOPED
TO A DANGEROUSLIFELONG
ADDICTION. FOR THE FDA HAS
ESTABLISHED SOME RESTRICTIONS
ON THE CIGARETTES THE FEDERAL
POLICY FAILS DANGEROUSLY AND
FALL SHORT IN IS RIDDLED WITH
LOOPHOLES THE FEDERAL RULES
EXEMPT FALL THE ORIGINAL CANDY
FLAVOR CAN ONLY RESTRICT
FLAVORS IN SOME CARTRIDGE BASED
THE CIGARETTES THIS STILL
LEAVES E. LIQUIDS IN EVERY
IMAGINAL FLAVOR WIDELY
AVAILABLE. THE TOBACCO INDUSTRY
HAS ALREADY INTRODUCED THE NEXT
FAD. HEAP DISPOSABLE E.
CIGARETTES THEY'RE CALLED TOUGH
BARS. ARE REMARKABLY SIMILAR TO
THE JEWEL DEVICE. AND COMEIN
FLAVORS LIKE BANANA ICE GRAY
AND PINK LEMONADE PUFF BARS ARE
EASY TO CONCEAL AND WIDELY
AVAILABLE BECAUSE THEY ARE
EXEMPT FROM FEDERAL E.
CIGARETTE RESTRICTIONS. THIS IS
JUST ONE OF THE MANY KIND KID
FRIENDLY PRODUCTS THAT ARE
EXEMPT. I KNOW WE HAVE HAD TO
ASSESS AND TO REASSESS OUR
PRIORITIES IN RESPONSE TO THE
DEVASTATING COVERT NINETEEN
EPIDEMIC. EMERGING EVIDENCE
ABOUT SMOKING AND COVERT
NINETEEN SUGGESTS THAT SMOKING
CAN PUT PEOPLE AT GREATER RISK.
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION WARNS
THE TOBACCO USE CAN INCREASE
THE RISK OF SUFFERING THE MOST
SEVERE SYMPTOMS OF COVERT
NINETEE. WE KNOW CONCLUSIVELY
THAT SMOKING AND IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD VAPING INCREASES
RISK OF RESPIRATORY INFECTION
WEAKENS THE IMMUNE SYSTEM AND
IS A MAJOR UNDERLYING CAUSE OF
LUNG DISEASE AND HEART DISEASE
AND DIABETES. THIS PANDEMIC
COMPELS US TO PURGE SMOKERS TO
QUIT AND ESTABLISH POLICIES
THAT INSURE YOUTH NEVER PICK UP
THE HABIT IN THE FIRST PLACE.
SB SEVEN NINETY THREE TAKES
WITH ACTION TO PROTECT YOUTH
AND VULNERABLE POPULATIONS BY
PROHIBITING THE RETAIL SALE OF
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
ADULTS CAN STILL BE ABLE TO
PURCHASE UNFLAVORED PRODUCT AT
RETAIL OR PURCHASE ANY THEY CAN
PURCHASE ANY FLAVORED PRODUCT
ONLINE. I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THEY CAN STILL PURCHASE
ANY FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS
ONLINE. WELL I AM DISGUSTED BY
THE U. THE CIGARETTE EPIDEMIC
I'M NOT SURPRISED. IT IS IN
LINE WITH BIG TOBACCO'S LONG
TRACK RECORD OF DESTROYING AND
DEVASTATING OUR COMMUNITIES.
BECAUSE OF THE INDUSTRIES AND
TOBACCO INDUSTRY'S TACTICS LOW
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY FORTINOS AN AFRICAN
AMERICANS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BURDENED BUT
TOBACCO RELATED MORBIDITY AND
DEATH. INSIDIOUS MARKETING OF
MENTHOL CIGARETTES HAS EXPLODED
AFRICAN AMERICAN NEIGHBORHOODS
FOR DECADES. FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND AFRICAN AMERICANS DIE
FROM A SMOKING CAUSED ILLNESS
EACH YEAR. AN ESTIMATED ONE
POINT SIX MILLION AFRICAN
AMERICANS UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN WILL BECOME REGULAR
SMOKERS AND ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WILL DIE PREMATURELY
FROM A TOBACCO RELATED DISEASE.
IT'S A FACT STORE FRONT TOBACCO
ADVERTISING IS MORE PROMINENT
IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. THE
TOBACCO INDUSTRY HAS A TARGET
ARE THE AUDIENCE OVER 90% OF
SMOKERS START BEFORE THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN. THE AVERAGE AGE OF A
NEW SMOKER IS THIRTEEN AND I'VE
GONE BACK AND THOUGHT FOR THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS. AND NO ONE
HAS EVER TOLD ME I'VE NEVER
ENCOUNTERED ANYONE THAT SAYS.
WHEN THEY WAKE UP WEATHER TO
TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY NINE OR THIRTY
THEY WAKE UP IN THE MORNING SAY.
I THINK I'M GONNA STICK UP
SMOKING TODAY. IT JUST DOESN'T
HAPPEN THAT WAY TO ENTICING
FLAVORS COLORFUL PACKAGING AND
NAMES AND LOGOS SIMILAR TO
POPULAR TYPES OF CANDY HAVE
BEEN USED SINCE I WAS A CHILD
TO GET US HOOKED. BIG TOBACCO
WEAPONIZED DECADES OF TREACHERY
TO LURE A NEW GENERATION TO
NICOTINE ADDICTION. IT'S TIME
THAT WE BREAK THAT CYCLE
CALLING. THANK YOU SENATOR HILL
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION STARTING
WAS SENATOR TO ROSS SO FOLLOWED
BY SENATOR BORCHERS. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION AS PRINCIPAL COOPER
OF THIS MEASURE THE BABY AN
EPIDEMIC AMONG OUR YOUTH IS
BEING DRIVEN BY THE WIDESPREAD
USE OF E. CIGARETTES AND E.
LIQUIDS USED IN BAKED THESE
DEVICES AND THE STATISTICS
DEPICTING THIS PROBLEM. ARE
ALARMING IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
ALONE E. CIGARETTE USE AMONG
YOUNG PEOPLE SEARCH BY A
HUNDRED AND 35% THERE ARE NOW
FIVE POINT THREE MILLION YOUNG
AMERICANS WHO USE EASE
CIGARETTES REGULARLY. 80% OF
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAVE EVER USED
TO BATTLE STARTED WITH THE
FLAVORED PRODUCT IT'S TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO TAKE THE STAND.
AGAINST THE WIDESPREAD
ADVERTISEMENT AND SELLING OF
THESE PRODUCTS TO PROTECT OUR
YOUTH I ASK FOR YOUR IBM. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALSO SENATOR BOARD
JUST. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND-
THE CO SPONSOR INTENDING
GOVERNOR FOR- BRINGING UP THIS
ISSUE I THINK WHAT I'VE SEEN-
IN MY FORMER CAPACITY IS AN
EDUCATOR I'VE SEEN THAT THERE
ARE SYSTEM- LESS THAN
REPUTABLE. ADVERTISERS IN THE
INDUSTRY THAT DO- FIND WAYS TO
CAPTURE- INVOLVING MARKET EARLY
ON SO I THINK WE DO KNOW THAT-
THE YOUTH OR VULNERABLE AND
MARKETING DOES WORK AND I CAN
HARKING BACK TO. THE US
CIGARETTE COMPANY THAT AT ONE
POINT TIME DURING WORLD WAR TWO
WAS GIVING OUT CIGARETTES TO G.
EYES. IT WASN'T BASED ON
PATRIOTISM IT WAS BASED ON
CREATING- A LOYALTY TO THE
BRAND IN THE USERS. THE JOINT I
KNOW IT'S THERE. MY QUESTION IS
THIS SUFFICIENTLY TAYLOR SO
LIKE. IF I COMPOSE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS- TO YOU THROUGH THE
CHAIR. MADAM CHAIR. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SO I UNDERSTAND THIS
DOES NOT THIS THIS BILL DOES
NOT COVER ADVERTISING IT IS NOT
TAILORED TO MECHANIZED
CIGARETTES. IT INCLUDES CHEWING
TOBACCO CIGARS AND A LIST WE
HAVE. I SUPPOSE SNUFFY PEOPLE
EVEN USE NOTHING MORE. BUT MY
QUESTION TO YOU IS HOW WAS IT
DIFFERENT HOW IS THIS NOT. THE
RIVER IS COULD YOU IMAGINE THIS
BEING MORE TAILORED NARROWLY TO
GO AFTER THE MOST UNIQUE IN
VULNERABLE- SEGMENTS OF THE
POPULATION WHILE STILL
PRESERVING THE RIGHTS OF FREE
CHOICE. AND THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION I THINK THIS IS
TAILORED BECAUSE ITS GOAL IS TO
ELIMINATE ALL FLAVORS AND AS I
MENTIONED 80% OF ALL THE NEW
YOUNG SMOKERS FOR PAPERS OR
WHATEVER PRODUCT. USE A
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS SO
IT'S THE HARSHNESS OF THE
TOBACCO IN THE CASE THAT WHEN I
TOOK MY FIRST HIT OF A
CIGARETTE I THINK IT WAS
THIRTEEN AT THE TIME THAT WAS
THE LAST ONE. BECAUSE IT TASTED
LIKE. OKAY FRANKLY. AND I
WASN'T INTERESTED IN ANYTHING
BEYOND THAT AND WHEN YOU LOOK
AT OTHER PRODUCTS LIKE A CIGAR.
WE FIND IT INTERESTING THAT
WHICH I THINK IS AN INTERESTING
NUMBER THAT. YOUTH THE SECOND
HIGHEST USE OF A NUMBER OF
SMOKERS AFFECT THE HEAD OF THE
NUMBER HERE. IS CIGAR SMOKING
BY YOU IS THE SECOND HIGHEST I
MEAN THAT IS THEIR SECOND CALL
BACK IS SMOKING FLAVORED
TOBACCO CIGAR BUT SOME TIME TO
THE ID IS THE FLAVOR NOT THE
DEVICE THAT IS ATTRACTING THE
YOUNG PEOPLE TO THE NICOTINE
AND THEN ONCE THEY GET ADDICTED
TO THAT NICOTINE- THEY STILL
WANT INCREASE FLAVOR BUT THEN
THEY WILL DEFAULT TO WHATEVER
PROVIDES THAT NICOTINE FIX IN
THE FUTURE. ALRIGHT I WON'T
BELABOR THIS MUCH FURTHER- THIS
IS A FINANCIAL- IS ISSUED BY
PHONE OR IN YOUR OWN TIME
SENATOR THIS WILL BE MY LOOK I
STILL SECOND MY LAST QUESTION
FOR YOU ACCEPT THE SECOND
QUESTION CENTER HILL YES IS
THAT HE CERTAIN CERTAIN FUNDING
SOURCES THAT MAKE THEIR WAY.
ROAD OR OTHER SERVICES THAT WE
HAVE IN QUE KEPT THE COUNTY
LEVEL MYBE THROUGH THE STATE-
HAVE WE DEVISED A WAY TO BACK
FILL THE DOLLARS THAT WILL
LIKELY BE LOS BASED ON THE
REDUCED. REVENUE BROUGHT ABOUT
BY. THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
BECAUSE WE EXPECT TO BETTER USE
WILL PROBABLY DECREASE SOME
BECAUSE OF IT. AND I KNOW FOR
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE FRESNO COUNTY
HAD A MEASURES SEVEN WAS A
MAJOR SEE BACK IN THE DAY WHICH
WENT TO- HIGHWAY WIDENING AND
STUFF LIKE THAT BASED ON
TOBACCO USAGE IF I REMEMBER
CORRECTLY. DO WE HAVE A BACK
FILL OF THE PROJECTED LOSS. TO
PASS THAT IS THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- THERE ARE THERE ARE
TWO PATHS THERE ONE IS- IT
FRANKLY AS I LOOK AT IT THERE
IS NO PRICE THAT WE SHOULD BE.
PAYING NOR A PRICE THAT WE
SHOULD SAY THAT WE HAVE TO BACK
FILL OR PROVIDE IF WE IF THIS
IS MONEY THAT. IS NOT SPENT
THEIR OWN LIVES SAVED IN THAT
THE ESTIMATE RIGHT NOW FROM A
SOME VERY VALID SOURCES THAT
THEY WOULD SAVE AT LEAST
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND LIVES IN
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN HEALTHCARE COSTS. BECAUSE
THOSE PEOPLE WILL BE SUFFERING
WILL NOT HAVE IT BUT TO ME IT'S
DOLLARS JUST AS WE DO IT DEALT
WITH COVERT NINETEEN IN THE
PROBLEMS THERE WE WERE WILLING.
TO SAVE A LIFE TO GIVE UP A
LARGE PORTION OF THE ECONOMY OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
PRICE WE PAY IN ORDER TO SAVE
LIVES. AND I THINK THERE'S NO
PRICE. THAT WE SHOULD PAY IN
ORDER HERE OR- ASSUME THAT WE-
A WILL LOSE TO SAVE THE LIVES
OF THE NEXT GENERATION AND THAT
NEXT GENERATION BECAUSE IT WILL
CONTINUE AFTER THAT SO. THAT
THAT WOULD BE MY- MY ANSWER TO
THAT TO THAT QUESTION IS THAT
THERE'S A THERE'S NO. NO DOLLAR
AMOUNT AND- SECONDLY THAT THE
HEALTH CARE COST SAVINGS. WILL
EQUAL THAT AMOUNT AT LEAST
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZERS. THANK YOU I'M AT AND
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I WANT
AYE AYE RIGHTS TAKEN AND THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL THE SENATOR
FROM THE PENINSULA FOR HIS FOR
HIS COURAGE AND PERSISTENCE IN
THIS MATTER THIS IS THE SECOND
YEAR THAT YOU HAVE LED US
TOGETHER TO MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD. BUT THAT IT'S A GREAT
BILL AND I AM PLEASED TO BE ONE
OF YOUR JOINT AUTHORS- IF YOU
TALK TO YOUR CHILDREN YOUR
FRIENDS CHILDREN YOUR NIECES
AND NEPHEWS YOU'LL BE VERY
CLEAR TO YOU THAT THIS IS A
EPIDEMIC OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
TODAY IT'S COMMON ALMOST IT
SEEMS LIKE OUT OF NOWHERE- BUT
IT IS NOW THE ENTRY LEVEL DRUG
FOR OUR YOUTH THIS NICOTINE
ADDICTION- IT'S INSIDIOUS IT'S
INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS AND
ADDICTIVE. AND THIS LEGISLATION
IS LONG OVERDUE THANK OU
SENATOR AND I URGE AND I'VE A-
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZERS
CENTER RUBIO. BENT I RAISE
CATTLE EIGHT IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE- I THINK OUR OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN MATTEO FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I KNOW
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT- WE'VE
HAD DISCUSSIONS ON AND I
PERSONALLY BEEN WORKING ON IT
AND BEEN VERY VOCAL ON THIS- I
AM ALARMED EVERY TIME I SPEAK
TO SOME OF MY FELLOW TEACHERS
AT THE CREATIVE NEW WAYS THAT
MANUFACTURERS MANAGED TO GET
VAPING DEVICES INTO THE HANDS
OF OUR CHILDREN. I THE
CREATIVITY IN TERMS OF
PRODUCING SCHOOL SUPPLIES THAT
LOOK LIKE SCHOOL SUPPLIES BUT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY VAPING DEVICES
IS ASTONISHING TO ME FROM AND I
FROM STAPLERS TWO PENCILS TO
EVEN SURE IT'S AND SO I THINK
EVEN THOUGH THIS DOESN'T TACKLE
THE MANUFACTURER BEING OF THE
DEVICES JUST ELIMINATING THE
BABY IN FLAVOR SO ALONE I FEEL
IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO STOPPING
THIS EPIDEMIC US- OUR COLLEAGUE
JUST MENTIONED IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS THREE MILLION. THREE AND
MORE OF A YOU ARE EIGHTEEN THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
TACKLE NOW VALLEY LATER SO WITH
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE BOOK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO.
PAN THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
TO A TO AT THE GOD FROM SAN
MATTEO FOR LEADING- ON THIS
BILL AND PROUD TO ALSO BE A
JOINT AUTHOR ON THIS BILL THAT
IS- MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
HORRENDOUS SAID- THAT THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT TRYING TO PROTECT
OUR USE FROM BEING ADDICTED TO
NICOTINE. AS A GATEWAY DRUG WE
KNOW THAT PEOPLE WHO START
VAPING ARE MORE LIKELY TO
EXCUSE COMBUSTIBLE CIGARETTES.
AND WHILE SOME OF THE OPPONENTS
MAY SAY THAT VAPING IS QUOTE
SAFER. THAN CIGARETTES IT STILL
DOESN'T MAKE IT SAFE IT'S
DANGEROUS. AND WE DON'T WANT
OUR USE HOPE TO NICOTINE AND WE
HAVE. TREMENDOUS EVIDENCE TO
SHOW THAT THAT IS WHAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW. IN THAT
AND THEY'RE BEING ATTRACTED
BECAUSE OF THE FLAVORS. THAT'S
WHAT THE RESEARCH SHOWS SO THIS
BILL IS A NARROWLY TARGETED
BUILD TOWARD THAT VERY POINTS
THAT WE DO NOT WANT TO USE TO
START. USING A DEVICE THAT WILL
GET THEM HOOKED ON NICOTINE.
PROBABLY FOR DECADES. BECAUSE
IT'S VERY HARD TO STOP. IN FACT
ACTUALLY PHYSICIANS ARE
STRUGGLING WITH HOW TO WEAN.
YOU OFF THESE DEVICES- BECAUSE
OFTENTIMES IN NICOTINE DOSES IN
THESE DEVICES ARE MUCH HIGHER
THAN THEY CAN EVEN GET AND
COMBUSTIBLE CIGARETTE. THE
OTHER THING I WOULD DO ONE OF
ALSO TOUCH ON IS THERE IS A
QUESTION THAT WAS ASKED ABOUT.
BACK FILLING COSTS I WILL POINT
OUT THAT THE COST. OF THE
HEALTH CARE RELATED TO PEOPLE
WHO START VAPING AND THEN
PERHAPS MOVE ONTO COMBUSTIBLE
CIGARETTES. IS CERTAINLY A MUCH
GREATER BURDEN ON OUR STATE WE
HAVE A MEDI CAL PROGRAM- THAT-
PAYS FOR A THIRD OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS WE ALSO HAVE-
WORKERS WHO WE COVER ALSO
LOCALITIES HAVE THAT AS WELL.
IT'S CERTAINLY MUCH GREATER
THAN WHAT WE WOULD COLLECT IN
TAXES IN FACT THIS IS AN
ARGUMENT USED AGAINST PROP
FIFTY SIX WELL WAS NOT FOCUS
JUST ON BEEPING ON GENERAL
SOMEONE CIVIL WHAT HAPPENS OUR
ONE STOP SMOKING AND I SAID YOU
KNOW WHAT WE WOULD SAVE A LOT
MORE MONEY THAN ANY MONEY WE
WOULD GATHER FROM THIS BACK
ATTACKS AND THEY'LL BE EXACTLY
WHAT WE WANT TO HAVE HAPPEN.
AND SO I WOULD ARGUE THAT EVEN
FROM A STRICTLY FINANCIAL
STANDPOINT THIS BILL MAKES A
LOT OF SENSE BUT I CERTAINLY
HOPE WE WILL VOTE FOR THIS BILL
NOT BECAUSE JUST BECAUSE OF THE
FINANCIAL BENEFITS BUT BECAUSE-
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS
AND CERTAINLY THE MORE BENEFITS
WE DO NOT WANT TO SEE OUR USE.
ADDICTED TO NICOTINE I
ORGANIZED A THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR PAN SENATOR
MITCHELL FALL BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MADAM PRESIDENT I STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATOR HILL
SUPPORTED IN COMMITTEE- I'VE
TALKED OFTEN ABOUT- YOU KNOW
LONG CANCER. TAKING BOTH MY
FATHER AND BROTHER WHO WERE
EXPOSED TO SMOKING ON IN THE
MILITARY AND SO YOU KNOW THIS
IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE FOR ME OF AN
INDUSTRY THAT PREYS ON UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
ACCORDING TO A NATIONAL STUDY
SEVEN OUT OF TEN BLACK YOUTH
SMOKERS. I YOU KNOW OUR SMOKING
THE MENTHOL FLAVOR- IN THE
NATION WIDE CENSUS TRACKS WITH
A GREATER PROPORTION OF BLACK
RESIDENTS HAVE HIGHER TOBACCO
RETAILER DENSITY AND SO THIS IS
YET ANOTHER EXAMPLE THE NET THE
NEXT ITERATION FOR THIS
INDUSTRY- ARE THESE NEW
PRODUCTS IN TOOLS AND THEY
CONTINUE TO ONCE AGAIN PREY ON
UNDER REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
WHEN I LOOK AT. THE DANCER
PROJECTS WORK IN TERMS OF
MAPPING THE SPREAD OF COAL BUT
NOW LAKE COUNTY AND WHILE YOU
WHEN YOU GO FROM. WEST TO EAST
AND NORTHTO SOUTH. AND SEEING
HOW THE DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS WHO BEEN
IMPACTED BY THAT VIRUS THAT
ATTACKS THE LUNGS. TO HAVE PRE
EXISTING LONG VULNERABILITY AS
A RESULT OF LONG TERM SMOKING
ONLY EXACERBATES THAT AND SO IS
AN INDUSTRY THAT'S PREYED ON MY
COMMUNITY AND I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK TO ELEVATE THAT. AND DO
ALL I CAN TO STOP IT SO I'M
PROUD TO STAND IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN NINE THREE. THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL SENATOR
BRADFORD FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
MORAL. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND I TO WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR HIS HARD
WORK ON THIS ISSUE I WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR BY NO MEANS TO I
SUPPORT MARKETING TO KIDS AND I
THINK THE FLAVOR TOBACCO
INDUSTRY THAT IS CLEARLY WHERE
THEY HAVE TARGETED FOR THE LAST
TEN YEARS. ONE OF MY FIRST
BILLS WHEN I GOT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ELEVEN YEARS AGO
WAS THE BANNING OF FLAVORED
BLUNT WRAPS AND I WASN'T ABLE
TO GET THAT OUT OF
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE I
ARGUED STRONGLY THAT THIS WAS
TARGETING OUR YOUTH AND ELEVEN
YEARS WE'VE CLEARLY SEEN THE
EXPANSION OF THAT MARKING TO.
OUR YOUTH I STAND HERE AS AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO LOST. THIR
FATHER. TO LUNG CANCER DESPITE
STOP SMOKING FOURTEEN YEARS
BEFORE HIS DEATH HE STILL SMOKE
FOR OVER TWENTY PLUS YEARS AND
TO COME THE LONG CANCER TO BE
TWENTY FIVE YEARS THIS NOVEMBER.
BUT I DO HAVE A CONCERN. AS IT
RELATES TO MENTAL BECAUSE WE
SAW WHAT HAPPENED AIR GARDNER
IN NEW YORK HE WAS KILLED BY
POLICE SIMPLY BY SELLING SINGLE
LUCY'S AS A SAY MENTHOL
CIGARETTES AND IT IS NO DOUBT
THAT AFRICAN AMERICANS AND
LATINOS AS WELL AS THE POOR.
THAT IS THE- INSTRUMENTAL.
CIGARETTE OF CHOICE FOR THEM I
DON'T SEE MANY YOUTH. ARE ANY
MANY ADULTS SMOKING A CIGARETTE
PRODUCT ANYMORE MOST OF THEM
ARE HAVING SOME TYPE OF VAPING
DEVICE THAT CLEARLY LETS OUT A
PLUME OF SMOKE THAT DOES BLOWS
ME AWAY THAT ANY BY WITH. ONE
OF FEEL THEIR LONGS WITH- SO
MUCH OF FOREIGN MATTER LIKE
THAT AND- I'VE SELDOM PANELS
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT. FROM ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY SPECIALLY
NOBLE. NATIONAL ORGANIZATION OF
BLACK LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THEY'RE VERY CONCERNED WITH THE
BANNING A MAP MENTHOL BECAUSE
THEY BELIEVE IT'S GONNA GIVE
LAW ENFORCEMENT EXTRA TOOL TO.
STOP HARASS INCARCERATE PEOPLE
OF COLOR OR POOR SOUL THAT'S MY
HESITATION AND I WOULD ASK THAT.
EVERYTHING IN THIS BILL I
SUPPORT AND IT WE COULD
CONSIDER MENTHOL AT THE SAME
LEVEL THAT USE CONSIDERED
HOOKAH. AND GAVE THEM AN
EXEMPTION TO THIS BILL I THINK
IT WOULD EASE THE FEARS AND
CONCERNS OF MANY FOLKS. ARE
AGAIN MOSTLY ADULTS AND I CAN
SAY I'M NOT ADVOCATING SMOKING
BUT I'M SURELY NOT WANTING TO
GIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT AND IT
SAYS A BAN BUT THE AUTHOR
STATES THATYOU CAN STILL BUY
SOMETHING SO EITHER IT'S BANNED
IN CALIFORNIA. OR DO NOT
BECAUSE IF IT'S BANNED IN
SOMEONE HAS IT WILL THEY BE
ARRESTED FOR HAVING MENTHOL
CIGARETTES ON THEIR PERSON.
SOUL AND I'M CONFUSED AT THE
FACT THAT THE SAID YOU CAN
STILL BUY IT ONLINE SO ARE YOU
REMOVING IT JUST FROM RETAIL
SALE OF SALES IN STORES WHICH
CAN STILL BUY IT ONLINE AGAIN.
FOR PREVENTS A YOUTH THEN FROM
OUR CORN THIS ONLINE SO I JUST
HAVE THOSE CONCERNS AND I WOULD
JUST WHICH THAT MEANT BY WOULD
BE GIVEN THE SAME CONSIDERATION
THAT HOPE HOPE HAS BEEN GIVEN
IN THIS. MEASURE THANK YOU
SENATOR BRADFORD SENATOR
MORLOCK THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I- APPRECIATE THE
CONCERNS ABOUT ONE DISEASE AND-
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR HAVING
A PASSION IN THE SPACE- JUST
FIND IT. IRONIC HOWEVER THAT
WHILE WE'RE WORKING TO EMPOWER.
MARIJUANA RETAILERS THIS BILL
INTERFERES IN THE MARKETPLACE-
SO MY LIBERTARIAN STREAK IS A
LITTLE CONCERNED. BECAUSE I CAN
SORT OF HAVE A POLICY THAT WE
SHOULD ALLOW INDIVIDUALS TO DO.
WHAT IS LEGALLY ALLOWABLE TO DO
AS LONG AS THEY'RE NOT HARMING
OTHERS. SO I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS APPROACH MAY BE MANY STATE
IF WE WANTED TO THROW THAT OLD
JARGON AND BUT APPROACH TO
DEALING WITH A LEGITIMATE
PROBLEM. SO IN LOOKING AT THIS
IN BEING CONCERNED ABOUT THE
YOUTH- I'M WONDERING IF IT
WOULD BE ADDRESSED BETTER IF.
WE TOOK A DIFFERENT APPROACH-
THROUGH A STEEPER PENALTY THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO NOT GET.
FLAVORED PRODUCTS INTO THE
HANDS OF MINORS AND IT IS
ILLEGAL FOR STORES TO SELL TO
MINORS BUT MAYBE THE PENALTY
SHOULD BE DOUBLE OR- TRIPLE OR
OR WHATEVER IF YOU ARE A
RETAILER AND YOU HAVE SOLD TO A
MINOR OR IF YOU PURCHASED IT
AND THEN RESOLD IT. AS A
PRIVATE INDIVIDUAL TO A MINOR
OR GIFTED IT TO A MINOR THERE
SHOULD BE SOME. STEEP PENALTIES
BUT I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHY RETAILER SHOULD BE-
IMPACTED IN AND THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW ADULTS TO PURCHASE
FLAVORED PRODUCTS ONLINE SO.
SOMEONE'S GOING TO GET A PROFIT
BUT IT WON'T BE A THE LOCAL
RETAILER SO WE CAN EVEN I DON'T
KNOW HOW WE REGULATE ONLINE
TRANSACTIONS HOW WOULD YOU KNOW
THAT IT WASN'T A MINOR. AND WHY
SHOULD CALIFORNIA RETAILERS BE
EXCLUDED FROM SELLING THIS
PRODUCT AT A PROFIT SO I'M
HOPING THE AUTHOR CAN HELP ME.
OUT WITH THAT BECAUSE I
APPRECIATE. WHERE HE IS AND
WHAT HE'S TRYING TO ADDRESS-
BUT I'M HOPING YOU CAN HELP ME
IN HIS CLOSING REMARKS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. THANK YOU
SENATOR DOLLINGER. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I STAND IN SUPPORT
OF THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION I
HAVE NOT DIDN'T GET OPPORTUNITY
SEATED ANY COMMITTEE BUT I READ
THE BILL AND I'M A PAIR OF.
THREE CHILDREN. BUT TO MY
KNOWLEDGE THEY ARE NOT. USING
ANY OF THESE PRODUCTS BUT I
WILL SHARE WITH YOU THAT I. AT
A YOUNG AGE. USEDTOBACCO AND
IS VERY ADDICTING THERE'S ONE
IT'S ONE OF THE HARDEST.
ADDICTIONS TO STOP IT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO OVERCOME
THAT AND- I DO NOT WANT MY
CHILDREN TO EVER- THEY EVEN
EXPERIENCE IT I AND I'VE AND
I'VE SHARED WITH THEM OBVIOUSLY
THE DOWNFALLS OF THAT BUT I
WANT TO JUST SAY I KNOW THE
AUTHORS WORKED REALLY HARD ON
THIS BILL BUT I WANT TO ADD
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE'RE
REALLY MISSING IN THIS
LEGISLATURE AND- MY COLLEAGUE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY TOUCHED ON A
LITTLE BIT IS THE MARKETING OF.
EDIBLES ANY OTHER KINDS OF
CANNABIS IT IS RAMPANT IS THAT
I FEAR THAT ACTUALLY MORE THAN
I FEAR THE TOBACCO FOR- MY
CHILDREN IS SOMETHING WE THAT
I'D BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
WHOEVER I WORKED ON IT IN THE
ASSEMBLY- FOR YEARS TRYING TO
COME UP WITH SOME WAYS TO STOP
THE MARKETING OF EDIBLES- TO
OUR YOUTH BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT- IT IS RARE IT IS GONNA BE
THE NEXT. THING AS WE HAVE SEEN
WITH- THESE VAPING PRODUCTS SO
I WILL STAND WITH YOU ON THIS
BILL I PURSUE YOU BRING IT
FORWARD- I HOPE THAT ARE USED
TO NEVER EXPERIENCES BUT I KNOW
IT IS BEING TARGETED TOWARDS
YOU AND I ALSO KNOW THAT
CANNABIS IS WIDELY BEING
TARGETED TO YOUTH AS WELL AND
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THAT AND- IT
IS I KNOW IT'S DIFFICULT BUT I
WOULD LOVE TO BE INVOLVED IN
THOSE CONVERSATIONS FOR THE
FUTURE SO I'LL BE SUPPORT I OR
DID I VOTE ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU CENTER DAHLE. ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING AND
HEARING NONE. SENATOR HILL YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM MADAM
PRESIDENT OF THREE RESPOND TO A
COUPLE OF THE COMMENTS THAT
WERE MADE OF THIS I A RETAIL
BàN RETAIL SALES BAN ON
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS ONLY
IT IS NOT A INCREASED PENALTY
OR FINE OR ARREST OPPORTUNITY
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT OF A MINOR.
THEY TODAY ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO
SMOKE IF THEY'RE UNDER TWENTY
ONE I DON'T THINK THAT'S
ENFORCED ANYWHERE- IF THEY HAVE
THAT NO ONE'S LOOKING FOR
CIGARETTES ON THEM THIS WILL
CHANGE NOT NOT IN NO WAY. THE
LAW IN THAT RELATIONSHIP
RELATED TO THAT WE GET INTO THE
POINT OF WHY IT'S IMPORTANT TO
GO AFTER DEAL WITH AND APPLY
THIS TO RETAIL SALES. 74% OF
THE TO PROP THE PRODUCTS THE
FLAVOR TOBACCO PRODUCTS THAT
YOU'D GET TODAY. THEY ARE
GETTING FROM RETAIL
ESTABLISHMENTS SEVENTY FOUR
PERCENT. NOW HISTORICALLY
BEFORE THEY WERE PURCHASING
THIS ONLINE. AND THEY COULD DO
THAT BUT YOU SUPPORTED AND
VOTED FOR A BILL I HAD LAST
YEAR THAT THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
THE TOOK EFFECT IN JANUARY. AND
THAT IS THE RETAIL THE
TREATMENT OF TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
NOW THAT ARE SENT THROUGH THE
POST. ON ANY FORM PURCHASED
ONLINE THEY NOW IT APPLIES THE
SAME WAY THAT IT APPLIES TO
ALCOHOL SAY. WE DON'T HAVE A
OVER ABUNDANCE OR PROBLEM WITH
ALCOHOL SALES TODAY GOING TO
MINORS THROUGH THE INTERNET OR
BY PURCHASING SO IF YOU
PURCHASE AN ONLINE TOBACCO
PRODUCT FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCT WHICH YOU COULD DO WHEN
IT'S DELIVERED IT WILL BE
CLEARLY MARKED THIS IS A
TOBACCO PRODUCT. THIS PACKAGE
REQUIRES AN ADULT TWENTY ONE
YEARS OR OLDER TO SIGN FOR IT
AND BEFORE IT'S DELIVERED
SOMEONE TWENTY ONE YEARS OR
OLDER HAS TO ACCEPT AND SIGN
FOR JUST AS YOU DO TODAY. WITH
ALCOHOL DELIVERIES AN ONLINE
PURCHASES TO THAT'S HOW WE KEEP
THEM FROM PURCHASE IN ONLINE IN
THE RESTRICTIONS NOW APPLY AND
HAVE WORKED BECAUSE BEFORE THIS
THAT'S WHERE THEY WERE GETTING
IT ONLINE NOW THEY'RE GETTING
IT CONTINUING TO GET IT AT
RETAIL ESTABLISHMENTS. SO WE'VE
SEEN AN INCREASE THERE AND I
BELIEVE WE SOLVE THE- THE
ONLINE SALE OF THAT THAT'S
BECAUSE THIS IS THE PROBLEM IS.
THEY ARE FOR IN THESE ONLINE
NOW MY GOOD FRIEND FROM LOS
ANGELES RAISE THE HOOKAH ISSUE.
IF WITH- WITH HOOK UP. THE
EIGHT EXEMPTION IN THIS
LEGISLATION IS BASED ON THE
FACT THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT A
HOOK UP AND I LEARNED A LOT IN
THIS I WAS NOT FAMILIAR WITH
HOW. THAT APPLIED BUT ALL WHO
GO. A BACKHOE SETIA ITS FLAVOR
IT IS HISTORICALLY THAT IS HOW
IT IS IT IS A FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS IT IS YOU KNOW IT IS
CONSUMED THROUGH A PIPE. IT'S
NOT CONCEALABLE IT'S NOT
SOMETHING YOU CAN WALK DOWN HE
STREET WITH IT'S NOT SOMETHING
YOU CAN PLUG INTO THE USB DRIVE
ON YOUR COMPUTER. IT IS A VERY
LARGE DEVICE IT IS ALSO THE USE
OF A HOOKAH ISSUES FOR
CELEBRITY- CELEBRATORY EVENTS.
ON SPECIAL OCCASIONS IT'S NOT A
DAILY USED PRODUCT. AND THAT'S
WHY IT'S DIFFERENT. THAN ANY
CIGARETTE IT'S DIFFERENT THAN
THE TOBACCO CIGARETTE. IS
DIFFERENT THAN A VAPING DEVICE
AND THAT'S WHY WE FELT IT WOULD
BE APPROPRIATE TO. EXCLUDE THEM
BECAUSE IT'S NOT THE SAME
PROBLEM IS REFINED TODAY. SO IF
I COULD CONTINUE BUT MADAM
PRESIDENT YOU KNOW BIG TOBCCO
HAS PUT A PRICE ON OUR KIDS
LIVES BUT I REFUSED TO DO SO.
SB SEVEN NINETY THREE WILL BE A
PUBLIC HEALTH VICTORY IN
CALIFORNIA WE WILL PROTECT.
AGAINST ANOTHER GENERATION
GETTING ADDICTED TO THESE
DEADLY PRODUCTS AND THAT TO BE
IS PRICELESS. COLLEGE IT'S TIME
THAT WE STAND UP FOR OUR YOUTH
IF YOU DO NOT BELIEVE ME ABOUT
THE TOBACCO INDUSTRY'S
INTENTIONS FOR OUR YOUTH AND
TAKE THEIR WORDS AND ACTIONS
INTO CONSIDERATIONS. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE PHILIP
MORRIS EXECUTIVE SAID AND I
QUOTE. IT IS IMPORTANT TO KNOW
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE ABOUT
TEENAGE SMOKING PATTERNS AND
ATTITUDES TODAY'S TEENAGERS
TOMORROW'S POTENTIAL CUSTOMER.
AND IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO AN
RJ REYNOLDS EXECUTIVE SAID
QUOTE. WE DON'T SMOKE BATCH
EXPLETIVE. WE JUST SELL WE
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO SMOKE FOR
THE YOUNG THE POOR THIS LACK
AND THE STUPID. IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR A MANUFACTURER
FRUITY SNUFF SAID CHERRY SCROLL
IS FOR SOMEBODY WHO LIKES THE
TASTE OF CANDY. IF YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M SAYING. JUL PURCHASED
AD SPACE ON NICKELODEON TO
NETWORK SEVENTEEN MAGAZINE AND
EVEN EDUCATIONAL SITES FOR
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
I IMPLORE YOU TO RECOGNIZE THIS
PATTERN OF ABUSE AND
RECKLESSNESS. MILLIONS OF KIDS
ARE NOW ADDICTED TO NICOTINE
AND YOUTH THE YOUTH VAPING
EPIDEMIC WILL HAVE UNKNOWNS AND
DETRIMENTAL IMPACTS AND PUBLIC
HEALTH. TOBACCO USE BEING THE
LEADING CAUSE OF PREVENTABLE
DEATH AND DISEASE WE NEED TO BE
COGNIZANT OF THE LONG TERM
CONSEQUENCES. OF A NEW
GENERATION HOOKED TO NICOTINE
THIRTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE DIE
EVERY DAY DUE TO TOBACCO
RELATED ILLNESSES. TO ME. THE
QUESTION. IS NOT I WE SHOULD
PROHIBIT THE SALE OF FLAVORED
TOBACCO. RATHER I ASK WHY WE
EVER ALLOWED THE MOST DEADLY
SUBSTANCE ON EARTH TO HAVE A
CANDY FLAVOR IN THE FIRST PLACE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
CALLING. WELL DEBATE HAVING
SEIZED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES.
BELL I FORGES. BRADFORD
CABALLERO I CHIANG. DALLY FIVE
DODD I ASSUME. HI GALGIANI I
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG. HI HILL AYE HUESO.
HI TADO. JACKSON I JONES NO
LEYVA I MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ NO
MITCHELL. I MONNING. I MORE
LOCK. ZERO NIELSEN I HAN HI
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER. HI STERN HI I'M
BURKE HI WHITE HOUSE SKI I FIVE
WIENER I WILK. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
BATES FOR AGES. BRADFORD I
CHIANG I TADO. MORE LOCK.
MORRELL LOOK AT ME. NO WELL.
SENATOR HILL MOVES TO CALL.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM THIRTY
NINE SENATOR BAIL YOU ARE
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN NINETY
FIVE BY SENATOR VAL AN ACT
RELATING TO ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT SENATOR BILL. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
TODAY PRESENT- THIS BILL SEVEN
NINETY FIVE IT'S A BILL THAT
CREATES A SUSTAINABLE FUN
SOURCE TO ADDRESS OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS WHILE
ALSO STIMULATING OUR ECONOMY
AND GENERATING HIGH WAGE JOBS.
THE BILL INVEST TWO BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR FIVE YEARS
IN THE CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS IN
PROGRAMS THAT ADDRESS AND
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL CREATES
TWO NEW PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED
BY THE OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OFFICE
KOBE IS TO HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH THEIR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND NATURAL DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS. OF FOCUSING ON
HOUSING PRODUCTION WILL ASSIST
US IN OUR CONRAD RECOVERY BY
CREATING AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
POOREST FAMILIES TO SHELTER IN
PLACE SAFELY WHAT GENERATING
HIGHWAYS CONSTRUCTION JOBS TO
HELP OFFSET THE HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT. BILLS NEED NOW
MORE THAN EVER ACCORDING TO THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE DEVELOP
DEPARTMENT HOUSING PRODUCTIONS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE ALMOST
ENTIRELY FUNDED WITH ON
PROGRAMS IN. THERE ARE LIMITED
FUNDS REMAINING. RIGHT NOW THE
MEASURE WE HAD A FEW YEARS AGO-
PROPOSITION ONE THE HOUSING
BOND IS DOWN TO ABOUT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS LEFT AND IT'S
GOING TO BE GONE IN A YEAR OR
TWO. SO WITHOUT NEW MULTI YEAR
FUNDING HOUSING PRODUCTION
WOULD DRAMATICALLY SO OURS AND
I VOTE ON THIS MEASURE. THANK
YOU SENATOR BILL DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM IS FOR
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NON MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES. REBEL FIVE FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I HAVE A- I CHIANG.
DALLY NO DODD. I DURAZO. I
GALGIANI I GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
FIVE HUESO. I TADO. JACKSON HI
I JONES NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL. I
MONNING BY MORLOCK NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN NO HAN FIVE
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO. I
SKINNER. HI STERN HI NUMBER I
LIKE HOUSE DE AYE WIENER. I
WILK NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. BATES.
GORGEOUS NO CHIANG NO GROWTH
NO- TADO. SENATOR BILL MOVES TO
CALL COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE ARE GOING TO NOW
MOVE TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING
FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE. SENATOR
GALGIANI WILL BE PRESENTING
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT ELEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN AN ACT
RELATING TO TAX LIMITATION.
CENTER GALGIANI THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT A CA
ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MALEN MAYES FRIEDMAN BURKE AND
GREAT. AC ELEVEN IF APPROVED BY
THE VOTERS WILL HELP OPEN
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE WHO FIND THEMSELVES
LOCKED OUT OF THE MARKET HELP
SENIORS RIGHT SIZE THEIR
HOUSING NEEDS AND PROVIDE
VICTIMS OF WILDFIRES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REBUILD THEIR
HOMES AND COMMUNITIES. DESPITE
OUR STATE'S ECONOMIC CHALLENGES
HOME PURCHASE PRICES AND RENT
STATE WHY CONTINUE TO RISE
FASTER THAN WAGES AS YOU KNOW
AND YET BECAUSE OF THE AND
FLEXIBILITY OF OUR PROPERTY TAX
LAWS IN SOME CASES PEOPLE ARE
FINDING THEMSELVES AND HOUSING
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY FIT
THEIR NEEDS THIS IS
PARTICULARLY PARTICULARLY TRUE
IN AREAS THAT ARE JOBS RICH AND
HOUSING POOR. LIKE IN THE BAY
AREA. ACA ELEVEN IS A
COMPROMISE THAT WAS REACHED TO
REPLACE AN ALREADY QUALIFIED
BALLOT MEASURE WHICH IS L. L.
ELIGIBLE FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
NOVEMBER GENERAL ELECTION. ACA
ELEVEN STRIKES A BALANCED
APPROACH THAT BENEFITS PROPERTY
OWNERS WHILE CREATING A STABLE
REVENUE SOURCE FOR BOTH FIRE
DISTRICTS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO IMPROVE SERVICES TO THEIR
CONSTITUENTS. SPECIFICALLY ACA
ELEVEN CONTINUES TO PROTECT
SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES BY LIMITING
PROPERTY TAX INCREASES ON
PRIMARY RESIDENCES AS
ORIGINALLY AND TEN INTENDED
UNDER OUR LAWS. ADDITIONALLY
THIS AMENDMENT EXPANDS THE SAME
PROPERTY TAX PROTECTIONS TO
WILDFIRE VICTIMS WHILE REMOVING
THE UNFAIR LOCATION
RESTRICTIONS THAT WERE BUILT
INTO THE LAW. BY ALLOWING
SENIORS THE DISABLED AND NOW
FIRE VICTIMS TO CARRY THE
BENEFITS OF PROP THIRTEEN TAX
PROTECTIONS FOR ANOTHER HOME
THOSE IN NEED WILL BE ABLE TO
MOVE CLOSER TO FAMILY OR CLOSER
TO MEDICAL CARE. TO A SENIOR OR
RETIREMENT COMMUNITY OR TO
REPLACE A DAMAGED HOME ANYWHERE
WITHIN CALIFORNIA. AND IT WILL
OPEN UP HOUSING TO FIRST TIME
HOME BUYERS AND OTHERS WHO NEED
MORE OPTIONS FOR HOUSING AND
ONCE AGAIN SPECIFICALLY IN
AREAS THAT ARE JOBS RICH AND
HOUSING POOR. AGAIN AC ELEVEN
IS IN NO WAY A CHANGE TO THE
PROPERTY TAX OWNERS TAX
PROTECTIONS PROVIDED UNDER PROP
THIRTEEN. BUT WHAT IF APPROVED
BY THE VOTERS CLOSE SEVERAL
UNINTENDED LOOPHOLES AND PROPS
FIFTY EIGHT AND ONE NINETY
THREE THAT HAVE ALLOWED OUT OF
STATE INVESTORS NON CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS AND TRUST FUND HEIRS
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF OUR
CURRENT TAX LAWS. UNDER A CA
ELEVEN PARENTS AND GRAND
CHILDREN WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
THE ABILITY TO PASS THE FAMILY
HOME TO THEIR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN. WITH THE
PROTECTIONS OF PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN ENSURING THAT THEIR
HEIRS CAN AFFORD TO MOVE INTO
THAT HOME AS THEIR PRIMARY
RESIDENCE BUT THE KEY IS THAT
HOME MUST BE USED AS A PRIMARY
RESIDENCE AND NOT A RENTAL. NO
MORE TURNING GRANDMA AND
GRANDPA'S HOUSE INTO A RENTAL
UNIT AND DENYING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE TAX REVENUES
THEY NEED TO PROVIDE SERVICES.
AND THE SURROUNDING HOMEOWNERS
PAYING A DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE
OF THE NEEDS ACA ELEVEN BRINGS
VITALLY NEEDED RESOURCES TO
HISTORICALLY UNDERFUNDED FIRE
DISTRICTS. AND BOTH RURAL AND
URBAN COMMUNITIES RESOURCES
WILL ALSO BE DEDICATED TO CAL
FIRE IN SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA'S
WILDFIRE RESPONSE. WHICH WILL
HELP TO PROTECT MILLIONS OF
HOMES AND LIVES FINALLY THE
AMENDMENT PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
LOCAL REVENUE TO COUNTIES
CITIES AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
BY CREATING A BALANCING
MECHANISM TO HELP SABILIZE
PROPERTY TAX RAISE REVENUE FOR
EVERY COUNTY ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AT A TIME WHEN COUNTIES NEED IT
MOST. ACA ELEVEN ALSO PROTECTS
COUNTIES AGAINST ANY POTENTIAL
REVENUE LOSS BY ESTABLISHING AN
OFFSET FIND WHICH WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL REVENUE PROTECTION
YEAR IN AND YEAR OUT. TO ENSURE
LOCAL GENERAL FUND STABILITY.
THIS MEASURE IS CO SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND
IS SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FEDERATION. THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
THE COMMERCIAL BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE
THE CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
GALGIANI DEBATER DISCUSSIONS
SENATOR HERTZBERG. THANK YOU A-
MADAM PRESIDENT TWO YEARS AGO.
SENATOR GALGIANI INTRODUCE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT. IN
THIS HOUSE THAT DEALT WITH THE
ISSUE THAT SHE JUST DISCUSSED
PORT. OF. TAX BASIS IN YOUR
HOME TWO YEARS AGO IN THIS
HOUSE SENATOR HILL. INTRODUCED
A MEASURE A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT SENATOR HILL. TO
ALLOW OR TO GET BASICALLY DEAL
WITH THIS IN EQUITY THAT OCCURS
WHEN FOLKS AS WAS INDICATED IN
THE PRESENTATION INHERIT A
PROPERTY AND DOES THAT MEAN
THEY INHERIT THE TAX BASE OF
THEIR GRANDPARENTS. AND HE
WANTED TO CORRECT THAT THAT WAS
INFORMED BY REPORT THAT CAME
OUT OF THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. THOSE TWO
MEASURES IN FORM THE FOUNDATION
OF WHAT'S BEFORE YOU TODAY. ONE
OF THE PROBLEMS THAT I WAS
TRYING TO BE SOLVED BY A CA
THAT I WOULD SUGGEST THAT THOSE
SOLUTIONS ARE QUITE ELEGANT IN
TERMS OF REALLY DEALING. FOR
SOMEONE SUGGEST REALLY DEALING
WITH SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES BIG
PICTURE CHALLENGE THE
CALIFORNIA'S FACING FIRST
HOUSING. WE HAVE RETIREES THAT
ARE SITTING IN THEIR HOMES THAT
THEY PURCHASED PRIOR TO
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT AT A
VERY LOW TAX BASIS OFTEN AS IN
THE CASE OF MY FAMILY THEY
WON'T MOVE OUT BECAUSE- HERE
SOMETIMES THE ONE PERSON IN THE
HOUSE. THEY WON'T MOVE OUT
BECAUSE THEY'RE PAYING ALMOST
NO PROPERTY TAX AND THEY'RE
NERVOUS THAT IF THEY WERE MOVED
TO BUY SOMETHING NEW. THAT THE
NEW TAX BASES THE COULD BEFORE
THE TAX BILL. THIS WILL BE ON
TOLD RESULT IN THE SALE OF
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND NEW HOMES
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN IT MEANS
FAMILIES ARE GOING TO BE
AVAILABLE IN THOSE HOMES OFTEN
ONLY HAVE ONE OR TWO PEOPLE IN
THEIR RETIREES PEOPLE THAT WANT
TO MOVE. AS WAS INDICATED IN
THE OPENING REMARKS THE WHOLE
NOTION ABOUT WORKING CLOSER. TO
YOUR WORKPLACE AND FREEING UP
THOSE HOUSES WHEN WE'RE TRYING
TO DO WITH A HOUSING CRISIS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
DELIVERABLE OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS WE DEBATE HERE
ON THIS FLOOR. SECOND THE IDEA
THAT WE'RE PROTECTING SENIORS
IS A HUGE ELEMENT THAT IS FINDS
ITSELF WITHIN THE
JURISPRUDENTIAL CONVERSATION
THAT WE HAVE HERE ACROSS THIS
FOR. THIRD WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT CLIMATE CHANGE
PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
SEEN THIS IN SO MANY
COMMUNITIES REPRESENTED BY
SENATORS ACROSS THIS FLOOR
WHERE THINGS ARE BURNING DOWN
THERE'S A BIG PROBLEM BECAUSE
THE CLIMATE CHANGE SO WHAT HAS
HAPPENED WITH RESPECT TO THIS
MEASURE IS A WAY TO BE ABLE TO
FUND THOSE FIRE DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE BEEN INAPPROPRIATELY
TREATED BECAUSE THE POST PROP
THIRTEEN OR THEY HAVE EVEN HALF
PROBLEMS OR THE LIKE AND WHAT
WE'VE DONE IS TO CREATE THIS
MEASURE WHAT THE AUTHOR AND
MISTER HILL HAVE DONE AND
MISTER MULLIN. TOGETHER WITH
THE LEADERSHIP OF THIS HOUSE IN
THE BRILLIANT STAFF OF THE
PROTEST MOVE WORKED THEIR
HEARTS OUT ON THIS THING. IS TO
FIGURE OUT. HOW TO DEAL WITH
THIS ISSUE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS APPROPRIATE REVENUE
STREAMS FOR THOSE FIREFIGHTERS
AND THAT'S JUST NOT
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
THAT'S ALSO VOLUNTEER FIRE
DEPARTMENTS. THAT BASICALLY A
PROFESSIONAL WISE ENOUGH AND-
OFFER SUPPORT FOR THEM. SO
WE'RE DEALING WITH THAT. FOR
THE OR THIRD OR FOURTH AMEND
LOST MY COUNT HERE BUT THE
POINT IS. THAT THE POINT IS
THAT WE ALSO HAVE THIS PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUE WHAT'S THE
DEFINITION OF PUBLIC SAFETY
WHAT DOES NOT LOOK LIKE WE'RE
TRYING TO. RE EXAMINE THAT
ISSUE HERE. ON THIS FLOOR IN IN
THIS LEGISLATURE. FIREFIGHTERS
ARE A VERY IMPORTANT PART OF
THAT PUBLIC SAFETY DELIVERY.
NOT JUST ON THE HEALTH STUFF
BUT WE SEE IN THE DEBATES WITH
RESPECT TO THE ISSUE. OF PARA
MEDICINE ON THIS FLOOR ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE INVOLVED
IN BRINGING FOLKS TO MENTAL
HEALTH FACILITIES ARE FOLKS
THAT ARE AFFECTED BY. DRUG
ADDICTION ALL OF WHICH ARE PART
OF THE- ARCHITECTURE OF PUBLIC
SAFETY SO WE'RE DEALING WITH
PUBLIC SAFETY WE'RE DEALING
WITH HOUSING. WE'RE DEALING
WITH CLIMATE CHANGE IT IN IN
THIS MEASURE. AND IT'S IS I
WOULD SUGGEST. QUITE IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THERE ARE IS A
COMPETING MEASURE ON THE BALLOT
TODAY. TODAY ARM AND THE IDEA.
I'M YEARS AGO COMPROMISED THAT
BROUGHT BACK THE NOTION OF THE
INDIRECT INITIATIVE
INTERCONNECTION OF CRATES A
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND PROPONENTS
OF BILLS THE IDEA IS THAT THERE
SHOULD BE A DISCUSSION AND
NEGOTIATION OFTEN WHERE WE DEAL
WITH LARGER PUBLIC POLICY
ISSUES AND WHAT HAPPENS HERE
TODAY'S RESULTS IF THIS MEASURE
GETS OFF THIS FLOOR AND OUT OF
THE OTHER HOUSE IS WE WILL I AM
HOPING RESULT IN PULLING THAT
MEASURE OFF ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
SAVING TAXPAYER DOLLARS AS OF
HAVING TO MEASURES. CREATING A
COMPROMISE THAT REALLY ALLOWS
THE LEGISLATURE THAT
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF TIMING
THOSE NEGOTIATIONS WERE
SOMEWHAT IMPEDED BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC TO THE GO SHADE UNDER
THE PRINCIPLES OF THIS INDIRECT
INITIATIVE I SUGGEST I REALLY
WANT TO STRESS THE ISSUE OF
COSTS NO STRESS THE ISSUE THE
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC WITH
RESPECT TO THE. DISCUSSIONS
WERE HAVING HERE TODAY.
POURTANT LEGAL PRINCIPLES AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. SO I JUST WANT TO.
CONGRATULATE THE- BOTH SENATORS
IN THERE FOR SIDE ON THIS AND
PROVIDING THE FRAMEWORK THAT
ALLOWS US TO MOVE FORWARD TODAY
HOPEFULLY IN AN EFFORT TO DEAL
WITH VERY SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES THE GET CALIFORNIA
IS FACING IN IS I LOVE TO
ALWAYS LIKE TO SAY IN A VERY
ELEGANT WAY I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG THE SHOW NEAL. NOT A
LETTERS YOU DEVON SENATE I URGE
THE NOBLE. THIS WILL NOT A-
WHAT I THINK SOME. INTENDED
THAT THE MIGHT ACCOMPLISH
FACILITATE GREATER UP TO PASS
THINGS ON CHILDREN I ARE THE
OPPOSITE. THIS LEGISLATURE FOR
THAT DIDN'T ADDRESS. THE
OPPRESSIVE INCREASE OF PROPERTY
TAXES. MONACO HOMEOWNERS. AND
THEY WERE MATT. AND THE BECAUSE
THIS PLACE DID NOT. SERVE THEIR
INTERESTS PROPOSITION THIRTEEN
OVERWHELMINGLY SECURED A PLACE
ON THE BALLOT. WELL AND GUESS
WHAT HAPPENED THE LEGISLATURE
WALK UP ALL MY GOSH THERE'S
SOMETHING OUT THERE WELL WE'VE
GOT A WHOLE LOT AS WE'RE NOW
ATTEMPTING TO DO HERE. THAT WAS
CALLED SENATE BILL ONE. AND
THAT WAS GOING TO BE THE GREAT
ANSWER. AND STOP PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN WELL GUESS WHAT. PROP
ONE SB ONE. WHAT DOWN IN FLAMES
PROP THIRTEEN STORMED THE LAND.
AND HAS BEEN PRESERVED EVERY
YEAR CENTS. NOTWITHSTANDING
ALMOST EVERY YEAR TAX. AT TAX
NOT TA X. BUT THE TAX ON PROP
THIRTEEN TO GET RID OF IT
BECAUSE WHY. WHICH IS AN
ELEMENTAL PURPOSE OF THIS.
LEGISLATION AND TO THE DEGREE
THAT INITIALLY MORE MONEY FOR
GOVERNMENT. MORE MONEY FOR
GOVERNMENT. AND THAT THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES. JUST CONFIRM THAT IN
THEIR LETTER AND THEY USE A NEW
VOTE WORDS NEW BOLD WORDS NET
REVENUE INCREASE. SOME WOULD
CALL AT TEXAS. AND THEY WANT TO
HAVE CITIES TO BE KEPT HOLE.
WHEN FOLKS MOVE AWAY. WELL WHAT
IF FOLKS MOVE AWAY BECAUSE OF
CITIES. ARE NOT PROVIDING. THE
SAY FOR AFFORDABLE HABITAT SO
THEY GO SOMEWHERE ELSE. OF
COURSE THEY DO. BUT WE WANT TO
KEEP THOSE WHOLE. NOW I NOBODY
HAS BEEN A GREATER CHAMPION. OF
THE CALYX OVER A CAREER THAN I
HAVE I KNOW THE PLIGHT OF THE
COUNTIES OF REPRESENTED
NINETEEN UP. THEY ALWAYS HAVE
HAD PROBLEMS. BECAUSE WHAT.
THEY SUFFER THE ONEROUS BURDENS
OF STATE AND FEDERAL MANDATES.
FAR BEYOND WHAT CITIES EVER
SUFFER. AND THEY HAVE MUCH
FEWER OPPORTUNITIES TO REYES
AND SECURE REVENUES. THEN THE
CITY'S SO MY HEART IS ALWAYS
BEEN WITH THE COUNTY. AND IT'S
ALWAYS WITH SIX SESSION. WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO IN OUR LIVES.
A CREW SOMETHING PARTICULARLY
IN THEIR CHARACTER THEIR HEALTH
AND THEIR BEING AND THEIR
VALUES TO OUR CHILDREN BUT ALSO
SOME OF THE PROPERTY THAT WE
HAVE ACCUMULATED. NOW THIS IS A
FALSE HOPE. BECAUSE IF YOU ARE
GOING TO THEN INHERIT
MOTHER AND FATHER'S PROPERTY
pHOW MANY CHILDREN ARE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO THE LIVE IN THAT
HOUSE. AND HOW MANY FAMILIES
HAVE ONLY ONE CHILD. TO INHERIT
THAT HOUSE. MY OWN INDUSTRY
BOREDOM THAT'S WHY BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THE SAME FEAR. AT THE SAME
THIS LOOMING OUT THERE. BUT HOW
MANY OF THEIR CHILDREN ARE
GOING TO LIVE ON THAT HOUSE AND
STAY ON THAT FARM. SADLY TODAY
FOR MANY REASONS AT ALL NOT
EVEN THE LABOR WITH YOU. THAT
IS NOT GONNA HAPPEN. SO WE DO
HAVE A PROBLEM. BUT LET'S JUST
CONSIDER WHAT IS REALLY HERE
THIS IS ABOUT MORE MONEY FOR
GOVERNMENT TO SPEND. DO THEY
HAVE OTHER RESOURCES WELL HECK
YEAH THERE'S SOME MONEY IN THIS
VERY BUDGET. AND I COMPLEMENT
THE GOVERNOR FOR PUTTING IT
THERE. THE RECOMPENSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PARTICULARLY COUNTIES LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN HAS NEVER HAD THE
STATE KEEP IT SHORT WITH ONE
EXCEPTION. TRIAL COURT FUNDING
THE STATE OVER DECADES DID KEEP
ITS WORD. ON RECOMPENSE IN THEM
THE LOST TRIAL COURT FUNDING
EVERYTHING ELSE NO. THIS
RENEGES. THIS IS A FALSE HOPE A
FALSE PROMISES A POLITICAL. THE
HEAD OFTEN INITIATIVE THAT IS
QUALIFIED AND AS FAR AS THE
BORDER THAT REALTORS HAVE C. A.
R. I THINK THEY SHOULD TALK TO
SOME OF THEIR MEMBERS. THERE
LISTENING I GUESS TO THEIR
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE AND THE
EMINENT WISDOM OF PEOPLE WHO
INHABIT SACRAMENTO. BUT I'VE
BEEN AROUND THE COUNTIES THAT I
REPRESENT THOSE REAL ACTORS ARE
NOT SEEN OLD BOY THIS IS GREAT.
THERE SAY AND WHAT. THEY DID
WHAT. I URGE A NO VOTE. SENATOR
HILL. AND I RISE IN SUPPORT AND
WITH MY COLLEAGUE- FROM THE
VALLEY AND CERTAINLY THE HARD
WORK OF OUR GOOD FRIEND THE
SENATOR FROM SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY IN CRAFTING AND WORKING
THROUGH THIS THIS ACA. THE
INTENT OF MY SCA THREE EARLIER
LAST YEAR WAS TO KIND OF CLOSE
A LOOPHOLE AND EVEN JOHN TO
PAUL FROM OF I REMEMBER
CORRECTLY WHEN I INTRODUCED
THIS THIS PARTICULAR MEASURE HE
SAID UP THINK THE WORDS WERE
THAT MAKES SENSE SOMETHING TO
THAT EFFECT BECAUSE THAT WASN'T
THE INTENT OF PROP THIRTEEN TO
ALLOW SOMEONE TO INHERIT THE
FRONT THE GOAL WAS IF YOU'RE A
PARENT PERHAPS LIVING IN THAT
HOME A CHILD LIVING IN THAT
HOME FROM YOUR PARENTS OR YOUR
GOING TO INHERIT THAT HOME AT
THEIR DEATH. IT GIVES YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO STAY IN THAT
HOME WITHOUT HAVING IT BE
REASSESSED AND REQUIRING YOU
PERHAPS TO MOVE BECAUSE YOUR
CURRENT INCOME DID NOT SUPPORT
THAT REASSESSMENT COST TO THAT
WAS THE GOAL OF PROP THIRTEEN
AND THIS HAS BEEN AYE BLOOM
ABUSED BECAUSE OF THE BENEFITS
OF OWNING THE PROPERTY RATING
IT FOR A LARGE AMOUNT AND THEN
NOT PAYING THE- TESTAMENT THAT-
IT WAS IT'S VALUED TODAY SO
THERE'S A WINNER BUT THERE'S A
WIN THERE I BELIEVE WIN FOR
TAXPAYERS. IN THIS DOESN'T
BENEFIT THE TAXPAYERS BUT ALSO
STILL PRESERVED I BELIEVE THE
REGIONAL INTENT OF PROP
THIRTEEN WHICH IS ALLOWED THOSE
THOSE CHILDREN THOSE PEOPLE WHO
INHERIT THOSE THOSE PROPERTIES
TO BE ABLE TO THAT TO LIVE IN
THERE AND RESIDE IN THOSE
PROPERTIES AT THAT TIME IT'S
ALSO A GREAT WIN FOR THE
COUNTIES AND FOR THOSE SENIORS
WHEN A SENIOR LEAVES AND IS
ABLE TO PORT OF THE ORDER MOVE
THEIR ASSESSMENT TO ANOTHER
LOCATION AS IN MANY COUNTIES
TODAY ALREADY ALLOW. THAT'S A
GREATOPPORTUNITY THAT IS A.
WIN FOR THEM. NOW THE PROPERTY
WILL THEN BE RESOLD. AND
PROBABLY BE. AT A HIGHER WE
WILL BRING IN REVENUE TO
COUNTIES THAT THEY WILL BENEFIT
FROM I CAN'T SEE A LOSS IN THIS
AT ALL. I SEE ALSO THAT THE
INITIATIVE THAT WILL GO ON THE
BALLOT WILL BE BETTER BECAUSE
OF THIS AND BECAUSE OF THAT.
THAT INHERITANCE ASPECT OF IT
IN THE OTHER PARTS OF THIS THIS
IS- INITIATIVE SO I STRONGLY
SUPPORT ACA ELEVEN. I THINK
THIS IS THAT ELEGANT SOLUTION
TO PROVIDE THE BENEFITS TO OUR
RESIDENTS AND CITIZENS AND
ENABLE THE TAX SYSTEM TO REALLY
WORK AS INTENDED IT TO BE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR GLAZER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS LEGISLATION WANT TO
THANK CENTERS GALGIANI IN HELL
FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS I
CERTAINLY WANT TO THANK THE
MAJORITY LEADER WHO. IN HIS
INTELLIGENCE AND INSIGHT HAD
HAS WORKED TOGETHER WITH ALL OF
YOU TO CRAFT THIS ELEGANT-
RESOLUTION NOT THAT I THINK HAS
ONLY WINTERS REALLY ONLY
WINNERS ARE SENIORS HUGE
WINNERS THE ABILITY TO SELL
THEIR HOME IN AND BUY A NEW ONE
AND NOT BE FACED WITH HIGHER
PROPERTY TAXES ARE FIRE
COMMUNITY BOTH CAL FIRE AND ALL
OF OUR RURAL FIRE DEPARTMENTS
HEAVY ENORMOUS BENEFITS FROM
THIS THOSE WHO ARE SKEPTICAL OF
GOVERNMENT. AND TAXES AND
SPENDING SHOULD LIKE THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT IT SHOWS EXACTLY
WHERE THE MONEY IS GOING.
EXACTLY WHERE THE MONEY IS
GOING. FOR FIRE PROTECTION. AND
THAT'S GOING TO BENEFIT OUR
GENERAL FUND THAT'S GOING TO
BENEFIT OUR SAFETY AND SO MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS SO I RISE TO
SUPPORT THIS COULD MEASURE THE
REALTORS ARE RUNNING AROUND
TRYING TO RAISE PEOPLE'S TAXES
ON THEIR HOMES- THERE ARE
TRYING TO VIOLATE PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN. THEIR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS THEIR SPONSORSHIP ALONG
WITH THE FIRE- ASSOCIATION I
THINK MAKES IT CLEAR THIS IS AN
ARTFUL COMPROMISE WORTHY OF
SUPPORT. AND I REGION I. THANK
YOU SENATOR DOLLY. FOLLOW BY
SENATOR BATES THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I. BUT NOT
OFTEN AT ODDS WITH MY- GOOD
FRIEND FROM TO HEMA BUT TODAY I
AM ON THIS ISSUE. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS AS A FARMER
NUMBER ONE WHO WOULD NOT HAVE
THE FARM IF IT WASN'T FOR PROP
THIRTEEN. BECAUSE ORIGINALLY
THE VALUES WOULD'VE BEEN SET AT
WHAT LAND CELLS NEXT TO FOUR SO
I AM VERY IS VERY NEAR AND DEAR
TO MY HEART THAT WE- TECH THOSE
ABILITIES TO BE ABLE TO. PASS
THAT LAND ON. A AND USE A PROP
THIRTEEN WHICH I LOVE. BUT THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION NUMBER ONE
THERE IS A QUALIFIED. BALLOT
INITIATIVE THAT'S ON THAT- IN
MY IN MY OPINION IS NOT A GOOD
PIECE OF LEGISLATION ARE GOOD
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE- CITIZENS
OF CALIFORNIA TO VOTE ON I
THINK IT WOULD IT WOULD I KNOW
WOULD DAMAGE. THE AGRICULTURE
AND IF YOU'LL IF YOU'VE NOTICED
IN YOUR ANALYSIS THAT THE FARM
BUREAU HAS SUPPORTED THIS.
PIECE OF LEGISLATION AND THAT'S
BECAUSE IT DOES PROTECT THE
FAMILY FARM AND THE AND THE
THOSE WHO HAVE THE PROP
THIRTEEN GUYS THE OTHER THING
THAT THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
DOES IS ALLOW YOU. TO MOVE YOUR
VALUE OF YOUR PROP THIRTEEN. IF
YOU SO CHOOSE TO WANT TO MOVE.
IT ALSO. FOR THOSE OF US WHO
HAVE HAD TOTAL COMMUNITIES
BURNED OUT. IT'S GOING TO HAVE
THE ABILITY IF YOU LOSE YOUR ON
THE FIRE YOU KNOW THAT SAME
ABILITY AS WELL. SO FOR THOSE
THREE REASONS THOSE ARE THE
REASONS THAT I'M SUPPORTING
THIS- BILL AND I ENCOURAGE YOU
TO AS WELL. THANK YOU SENATOR
DOLLY SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I HAVEN'T
REALLY DECIDED ON THIS BILL IT
HAS SOME GOOD THINGS BUT
THERE'S SOME THINGS THAT ARE
TROUBLING IN TERMS OF THE
AFFORDABILITY AFFORDABILITY
ASPECT THAT COULD BE
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED OUR WITH
THE BILL LAND OF THE PROPERTY
CHANGES HANDS. SO YOU H
HAVE A HOME- YOU PASS AWAY
CHILDREN IN HERE AT IT THEY'VE
GOT THAT PRIVATE PROPERTY TAX
WITH THE CAN'T MOVE IN SO THEY
DECIDE THEY WANT TO RENDON
BATCH OF THE THEY'RE NOT LIVING
IN IT THE TAP ON IT ARE GOING
TO BE REASSESSED ITS CURRENT
VALUE AT THE TIME THAT IT IS
SOLD. SO THE RANSOMED OUT FOR
WHOMEVER YOU KNOW IT'S NOW TO
ARE GOING TO PAY A HIGHER RAMPS
AND ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CALIFORNIA AND
MANY OF THE COMMUNITIES. THAT I
REPRESENT MORE THAN MEDIAN.
COST OF A HOME OR THAT. ALL
RIGHT AROUND SAY EIGHT HOW NINE
DOLLARS. AND I BELIEVE IS REFER
IN NORTHERN NOW CAN IS ON AND
THE- BOB AREAS. SECONDLY I'M A
SENIOR YOU GUYS I SO MY BECAUSE
CAPITAL GAINS TO. ON MY HOME
WOULD PROVE ME FOR BUYING. WITH
THE PROCEEDS OPT HOME THAT IS
EQUAL TO IN TERMS OF WHAT I
WOULD BE LOOKING FOR. THE TAX
STRUCTURE IN THE STATE AND
CERTAINLY IN THE NATION WHEN IT
LOOKS AT PROPERTY IS
SIGNIFICANT. LEAVE BEHIND THE
TIMES IN TERMS OF. OUR MOBILITY
AND I THINK YOU NEED TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT IN TERMS OF THIS
CITY IS GOING TO BE A PROPERTY
TAX INCREASE. FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION. AND IF WE WANT TO
HELP WITH MOBILITY SOME OF THE
TAXES THAT WE PUT ON. THE BACKS
OF PEOPLE WANTING TO MOVE. OF
TWENTY TO BUY OR ARE
SIGNIFICANT AND I THINK OF A
DEEPER LOOK ASSESS OF WHAT THIS
REALLY DOES. IT REALLY HELPS-
IS ESSENTIAL BEFORE. IT REALLY
SHOULD BE SUPPORTED BY. PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA IT IS REALLY
REALLY. KIND OF A MIXED.
DOESN'T DOESN'T GET ME THERE
AND I'M SURE WHEN IT GETS ON
THE BALLOT IN THE ARGUMENTS OF
A MERGE. OF THE BE A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
AFFORDABILITY ISSUE AND THE
FACT THAT SENIORS WHO HAVE
ACQUIRED. SOME SIGNIFICANT
PROPERTY ASSETS HAVE TO STAY
THERE BECAUSE OF WHAT'S TAKEN
AWAY FROM THEM AND CERTAINLY
WHAT COULD BE PASSED ON TO
THEIR CHILDREN. WHO MIGHT
REALLY NEED THOSE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AT THIS TIME IN OUR
ECONOMY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
GALGIANI MY CLOTHES I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE BY THANKING
SENATOR HERTZBERG AND SENATOR
HILL SENATOR HILL FOR YOUR
VISION OF CLOSING THE GAP AND
FINDING THAT WOULD NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED AND SENATOR HERTZBERG
FOR COMING UP WITH A MECHANISM
FOR STABILIZING THE REVENUE AND
SENATOR HILL TO YOUR- COMMENTS
ABOUT THE FORMER POLICY
DIRECTOR OF THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION. HIS
QUOTE IS THIS INITIATIVE HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH PROP
THIRTEEN IN FACT IT STRENGTHENS
PROP THIRTEEN FOR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS OF
SENIORS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND WILD FIRE
VICTIMS AND TO MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FOUND FROM THE NORTH
WITH REGARD TO THE INHERITANCE
TAX THIS REPEALS THE PARENT
CHILD GRANDPARENT GRANDCHILD
EXCLUSION. BUT UP TO A MILLION
DOLLARS IN AGGREGATE VALUE OF
ALL OTHER TYPES OF PROPERTY-
SECONDLY WITH REGARD TO
ADDITIONAL REVENUE FOR THE
STATE ASSEMBLY PROVIDES A
BALANCING MECHANISM WITH TWO
DIFFERENT WANT FRIENDS ONE IS
THE COUNTY REVENUE PROTECTION
FIND IN THE EVENT THAT A COUNTY
COMES UP SHORT BECAUSE OF A
MOVE AND SECONDLY THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE RESPONSE FIND.
AND IT IS VERY SPECIFIC THAT A
COUNTY WHO ENDS UP HAVING OF
ADDITIONAL REVENUE COMING AND
IS NOT ELIGIBLE FOR ANY OF
THESE FUNDS AT ALL IT'S ONLY
FOR THOSE COUNTIES THAT COME UP
SHORT THIS IDEA WAS BORN OUT OF
THE PROBLEM THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE RECOGNIZED BACK IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE THROUGH
TWO THOUSAND. WHEN SENATOR TORE
LOOKS AND WAS HERE AND WE WERE
STARTING TO HAVE THE JOBS
HOUSING IMBALANCE WHEN WE HAD A
GROWING NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY
COMMUTING IT USED TO BE AN HOUR
AND A HALF TO DRIVE FOR ME FROM
SAN FRANCISCO HOME AND VICE
VERSA IT IS NOW THREE FOUR.
FIVE DURING. SENATOR TOILET BUT
A BILL THAT WOULD CREATED FINE.
FOR CREATING ADDITIONAL JOE AND
HOUSING FOR AREA. AND ALSO A
HOMES AND JOB RICH AREAS THAT
BILL PASSED WAS SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR BUT THEN WE HAD THE
DOT COM CRASH AND THE REVENUE
WASN'T AVAILABLE SINCE THAT
TIME WE'VE CONTINUED TO
STRUGGLE. AND AGAIN THIS THIS
BILL WAS BORN OUT OF THE IDEA
THAT IF WE HAVE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE IN THESE INE COUNTY BAY
AREA AS REGIONAL AREA THAT ARE
RETIRING AND DON'T NEED TO BE
WORKING LIVING IN EIGHT. JOBS
RICH AREA ANY LONGER AND WHO
ARE WANTING TO MOVE INTO SLOWER
PACED ENVIRONMENT OR NEAR THEIR
CHILDREN OR WE CUT TERMINATE
COMMUNITY. OR FOR THAT MATTER
THERE WANTING TO MOVE OUT OF
THEIR FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR CONDO AND MOVED TO SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY TO A HOME FOR
THE SAME PRICE ON A LAKE IT
WOULD GIVE THEM THAT ABILITY.
AND THEN FREE UP THOSE HOMES
AND THE JOBS WHICH AREAS SO
THAT THOSE WHO ARE WORKING AND
REALLY NEED TO LIVE THERE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DO SO. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER. ALL
DEBATE SAY MADAM SIR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. ARCHULETA
I ATKINS I BATES NO BELL I
BORDERS BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I
CHIANG. DALLY FIVE DODD. FIVE
TORONTO. I GALGIANI FIVE GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO. I TADO.
JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA I
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ NO MITCHELL.
I MONNING I MORE LOCK MERLE. NO
NIELSEN NOPAN AYE PORTANTINO
HI ROSS. I RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN. I'M BURKE I LIKE HOW
STEVE. FIVE WIENER FIVE WILK HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME. ALAN. BARGES
CHIANG. GROWTH TADO. MORE LOCK.
STERN HI. SENATOR GALGIANI
MOVES A CALL COLLEAGUES WE'RE
NEVER GOING TO GO BACK TO OUR
SENATE THIRD READING WHERE IT
FILE ITEM FORTY. SENATOR PAN.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHT FIFTY TWO BY
SENATOR PAN AND ACTUALLY DID TO
HEALTH CARE SENATOR PAN THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS SB
EIGHT FIFTY TWO REQUIRES A
STATE CONTRACTOR PARTNER TO
MANUFACTURE INSULIN TEN OTHER
GENERIC DRUGS WITH THE INTENT
THAT THESE DRUGS BE MADE WIDELY
AVAILABLE THERE FOR SURE AND WE
HAVE A RELIABLE COST EFFECTIVE
SUPPLY OF GENERIC MEDICATIONS.
THIS POLICIES MORE PORN
ENDEAVORS THE COVE IN NINETEEN
FRONT PANDEMIC HAS BROUGHT TO
LIGHT GLARING GAPS AND SUPPLIES
OF ESSENTIAL DRUGS MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT SUPPLIES WE WITNESS
THIS WITH PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT VENTILATORS BASED
MEDICAL SUPPLIES TO SWABS IN
TUBES NECESSARY FOR TESTING AND
EVEN PRESCRIPTION DRUGS-
PERHAPS ONE EXAMPLE WAS
HYDROCHLORIC WHEN WHICH WAS
ORIGINALLY TOUTED BY SOME AS A
POTENTIAL TREATMENT TO OTHER NO
LONGER- BUT- PATIENTS WHO
ACTUALLY DEPEND ON THE STRUGGLE
AT LUPUS AND ARTHRITIS ACTUALLY
HAD DIFFICULTY OBTAINING YET.
IN AREAS SUCH AS- AN AREAS IN
THE COUNTRY WHICH WERE
PARTICULARLY HARD HIT BACK OF A
NINETEEN THERE WERE REPORTS OF
POSSIBLE LOW RUNNING LOW ON
DRUGS NECESSARY FOR INTUBATION
INCLUDING MUSCLE RELAX AND- AS
DRUGS ARE DEFINED AS- AS
EFFECTIVE TREATMENTS FOR COVER
NINETEEN PATIENTS IT'S LIKELY
DOBIE SUPPLY ISSUES FOR THOSE
DRUGS AS WELL. SO IN ADDITION
TO INCREASING COMPETITION
LOWERING PRICES IN ADDRESSING
SHORTAGES SETTING UP A
STRUCTURE WHICH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS ITS OWN DRUG
MANUFACTURING CAPACITY WILL
HELP PREPARE TO STATE FOR THE
NEXT PANDEMIC I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN DEBATER DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM SENATOR MORE LAW.
SACRAMENTO PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES- THIS IS ANOTHER.
BILL THAT ENCOURAGES IS DRIFT
FROM WHAT IS THE MAIN PURPOSE
OF GOVERNMENT. OBTAINING
AFFORDABLE DRUGS WHILE
ADMIRABLE IS NOT THE CORE
FUNCTION. OF STATE GOVERNMENTS
WHY ADD MORE EMPLOYEES WITH THE
RESULTING EXPENSIVE PENSION
PLANS AND OTHER BENEFITS FAR
EXCEEDING WHAT IS OFFERED IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR TO THE
STATE'S PAYROLL. SINCE THERE IS
NO BUT IN THE ANALYSIS ALL WE
CAN ASSUME IS THAT THIS NEW
DEPARTMENT WILL SELL
MANUFACTURE GENERIC
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AT A FAIR
PRICE. ONE HAS TO ASSUME THAT
THE PRICE IS HIGHER THAN THE
COST TO MANUFACTURE PLUS
OVERHEAD. BUT IT SEEMS TO BE
SILENT ON WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU
HAVE AN EXCESS INVENTORY. IS IT
SOLD BELOW COST THIS IS THE
STATE SUBSIDIZE THE LOS IS THIS
A FOR PROFIT ENDEAVOR LIKE AN
ENTERPRISE FUND. AND HARPER
PROFITS HANDLED SHOULD THEY
OCCUR. I WOULD APPRECIATE THE
BUSINESS PLAN IN THE OFFICE
CLOSING REMARKS AND IN THE
MEANTIME UNDER THE FISCAL
CIRCUMSTANCES I WOULD RECOMMEND
DEFERRING SB EIGHT FIFTY TWO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORE LARGE
SENATOR SKINNER. MADAM
PRESIDENT A MEMBER SO I STAND
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE AND
I WOULD JUST POINT OUT I THINK
MANY OF US FEEL THAT A VERY
FUNDAMENTAL ROLE OF GOVERNMENT
IS TO PROTECT OUR CONSUMERS AND
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE COST OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. AND THE
INCREDIBLE PRICE INCREASES OR
JUST THE PRICES THAT AMERICANS
FACE COMPARED TO CANADIANS AND
EVERY OTHER OECD COUNTRIES. YOU
GOTTA WONDER WHAT'S WRONG AND
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE LOOK AT
ESSENTIAL LIFESAVING DRUGS LIKE
THOSE THAT DIABETICS NEED WHICH
ANYONE CAN CHECK AND SEE OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS HOW
THEIR ASTRONOMICAL RICE. SO I
THINK A IF A DEPARTMENT LIKE
THIS. WOULD COULD RESULT IN
GIVING. RELIEF TO THE MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS WHO PAY OUT
REGIS PRICES FOR THEIR
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS THEN WE
WOULD BE DOING A GREAT SERVICE
AS THE STATE GOVERNMENT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING AND HEARING
ON SENATOR PAN YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- I
FIRST OF ALL I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT. ANY OF THESE DRUGS. ARE
DRUGS IN WHICH- PEOPLE'S LIVES
DEPEND ON THEM- AND- FOR
EXAMPLE INSULIN IF YOU'RE A DIE
BACKING OF INSULIN YOU WILL DIE.
SO ASSURING THAT WE HAVE A
RELIABLE SUPPLY IS CERTAINLY
VERY IMPORTANT OR OTHER
MEDICATIONS WELL WE'VE ACTUALLY
HAD DINNER MEDICATIONS WHICH
HAVE BEEN SEVERE SHORTAGE
BECAUSE- UNFORTUNATELY
ECONOMICS DID NOT ALLOW FOR
LIABLE SUPPLIES SO. BUT TONIGHT
SO- THERE'S A DRUG THAT
BASICALLY STE USED TREATING-
LEUKEMIA THAT WAS IN SHORT
SUPPLY AND THERE WAS A
CHALLENGES TRYING TO PROVIDE
LEUKEMIA TREATMENTS FOR
CHILDREN BECAUSE OF THAT- WITH
THAT OTHER OCCASIONS AS WELL AT
THE SAME TIME WE'VE ALSO
EXPERIENCED. AND SEEN STORIES
ABOUT MEDICATIONS AND WHICH-
MAYBE IT'S GONE DOWN THE ONE
MANUFACTURER AND HEDGE FUND
MANAGER DECIDES TO BUY THAT
COMPANY AND JACK UP THE PRICES
SO- I THINK WE'VE ALL HEARD
ABOUT SOME OF THOSE EXAMPLES AS
WELL. AND NOW IT AND SO KNOWING
THAT- AN ENTITY LIKE THE STATE-
MIGHT ENTER SUCH A MARKETS-
WOULD ACTUALLY DISCOURAGE
PEOPLE FROM TRYING TO ENGAGE IN
THIS KIND OF PREDATORY
BEHAVIOR. BECAUSE ESSENTIALLY
PATIENTS WHO ARE DEPEND ON
THESE DRUGS HAVE NO CHOICE BUT
ALSO POINT OUT THE BILL
ACTUALLY ACCESS TO FURTHER
INVESTIGATE- THE VIABILITY OF
THIS IDEA AND TO LOOK INTO SOME
OF THE TAIL SO WHY APPRECIATE-
MY GOOD FRIEND FROM COSTA MESA
ASKING FOR THE BUSINESS PLAN
PART OF THE- BILL. IS ACTUALLY
TO DO JUST THAT SO I HOPE YOU
WILL VOTE FOR THE BILL SO WE
CAN. HAVE THAT PLAN WHICH THEN
WE WILL CRAFTING TO FURTHER
LEGISLATION IF WE CHOOSE TO
BASED ON THE INFORMATION WE
GATHER- TO MOVE FURTHER IN THIS
DIRECTION AND IN TERMS OF
IMPLEMENTATION. SO THAT I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. WELL DEBATE HAVING SAY.
MADAM SIR. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE PROJECT FOR NO ALLEN. YEAH
I ARE. I AT. I PLEASE. NO BELL
I FORGES. NO BRADFORD HI BY
ADAM I CHIANG. I VALLEY NO DODD.
I TORONTO HI GALGIANI FIVE
GLAZER BY GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HILL I HUESO. I TADO
I JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA I
MCGUIRE. I MELINDA'S NO
MITCHELL. I MONNING I MORE LONG
NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO HAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO. I
SKINNER I STERN HI AMBER I LIKE
HOW SKI. I WIENER I WILK HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROVE. I HERTZBERG. GROVE I
DON'T KNOW. HERTZBERG. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE
MORE TIME. HERTZBERG HI ALL
EYES THIRTY ONE KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES COLLEAGUES WERE
GONNA JUMP BACK TO ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING NOW JUST A LITTLE
EXERCISE TO KEEP US OLD NIMBLE
HERE. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO FILE
ITEM EIGHTY FOUR. WHICH IS A CA
FOR BY SENATOR MULLIN IT WILL
BE PRESENTED BY SENATOR UMBERG.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT FOR BIAS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN AN ACT RELATING
TO ELECTIONS SENATOR UMBERG THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES LET ME
KNOW YOU BEGIN BY COMPLIMENTING
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MULLIN AND
LOW- EACH OF THEM HAD-
COMPETING MEASURES TO ALLOW
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS TO VOTE IN
THE GENERAL ELECTION. AFTER A
LOT OF HARD WORK ON EACH OTHER
PARTS THEY CAME TOGETHER AND
COMPROMISED ON A CA FOR WHAT DO
YOU SEE FOUR DOES IS IT ALLOWS
SOMEONE WHO TURNS EIGHTEEN BY
THE NOVEMBER ELECTION TO BE
ABLE TO VOTE IN THE PRIMARY OR
CAUCUS. THAT'S ALL IT DOES IN A
PLACES THIS BEFORE THE SELECT
THE VOTERS. WHETHER OR NOT THEY
THINK SOMEONE WHO TURNS
EIGHTEEN. BY THE GENERAL
ELECTION DATE SHOULD BUILD A
VOTE IN THE PRIMARY- RESEARCH
INDICATES THAT THE YOUTH
POPULATION IS THE LOWEST VOTER
TURNOUT OF ANY AGE DEMOGRAPHIC
TURN OUT FOR ELIGIBLE. YOUNG
VOTERS IS ONLY TWENTY SEVEN
POINT 5% FOR THE GENERAL
ELECTION WAS ONLY TWENTY SEVEN
ELECTION. FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
PRIMARY ELECTION YOUNG PEOPLE-
MADE UP ONLY FOURTEEN POINT 5%
OF THE POPULATION EXCUSE ME
THEY MADE UP FOURTEEN POINT 5%
OF POPULATION BUT ONLY SIX
POINT 3% OF THOSE. VOTED AC
FOUR WOULD CREATE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO
ENGAGE EARLY ON. EARLY ON IN
THE PROCESS FOR LIFELONG
PARTICIPATION. IN OUR ELECTORAL
PROCESS- THIS IS NOT EXACTLY
CUTTING EDGE IF WE ADOPT THIS
OF THE VOTERS ADOPT THIS. IN
NOVEMBER WE WOULD BE. ARE AMONG
THE ALMOST HALF THE STATES THAT
ALREADY ALLOWED SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLDS TO VOTE IN THE GENERAL
ELECTION IF THEY TURN EIGHTEEN
BY THE ELECTION DATE- THIS IS
A- MEASURE THAT HAS
IMPLICATIONS FOR LIFE LONG
ENGAGEMENT. URGENT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION SENATOR NIELSEN.
THAT A PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN THE SENATE YOU KNOW
THAT VOTING AGE USED TO BE
TWENTY ONE. AND FOR ALL THE
SAME ARGUMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
POSED NOW. WE'RE GONNA TAKE
EIGHTEEN. AND THE MANY ENSURING
YEARS WHAT HAS HAPPENED HOW
DOES A USEFUL VOTERS GOTTEN
MORE ENGAGED. OBVIOUSLY NOT THE
STATISTICS. A TERRIBLE. THERE
MAY BE CERTAIN REASONS I'D
ARGUE THAT TO HAND K. TWELVE
EDUCATION OUR CIVIC EDUCATION
JUST ABOUT NONEXISTENT. WE'RE
NOT MOTIVATING THEM THOSE YOUTH.
GIVING THEM GOOD REASONS
UNDERSTAND OR PARTICIPATE IN
THEIR GOVERNMENT SHOWING THEM
WHAT OPPORTUNITIES DO EXIST AND
WHAT THAT INCREDIBLE. RIGHT TO
VOTE REALLY MEANS HOW SACRED IT
IS. I WOULD THAT MORE HER
TRAVEL TO ANOTHER COUNTRY
SHOULD DO NOT HAVE THIS AND I
HAVE. IT WAS IN INDIA. THE YEAR
THAT INDIRA GANDHI THE PRIME
MINISTER IMPOSED HER EMERGENCY
POWERS AND SUSPENDED BOATING.
AND THAT HUGE NATION. TRAVEL
THE VILLAGES OF INDIA. THE
PEOPLE WERE NOT COMPLAINING
ABOUT THEIR PLIGHT THE HEALTH
THE POVERTY. THEY WERE MAD THAT
THEY WERE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE
TO VOTE. BUT YOU COME BACK TO
AMERICA. AND EVEN OUR ADULTS.
OUR COMPLACENT. TAKES A LOT
EVEN GET THEM OUT TO VOTE. BACK
TO THE YOUTH. I WOULD PROTECT
THE- TWO YEARS HENCE. FOUR
YEARS HENCE WE LOOK AT THIS
BOTH THE SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS.
DID THEY COME SWARMING INTO THE
POLLS. I WOULD HOPE SO. BUT I
DOUBT IT. AND THEN THERE'S
ANOTHER LITTLE ASIDE TO THIS.
YOU KNOW HERE IN MANY AREAS IN
TERMS OF PROTECTING OUR YOUNGER
CITIZENS. IT'S SUCH THINGS AS A
DRIVING. WE'RE ELEVATING THE
AGE. THAT THEY NEED MORE
MATURITY. MORE EXPERIENCE.
THOSE SAME POINTS LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN APPLY HERE. ONE THING
ABOUT THIS GENERATION. MAYBE
IT'S BEEN A LITTLE BIT TOO EASY
FOR. I ARGUED IT WAS TOO EASY
FOR MY GENERATION. AND I
ACTUALLY MISSED THE GREATEST
GENERATION BY YOURSELF. BUT I
ALWAYS SAID THAT MY PARENTS
FAILED ME THEY WERE THE PRODUCT
OF THE GREAT DEPRESSION. AND
THEY VOWED THAT THEIR CHILDREN
WILL NEVER SO SUFFER AND SO
THEY MADE IT TOO EASY FOR US.
WELL MY DAD DIDN'T MAKE IT
EASIER FOR ME BUT THAT'S
ANOTHER STORY AND I'VE ALWAYS
THANKED HIM FOR THAT. BUT ALSO
APPRECIATED THE MATURITY AND
WISDOM. GROWING UP WITH MORE
RESPONSIBILITIES. AND NOW THEN
I THINK MYSELF I'M GUILTY WITH
MY OWN CHILDREN OF BEING TOO
GOOD TO THEM. MAKING THINGS TOO
EASY ON THEM. LIFE EXPERIENCE
IS VERY IMPORTANT AND YOU LEARN.
FROM YOUR LIFE EXPERIENCE. IT
AGAIN THE ABJECT IN ATTENTION.
OF OUR KILL CHILDREN TO THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT SURROUND
THEM THAT THEIR GOVERNMENT
MEANS TO THEM. IT'S SAD. SO I
HAVE DEDICATED MYSELF TO
MENTORING THAT'S MY SMALL
CONTRIBUTION CHILD BY CHILD.
BUT HERE I DON'T THINK WE'RE
GOING TO DO ANY GOOD. TO
MOTIVATE TO SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS
TO SHOW UP AT ANY GREATER.
BREAK THE POLLS IN THE EIGHTEEN
YEAR OLDS. I HATE TO SAY IT BUT-
I GUESS IT'S BROKEN LET'S LEAVE
IT BROUGHT. READY SENATOR
BORGIAS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I KINDA LOOKED AT
THIS. PROPOSITION AND IT
HARKENS BACK TO OF A NUMBER OF
OTHER ISSUES WHERE I'M
SCRATCHING MY HEAD ASKING FOR.
A DEFINITION WHAT IS AN ADULT.
NORMALLY YOU TRIBUTE ADULT HOOD
TO A NUMBER OF YEARS. AND BY
VIRTUE OF THAT YOU HAVE CERTAIN
RESPONSIBILITIES AND
OPPORTUNITIES. NORMALLY I THINK
IT'S CITY CALIFORNIA WE
DETERMINE AN ADULT TO BE
EIGHTEEN YEARS OF AGE. THE
REASON I BRING THAT UP IS THAT
THERE SHOULD BE A DEGREE OF
CONSISTENCY. ON A NUMBER OF
FRONTS WHEN INDIVIDUAL BUT- A
MATURE AGE OF EIGHTEEN THAT
ALONG WITH THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
COME RESPONSIBILITIES. BUT IF
YOU INVENTORY AL ALL OVER THE
BOARD WE ARE AS A STATE MSG
OTHER STATES ARE THE SAME WAY
THAT YOU MUST BE TWENTY ONE
YEARS OF AGE TO DRINK. YOU
DON'T GET TO DRINK SIX MONTHS
OR A FEW MONTHS BEFORE YOU HIT
TWENTY ONE BECAUSE YOU'RE THAT
CLOSE. YOU GET TO BE EIGHTEEN
YEARS THE GAMBLE OR TWENTY ONE
OF ITS IN A CASINO DEPENDING ON
THE STATE. YOU DON'T GET TO
WALK IN TO A GAMBLING OPERATION
IF YOU'RE A FEW MONTHS AWAY
FROM EIGHTEEN. YOU HAVE TO BE
TWENTY ONE TO BUY CIGARETTES.
WE HAVE TO BE EIGHTEEN TO JOIN
THE MILITARY CAN POSSIBLY RISK
YOUR LIFE. IN THE PROCESS. IT
WAS FUN GOING WITH ALL THIS IS
THAT IF WE HAVE A RANGE
BETWEEN. YOU KNOW. EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY ONE WHAT IS THE LOGIC IN
ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS TO VOTE I
WANT PEOPLE TO VOTE I WANT
YOUNGSTERS TO VOTE WE HAVE A
HORRIBLE TURNOUT WHEN IT COMES
TO YOUNG FOLKS TURNING OUT AND
BEING PART OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS. THAT'S A VISIBLE
THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE. BUT THIS
IS NOT GOING TO BE THE ANSWER
IN FACT HE JUST CREATES ANOTHER
STRANGE IRREGULARITY
INCONSISTENCY ON WHAT IT MEANS
TO BE AN ADULT. IF IT'S
EIGHTEEN MINUTES EIGHTEEN VOTE
IF IT'S TWENTY ONE TO DRINK
IT'S TWENTY ONE TO DRINK I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHERE WE'RE-
CREATING. THESE ODD
ENCUMBRANCES IN EXCEPTIONS TO A
PROCESS WHEN YOU'RE IN ADULT
YOU ACHIEVE THE
RESPONSIBILITIES AS WELL AS THE
OPPORTUNITIES. YOU CAN'T GO
FASTER. THANK YOU SENATOR MITCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MADAM
PRESIDENT YOU KNOW THOSE ON THE
FRONT LINES OF MOST JUSTICE
MOVEMENTS THROUGHOUT HISTORY
HAVE BEEN YOUNG PEOPLE THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT IS A
PERFECT EXAMPLE OF THAT- THE
MUSCLE BEHIND THE VOTING RIGHTS
ACT FOR YOUNG PEOPLE AND LET'S
NOT FORGET DOCTOR KING HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED ALL THAT WE KNOW
THAT HE HAD ACCOMPLISHED BEFORE
HIS ASSASSINATION AT THIRTY
NINE. YOU KNOW IN MY OPINION
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT CAN'T START
EARLY ENOUGH. BONY WE HOPE TO
BECOME A PRACTICE VOTING IS ONE
EXAMPLE OF HOW YOU ENGAGE
SEPARATELY. AND WE RECOGNIZE
THAT ALMOST EVERY ASPECT OF A
YOUNG PERSON'S LIFE IS GOVERNED
BY A DECISION MADE BY SOME
ELECTED BODY. THE FACT THAT
THEY HAVE TO GO TO SCHOOL THE
TYPE OF CURRICULUM THEY STUDY
IN CALIFORNIA FOR A WHILE YOU
HAD TO PASS A HIGH SCHOOL EXIT
EXAM THE DECISION MADE BY THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE. SO WHAT
IS THE HARM IN GIVING THEM
ENCOURAGING THEM INVITING THEM
TO ENGAGE SPECIFICALLY AS EARLY
AS POSSIBLE. THEY WILL BE
VOTING AT EIGHTEEN BY THE
NOVEMBER GENERAL THIS IS SIMPLY
ALLOWING THEM TO ENGAGE IN THE
PROCESS INFILL PART OF THE
PROCESS BY CASTING THEIR VOTES
LEADING UP TO THE PRIMARY. WHAT
IS THE HARM IN THAT LET'S BE
CLEAR VOTING TURNOUT IS A BIT
SMALL ACROSS AGE GROUPS. THE
LET'S NOT CRIMINALIZE YOUNG
PEOPLE. HALF OF THE FOLKS IN
THE STATE AND OUR OWN AGES
DON'T BLOW. FULL JUST MAYBE IF
WE CAPTURE THE ATTENTION IN THE
IN THE IN IN THE INTEREST. OF
YOUNG PEOPLE FRESH OUT OF U. S.
HISTORY- CALIFORNIA HISTORY
CIVICS CLASSES IN HIGH SCHOOL
MAYBE WE CAN HELP TURN THE TIDE
IN TERMS OF INCREASING VOTER
TURNOUT ACROSS THE STATE. I
TRAVEL WITH THE SENATE MANY OF
TO FALLS AGO. IT IS A TEN YEAR
DEMOCRACY AT THE NEW DEMOCRACY.
WE WERE BLOWN AWAY AND QUITE
FRANKLY EMBARRASSED WHEN WE
LEARNED OF THEIR VOTER TURN OUT.
THINK THE VOTER TURNOUT WAS
NINETY SOME PERCENT. THEY
LOOKED AT US WE MET WITH MANY
THEIR ELECTED LEADERS AND THEY
LOOK AT US AND ASK US WHAT ARE
VOTER TURNOUT WAS AND WE ALL
GOT COMPLETELY CONFUSE OWNED
STARTED MUMBLING. AND I WAS
JUST INTRIGUED BY THAT I
WODERED WHY AND I THOUGHT
MAYBE BECAUSE OF THE NEW
DEMOCRACY. ON PEOPLE ARE GAYS
ARE INTERESTED WANT TO BE A
PART OF IT. I DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER. BUT I REALLY. COME ON I
THINK THE FURTHER WE GET FROM
SEVENTEEN THE FOGGY ARE REAR
VIEW MIRROR GETS IN TERMS OF
WHAT ARE ONLY HAS WERE LIKE GET
SEVENTEEN. WHY NOT. ENGAGE OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE. IN STARTING CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE. AND GIVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN IN
TERMS OF HOLES ON THEIR LOCAL
SCHOOL BOARD. WHO RUNS THEIR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. WHO WINS
THEIR CITY COUNCILS WHO WHO
RUNS THEIR- WATER BOARDS IN
THEIR DISH ONE. ON THE IN
SUPPORT OF CA. THANK YOU SIR
MITCHELL SENATOR HELLO. YEAH.
SENATOR ALLEN YOU WISH TO SPEAK.
TO MY COLLEGE FROM WESTERN TO
CONTEST JOB OF THINGS OF REALLY
COME IT I MEAN IN THE END OF
THE DAY GUYS YOU KNOW WE'RE
CALL THIS I DON'T THE THIS IS
HAVE THIS IS. WHAT YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE JUST LETTING FOLKS
PARTISAN IN THE PRICE A- FOR
THAT'S PART OF THE SO CHOOSING
THE CANDIDATES THAT WILL BE ON
THE NEW BALLOT SOMETIME OF
COURSE THE PRIMARY LET. AND
BEING THE FINE ACTION AS SAW
YOU KNOW WITH BUT THERE ARE
GOOD FRIEND DAILY ON WHO IS
JUST ALLOW TO THIS COUNCIL
BECAUSE HE REACHED THAT PER
THREAT IN THE IN IN IT IS CAL
RACE AND SO HE'S RAISED MAKE IT
TO THE NOVEMBER EVEN THOUGH
OTHER RACES MAKE IT TO NOVEMBER
BOUT NAY AND IT IS VERY WOULD
HAVE BEEN ME TO THE NOVEMBER
ABOUT. NINE FIFTY FOR SO THE
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE THE OPTION.
TO YOU KNOW WHO WHO SHOULD KEPT
IN ON WHO KNEW. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE CYCLE THAT THEY WOULD
NORMALLY BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
AND AS- GIVEN THE FACT THAT
ABOUT TO TURN EIGHTEEN. AND
I'VE A- THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN
SENATOR STERN. A VERY BRIEFLY
IN THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT-
LONG TIME COMING HERE. AB THIS
THIS EXPANSION OF
ENFRANCHISEMENT AND SUFFRAGE TO
BASICALLY A VOICELESS
GENERATION IS SORELY NEEDED AT
THIS MOMENT WE ALLOW SIXTEEN
YEAR OLDS TO DRIVE. TWO
THOUSAND POUNDS METAL OBJECTS
CALLED CARS AROUND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AT THE AGE OF
SIXTEEN ON OUR ROADS- THEY GO
TO SCHOOLS. THEY PLAY IN THE
PARKS THAT WERE SUPPOSED TO BE
FUNDING OR THE LACK THERE OF-
THEY LIVE IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND THERE'S TRYING TO SPEAK UP
BUT NOW WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO
GIVE THEM A VENUE FOR THAT
VOICE AT THE BALLOT AND IT
COULDN'T COME QUICKLY ENOUGH- I
TAUGHT CIVICS AFTER I WENT TO
COLLEGE. AND I HATED TO SPEAK
INTO THOSE HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS.
BASS HE- AND THEN THE DAHLE
PEDICLE. THE IDEA YOU GET TO
LEARN ABOUT THE CONSTITUTION
AND YOU LEARN ABOUT HOW BILL
BECOMES A LAW AND YOU WATCH
THIS SCHOOLHOUSE ROCK VIDEO BUT
YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT FOR YOU
RIGHT NOW YOU'RE ON OLD ENOUGH
YOU'RE NOT MATURE ENOUGH.
WEIGHT TO YOU MOVE AWAY FROM
HOME. DISCONNECT YOURSELF FROM
YOUR FAMILY AND YOUR COMMUNITY.
MAYBE YOU GO OFF TO COLLEGE
SOMEWHERE AND THEN FIGURE OUT.
HOW TO ENGAGE IN CIVICS. BUT
FOR ALL THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE
LEAVING HOME. WELL LISTEN- WE
TEACH HIM THAT FIRST VOTERS IN
CONNECTED TO WHERE THEY'RE
FROM- WE BUILD CIVIC HABIT.
STARTING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL-
THANK THE AUTHOR AND ELECTIONS
CHAIR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
IN STRONG SUPPORT ACA FOR.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- SAY- I WAS
TO GO INTO THINGS THAT MOST TO
ENJOY IS ACTUALLY- MEETING WITH
HIGH SCHOOL- CLASSES TO TALK
ABOUT- OUR GOVERNMENTS AND
THINK IT IS- FRIEND JUST
REFERENCED AND- THE IDEA THAT
WOULD BE TALKING TO THEM ABOUT
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO BE
ENGAGE DIRECTLY INTO VOTE AND
YET TELL THEM THAT WELL LATER
IS WHEN YOU'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO DO IT IS A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY AND CERTAINLY AT A
DEVELOPMENTAL PEDIATRICIAN I
THINK WE CAN HAVE THE BATES
ABOUT. YOU KNOW PEOPLE'S MENTAL
SO FORTH BUT I THINK IT'S
PRETTY REASONABLE TO SAY THAT A
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD ON AVERAGE-
BECAUSE WE TALK ABOUT ON
AVERAGE IS CERTAINLY REPORTING
CABLE ONE I'D POINT ACTUALLY BY
EXPERIENCES THAT AT THAT AGE
THEY'RE MORE CURIOUS AND MORE
INTERESTED IN ASKING QUESTIONS
AND GETTING ANSWERS ABOUT THE
ISSUES THEN FRANKLY A LOT OF
OTHER VOTERS ARE SO I'M PRETTY
CONFIDENT THAT GETTING THIS
OPPORTUNITY NOT ONLY GETS MORE
ENGAGED USE BUT ALSO WILL BRING
IN VOTERS THAT ACTUALLY. ARE
MORE INTERESTED IN TRYING TO
EXPOSE THESE ISSUES BECAUSE ALL
BRAND NEW TO THEM AND- SO I
TONIGHT BUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR PAN SENATOR WILK
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR ARCHER LET.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF A CA FOR. I
KNOW FOR ME MY FIRST ELECTION
WAS IN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT.
AND THE FIRST PERSON EVER CAST
A VOTE FOR WITH KEN MADDY AND
COURSE WE HAVE OUR OUR OF ROOM
HERE- NAMED AFTER HIM. AND I
WAS INVOLVED IN THAT CAMPAIGN
VOTED FOR HIM IF IT HAD BEEN AN
EARLY PRIMARY LIKE TO WAS THIS
YEAR I WOULD HAVE NOT HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE FOR HIM
EVEN THOUGH I WAS VOLUNTEERING
FOR HIM. AND AS MENTIONED BY MY
FRIEND FROM SACRAMENTO HI TO
SPEND A LOT OF TIME TALKING TO
YOUNG PEOPLE WHETHER IT'S IN
THE CLASSROOM YMCA BOYS AND
GIRLS CLUB AND- THEY ARE
INTERESTED IN IN SAID EX BUT
THEY'RE ALSO STUCK BY THE
INFORMATION I GIVE THEM.
BECAUSE I WANT TO GIVE THEM THE
AND FILTERED TRUTH AND WE ALL
TALK ABOUT THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD AND THAT
IS IN FACT TRUE. BUT I JUST GOT
A LATEST FIGURES FROM OUR GOOD
FRIEND FROM. COUNTY ARE
UNRESTRICTED NET POSITION FOR
THIS STATE IS NEGATIVE TWO
HUNDRED THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS. WE ARE SELLING THE
NEXT GENERATION WITH CRUSHING
pBE INVOLVED NOW AND HAVE A SAY
NOW- BEFORE WE DO ANY MORE
DAMAGE I THINK THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE INCREDIBLY SMART
THIRTY MAKING WIDE- WISE
CHOICES. AND I THINK THE SOONER
THE WE GET THEM ENGAGED AT THE
BETTER AND I THINK I A CA FOR
IS A RESPONSIBLE. OF RESPONSE
TO LACK OF BEEN A CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
THANK YOU. SENATE SENATOR WILK
SENATOR ARCHER LET. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE IN
SUPPORT. YOU KNOW WE WERE HEARD
SOMEONE MENTION THE MILITARY.
AND I SERVED WITH YOUNG MEN WHO
WERE SEVENTEEN TURNED EIGHTEEN
BEFORE WE WENT INTO COMBAT I
WAS EIGHTEEN WHEN I JOINED- MY
SON ONE OF MY SONS WENT OFF TO
WEST POINT HE WAS SEVENTEEN.
ALL DURING HIS SENIOR YEAR AND
I SEND THEM OFF TO- WEST POINT
PREP SCHOOL WHEN HE WAS
SEVENTEEN AND CHANGE I FORGET
EXACTLY WAS BUT HE TURNED
EIGHTEEN WHILE HE WAS AT WEST
POINT. OF THE QUESTION IS WHAT
ARE YOU AFRAID OF. ARE YOU
AFRAID OF THE YOUNG MEN AND
WOMEN THAT ARE. PROTESTING UP
AND DOWN THE STREETS WHO ARE.
ABOUT THAT AGE THAT ARE
SEVENTEEN WILL BE EIGHTEEN WHEN
IT'S READY TO VOTE ARE YOU
AFRAID THE FACT IS THAT THEY
WILL CHANGE THE SOCIETY IN SUCH
A WAY. THAT NOW WE SEE A
QUALITY OF FURNACE TODAY WE
TALKED ABOUT BILL THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR BETTER WAYS FOR
PEOPLE TO LIVE AND WORK- WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY NOW TO OPEN
THE DOORS FOR THIS NEXT
GENERATION. AND AGAIN REMEMBER.
IT IS SEVENTEEN THAT'S A
PRIMARY IT'LL TAKE A MINUTE
EIGHTEEN SO I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD STOP THEM. FROM THEIR
PROGRESS IN EDUCATION AND
PARTICIPATING BECAUSE I THINK
RIGHT NOW WHAT WE'VE SEEN MORE
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN. INVOLVED
IN SOCIETY IN WHAT'S GOING ON
THAN WE'VE EVER SEEN BEFORE. SO
I THINK WE SHOULD TAKE A HARD
LOOK I THINK WE SHOULD
UNDERSTAND THIS IS THE NEW WAVE
AND WE SHOULD SUPPORT IT. AND I
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR ARCHER LETTER
SENATOR RUBIO. MADAM PRESIDENT
I JUST WANNA MAKE ONE QUICK
POINT WE ALL HAVE ALREADY
BELABOR THE POINT SPREAD YOU
KNOW PERSONALLY FOR ME I
REMEMBER THE FRUSTRATION I FELT
HEARING CALIFORNIA WHEN WE
WOULD SEE ALL THE PRIMARY
SAPPING ALL OVER IT. THE UNITED
STATES AND BY THE TIME WE HAD
TO GO INTO OUR TO VOTE PRETTY
MUCH WE WERE LEFT WITH. WHAT
SOMEONE ELSE HAD DECIDED FOR US
AND SO I THINK THIS IS JUST A
WAY FOR ALLOWING THEM TO ALSO
BE PART OF. YOU KNOW WHO WE
SELECTED MOVE FORWARD TO THE
NOVEMBER ELECTION SO I THINK
IT'S JUST A GOOD WAY TO. TAKE
IT OUR YOUNG FOLKS ASSN VAGUELY
ENGAGE BUT AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY. HOW THE DECISION
MAKING. GOING TO THE PRIMARY SO
THEY CAN TAKE THE PERSON THAT
THEY WANT ASKED HI LIKE I SAID
WAS VERY FRUSTRATED THAT WE
ALWAYS. EAT I DON'T MEAN TO
DISRESPECT BUT THE LEFTOVER OF
WHAT OTHER STATES HAVE DONE SO
WITH THAT I ALSO ASK FOR NAVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DEBATE AND
DISCUSSION. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE SENATOR UMBERG YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
LET ME RESPOND A FEW COMMENTS
HERE- FIRST. LET ME RESPOND TO
A COMMENT. FROM THE CENTER FROM
TECH HAM I AGREE WITH YOU THE
SYSTEM'S BROKE. BUT I DON'T
AGREE THAT WE SHOULD LEAVE IT
BROKE WE CAN. BEGIN TO
ENCOURAGE AND TO INVOLVE
YOUNGER PEOPLE. NOW THE COMMENT
WITH RESPECT TO MY FRIEND FROM
FRESNO THAT WE ONLY ALLOW
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS TO A
MILITARY ACTUALLY SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLDS DO AND DO JOINT
MILITARY AS MY FRIEND FROM
PEOPLE REVERE AND MY FRIEND
FROM RIVERSIDE POINT OUT THAT
THERE ARE SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS
IN THE MILITARY AND IF WE TRUST
THE SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD TO JUMP
OUT OF A C. ONE THIRTY WITH AN
M. FOUR STRAPPED TO HIS OR HER
SIDE. I THINK WE CAN TRUST THEM
WITH A PRIMARY ABOUT HYDROGEN
AYE VOTE. WELL DEBATE HAVING
SEIZED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES.
BELL I FORGES. BRADFORD. COVER
THEIR CABALLERO. I CHIANG FIVE
DOLLY. DODD I DORADO. I
GALGIANI I GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG I HELLO I
HUESO. HI TADO I JACKSON HI I
JONES NO LEYVA. I MCGUIRE AYE
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL. I
MONNING HI WARLOCK MORRELL NO
NIELSEN. NO HAN FIVE PORTANTINO
I ROTH. I RUBIO. I SKINNER. I
STERN HI I'M BURKE AYE AYE WHAT
CASKEY. I WIENER I WILK HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE BASE. FOR JUST NO BRADFORD
I DALLY. GROWTH NO MORE LOCK.
NOW. I THIRTY ONE KNOWS SEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES COLLEAGUES
WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO BACK AND
LIFT THE CALLS ON THE PRIOR
ITEMS FOR WHICH WE PLACE THEM
ON CALL AND WE WILL START.
MOMENTARILY.
REALLY.
COLLEAGUES
WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM THIRTY. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ACTION MEMBERS. FILE ITEM
THIRTY. ARCHULETA I GORGEOUS.
CABALLERO. GALGIANI GLAZER I
HILL. I HUESO TADO. PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH HI RUBIO I
AM BURKE HI HI VICE TWENTY FIVE
KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE PASSAGE.
I'M SORRY GALGIANI AYE GALGIANI
AYE. THE SECOND. BUT LET'S CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME PLEASE. FOR JUST NO
CABALLERO AYE HUESO TADO. ICE
TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS ELEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO SB
TWELVE THIRTEEN FILE ITEM
THIRTY SEVEN BY SENATOR LEYVA
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FOR JUST. TADO HI MELENDEZ. I
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
THIRTY EIGHT SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE BY SENATOR HILL PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES
GORGEOUS. TADO I MORE LOCK.
WILK HI. FIVE THIRTY THREE
KNOWS FOR IF THE MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE S. BE
SEVEN NINETY FIVE BY SENATOR
BAIL PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BATES TADO HI I TWENTY
NINE KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE
AC EIGHT ELEVEN. VICE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN FOR JUST.
CHIANG GROVE TADO. MORE LOCK. I
TWENTY NINE KNOWS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING BACK NOW
TO SENATE THIRD READING I- FILE
ITEM FORTY ONE FILE ITEM FORTY
ONE BY SENATOR WIENER. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL EIGHT FIFTY FIVE BY
SENATOR WIENER AN ACT RELATING
TO HEALTH COVERAGE SENATOR
WINNER FIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE PRESIDENT OF COLLEAGUES
SB EIGHT FIFTY FIVE- IS A BILL
THAT WILL HELP US ON OUR LONG
JOURNEY TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
WHO HAVE MENTAL HEALTH OR
ADDICTIONS CHALLENGES CAN
ACTUALLY GET THE CARE THEY
NEED. SPECIFICALLY IT WILL
REQUIRE INSURANCE COMPANIES TO
COVER ALL MEDICALLY NECESSARY
MENTAL HEALTH AND ADDICTION
CARE THAT SEEMS PRETTY COMMON
SENSE IF THE DOCTOR SAYS THAT
PARTICULAR CARE IS MEDICALLY
NECESSARY YOU WOULD THINK THAT
INSURANCE COMPANIES WOULD COVER
IT UNFORTUNATELY THEY OFTEN
DON'T AND RIGHT NOW WE HAVE FAR
TOO MANY SITUATIONS WHERE
INSURANCE COMPANIES WILL ONLY
COVER MENTAL HEALTH AND
ADDICTION CARE. IF YOU ARE
ALREADY IN CRISIS IF YOU'RE
ALREADY HEADING TO THE SITE
EMERGENCY ROOM IF YOU'RE ALL ON
RAVELING IS REALLY NO DIFFERENT
THAN IF YOU WERE DIAGNOSED WITH
STAGE LUNG CANCER AND YOUR
INSURANCE COMPANY TURNED AROUND
AND SAID. IT'S TOO EARLY WE
WILL COVER YOU ONCE YOU'RE
STAGE FOUR CANCER WE WOULD
LAUGH THEM OUT OF THE BUILDING.
IF THEY TALK ABOUT POSITION BUT
THAT IS WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
MENTAL HEALTH AND ADDICTION
THERE. ANSWER THE CALIFORNIA
MENTAL HEALTH PARITY ACT. WHICH
SAYS THAT YOU HAVE TO TREAT
MENTAL HEALTH. THE SAME AS
PHYSICAL HEALTH BECAUSE WE KNOW
TO FRANKLY ARE NO DIFFERENT AND
IT'S TIME TO MOVE BEYOND. THE
THIRD PART OF ME. THE ACT IS
INCOMPLETE IT IS LIMITED TO A
SUBSET OF MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS. IT DOESN'T COVER
THINGS LIKE PTSD. IT DOESN'T
COVER SUBSTANCE USE. DISORDER
IT DOESN'T COVER ANXIETY
CONDITIONS IT DOESN'T COVER A
WHOLE VARIETY OF CONDITIONS A
REALLY HARM PEOPLE'S LIVES. WE
KNOW THAT WE HAVE A MENTAL
HEALTH AND ADDICTION CRISIS IN
THE STATE. NGUYEN CMO IS
VISIBLY ON OUR STREETS BUT IT
IS NOT JUST ON OUR STREETS AND
COVER NINETEEN IS MAKING IT
WORSE. PEOPLE NEED TO HAVE
ACCESS TO CARE. EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE WILL DO THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER
DEBATER DISCUSSIONS SENATOR
BAIL. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
TO MEMBERS- RISES SO PROUD
PRINCIPLE COSTS ARE IN SUPPORT
OF- SP- EIGHT FIVE FIVE MENTAL
HEALTH HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
SEGREGATED ELEMENT OF HEALTH
CARE. WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO IN
OUR MINDS TO THINK OF MENTAL
HEALTH AS A SOCIAL FAILING NOT
A LEGITIMATE HEALTH CAREISSUE.
THE STIGMA IS DANGEROUS TO HAVE
DURING A TIME WHEN PEOPLE NEED
MENTAL HEALTH CARE MORE THAN
EVER. STRESS FOR ON. IS A- BY
DURING THE PANDEMIC PEOPLE ARE
LOSING JOBS AND BE ABLE TO PAY
RENT. LOSING THEIR HOMES
EXPERIENCING A SENIOR ISOLATION.
STRESS CAN BE DETRIMENTAL FOR
MANY PEOPLE STRUGGLING WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES ESPECIALLY
FOR THOSE FIGHTING A DRUG
ADDICTION NOW THE ADDICTION
POLICY FORM FOUND IN A RECENT
STUDY. 20% OF RESPONDENTS
REPORTED INCREASED SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TO THE CORNER VIRUS
PANDEMIC. MENTAL HEALTH PARITY
IS AN EMPTY PROMISE IF PEOPLE
STRUGGLING WITH ADDICTION. GET
EFFECTIVE TREATMENT AND UNDER
THE CURRENT SYSTEM INSURANCE
COMPANIES ARE ABLE TO DELAY OR
DENY LIFESAVING MEDICATION
SINCE THE TREATMENT PRESCRIBED
BY THE DOCTOR. MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS ARE JUST LIKE ANY
OTHER DISEASE WE DON'T TREAT IT
IT GETS WORSE AND WORSE. IN
ADDITION TO THIS BILL THE
MENTAL HEALTH CAUCUSES
SUPPORTED SB ZERO THREE WHICH
ESTABLISHES THE PEER SUPPORT
CERTIFICATION WE NEED TO PASS A
MENTAL HEALTH. ROBUST MENTAL
HEALTH BILL PACKAGE UNLESS WE
REQUIRE PARITY PEOPLE WILL
CONTINUE TO FACE A ROAD BOX TO
MENTAL HEALTH CARE. FOR THIS
REASON I STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AN URGENT
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
BILL SENATOR MORE LAW. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. I I'M NOT
GOING TO REPEAT WHAT THE AUTHOR
IN CENTER FROM SANTA CLARA
STATED I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
THEY SAID. I'M JUST ENJOYING
BEING IN THE MIDDLE OF A
RECESSION. RAINY FIGURE OUT HOW
WE PAY FOR ALL THE GREAT. ITEMS
THAT WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING
TODAY. AND SO I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE RESOLVE
THE OBJECTIONS TO THIS BILL BY
THE MEDICAL INDUSTRY SO IN HIS
CLOTHES REMARKS I'D- LIKE TO
CHALLENGE THE AUTHOR TO. MAYBE
HELP ME WITH A FEW THINGS SO
THAT I COULD. BE SUPPORTIVE FOR
THIS BILL- ARE. EXPANDING THE
LIST. TO ANY AND ALL MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DIAGNOSES. COULD BE A REAL
SHOCK TO THE SYSTEM. IT WILL
IMPACT THE PREMIUMS PAID FOR
HEALTH CARE WHICH WILL IMPACT
EVERYONE. IN THIS STATE. BUT IT
MUST BE DONE. I'M NOT ARGUING
AGAINST WHAT WE NEED TO DO I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW AND WHEN WE
DO IT. OUT OF NETWORK COVERAGE
IS ALSO A PREMIUM RAZOR. WE'VE
ATTEMPTED TO ADDRESS THIS NASTY
STICKER SHOCK PROBLEM IN THE
PAST AND LIKE TO KNOW HOW WE
RESOLVE THAT. I WILL ALSO MAYBE
GIVE A COUPLE OF IDEAS. ONE
HAVE THE STATE'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PLAN THE TOP SB A
FIFTY FIVE AS A PILOT. WHY
DON'T WE START WITH THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND ITS WORK
FORCE. BUT SEE WHAT IT DOES TO
THE COST OF THE PREMIUMS AND
SEE HOW IT WORKS LET'S. TESTED
WE COULD DO IT OURSELVES AND BE
THE FIRST. CLIENT AND THEN WE
CAN. MIGRATED OVER TO THE REST
OF THE STATE OR TWO. AB WE
PHASE IN. THE NINE SEVERE
MENTAL HEALTH ILLNESSES MAYBE
ONE PER YEAR. TO EASE THE PAIN
OR THE PROGRESSION OF WHAT
COULD APPEAR IN INSURANCE
PREMIUMS JUST TRYING TO SEE HOW
WE- FIT IN. IF WE DO IT OVER
THE NINE YEARS IT'LL IT'LL
PROVIDE- PROVIDERS THE ABILITY
TO HAVE EXPERIENCE STUDIES TO
SEE HOW. THE PRICING THEIR
PREMIUMS AND HOW. THEIR
CALIBRATING FAIR AND
APPROPRIATE. PREMIUMS SO WE
NEED TO STRIKE A BALANCE I
THINK BETWEEN AFFORDABILITY.
WHICH IS IMPORTANT TO THE
TAXPAYERS ESPECIALLY NOW AND TO
THE PROVIDERS I COMMEND THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS EFFORTS IN GOALS
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO ACHIEVING
A SOLUTION. A MAJOR BUT LONG
OVERDUE THIRTY INITIATIVE MUST
BE PURSUED I'M JUST CONCERNED
ABOUT THE TIMING THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. FOR MORE LARK
IS ARE ANY FURTHER DEBATE FOR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SEEING
AND HEARING NONE. SENATOR
WINNER YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU- MADAM PRESIDENT- THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES- TO THE- CENTER FOR
ORANGE COUNTY THANK YOU FOR
THOSE REMARKS I DO WANT TO SAY
THAT THAT SUBURBAN NOW. THAT
ANALYZES FOR ANY COVERAGE
MANDATE WHAT THE IMPACT ON
PREMIUMS GOING TO BE PROJECTED
A DE MINIMUS IMPACT ON PREMIUMS
BECAUSE OF THIS BILL TRULY THE
MINIMUS AND SO THAT REPORT IS
THERE ARE YOU KNOW TO BELIEVE
ME ARE NEUTRAL- EVALUATORS MADE
THAT DETERMINATION. AND IN
TERMS OF TRYING MEDI CAL FIRST.
THE REALITIES MEDI CAL IS
ALREADY DOING THIS MEDI CAL
DIDN'T NEED A LEGAL MANDATE TO
DO IT AND MEDICAL COVERAGE IS
MUCH BROADER THAN THE PRIVATE
INDUSTRY IF THE PRIVATE HEALTH
INSURANCE INDUSTRY WERE ALREADY
DOING THIS WE WOULDN'T NEED A
BILL. UNFORTUNATELY WE SEEN
YEAR AFTER YEAR DECADE AFTER
DECADE. THAT THE PRIVATE HEALTH
<c.red>NSURANCE INDUSTRY- HAS</c>
DRAMATICALLY LIMITED ITS
COVERAGE. AND WE WOULD NEVER
TOLERATE THAT FOR PHYSICAL
HEALTH HOWEVER AND YET WE'VE
BEEN TOLERATING IT FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE ADDICTED. PEOPLE WHO
ARE SUFFERING FROM SEVERE
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES AND
WHAT HAPPENS TO THOSE PEOPLE-
WHEN THEY'RE PRIVATE HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANY DOESN'T COVER
THEM. GOING TO CRISIS THEY LOSE
THEIR JOB THEY LOSE THEIR
HOUSING THEY LOSE THEIR FAMILY.
AND THEN WHO PAYS FOR THEM
GUESS WHAT NOT THE PRIVATE
HEALTH INSURANCE INDUSTRY.
BECAUSE THEY LOST THEIR JOB
THEY'VE LOST THEIR INSURANCE.
US IT'S THE TAXPAYERS AND S BY
THE HEALTH INSURANCE INDUSTRY
REFUSING TO COVER FAILING TO
COVER SO MANY MENTAL HEALTH AND
ADDICTION CHALLENGES. IT
BECOMES A SUBSIDY BY THE
TAXPAYERS BECAUSE THOSE PEOPLE
AND ARE IN CRISIS ON THE
STREETS INDIGENT AND THE
TAXPAYERS CARE FOR THEM. SO I
THINK THE HEALTH INSURANCE
INDUSTRY SHOULD DO ITS JOB. AND
SHOULD COVER ALL MEDICALLY
NECESSARY MENTAL HEALTH AND
ADDICTION CARE. THIS IS ONLY
ONE A DOCTOR SAYS UNDER
APPLICABLE MEDICAL STANDARDS
THAT THIS TREATMENT IS
MEDICALLY NECESSARY FOR THIS
PERSON TO TREAT THIS CONDITION.
I THINK IT'S A REASONABLE THING
TO ASK AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL DEBATE
HAVING SEIZED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES NO
WELL I FORGES. BRADFORD HI COME
BY ALONE I CHIANG. DALLY. DODD
I THERE ARE SO I GALGIANI I
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE HUESO I
TADO I JACKSON HI I JONES NO
LEYVA. FIVE MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S.
MITCHELL MONNING I MORE LOCK.
MERLE NIELSEN. PAN I PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER I
STERN I AMBERG I LIKE CASKEY I
WIENER I WILK I. BETTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
FOR JUST. CHIANG DALLY. GROWTH
NO MELENDEZ. MITCHELL MORE LOCK.
MORALE NIELSEN. SENATOR WIENER
MOVES TO CALL. MOVING ON NOW TO
FILE ITEM FORTY TWO. A SENATOR
WINNER ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE
UP THIS ITEM. SENATOR WIENER
ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM FORTY TWO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL EIGHT NINETY NINE BY
SENATOR WIENER AND ACTUALLY
NEED TO HOUSING. SENATOR WIENER.
HI THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT BY COLLEAGUES I
SENATE BILL EIGHT NINETY NINE-
IS AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING BILLS
IT IS PART OF THE SENATE'S
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRODUCTION
PACKAGE- AND IT WILL ENABLE US
TO PRODUCE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF ADDITIONAL HOUSING
AFFORDABLE TO LOWER INCOME
RESIDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SPECIFICALLY THE
BILL ALLOWS RELIGIOUS
INSTITUTIONS INCLUDING CHURCHES
BALM AS WELL AS NONPROFIT
COLLEGES TO BUILD 1100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON THEIR
LANDS. RIGHT NOW IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE MANY
CHURCHES AND OTHER RELIGIOUS
INSTITUTIONS NONPROFIT COLLEGES
THAT HAVE TEXAS LANDS- THAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO DEVELOP
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON WHETHER
IT'S FOR LOW INCOME SENIORS ARE
FOR EMANCIPATED FOSTER YOUTH.
OR FOR FORMALLY HOMELESS PEOPLE
WERE LOW INCOME WORKING
FAMILIES- THEY WOULD LIKE TO DO
IT BUT THEY ARE UNABLE TO LOCAL
RESTRICTIONS. THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW THEM TO BUILD THAT
HOUSING- WE HAVE WORKS TO MAKE
SURE. THAT THE BILL DOES SO IN
A WAY THAT IS SENSITIVE TO THE
LOCAL CONTACTS. IN TERMS OF
HIGH INTENSITY AND I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THOSE ISSUES ARE
BECAUSE THIS IS A GOOD AND
WORTH BILL WE ARE SHORT
MILLIONS OF HOME. AND YEAH. AND
ABOUT HALF OF THAT SURE. IS FOR
LOW INCOME RESIDENTS AND SO WE
SHOULD ALLOW THESE NON. TO FILL
THURMOND AND TO HELP PEOPLE GET
HOUSING- I WON I WANT TO THANK
OUR SPONSORS THE TWO LARGEST
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COALITIONS
IN THE STATE THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFIT HOUSING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER
DEBATER DISCUSSIONS SENATOR
BAIL. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE GOOD CENTER FROM SAN
FRANCISCO FOR ITS CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP- ON IN OUR EFFORTS
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND I
SUPPORT THE EFFORTS TO HELP-
DEVELOPERS BUILD PROJECTS
QUICKER HOWEVER I BELIEVE WE
NEED TO PASS LEGISLATION THAT
NOT ONLY HELPS DEVELOPERS BUILD
PROJECTS FASTER BUT ALSO.
PROVIDES WORK OPPORTUNITIES IN
MIDDLE CLASS WAGES TO THOSE
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS HARD TO
BUILD IT NOW MORE THAN EVER.
DURING THIS TIME A PANDEMIC
BECAUSE- BECAUSE RECESSION WHEN
FAMILIES ARE STRUGGLING. WE
MUST BE PRUDENT AND ENSURE WE
TAKE EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
CREATE GOOD PAYING JOBS AND
PREVAILING WAGE AND THE
REQUIREMENT OF SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORK FORCE PROVIDES A
PATH TO THE MIDDLE CLASS A PAST
THAT IS NOT NOW NEAR
IMPOSSIBLE. SO I SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY BUT A CURSE THE
AUTHOR TO ADD THESE CRITICAL
WORK FORCE PROTECTION AS IT
MOVES TOWARDS IN THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BELL SENATOR
NIELSEN. BETTER PRESENT LAYS
DOWN THE SENATE I. WANT TO
FULLY ENDORSE THIS BILL. AND I
SPEAK WITH THE AUTHORITY IS A
FOUNDING PRESIDENT THE
CALIFORNIA LIES TO PICK PRIVATE
PROPERTY RIGHTS AND WHAT I LIKE
ABOUT THIS SENATORS YOU'RE
PUTTING PRIVATE PROPERTY TO
VERY GOOD USE DIRECTED THAT TO
A GOOD USE FACILITATING THAT
GOOD USE AND GOOD PURPOSE.
BUYERS AND I WILL. THANK YOU
SIR NIELSEN SENATOR ROBB SO.
BRYCE TO SUPPORT- THIS BILL
AND- THANK A CENTER WIENER THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS COMMITMENT TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- OF WE KNOW
THAT- PRODUCTION OF HOUSING IN
GENERAL IS GOOD THERE'S NOTHING
WRONG WITH MARKER RATE AND ALL
THE OTHER KIND OF HOUSING THAT
WE NEED. BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE A
SERIOUS COMMITMENT TO A MUCH
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE
WORLD TRYING IN DIFFERENT WAYS
SO BUT I ALSO WANT TO REITERATE
WHAT THE A SENATOR FROM SOUTH
WHO SAYS SAID WHICH IS I KNOW
YOU CARE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE- JOBS THAT ARE
CREATED. ARE GOOD PAYING JOBS
AND- WITH ALL THE BENEFITS AND
STANDARDS THAT WE EXPECT IN
CALIFORNIA SO WITH THAT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
WINNER YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT I
WANT TO THANK HER COLLEAGUES
FOR- FOR THE COMMENTS REGARDING
THE COMMENTS FROM THE CENTER
CONSENT AS A AND THE CENTER
FROM FROM LOS ANGELES. WE ARE
CONVENING- DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN-
THE BUILDING TRADES AND THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OUR
COMMUNITY- THERE'S BEEN SOME
LONG STANDING DISAGREEMENT SOME
TENSIONS BETWEEN THOSE TWO
COMMUNITIES- SO I'M ACTUALLY
WORKING WITH MY COUNTERPART IN
THE ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TO- TO CONVENE CONVERSATIONS
LIFE TO TRY TO BECOME STRIVE
COME UP WITH A RESOLUTION. TO
THE BURKE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR PRO THANK YOU FOR
WINNER ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED
WE WILL GO THROUGH THE ROLE ONE
TIME AND PLACE THE ITEM ON CALL
WE HAVE A MEMBER WAS OFF THE
FLOOR. WITH THAT MADAM
SECRETARY HE'S CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS AYE
BATES I TELL I BORDERS I
BRADFORD. CABRERA FIVE CHIANG I
DALLY. DODD US FIVE TERRAZZA.
HI GALGIANI HI GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I HERTZBERG.
HILL AYE HUESO. TADO I JACKSON
I JONES I LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE
AYE MELINDA'S AYE MITCHELL.
MONNING I MORE LOCK I MORAL. I
NIELSEN. I CAN I PORTANTINO.
ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER. HI
STERN HI I'M BURKE AYE AYE WHAT
COUNTS SKI. I WIENER HI WILK HI.
SENATOR WIENER MOVES A CALL
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
FORTY THREE SB NINE AWAIT BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE KEYS
PREPARED TO PRESENT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE. READ THE BILL.
SENATE BILL NINE OH EIGHT BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI AN ACT
RELATING TO DEBT COLLECTORS
SENATOR WORK OWSKI MAN
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES SB NINE
AWAIT IS A IS A BILL THAT DOES
SOMETHING THE CALIFORNIA SHOULD
HAVE DONE LONG. IT WILL IS THE
DAY CAPTION AND THE DEADLINE IN.
NO CALIFORNIA'S HEAD ON THIS
BOOK SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN LAWS THAT REQUIRE FIGURE
DEBT COLLECTING PRACTICES- BUT
THOSE STILL LAWS REALLY DO VERY
LITTLE- BECAUSE- TO STEM THE
BETTER. IT'S GOING ON IN THIS
AND STOP THESE ABUSES. THE
PROBLEM IS THIS LAW REQUIRES
THAT THE CONSUMER THAT
INDIVIDUAL PERSON. TO THESE
COLLECTING. COME IS WHEN I WAS
PRACTICING IT'S JUST. IT'S JUST
HARD FOR PEOPLE TO COME UP THE
MONEY HAVE TO PAY FOR. AND
THAT'S THE- DOES WELL THAT THAT
ANSWER IT. IS THE- HELP THE CAN
BEING. FOR THESE TO BE ARE
CHALLENGES THAT HAVE SO I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE INDUSTRY
AND I'M COMMITTED TO MAKING
REASONABLE CHANGES GOING
FORWARD WHILE STILL MAINTAINING
APPROPRIATE. CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS NINE AWAIT WELCOME
WILL ADD THE CITY CALIFORNIA TO
THAT LIST OF THIRTY FOUR OTHER
STATES THAT REQUIRE A LICENSE
IN ORDER TO COLLECT THE DEBT A
CONSUMER DEBT I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. TURNER Y. KOWSKI IS
THERE ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM SENATOR MORE LAW.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I WAS
SUPPORT THE BILL I JUST WANTED
TO. FAST ON SOME OF THESE BILLS
ARE WHERE THERE ARE. PASS
RELATED I'M I'M CURIOUS HOW
THEY FIT IN. WITH THE
PREPARATION OF THE BUDGET WHEN
WE'RE TRYING TO. MAYBE MAKE
CUTS TO DEAL WITH ISSUES OF MY
COMMENTARY SHOW THIS AS A TEN
MILLION DOLLAR COST SO I'M I'M
CURIOUS ABOUT THIS AND A FEW
OTHER BILLS TODAY ON ON HOW WE
RECONCILE STEM NEW INITIATIVES
AS WERE TRYING TO. DOWNSIZE
THANK YOU MADAM PRESS. THANK
YOU SENATOR MORE WHAT IS HER
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE CENTER AKOWSKI YOU MAY
CLOSE. MAN PRESENT JUST
GENERALLY IS AN ALL LICENSING
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE THEIR
SAID INITIAL COST WE PUT OUT
BUT AS A LICENSES ARE GIVING
OUT IT REPLENISHES. IT'S
USUALLY A NET. TO MINIMIZE
IMPACT ON THE STATE BUDGET AND
WITH THAT I WOULD URGE AND I'VE-
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED WE
WILL DO ONE ROUND AND THEN WE
WILL PLACE THE ITEM ON CALL
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE-
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS
AYE BATES. TELL I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I CABALLERO. CHIANG
DALLY. DODD I THERE ARE SO.
FIVE GALGIANI. I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. HERTZBERG
HILL AYE HUESO. I TADO FIVE
JACKSON WHY I JONES. NO LEYVA
FIVE MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ NO
MITCHELL MONNING I MORE LOCK.
MORRELL NO NIELSEN. NO HAN. HI
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO. I
SKINNER. I STERN. I UMBERG I Y.
CASKEY I WIENER I WILK. SENATOR
Y. CASKEY MOVES A CALL MOVING
ON NOW TO FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR.
SENATOR BELL. BOTTOM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL NINE
TWELVE BY SENATOR BELL AN ACT
RELATING TO FOSTER CARE AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
SENATOR BILL. MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON I WANTED
TO BEGIN BY THANKING. OUR PRO
TEM AND THE LEADERSHIP IN BOTH
HOUSES AND ADMINISTRATION FOR
COMING TO AN AGREEMENT WHICH
FOR TRACTS OF. RANCID
TRANSITION AGE FOSTER YOU THE
BUDGET WILL NOW ALLOW YOU TO
REMAIN IN EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
FOR ANOTHER YEAR AND ALLOW THEM
TO RECOVER FROM THE CODE. OF IT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. BY THIS
EXTENSION COULD NOT HAVE BEEN
MORE TIMELY FOR THOUSANDS OF
FOSTER YOU THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. WELL THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP WE CANNOT STOP
HERE THIS BILL SB NINE ONE TWO
WILL CREATE AN EMERGENCY
PROTOCOL TO PROTECT FOSTER YOU.
THE BILL WILL ENSURE THAT UPON
A STATE WIDE DECORATION OF
EMERGENCY FOSTER YOU'VE WILL
HAVE STABILITY OF PLACEMENTS
FOR AT LEAST ONE YEAR WHEN THE
CRISIS HAPPENS FOSTER USE ARE
USUALLY HIT THE HARDEST. WHILE
WE NEGOTIATE DEBATED BUDGET
FOSS YOU FOR BEARING THE BRUNT
OF THE ECONOMIC DOWNTURN FIRST
OF ALL FOR THOSE TURN. EIGHTEEN
OR TWENTY ONE DURING THE CRISIS
THEY WILL BE CUT FROM ESSENTIAL
SERVICES. NEEDED TO MAINTAIN
HOUSING- MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AND KEEP UP WITH THEIR
EDUCATION. NOW EVEN WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S QUICK ACTION. TO
ISSUE AN EXECUTIVE ORDER FOSTER
USE WERE FACED WITH THE TICKET
CLOCK. BECAUSE HE STELLAR
STUDENT APRIL AND THEN ON JUNE
THIRTIETH EXPIRED. SO UNTIL THE
BUDGET IS APPROVED SELECT.
HOPEFULLY TONIGHT OF THEY
DIDN'T REALLY KNOW WHAT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN. THESE ARE LIKE
KIDS. SO THESE YOU HAVE ALREADY
FACED ABUSE IN THE COLLECTION.
SO THIS BILL WILL APPLY THE
ACTIONS IN THE BUDGET AND APPLY
THEM TO A STANDARD REGULAR
PROCEDURE SO WE DON'T HAVE THE
SITUATION OCCUR AGAIN. THE BILL
WILL ALSO STREAMLINED THE COURT
PROCESS DURING EMERGENCIES FOR
YOU. TO SEEKING TO ENTER THE
NON MINOR. DEPENDENCY SYSTEM
BOB. NOW WE WILL BE REMOVING.
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL THAT
HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED IN THE
BUDGET. SO IT'LL BE A
PROCEDURAL BILL FROM HERE ON
HOW THEY DO THE PROCEDURE THE
OF THE SITUATION OCCURS AGAIN
SO URGENT AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BILL IS
JOURNEY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SENATOR BORDERS. IN SOME OF THE
SUN IT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE
THANK YOU FOR BRING IT FORWARD.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE CENTER BILL YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU ARE YOU'RE CHEN AYE
VOTE THIS- WILL PROVIDE
CERTAINTY FOR FOSTER USE IN
EMERGENCIES. ENSURE THEY WILL
NOT BE USED AS A POLITICAL
BARGAINING CHIP OR SOME KIND OF
BUDGET SITUATION- IT'S TIME
THAT WE STATUS THIS PROCEDURE
SO THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN
THANK YOU. ADAM SECRETARIAL
DEBATE HAVING SEIZE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ONE TIME. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES I
FELL FIVE GORGEOUS I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CHIANG I DALY. I
DODD. AYE TERRAZZO HI GALGIANI.
I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HILL HI HUESO. I TADO
I JACKSON AYE JONES I LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S I
MITCHELL MONNING I MORE LOCK I
RURAL. I NIELSEN I PAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN HI I'M BURKE
AYE I Y. CASKEY. I WIENER. HI
WILK. I SENATOR BILL MOVES TO
CALL. MOVING NOW TO FILE ITEM
FORTY FIVE FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE
SENATOR LEYVA. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL NINE
FIFTEEN BY SENATOR LEYVA AN
ACTUAL LEADING TO MOBILE HOMES
SENATOR LABEL THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS SB NINE FIFTEEN WILL
HELP KEEP VULNERABLE MOBILE
HOME RESIDENTS IMPACTED BY KOBE
NINETEEN FROM BEING EVICTED
FROM THEIR MOBILE HOMES THIS
BILL CREATESA PROTECTIVE
PROCESS FOR THESE DIRECTLY
AFFECTED WILL HOME RESIDENTS BY
PREVENTING THE MANAGER AND OF
MOBILE HOME PARKS FROM
TERMINATING OR ATTEMPTING TO
TERMINATE THE TENANCY OF THESE
RESIDENTS. SB NINE FIFTEEN
WOULD SIMPLY GIVE MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS THE RIGHT AND
OPPORTUNITY TO REPEAT REPAY
THEIR RENT AND AVOID EVICTIONS
MEMBERS SB NINE FIFTEEN IS NOT
A RENT FORGIVENESS BILL
RESIDENTS ARE REQUIRED TO REPAY
THEIR REPENT WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT AFFECTED. READ AMOUNT OF
TIME TO MAKE THE REPAYMENT SB
NINE ALLOW CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT H. C. D.
AS WELL AS MOBILE PARK HOME
OWNERS TO ENFORCE EVICTIONS FOR
HEALTH AND SAFETY VIOLATIONS.
THE COULD CAUSE HARM TO
RESIDENTS. MOBILE HOMES ARE
UNDER DIFFERENT CODE SECTIONS
THAN TRADITIONAL RENT
RESIDENTIAL HOUSING AND ARE
GOVERNED BY SPECIAL A SPECIAL
BODY OF LAWS KNOWN AS THE
MOBILE HOME RESIDENCY LOT THE
M. R. L. FOR THE BIBLE. THE
GOVERNOR'S RECENT EXECUTIVE
ORDER BANNING EVICTIONS WAS NOT
SPECIFIC TO THESE MRO CODE
SECTIONS THE GOVERNMENT WILL
HOME PARK RESIDENTS AS WELL AS
A THREE DAY SEVEN DAY A SIXTY
DAY NOTICE REQUIREMENTS. THAT
COULD LEAD TO EVICTIONS FOR
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS AGAIN SB
NINE FIFTEEN APPLIES ONLY TO
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS. AFFECTED
BY COVERED TEEN MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER LATER BETTER
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM IS SIR
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES. WELL I FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD. CABALLERO I CHIANG NO
DALLY NO DODD. I DORADO HI
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. HERTZBERG HELLO FIVE
HUESO. HI TADO TADA. I JACKSON
I JONES NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S. MITCHELL MONNING I
MORE LOCK NO MORAL. NIELSEN NO
PAN I PORTANTINO. I ROTH I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN HI
I'M BURKE HI WHAT CASKEY. I
WIENER. HI WELL NOW. BETTER
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES BRADFORD.
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG. MELENDEZ.
MITCHELL MORALE. CENTER MOVES
THE CALL. PLEASE IN GENERAL THE
SENATE WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN THAT'S SB
NINE SEVENTY THREE SENATE
JACKSON IS PREPARED TO PRESENT
MADAM SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL NINE SEVENTY
THREE BY SENATOR JACKSON AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT. LEADING
CENTER JACKSON THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. WE'RE WORKING ON THE
MICROPHONE IS GIVE US A MOMENT.
JACKSON HAS TRIED OUT. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES. YOU
KNOW YESTERDAY ON THIS FLOOR WE
HAD A VERY I THINK HEART FILLED
DISCUSSION. ARE DEALING WITH
RACE AND QUESTIONS ABOUT BIAS.
AND THE- GENDER BIAS RACISM
THAT THAT THE NOTION THAT. MOST
OF US BELIEVE THAT WE ARE FAIR
AND IMPARTIAL. AND YET WE KNOW
IN THIS WORLD TODAY THERE ARE
INSTANCES WHERE RACE AND GENDER
HAVE HAD AN ADVERSE IMPACT ON
PEOPLE BECAUSE WE ARE KNOWINGLY.
ARE FINE SO SOMETIMES WITH A
BIAS. AND SO THIS IS A BILL.
THAT IS DESIGNED TO FIGHT PAY
DISCRIMINATION WITH DATA WITH
INFORMATION. ABOUT PAY
DIFFERENTIALS YOU KNOW WE KNOW
THAT WOMEN ARE PAID EIGHTY FOUR
CENTS TO EVERY DOLLAR A MAN
MAKES AND THAT WOMEN OF COLOR
FARE EVEN WORSE BUT WE DON'T
THINK THAT WE PAY PEOPLE FLASH
WE DON'T THINK THAT THERE ARE
LEVELS OF DISCRIMINATION IN
HIGHER. UP RESPONSIBILITY
MANAGEMENT TYPE POSITIONS AND
YET. THERE ARE THESE
DIFFERENCES AND SO THIS IS A
BILL. THAT WILL PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR LARGE COMPANIES
TO LOOK IN THE MIRROR. AND TO
SEE WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE IN
FACT. DEMONSTRATING LEVELS OF
BIAS BECAUSE IN THOSE BANDS IF
YOU WILL. YOU'LL FIND WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR. FOR MORE IN
THE LOWER INCOME BRACKETS THEN
IN THE HIGHER UPPER MANAGEMENT
BRACKETS SO THIS IS A BILL THAT
TRIES TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
PAY INEQUITY. BECAUSE IF YOU
CAN'T SEE SOMETHING. YOU CAN'T
FIX IT AND THAT IS WHAT THIS
BILL DESIRES TO DO AND IS
DESIGNED TO DO IT WILL REQUIRE
LARGE EMPLOYERS TO SUBMIT A PAY
DATA REPORT EVERY YEAR TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING OUTLINING THE
COMPENSATION AND HOURS WORKED
OF EMPLOYEES BY GENDER. BY RACE
BY ETHNICITY AND BY JOB
CATEGORY NOW IN RESPONSE TO
BUSINESS COMMUNITY CONCERNS
THIS DATA WILL NOT BE MADE
PUBLIC MY GOAL HERE IS NOT TO
SHAME ANYONE TO OUT ANYONE IT'S
JUSTSIMPLY TO GET COMPANIES TO
LOOK IN THE MIRROR. AND SEE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE INDEED
DISCRIMINATING ON THOSE VARIOUS
SPECIES. SO IT ENCOURAGES
EMPLOYERS TO ANALYZE THEIR OWN
PAY HIRING AND PROMOTION
PRACTICES AND ALLOW FOR SELF
CORRECTION. THIS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE ONE OF THE KEY
CONTRIBUTORS TO THE PAY GAP IS
WHAT IS CALLED JOB SEGREGATION
THE CONCENTRATION OF WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR AS I MENTIONED
IN LOWER WAGE POSITIONS IN THE
COMPANY. THE BILL WILL ALSO
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING TO
GATHER IMPORTANT DATA. THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO SHE PATTERNS OF
WAGE DISPARITIES AND IF THEY
NOTICED THERE ARE DEVIATIONS OR
OUT LIARS. TO INVESTIGATE
FURTHER. THIS BILL IS CLOSELY
MODELED AFTER EFFORTS THAT WERE
STARTED DURING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION. BUT HAVE BEEN
HALTED UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION MAKING IT I
BELIEVE MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER THE CALIFORNIA PER SHOULD
WHICH OWN PATH AND IN CASE
YOU'RE WONDERING IF THERE'S A
DATA MAKES A DIFFERENCE LAST
YEAR. INTEL THE INTEL
VOLUNTARILY RELEASED THIS DATA
AND REVEALED THAT FORTY ONE OF
FIFTY TWO TOP EXECUTIVES MAKING
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR FOR MEN.
AND THIRTY SEVEN OF THOSE FIFTY
TWO WERE WHITE. THIS REVELATION
WAS ACTUALLY I OPENING TO THEM
AND LED TO CALLS FOR CHANGE
WITHIN THE COMPANY SO MEMBERS
THE PAY GAP REMAINS A SERIOUS
PROBLEM THE COSTS AN ESTIMATED
SEVENTY NINE BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR IN LOST WAGES FOR
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE ADVERSELY.
AFFECTED BY THE COLD NINETEEN
CRISIS YET THE VENT EVEN
WITHOUT THIS PANDEMIC RECENT
STUDIES PREDICT WE WILL NOT
FULLY CLOSED THE PAY GAP. IF WE
DON'T TAKE AGGRESSIVE STEPS FOR
A HUNDRED AND ONE YEARS. I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU BUT I
CAN'T WAIT THAT LONG SO WITH
THAT I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATE
JACKSON MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
WE'RE GONNA BE OPENING UP FOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE WE'RE
GONNA START WITH SENATOR LEYVA.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
CITY SOLICITOR PAY GAP HAS
BARELY BUDGED IT WILL NOT CLOSE
FOR AS WE HEARD MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED YEARS. AT OUR CURRENT
RATE THAT IS FAR TOO LONG FOR
OUR DAUGHTERS AND OUR
GRANDDAUGHTERS TO WAIT. THIS
BILL WILL FORCE LARGER
COMPANIES TO LOOK IN THE MIRROR
AND EXAMINE HOW THEY'RE PAYING
HIRING AND PROMOTING THEIR
EMPLOYEES. SOME MAY BE AND
WHERE. AND WHERE WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR FALL IN THE.
FOR ALL THE WHITE MEN CLUSTERED
IN THE TOP PAYING JOBS ARE
WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR IN
MORE OF THE JOBS THAT PAY LESS.
THIS WILL BE A BIRDS EYE VIEW
PICTURE THAT EMPLOERS WILL BE
ABLE TO SEE FROM THESE REPORTS.
THIS BILL GIVES EMPLOYERS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL FOR FIXING EQUAL
PAY AND HIRING AND PROMOTION
PRACTICES I BELIEVE THAT MANY
EMPLOYERS WHEN FACED WITH A
TRUE PICTURE OF THEIR
COMPANIES. WILL CHOOSE TO DO
THE RIGHT THING I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR.
MEMBERS FOR GOING TO GO TO
LEADER GROW. THEN CENTERS
SKINNER BEEN SKINNER MORLOCK.
MADAME LEAVE. THANK YOU AND
MISTER PRESIDENT I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR. SENATE
JACKSON WOULD YOU ACCEPT
QUESTIONS LATER WROTE CERTAIN
SHE WILL LEADER REAL PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FIRMS SANTA BARBARA.
AS AN EMPLOYER WITH OVER ONE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES- I KNOW IT'S
AGAINST THE LAW FOR ME TO ASK.
ME GO RIGHT THROUGH YOUR BILL
HERE IT'S IT GETS A LOT FOR ME
TO ASK SOMEONE'S RACE ETHNICITY
OR SEX. SO I GUESS JUST ASKING
FOR WISDOM AND GUIDANCE UNDER
THE AUTHORS DIRECTION OF THIS
BILL HOW WOULD I AM EIGHTEEN
THIS INFORMATION TO PROVIDE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR IF IT'S
ILLEGAL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR ME TO ASK FOR
THIS INFORMATION. CONSIDER
JACKSON THANK YOU THIS IS DONE
IN IT AT ON DISH AGGREGATED
FORM SO HAT THE NAME AND
IDENTITY OF INDIVIDUALS. IS NOT
INCLUDED THIS IS CHARLES TO
FIND NUMBERS HOW MANY PEOPLE OF
COLOR- HOW MANY WOMEN- YOU
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE TO. ASK
THEM I DON'T KNOW WHETHER TO
LEGAL WHEN SOMEONE IS HIRED- TO
KNOW TO WHETHER THEY ARE MALE
OR FEMALE BUT THIS IS NOT
DESIGNED TO IDENTIFY ANY ONES
PERSON SPECIFICALLY. IT IS
INTENDED TO NOTIFY FOR EXAMPLE
IF YOU WORK AND IT ONLY APPLIES
TO COMPANIES OF A HUNDRED OR
MORE SO LET'S SAY YOU HAVE A
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES. YOU HAVE TEN
PEOPLE IN TOP MANAGEMENT THE
QUESTION IS HOW MANY YEAR MAN
HOW MANY ARE WOMEN. HOW MANY
ARE OF PEOPLE OF COLOR. HOW
MANY ARE PEOPLE OF A DIFFERENT
ETHNICITY SO IT DOESN'T ASK WHO
THEY ARE AS INDIVIDUALS IT JUST
SETS TO TRY TO GET THE IDEA A
GENERAL NOTION. OF WHETHER OR
NOT YOU HAVE IN YOUR UPPER
LEVELS MID LEVELS LOWER LEVELS.
I THE DISCRIMINANT. FACTUALLY
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICE NOT
NECESSARILY INTO. BUT THAT IN
FACT THERE ALL BY THE SECOND
QUE. ARE WITHIN YOUR EMPLOYMENT
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON LEADER
GROWING YOUR OWN TIME
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AND NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTION I THINK MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM SENATE
SANTA BARBARA FOR ANSWERING
THAT QUESTION I GUESS. GENDER
FLUIDITY BEING THING THAT IS-
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WHERE YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO ASK
A MEMBERS GENDER- YOU CAN. YES
I GUESS. BUT IT WOULD BE
PROVIDING I'M SURE THERE'S SOME
TYPE OF DISCLOSURE ON THIS
DOCUMENT IT'S GOING TO BE
REQUESTED THAT CERTIFIES YOU
UNDER PENALTY OF PERJURY LIKE
MOST REQUIREMENTS THAT
EMPLOYERS FACE AND I GUESS YOU
COULD GUESS WHAT NATIONALITY OR
RACE SOMEONE IS. BUT WITHOUT
BEING SPECIFIC IN ASKING OR
HAVING SOME TYPE OF LANGUAGE IN
THIS BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
EMPLOYEE TO SELF IDENTIFY WHICH
WOULD MAKE IT A LITTLE BIT
EASIER- I STILL DON'T KNOW. AND
I UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE GOING
I DO I UNDERSTAND WE'RE GOING
TO YOU KNOW WE'RE HAVING A
CONVERSATION EARLIER AND I WAS
THINKING ABOUT MY OWN STAFF.
THE TOP FIVE EXECUTIVES IN MY
COMPANY YEAR OLD WOMEN EVERYONE
OF THEM- FOR OUR LATINO AND
THEN YOU GOT ME. SO AND THEN
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE MIDDLE
LEVEL MANAGEMENT AGAIN- YOU
KNOW IT'S PRETTY DIVERSE AND-
SO LIKE YOU KNOW WHEN THAT THAT
JUROR THAT CONVERSATION THAT
YOU AND I WERE HAVING EARLIER.
SO I AGREE WE'RE GOING WITH IT.
FROM BOARD ROOMS IN THERE ARE
WOMEN ABSENT AND THERE ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR ABSENT IN HIGH
LEVELS IT SOME COMPANIES. AND I
THINK THE WHERE YOU'RE GOING
WITH IT SOUNDS GOOD ABOUT
GETTING THE INFORMATION BUT IT
DOESN'T WORK ON THE GROUND IT
DOESN'T WORK IN THE PRIVATE
BUSINESS SECTOR WE'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO ASK THAT INFORMATION
WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO ASK IT IN
THE IDENTIFIES AS MALE OR
FEMALE WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
ASK IF THERE. ARE FEMALE WE ARE
NOT ALLOWED TO ASK THEIR RACE
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO EVEN
BRING THAT INTO A COP TOPIC OF
CONVERSATION IN AN INTERVIEW.
SO I GUESS IF YOU'RE NOT GONNA
REQUIRE THE EMPLOYER TO. I
DON'T KNOW CERTIFY UNDER
PENALTY OF PERJURY THAT THE
pAND CORRECT. THEN THAT WOULD BE
ONE THING THAT I'M SURE LIKE I
LIKE I SAID EVERY OTHER THING
THAT WE HAVE TO SUBMIT TO
AGENCIES- IS REQUIRED THAT WE
HAVE TO SIGN AND IF THERE'S NO
WAY FOR US TO GATHER THIS
INFORMATION WITHOUT BREAKING
THE CURRENT LAW. IN FACING
FINES AND PENALTIES AND PAGO
LAWSUITS. IT DOESN'T THIS BILL
JUST DOES NOT WORK ON THE
GROUND UNLESS YOU HAVE A
PROVISION IN THAT BILL THAT
ALLOWS US TO GARNER THIS
INFORMATION. TO PROVIDE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING- UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY THAT. THIS IS THE
CORRECT IMPROPER INFORMATION
BUT WITHOUT BEING ABLE TO ASK
THOSE QUESTIONS I DON'T SEE HOW
THIS CAN BE PUT TO WORK ON THE
GROUND SO I WOULD REQUEST A NO
VOTE RESPECTFULLY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR MEMBERS FOR
GONNA BE MOVING ON TO CENTER
SKINNER THEN WE'RE GONNA TURN
THE FLOOR OVER TO CENTER MORE
LOCKED GOOD EVENING CENTER
SKINNER. THANK YOU AT. MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS- I READ
WITH INTEREST I. WAS ABOUT SIX
MONTHS AG I THINK- AN ARTICLE
THAT CITED- BENNY OFF MARC
BENIOFF WHO IS THE CEO OF SALES
FORCE. NOW FOR THOSE OF YOU
FOLLOWED. MARC BENIOFF IS.
VIEWS HIMSELF AS QUITE A- VERY
SORT OF. SOCIALLY RESPONSIBLE
CEO. VERY LARGE FROM A COMPANY.
AND HE ASKED HIS OWN HR
DEPARTMENT. TO PROVIDE FOR HIM
SOME DATA. ONE THE EMPTY HOW
MANY WOMEN WERE EMPLOYED OF
WHERE THEY WERE IN MANAGEMENT
PAY RATES. AND HE AND HE WAS
QUOTED THAT HE ASSUMED. THAT
HIS COMPANY BECAUSE OF HIS
ATTITUDES AND SUCH AND HE HE
HAD A- THERE WAS AT LEAST ONE.
PROMINENT WOMAN IN HIS
EXECUTIVE SUITE. THAT HE JUST
ASSUMED THAT HE WOULD HAVE GOOD
NUMBERS OF WOMEN IN TOP
MANAGEMENT AND THAT THEIR PAY
SCALES WOULD BE COMPARABLE TO
THE MEN. HE WAS. VERY SURPRISED
TO LEARN THAT EVEN IN HIS
COMPANY. THE WOMEN WERE PAID
FAR LESS THAN THE MEN FOR
ALMOST THE SAME POSITIONS
FORCED THE SAME I SHOULDN'T
EVEN SAY ALMOST. AIRLINES THAT
THEY WERE NOT IN THE SAME
LEVELS OF MANAGEMENT AND SO HE
BASICALLY ORDERED HIS COMPANY.
TO REDO THE SALARY SCHEDULES
AND- FIX THAT. THAT ERROR THAT
HE FOUND TWENTY GOT THE DATA.
SO I THINK THAT OR DID SENATOR
FROM SANTA BARBARA'S POINT OF A
COMPANY BEING ABLE TO HAVE A
MERE AND TO LOOK AT IT. THAT
HOPEFULLY IT WILL CAUSE MANY
COMPANIES TO DO JUST WHAT
MISTER BENNY OPTED WITH SALES
FORCE AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATE
SKINNER. GETTING CENTER MORE
LIKE THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT GOT A
QUESTION ABOUT THE AUTHORED BY
MAY. THANK YOU CENTER MORLOCKS
INTERJECTED YOU ACCEPT THE
QUESTION SIR. THREE MORE LUCKY
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
QUESTION THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT THINK IS- BETTER
PRESIDENT I'M JUST. IS IT IN
THE DATA THAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR
ONE OF THE THINGS I DID NOT SEE
WHAT IS YEARS OF SERVICE. IS
THAT NOT IMPORTANT. WELL AGAIN
THE ISSUE HERE IS NOT TO JUDGE
WHAT OF OR TO HAVE ANYONE JUDGE
WHAT THE COMPANY IS DOING OTHER
THAN THE COMPANY ITSELF. OUR AS
WAS MENTIONED OF MISTER BENNY
OFF DID THIS WITH HIS OWN
COMPANY IT'S JUST THE IT'S
BASICALLY A TOOL FOR A COMPANY
TO SELF ASSESS AND TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THOSE SITUATIONS SO.
THIS ISN'T ANYTHING WE'RE WE'RE
COMPARING BETWEEN COMPANIES OR
WITHIN THE COMPANY ITSELF OTHER
THAN TO IDENTIFY. WHO IS BEING
PAID THE UPPER MANAGEMENT JOBS
WHAT THEIR GENDER AND RACES AND
BY THE WAY THEY SELF IDENTIFY
THE LAW DOES PERMIT INDIVIDUALS
TO SELF IDENTIFY SO WHEN YOU
ARE ASKED- DURING YOUR- FOR
EXAMPLE- WHAT JOB DO YOU HAVE
WHAT IS YOUR GENDER WHAT IS
YOUR RACE. YOU HAVE THE ABILITY
TO SELF IDENTIFY THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE WHO MAY BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE NOW TODAY THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO DO NOT IDENTIFY AS
MALE OR FEMALE SO THERE IS ALSO
THE ABILITY TO IDENTIFIES NON
BINARY. THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE
THE ISSUE IS WHETHER OR NOT A
COMPANY IN THE VARIOUS BANDS OF
EMPLOYMENT THE G. VERY JOB
CATEGORIES WHETHER WE ARE
SEEKING PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
WOMEN IN. A PARTICULARLY
SEGREGATED INTO CERTAIN JOB
CATEGORIES THAT IS THE PURPOSE
OF THIS LEGISLATION CENTER MORE
LIKE TO HAVE A FOLLOW UP ON
THAT WATER AB I JUST YEAH I
DON'T HAVE THE QUESTION TO ME.
HAVE MY OWN COMMENTS FOR
INSTANCE IN YOUR OWN TIME I'M
IN MY FOURTH CAREER MISTER
PRESIDENT AND- THAT WAS A
PARTNER IN A CPA FIRM TO
OFFICES ARE NOT A HUNDRED
PEOPLE BUT- PRETTY SIZEABLE
WHEN YOU COMBINE BOTH OFFICES-
AND THEN I WAS TREASURER I'D-
75% OF MY EMPLOYEES WERE FEMALE
IN. THE WORK FORCE WAS VERY
COSMOPOLITAN IT I LOVE THAT SO
MANY COUNTRIES REPRESENTED
SEVEN CUP ALONG WE HAD A BALL
HER CLASS SHOULD. BE A BETTER
ADJECTIVE BUT SO I'M I'M. JUST
REFLECT. AND I'M THINKING WELL
IF I HAD A IN MY FOR IF I WOULD
HAVE HIGHER. WOMAN WHO. HAS
BEEN WERE THE FIRM FOR TEN
YEARS AND WORKED HER WAY UP TO
ONE OF MY MANAGEMENT SPOTS- AND
HAS THAT TITLE- BUT THEN I HIRE
A MAN WHO HAS ONLY BEEN THERE
FOR A YEAR. DO I NEED TO PAY
HIM THE SAME SALARY THAT. SHE
IS MAKING WHEN SHE HAS WORKED
HER WAY UP. YEAR AFTER YEAR
WE'VE GIVEN TO PAY INCREASES.
AND SO I WOULDN'T WANT TO SAY
HEY THERE MIGHT THERE MIGHT
BOTH HAVE THE SAME TITLE BUT
THE MAN SHOULD BE PAID LESS
BECAUSE HE HASN'T BEEN WITH THE
FIRM. LONG ENOUGH FOR AS AS
LONG. AS SO I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE- WE'RE LOOKING AT
THINGS THAT WITH THAT THE DATA.
ISN'T SO SIMPLE THAT YOU COME
UP WITH THE WRONG CONCLUSIONS
AND SO THAT'S WHY I INQUIRED
MISTER PRESIDENT WHY. MAYBE WE
DON'T HAVE YEARS OF SERVICE SO
THAT WE COULD HAVE A FAIR.
COMPARISON BETWEEN. CERTAIN
COMPONENTS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SONORA.
BASINGER IN THE SENATE WE'RE
GONNA RECOGNIZE SENATOR JONES
COULD EVEN SENATORS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR PRESIDENT YOU'RE
DOING A GREAT JOB. I JUST HAVE
A QUICK QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR
IF THAT'S OKAY. SENATE JACKSON
WOULD YOU ACCEPT THE QUESTION
FROM CENTER JONES CERTAIN
CENTER JONES PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU I'M ENQUIRING IF THE
BILL- AND THE AND THE
REQUIREMENTS WOULD. BE
APPLICABLES TO A GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES- IN PARTICULAR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- CITIES AND- MAYBE
MOST IMPORTANTLY STATE AGENCIES
THANK YOU. YEAH AND IF NOT WHY
NOT SENATE JACKSON IF YOU TO MY
PROCEED ON THE ANSWER CERTAINLY
THIS BILL IS MODELED AFTER THE
EO ONE DOCUMENT. THAT COMPANIES
OF OVER A HUNDRED HAVE BEEN
REQUIRED TO THROUGHOUT THIS
COUNTRY THE FILE FOR THE LAST
FIFTY YEARS. IT JUST SIMPLY
ADDS TO THAT DISCUSSION.
WHETHER OR NOT OR WHAT THE RACE
AND GENDER ARE OF THE PEOPLE
WHOSE INFORMATION IS ALREADY
BEING FOR REQUIRED UNDER THE
EMAIL ONE DOCUMENT. THIS SIMPLY
ADDS AN ADDITIONAL CATEGORY TO
THAT PROCEDURE SO IF YOU ARE
BEEN REQUIRED TO FILE IN THE
YEAR ONE DOCUMENT YOU WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO FILE IT AGAIN AND
THIS TIME IT WOULD ALSO INCLUDE
THE INFORMATION WHICH I HAVE
JUST IDENTIFIED IN BANDS HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE MALE OR FEMALE
I SHOULD SAY WHO ARE IN THE
JANITORIAL PART OF YOUR
BUSINESS. YOU DON'T HAVE TO
ANSWER. WELL I'VE GOT FOUR WHO
HAD TEN YEARS EXPERIENCE OR TWO
WHO HAD ONE YEAR EXPERIENCE
WHICH TRUSTS LOOKING AT
CATEGORIES WE BECAUSE THERE IS
A CONCERN. THAT WE HAVE FOUND
PEOPLE BASED UPON RACE AND
GENDER ARE OFTEN PUT INTO
VARIOUS SEGREGATED CATEGORIES
THE GOAL IS TO HAVE COMPANIES
THAT HAVE TO FILE THE EO ONE
ANYWAY TO ALSO INCLUDE THIS
CRITERIA SO THAT THEY CAN
REALIZE WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE.
IMPLICITLY BIASED IF YOU WILL
NOT THAT WE'RE GOING TO PUNISH
THEM BUT SO THEY DO CAN LOOK IN
THE MIRROR AS MISTER BENNY
OPTED AND DISCOVER THESE FEMALE
EMPLOYEES WERE BEING PAID
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS FOR THE SAME
IN THE SAME JOHN CATEGORY. AS
THEIR MALE EMPLOYEES THAT HE
DIDN'T HAVE VERY MANY PEOPLE OF
COLOR. WHO WERE IN HIGHER
MANAGEMENT POSITIONS IT'S A
CHANCE TO LOOK IN THE MIRROR.
THAT'S WHAT THE BILL DOES AND
IF YOU HAVE BEEN IN THE EO ONE
FILER THEY'RE JUST ADDING THAT
PART ON TO THE EAGLE ONE FORM
THAT YOU'VE GOT TO DO VERY
YEAR ANYWAY. THANK YOU SIR
JACKSON- GOING TO TURN IT BACK
OVER TO SENATOR JOHN CENTER
JONES DO YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS SIR- YES JUST A JUST
BRIEFLY- YEAH I'M NOT A LABOR
ATTORNEY AND- IN MY BUSINESSES
OF FORTUNATELY OR UNFORTUNATELY
I'VE NEVER. HAD TO THE EMPLOYEE
OVER A HUNDRED PEOPLE SO I'M
NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE E. ALL
pIN HER CLOTHES COULD EDUCATE US
ON WHETHER THE STATE AGENCIES
HAVE TO FILE THE EO ONE OR NOT.
AND LOCAL AGENCIES AS WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
CENTER JONES. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE IS THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. IS GOING
TO BE LAST CALL FOR DISK OR TO
BE IN THE SENATE. HEARING SEEN
NINE RETURNED BACK TO CENTER
JACKSON FOR CLOTHES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH INTERESTING
DISCUSSION BUT NOT ON POINT TO
WHAT THE BILL DOES. OUR THE
BILL WHICH IS SIMPLY- SO THAT
WE CAN ASCERTAIN WHY IT IS OR
IF IT IS THAT WOMEN AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR. ARE PAID LESS IN VERY
IS JOBS SEGREGATED CATEGORIES.
IF YOU WRITE IN A PARTICULAR
JOB I WOULD SUBMIT AS- AS A
JANITOR YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BE
PAID AT THE SAME LEVEL YOU WILL
BE PAID IF YOU ARE A MANAGER.
AND THIS IS PART OF THE ISSUE
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS
WHY ARE ARE WE SEEING WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR IN THE LOWER
PAYING JOB CATEGORIES IN
COMPANIES BECAUSE THEY WILL BE
PAID LESS OBVIOUSLY I DON'T
KNOW TOO MANY JANITORS TO MAKE
TWO HUNDRED EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR. WHICH IS WHAT A
MANAGER IN SOME OF THESE
COMPANIES MAKE. SO THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE WHAT I
CONSIDER TO BE. AN ELEGANT
SIMPLE SOLUTION THE INFORMATION
IS KEPT CONFIDENTIAL IT'S A
BIRD'S-EYE VIEW. SO A COMPANY
CAN SEE WHAT THEY ARE THEY'RE
NOT BEING COMPARED. TO ANOTHER
COMPANY IT'S WHAT IS THIS
COMPANY TO. AND AGAIN- IT IS
FOR PEOPLE WHO FILED COMPANIES
TO FIRE THE HE HE'LL ONE FORM
AND THOSE ARE A PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS EMPLOYEES ARE
ALREADY. REPORTING THIS
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION THE
CHEST PULLS IT TOGETHER SO THAT
A COMPANY CAN LOOK IN THE
MIRROR AND SHE WHETHER OR NOT
THEY ARE IN FACT SEGREGATING
PEOPLE ON THE BASIS OF RACE OR
GENDER. IN VARIOUS AND LONG
USUALLY LOWER JOB CATEGORIES IN
THE GOAL OF COURSE ISN'T THEY
WILL CORRECT THE PROBLEM SO
THAT WE WILL SEE MORE PEOPLE.
BEING ACTIVE AND I COMMEND THE
MINORITY LEADER SHE KNOWS THAT
THE FIVE LEADERS OF HER COMPANY
WERE ALL WOMEN SO THERE WAS NO
GUESSING THERE YOU DON'T HAVE
THE GAS- AND- IF YOU HAVE A
COMPANY AND YOU THINK YOUR-
TOP. TEN OF YOUR TOP EXECUTIVES
ARE FEMALE BUT ONLY ONE IS THE
WAY MISTER BENNY OFF DISCOVERED
HE WAS IN FACT NOT MEETING HIS
OWN EXPECTATIONS. OF EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY IT'S THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CORRECT THAT
PROBLEM. WITH THAT ARE GOOD
RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR- THANK
YOU SENATOR JACKSON'S INSPECTOR
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I LETTER OR I ATKINS AYE
BATES. NO BELL I FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD. CABALLERO I CHIANG.
DALLY NO DODD- I RAZA. I
GALGIANI FIVE GLAZER. GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG. HELLO
HI HUESO HI TADO. I JACKSON I
JONES. NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE BYE
BYE MELENDEZ NO MITCHELL.
MONNING I MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN NO HAN I PORTANTINO.
HI ROSS I RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN I AM VERY I WHITE HOUSE
SKI I WIENER I WILK. MOVING A
CALL WE WILL MOVE ON NOW TO A
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT SENATOR
UMBERG MADAM SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ. SAN BILL NINE EIGHTY BY
SENATOR UMBERG AND ACTUALLY TO
PRIVACY SENATOR UMBERG THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM PRESIDENT
IN. MEMBERS MANY OF US.
PROVIDED SPECIMENS FOR PURPOSES
OF DNA ANALYSIS WE COULD FIND
OUT ALL KINDS OF INTERESTING
THINGS YOU CAN FIND OUT WHO
YOU'RE RELATED TO YOU CAN FIND
OUT ABOUT GENETIC
PREDISPOSITIONS. YOU CAN FIND
OUT THAT YOU HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
COMPONENT OF YOUR DNA THAT'S
DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE
NEANDERTHALS. AND YOU CAN FIND
OUT TO YOUR SPOUSE IS NOT
SURPRISED. ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THOUGH. THAT I FOUND
OUT ABOUT WAS THIS PAST
DECEMBER WHEN I READ A MEMO
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
AND LET ME. MADAM PRESIDENT BY
MIGHT READ WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WHERE THIS MEMO DISTRIBUTED
EVERY MEMBER WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE SAYS.
THERE'S AN INCREASED CONCERN IN
THE SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY THAT
OUTSIDE PARTIES ARE EXPLOITING
THE USE OF GENETIC DATA FOR
QUESTIONABLE PURPOSES.
INCLUDING MASS SURVEILLANCE AND
THE ABILITY TO TRACK
INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT THEIR
AUTHORIZATION FOR AWARENESS. SO
THE COMPANIES THAT HAVE DIRECT
TO CONSUMER ENETIC TESTING.
FACILITIES PROVIDE THAT SERVICE
THAT. THEY CAN FOR EXAMPLE SELL
THAT MATERIAL THEY CAN
DISTRIBUTE THAT MATERIAL. WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS SIMPLY SAYS
THAT THEY CAN STILL DO THAT
THEY JUST NEED TO HAVE YOUR
CONSENT AND INFORMED CONSENT SO
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE CONSENTING
TO YOU CAN CONSENT TO
COMMERCIAL DISTRIBUTION FACT
THEY CAN PAY YOU IF THEY WANT
TO ALLOW THEM TO SELL THAT
MATERIAL. YOU CAN CONSENT TO
RESEARCH PURPOSES THAT'S ALL
THIS BILL DOES IS IT REQUIRES
THAT THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
PROVIDES THAT SAMPLE PROVIDE
CONSENT IN FACT MOST OF THE
REPUTABLE DIRECT TO CONSUMER
DNA ANALYSIS COMPANIES DO THAT
ALREADY BUT THERE ARE A FEW OUT
LIARS WHO DO NOT IN THIS BILL
SIMPLY SAYS YOU GOT TO GET
INFORMED CONSENT. HI VIRGIN AYE
VOTE. DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM WAS SERVED TO IS OUR
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SENATOR
BORCHERS. PRESIDENT OF A
QUESTION POSED TO THE AUTHOR IF
YOU TAKE A QUESTION CENTER ON
BURKE I WOULD LOVE TO TAKE A
QUESTION FROM SENATOR FROM
FRANK WITHOUT OBJECTION THANK
YOU I THINK THIS IS. A GOOD
PIECE OF LEGISLATION JUST A
CLARIFICATION SO FROM WHERE LAW
ENFORCEMENT STANDPOINT- WOULD A
LAW ENFORCEMENT ENTITY BE ABLE
TO ACCESS THIS INFORMATION. BY
IF THERE WAS A DUE PROCESS
COMPONENT TO IT OR IS THERE DUE
PROCESS CANNELLA THAT THAT
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION CENTER
AND WHEN WHAT WE'RE DOING WE'RE
WORKING WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
RIGHT NOW. TO CREATE A
PROCESSES THEY CAN ENGAGE- BUT-
WOULD REQUIRE SOME SORT OF A
SUBPOENA OR SOME SORT OF OTHER
PROCESS NOT SIMPLY. ALLOWING A
COMPANY THAT DOES DIRECT TO
CONSUMER DNA ANALYSIS TO TURN
OVER THEIR DATABASE. TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT IT'S IMPORTANT
SUPPORT LAW ENFORCEMENT TOOL.
AND WE'RE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
LONG FORCE MAKE SURE THAT THEY-
HAVE REASONABLE ACCESS WITH.
SOME PROCESS IN PLACE. THE
REASON WHY I BRING THIS UP ON.
STEM CELL RESEARCH FOR AFTER A
WOMAN HAS GIVEN BIRTH THERE'S
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESERVE SOME OF
THE REMAINDER OF WE DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHERE- RESEARCH IS
GOING TO GO BUT PEOPLE PAY
MONEY TO FREEZE- SOME OF THIS
ON PHYSICAL MATERIAL. IN THE
IDEA THAT IT CAN BE BROKEN DOWN
AND ANALYZED AND MARKETED-
WITHOUT YOUR KNOWLEDGE OR
CONSENT DOES NOT SEEM FAIR- SO-
I HOPE YOU'LL CONTINUE- TO- TO
WORK WITH LONG FOR SOME MAKE
CERTAIN THAT. THERE REASONABLE
PRECAUTIONS IN PROTECTIONS IN
PLACE WHILE ALLOWING THEM TO DO
THEIR JOB BY THIS IS A GOOD
PIECE OF. LEGISLATION. THANK
YOU SIR BORCHERS SENATOR GROW.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I TO
HAVE A QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR
JUST TO CONFIRM- IF YOU WOULD
BE WILLING TO TAKE A QUESTION
WOULD YOU TAKE A QUESTION SURE
SIMILARLY TO MY COLLEAGUE IN
FRESNO- DNA HAS BEEN USED TO
FREE THOSE FALSELY ACCUSED.
RIGHT BY A WITNESS TESTIMONY
AND SOMEBODY IS SERVED A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF TIME IN
PRISON IN DNA IS FREEDOM. A DNA
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE SAID AT A
FRESNO HAS ALSO- CONVICTED
MANY- BECAUSE THE DNA FOR RAPE.
MURDER ANY OF THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT HAPPENED THAT ARE
JUST AN- ATROCITY TO OUR
SOCIETY. SO I GUESS YOU KNOW
JUST LIKE THE GOLDEN STATE
KILLER YOU KNOW THAT WAS HERE
THAT'S GOT I JUST RECENTLY
RATES GOING TO BE. I DON'T KNOW
SOMETIMES ANNOUNCEMENT AT SAC
STATE. SO I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS THAT YOU DID SAY YOU WERE
WORKING WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
BUT I GUESS I WOULD WANT YOUR
COMMITMENT THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT. OR JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS TRYING TO FREE. A
PEOPLE WHO ARE WRONGLY
CONVICTED. SO JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHO ARE TRACKING TO
CONVICT THE RIGHT PEOPLE. BASED
ON DNA WOULD NOT BE AFFECTED BY
THIS BILL AT ALL. THEN PRESENT.
YES SENATOR IF I MIGHT RESPOND
OF COURSE IS PRESENT- YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT IN A IS AN
INCREDIBLY POWERFUL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TOOL VOTE TO
CONVICT AS WELL AS TO A QUICK.
END TO EXONERATE- YES THE
CHALLENGES THE GOLDEN STATE
KILLER IS A GOOD EXAMPLE. IT
WAS USED IN THAT MATTER TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT WE BROUGHT
SOMEONE A SECURE KILLER TO
JUSTICE- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT STILL ACCESSIBLE LAW
ENFORCEMENT BUT NOT SUCH THAT.
WE SIMPLY TURN THE DATABASE
OVER TO A THIRD PARTY SO FOR
EXAMPLE- AS I MENTIONED THE-
MOST PROMINENT THE MOST
PROMINENT. COLLECTORS OF DNA
AND THOSE WHO ANALYZE THE AND I
HAVE A PROCESS IN PLACE WHICH
REQUIRES OTHER SUBPOENA. I
PERSONALLY THINK A SEARCH
WARRANT IS TOO MUCH BUT BUT
THERE'S GONNA BE SOME MIDDLE
GROUND WHERE THERE'S A
REASONABLE PROCESS SO THAT THEY
CAN ACCESS THAT INFORMATION AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM. SO LIKE USING THE EXAMPLE
OF THE GOLDEN STATE KILLER ON
MY OWN TIME I GUESS HUSING
EXAMPLE AND YOU CAN CORRECT ME
IN YOUR CLOTHES IF I'M WRONG.
IF THEY WEREN'T ALLOWED TO GET
THAT DE ANNE THEN THERE'S A
GOOD CHANCE THEY WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO CONVICT THIS
PERSON THAT HAD RAPED AND
MURDERED SEVERAL WOMEN. BUT
UNDER. THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION- THERE IS A
POSSIBILITY THAT THAT.
INFORMATION BECAUSE IN YOUR
STATEMENT YOU SAID THAT. THE
PERSON SO THE GOLDEN STATE
KILLER WOULD HAVE TO AUTHORIZE
THE RELEASE. OF HIS DATA. WHICH
I REALLY DON'T THINK THE GOLDEN
STATE KILLERS GOING TO
AUTHORIZE. THE RELEASE OF HIS
DATA THAT HE KNOWS THAT WOULD
CONVICT HIM. I COULD BE WRONG.
BUT I DON'T THINK SO. SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS THAT. WITH
THIS BILL I BELIEVE. I REALLY
DO BELIEVE I UNDERSTAND WE'RE
GOING I THINK IT'S A PRIVACY
ISSUE. BUT I REALLY DO BELIEVE
THAT IT WILL HINDER. JUSTICE
FOR THOSE THAT- WANT TO GO
FREE. AND I THINK IT WILL
HINDER. AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
FOR THE SAME REASON THAT I
DON'T THINK SOMEONE LIKE THE
GOLDEN STATE KILLER WHO IS
RAPED. AND MURDERED SEVERAL
WOMEN. IT'S GOING TO AUTHORIZED
THEIR DNA TO BE RELEASED FOR
TEST. SO I WOULD URGE ANO VOTE
ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR
GROVE ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR GALGIANI.
I'M GOING TO REFRAIN FROM
VOTING TODAY ON THIS MATTER
BECAUSE I NEED TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT THIS ISSUE BUT I CARE
ABOUT IT VERY DEEPLY. I CARE
ABOUT THE GOLDEN STATE KILLER
BUT I ALSO CARE ABOUT. MISSING
PERSONS INCLUDING MY COUSIN
DINO WHO WENT MISSING. WHEN I
WAS SEVENTEEN IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE WHO STILL HASN'T
BEEN FOUND. AND DURING THE BY
WE'VE BEEN ON BREAK FOR CORONA
VIRUS FOR CASE MY COUSINS CASE
WAS REOPENED. AND I WAS
CONTACTED BY DETECTIVE AT THE
STARTED BABY. ABOUT A CASE
BECAUSE IT WAS LEARNED THAT
SOMEONE WHO IS A FRIEND OF HERS.
WHO WENT MISSING A YEAR EARLIER
AND WAS FOUND A FEW MONTHS
LATER- DEAD AND- WELL HER
PERPETRATOR HAD NOT BEEN CAUGHT
THERE WAS DNA THAT WAS LEFT IN
THAT NOW THERE'S A POTENTIAL
CONNECTION. TO MY COUSIN I
DON'T WANT ANY DOORS FACT FOR
FAMILIES WHO HAVE MISSING LOVED
ONES WHO HAVE YET TO HAVE THEIR
THEIR KILLER BROUGHT TO JUSTICE
AND I WILL I WILL USE ANOTHER
EXAMPLE- MANY OF YOU WHO
REMEMBER WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY HAD NEVER TO SERIAL
KILLERS IN MY DISTRICT. WHO ONE
WAS BEING PULLED AND OBTAIN MY
DISTRICT AND WE WERE FIGHTING
THE PULL IT WAS LEARNED LATER
THAT THEY HAD MANY OTHER
VICTIMS AND WESLEY SHERMAN TIME
STARTED TELLING WHERE THE
VICTIMS WERE BURIED. IN A WELL
IN RENDON HAND THEY WERE
CONVICTED OF FIVE MURDERS
ORIGINALLY AND AT WESLEY
SHERMAN CONSTRUCTION THREE MORE
INDIVIDUALS AND A BABY WERE
FOUND AT THE BOTTOM OF THE WELL.
LESLIE SHERMAN TIME. WAS
CONVICTED OF THE MURDER CHEVY
WHEELER NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE
WHEN DNA WAS NOT AVAILABLE. AND
IT WASN'T UNTIL FOURTEEN YEARS
LATER FOURTEEN YEARS LATER AND
MANY MANY MORE INDIVIDUALS WERE
KILLED. THAT THEY WERE ABLE TO
USE THE PREVIOUS DNA THAT WAS
COLLECTED NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE.
TO BE ABLE TO STOP SHERMAN
TIENEN HERSELF FROM KILLING
MORE INDIVIDUALS SO- I AM NOT
GOING TO BE VOTING FOR THIS
TODAY I NEED TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT IT. I MADE VOTE FOR IT AT
THE END BUT THESE ARE THE
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE ABOUT THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER DEL MONTE SENATOR
DOLLINGER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I WOULD. FOR FIVE AND
A SUPPORT THIS BILL HI THIS
WHICH SHARE REAL QUICK THAT I
HAVE THE ANCESTRY DOT COM
PACKET THAT MY FAMILY BOUGHT ME
FOR CHRISTMAS THREE YEARS AGO
STILL SITTING IN THE DOOR I
HAVEN'T USED. JUST FOR THIS
REASON I DON'T WANT MY
INFORMATION TO BE SOLD OR
MARKETED TO SOMEBODY ELSE SO I
THINK THIS BILL IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION I KNOW
THERE MIGHT BE A THEIR
OPPOSITION FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
I SEE- SO BUT I AM I WAS
WONDERING IF ME CONGESTION YOUR
CLOTHES- WHAT ABOUT THE TEST
FOR COVERT IN THE INFORMATION
THAT THEY'RE GATHERING- BY THE
MILLIONS- NOT ONLY CALIFORNIA
BUT NATIONWIDE AND WORLDWIDE.
THANK YOU AND I ASSUME THAT
THE- SENATOR WILL CONSIDER THAT
QUESTION IN THIS CLOSE IS THERE
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING AND HEARING
ON SENATOR UMBERG YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU BUT LET ME ADDRESS
THE TWO QUESTIONS THAT ARE
RAISED UP THE FIRST WITH
RESPECT TO THE GOLDEN STATE
KILLER THIS DOES NOT REQUIRE
SOMEONE WHO'S ARRESTED THE
CONSENT TO HAVE THEIR DNA TAKEN.
THAT THAT ISSUE IS DONE IN
RESULT. THIS DOESN'T REQUIRE
THE CONSENT OF ANYONE WHO FOR
EXAMPLES BEEN CONVICTED. TO
PROVIDE THEIR DNA THAT'S
ALREADY RESOLVED. WHAT THIS
DOES IS IF YOU'RE A THIRD PARTY
AND YOU SUBMIT YOUR SAMPLE TO A
DIRECT TO CONSUMER. DATA
ANALYSIS DNA ANALYSIS COMPANY.
YOU'VE GOT A CONSENT TO ALLOW
IT TO BE IS NOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
YOU'RE NOT. WE WON'T REQUIRE
YOU TO CONSENT TO HAVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT BUT WE ARE GOING
TO. REQUIRE MUCH LIKE THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION THE
ADMINISTRATION CURRENTLY IN
POWER. RECENTLY SAID IF YOU'RE
GETTING FEDERAL FUNDS YOU CAN'T
JUST TURN OVER THE DATABASE THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN'T JUST ASK
FOR THE DATABASE AND GIVE THE
WHOLE DATABASE. AND THEN START
USING IT FOR WHATEVER PURPOSE.
THAT SOMEONE HAS A PRIVACY
INTEREST WHEN THEY BUY A DNA
ANALYSIS K<c.cyan>. SO IT WOULDN'T.</c>
THE SITUATION THAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBED WITH RESPECT THE
GOLDEN STATE KILLER ONE HE
WASN'T REQUIRED TO GIVE CONSENT
TO HAVE HIS DNA AND ANALYZED IT
WAS RELATIVES THAT THAT THEY
FOUND. IN ANOTHER DATABASE THAT
THAT THE CONNECTING ROOMS
BAKER. END UP. WE ALSO SENATOR
DOLLY EXCELLENT QUESTIONMY
STAFF TO BE PROUD OF YOU
BECAUSE I DIDN'T MENTION MY
TALKING POINTS THAT THIS HAS
EVEN A MORE DIRECT APPLICATION
TODAY BECAUSE ALL THOSE ARE
BEING TESTED FOR COVERT
NINETEEN THAT THAT MATERIAL
WHILE IT'S FAR IN A NOT DNA
IT'S THE SAME MATERIAL AND SO
YOU CAN BE CONVERTED TO DNA.
AND SO THAT'S ANOTHER REASON
WHY IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
SOME PRIVACY PROTECTIONS- I
HEARD TONIGHT WILL THANK YOU.
CAPTION CONTROL WELL DEBATE
HAVING CEASE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
AM I ARCHULETA. I ATKINS AYE
BATES I TELL I FORGES. FIVE
BRADFORD. CABALLERO HI CHIANG
HI DOLLY I DODD. HI THE RISING
I GALGIANI. GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG I HILL AYE
HUESO. I TADO HI JACKSON HI I
JONES NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE. WHAT
HI ONE DOES. I MITCHELL. MONEY
I MORE LOCK. FIVE ZERO. I
NIELSEN HI I PAN. HI PORTANTINO
HI ROTH. I RUBIO. I SKINNER. I
STERN HI AMBER I WHO I CAO SKI.
I WIENER ALL RIGHT HI WILK HI
HI IN THE SENATE. SENATOR
UMBERG MOVES TO CALL MOVING ON
NOW TO FILE ITEM FORTY NINE
SENATOR ATKINS. THEN SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL NINE
NINETY FIVE BY SENATOR ATKINS
AND ACTUALLY INTEND BY MENTAL
QUALITY SENATOR ATKINS. MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
MY COLLEAGUES ARE RISING
PERCENT SB NINE NINE FIVE.
WHICH EXTENDS THE SUNSET OF
EXISTING CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT OR
SEEK WHAT STREAMLINING
PROVISIONS AND ENABLE SMALL
SCALE HOUSING PROJECTS TO
BENEFIT FROM THE STREAMLINING
AS WELL. SB NINE NINETY FIVE AS
PART OF THE WORK DONE ON A
HOUSING PRODUCTION PACKAGE OF
BILLS TO ADDRESS THE CRITICAL
NEED FOR HOUSING SUPPLY IN OUR
STATE. I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE-
THE SENATE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
WHOSE HARD LOOSELY ON THE ISSUE
OF HOUSING PRODUCTION FRANKLY
HE'S PUSHED US ALL AND MOVE THE
BALL FURTHER ON HOUSING
PRODUCTION THAN ANYONE IN
CALIFORNIA AND QUITE A WHILE. I
ALSO HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE A
GROUP OF SENATORS ARE WHO
WORKED ON THIS PACKAGE
INCLUDING THIS BILL THE
SENATORS FROM- HEALDSBURG
SALINAS LONG BEACH SAN MATTEO
RIVERSIDE BALDWIN PARK IN EAST
LA I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR
WORK. FIVE EIGHT EIGHT CLEARLY
HAS MADE A DIFFERENCE ON THE
APPROACH THAT WE HAVE TAKEN. SB
NINE NINETY FIVE I THINK IS A
KEY PART OF THAT PACKAGE OF
BILLS IN THAT IT ENSURES THAT
SMALL SCALE HOUSING PROJECTS.
ARE NOW ELIGIBLE FOR AB NINE
HUNDRED PROGRAM RELIEF AND PUTS
IN PLACE TOOL FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. TO CONDUCT MORE
EFFICIENT SEQUEL REVIEWS. BY
UTILIZING THE MASTER AND
FOCUSED ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
REPORT PROCESS. IN TWENTY
ELEVEN THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
IN THE GOVERNOR SIGNED AB NINE
HUNDRED. THAT ESTABLISHED A NEW
PROCESS UNDER SEQUEL TO
STREAMLINE ADMINISTRATIVE
RECORD PAPER WORK. AND IT
EXPEDITED LEGAL CHALLENGES FOR
LARGE MULTI BENEFIT HOUSING
CLEAN ENERGY AND MANUFACTURING
PROJECTS. THAT HAVE A CAPITAL
INVESTMENT OF OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. AB NINE
HUNDRED SUNSET ON JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THIS BILL
EXTENDS AB NINE HUNDRED UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND IT
EXPERIENCES SO THAT WOULD APPLY
TO MUCH SMALLER HOUSING
PROJECTS. THIS IS SO THAT ALL
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA HAVE ACCESS
TO THE BENEFITS OF THIS TOOL
NOT JUST LARGER CITIES. RURAL
COMMUNITIES IN OTHER PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL. FOR CURRENT
AB NINE HUNDRED LAW NOW SAYS
ONLY PROJECTS THE HUNDRED
MILLION OR GREATER OR ELIGIBLE
SB NINE NINE FIVE LOWER SET
THRESHOLD TO FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS SO SMALLER HOUSING
PROJECTS QUALIFY. LIKE FLIES
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES THAT
HOUSING PROJECTS HAVE AT LEAST
50% AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THE
HIGHEST PERCENTAGE REQUIRED IN
STATE LAW. TODAY EIGHTY NINE
HUNDRED HAS RESULTED IN AT
LEAST FOURTEEN SEPARATE
MEGAPROJECTS REPRESENTING OVER
TWO BILLION. IN INVESTMENT IN
OUR STATE. TURNING TO THE
INFORMATION FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
AND THE SENATE OFFICE OF
RESEARCH THESE PROJECTS HAVE
PROVIDED OVER TEN THOUSAND NEW
HOUSING UNITS AND CREATED
THOUSANDS OF NEW HIGH WAGE
CONSTRUCTION AND PERMANENT
JOBS. A MINUTES TAKEN IN THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MAKE IMPORTANT UPDATES TO THE
AB NINE HUNDRED PROCESS
INCLUDING CLARIFICATIONS. OF
PAPERWORK TIME LINES AND
ENSURING THAT PROPERLY SKILLED
TRADES WORKERS BUILD THESE
PROJECTS. EARLIER THIS YEAR I
MADE A PLEDGE THAT THERE WOULD
BE A HOUSING PRODUCTION FOCUS
AND LEGISLATION THIS SESSION
FROM OUR SENATE. SB NINE NINE
FIVE IS A KEY PART OF FEELING
THAT PLEDGE TO SPUR HOUSING
PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA. IT'S
SUPPORTED BY A BROADRANGE OF
STAKEHOLDERS I WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND YOUR AYE THOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM THANK YOU
SENATOR ATKINS DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR WILK
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR DERON SO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TO SUPPORT THE EXPEDITED
REVIEW IN SEQUENCE STREAMLINING
CONTAINED IN SB NINE NINE FIVE
THIS WILL HELP CALIFORNIANS GET
BACK TO WORK. AND CREATE MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS WHILE DELIVERING
MORE HOUSING TO OUR COMMUNITIES
WHICH WE DESPERATELY NEED.
REQUIRING A SKILLED IN TRAIN
LOCAL WORK FIRST HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDED
APPRENTICESHIP OPPORTUNITIES
WITHIN MY DISTRICT I'VE SEEN
FIRST HAND THAT APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS PROVIDE A PATH TO THE
MIDDLE CLASS. THEY LIFT
BUILDING TRADE WORKERS INTO A
LIFELONG CAREER WHERE THEY ARE
PAID FAIRLY PROVIDED WITH
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES
AND EVEN IN TODAY'S CALIFORNIA
A FOR THAN THE ABILITY TO
BECOME HOME NO HOMEOWNERS. FROM
PALMDALE IN LANCASTER SANTA
CLARITA. COMMUNITY WORKFORCE
AGREEMENTS. HAVE GREATLY
BENEFIT IN MY CONSTITUENCY
PROVIDED MORTGAGE PAYING JOBS.
EVEN THROUGH THE ENVIRONMENT BY
PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO WORK
LOCALLY INSTEAD OF MAKING THE
SEVENTY MA A SEVENTY MILE
COMMUTE TO DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES
AND THE IMPROVE THE QUALITY
LIFE'S A FAMILIES BECAUSE THE
PARENTS ARE ABLE TO STAY IN THE
COMMUNITY BE INVOLVED IN THE
SCHOOLS BE INVOLVED IN YOUTH
SPORTS AND OTHER ACTIVITIES.
PROJECTS BUILT WITH SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKERS WORK FORCE ARE
USING THE LEAST AMOUNT OF
WORKERS BUILT IN THE LEAST
AMOUNT OF TIME. AND DONE RIGHT
THE FIRST TIME SO FOR THESE
REASONS I STRONGLY SUPPORT S.
B. NINE NINE FIVE. THANK YOU
SENATOR WILK CENTER TO ROSS OF.
YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I
ALSO RISE TO SUPPORT- SB NINE
NINE FIVE AND I REALLY. PROUD
TO HAVE SERVED WITH THIS GROUP
UNDER THE PRO TEM'S LEADERSHIP-
BESIDES. THE FIRST GOAL OF
BUILDING MORE HOUSING- AND THE
ESPECIALLY OF. AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE ALSO LOOKED AT THE
HOUSING PRODUCTION AS A WAY TO
REALLY SPUR THE ECONOMY BACK
AND PART OF THE SPRING THE
ECONOMY IS CREATING THESE
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS. I HAVE SEEN
THESE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
I'VE WORKED WITH THAT ALL MEN
AND WOMEN WHO JOINED HIS
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND
THEY ARE QUITE EXTRAORDINARY
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THAT
COMPLETELY TRANSFORM PEOPLE'S
LIVES. SO WHETHER IT'S WOMEN
ALL AFRICAN AMERICANS
IMMIGRANTS UP ALL FOSTER YOUTH.
THERE ARE SO MANY COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE BENEFITTED FROM THESE
PROGRAMS AND I'M GLAD TO SEE
THAT WERE INTEGRATING THE GOALS
OF HOUSING PRODUCTION WITH THE
GOALS OF THE ECONOMY AND GOOD
JOB CREATION SO I THANK THE PRO
TEMPORE THIS. FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR TO ROSS SO
SENATOR MORE MORE LOCK. THANK
YOU MADAM SAYS. LORD KNOWS WE
NEED SIX FOUR FOUR. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND- BUT THIS BILL
NINE NINE FIVE LIMITS PROJECTS
TO THOSE THOSE THAT UTILIZE A
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT. AND I
CAN TO GET A REPORT EVERY EVERY
MONTH SHOWING HOW PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS HAVE BEEN FAILING.
ESPECIALLY IN GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTS- THERE COST OVER RUNS
AND EVEN JUST RECENTLY HERE IN
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO AFTER
REQUIRING PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS THE BIDS FOR SLURRY
AND PAVING. CONTRACTS DROP BY
80% AND IT WAS JUST REPORTED
HERE IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY I WON'T GO INTO OTHER
DETAILS ANOTHER REPORTS BECAUSE
OF LIMITED TIME. BUT BECAUSE OF
THE REQUIREMENT OF A PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENT I WILL BE
OPPOSED TO SENATE BILL NINE
NINE FIVE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI. MEN PRESIDENT
I CAUTIOUSLY OUR RIGHTS SIDE
VOTED FOR THIS BILL IN-
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY IN ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE
THIS YEAR WITH OUR TRUNCATED
PROCESS IS THAT WE DON'T HAVE
THE BENEFIT OF HAVING THE
REFERRAL TO THE DIFFERENT
COMMITTEES THAT AT THAT LOOK AT
IT AND ONE OF THE- CHALLENGES
IS THE- EXPEDITED. REVIEW
PROCESS UNDE SEE UNDER THAT TO
FLORIDA- DIFFERENT PROJECTS IN
AB NINE HUNDRED- I WAS.
DELIGHTED WHEN THE BILL WAS IN-
APPROPRIATIONS TO SEE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT CLARIFY THE TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY DAYS WILL BE
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
BUSINESS DAYS BECAUSE THERE'S
BEEN JUST A FEW CASES THAT
ACTUALLY HAVE GONE IN THIS. IN
NINE YEARS WE'VE SEEN FOURTEEN
PROJECTS BUT THERE'S ONLY BEEN
A FEW CASES THIS WE'VE BEEN
TOLD BY THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
THAT THIS IS A- BIG IMPACT ON
THE COURTS. AND WELL WE'VE BEEN
SHELTERING IN PLACE AND COPE AT
OUR CORE TIPPING CLOSE THERE'S
NO TRIALS GOING ON WITH EITHER
CIVIL OR OR CRIMINAL AND I A I.
UNDERSTAND THE ENTHUSIASM OF
THE HOUSING PRODUCTION PEOPLE
THAT WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
NOTHING WILL STOP THEM WE'VE-
HAVE OUR OWN SENATE RESEARCH
OFFICE THE VIRAL CALL THE
COMMITTEE HAVE CREATED REPORTS
ABOUT. THE PROBLEM MAY NOT BE
SEEK WHAT MAY NOT BE THIS
EXPEDITED- PROCESS IT MAYBE THE
ZONING ORDINANCES THAT THEY
HAVE SO- FIVE CAUTIOUSLY WILL
BE VOTING FOR THE BILL TODAY I
HOPE. THAT THE AND I KNOW THAT
WHEN THIS BILL GETS TO THE-
ASSEMBLY SITE THAT WE LOOK AT
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL I KNOW
THAT WE'VE THE- PEOPLE AVE
SPOKEN ABOUT THE LABOR CHANGES
IN THE BILL BUT THE OTHER THE
THIRD BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT THE
COURTS WHO REALLY HAVE TO
PROCESS THESE. THESE ITEMS FOR
THESE CHALLENGES IF THEY DO
COME UP. THE FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR THRESHOLD WHICH IS GREAT
FOR- THE PROJECTS ARE GOING
FORWARD IT IS VERY SCARY A
THING FOR THE COURTS TO BE
LOOKING AT WHAT THE POTENTIAL
IS FOR ALL THESE QUICK.
DECISIONS THAT THEY HAVE TO
MAKEBECAUSE- WHETHER WE LIKE
IT OR NOT OUR COURTS ARE NOT
SET UP FOR THAT IN THE-
CALIFORNIA BAR PROTECTION X.
ONLY ALLOWS FOR THE REVIEW OF
THESE. DECISIONS IN THE COURT'S
THERE'S NO SUCH ADMINISTRATIVE
APPEALS SO- WITH THAT. CAUTIOUS
TALE I WILL BE VOTING YES.
THANK YOU CENTER Y. CASKET
CERTAINLY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. CENTER GLAZER.
THANK YOU ARE MADAM PRESIDENT-
AND NUMBERS I WANT TO SPEAK TO
THE BILL AND I ALSO WANT TO
SPEAK TO THE BROADER DISCUSSION
OF HOUSING THAT- THIS BILL
REPRESENTS AN THEIR OTHERS. BUT
LET ME OF FIRST TO ADDRESS THE
POINTS FROM THIS. SENATOR FROM
FREMONT THAT HE REYES. ABOUT
THE- EXPEDITED REVIEW THIS BILL
PROVIDES AND I'M VERY SUPPORT
OF A- WE HAD A BILL- LAST YEAR-
THAT I AUTHORED THAT PASSES
FLOOR THAT PROVIDED FOR THAT.
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY DAY REVIEW.
AT THE SAME CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED ABOUT THAT IN TERMS OF
THE COURT PROCESSING OF THOSE
ISSUES. BUT I WOULD SAY TO MY
FRIEND. AND TO ALL OF YOU THAT
IF THE ISSUE IS A WE HAVE A
HOUSING CRISIS. AND THAT WE'RE
SIMPLY ASKING THE COURTS IN THE
UNUSUAL CASES WERE CHALLENGES
AT A VAST THAT THEY- REVIEW IT
AND PROCESS IT QUICKLY. IT
WOULD SEEM TO ME THAT IF THERE
IS A NEED FOR RESOURCES TO GO
TO THE COURTS TO DO THAT AND
THOSE UNIQUE CASES. THAT IT
WOULD BE AN EASY SELL FOR ALL
OF US TO MAKE SURE THE COURTS
ARE PROPERLY FUNDED. TO DO THAT
IS THAT A SEQUEL CORD. NORTH
SIX THE COURT SOUTH I DON'T
KNOW BUT I DO KNOW THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A PENNY. FOR
SOMETHING THAT HAS A AND A
MULTIPLE BENEFIT THAT WE ALL
RECOGNIZE. WHICH IS THE HOUSING
CRISIS THAT WE ARE. FACING THE
ISSUE THAT I HAVE REYES
PREVIOUSLY AND IT. IS A BROADER
ISSUE ON THE HOUSING PACKAGE.
SUCH AS THIS BILL WHICH I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT TODAY. IS THE
FACT THAT. WE EXERCISE OUR
GREAT WISDOM ABOUT HOW WE CAN
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE SOLVED BY GOVERNMENT
SUBSIDY. IT'S GOING TO BE DONE
BY PRIVATE SECTOR. INVESTMENT
THAT DECIDES THAT THE RISKS ARE
WORTH THE REWARDS. AND SO
WHATEVER WE DO ON THIS FLOOR IN
THIS LEGISLATURE IF IT DOESN'T
MEET THAT. FIVE EQUALS SIGN
NOTHING ELSE IS GOING TO REALLY
HAPPEN. IN CALIFORNIA TODAY WE
HAVE FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND APPROXIMATELY APPROVED
UNITS THAT CAN BE DEVELOPED
RIGHT NOW. NO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
REVIEWED NO CYCLIC CHALLENGES
THEY CAN BE ADVANCED. AND YOU
HAVE TO ASK THE QUESTION WHY
AREN'T THEY BEING BUILT THAT'S
A TWO YEAR SUPPLY TODAY. AND A
LOT OF THE BILLS IN THE
CRITICISMS THAT HAVE COME
FORWARD OR THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE THE BLOCKAGE
THEY'RE STOPPING THESE
APPROVALS. AND UNFORTUNATELY I
THINK THAT- POINTING A FINGER
AT A PROBLEM THAT IS NOT SO
APPARENT BUT- I KNOW THAT THE
HOUSING BILLS THAT JUST THIS
ONE BUT OTHERS THAT WE ARE
CONSIDERING. TRY TO GO AT THAT
ISSUE. OF EXPEDITING REVIEW BY
RIGHT APPROVALS. AND I'M I'M
FINE. CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
APPROACH BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT I JUST LAID OUT A MOMENT
AGO. IN MY DISTRICT A FEW
MONTHS AGO HI WE HAD A PROJECT
FOR THIRTEEN THOUSAND HOUSING
UNITS. IN THE CITY OF CONCORD
THIRTEEN THOUSAND A LITTLE
PROJECT. IT HAD BEEN WORKED ON
FOR YEARS. AND IT FELL APART A
FEW MONTHS AGO BECAUSE OF A
DISPUTE BETWEEN THE UNION AND
THE DEVELOPER. AND THE CITY
DECIDED. BASED ON THAT DISPUTE
THEIR INABILITY TO AGREE ON A
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT AND THE
DEVELOPER HAD PUT FORWARD
NUMEROUS PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS AND IDO AGREE TO
INCLUDE UNION LABOR THROUGHOUT
THE PROJECT. BUT BECAUSE THERE
WAS AN AGREEMENT THE DECISION
WAS MADE BY THE CITY TO
TERMINATE THAT RELATIONSHIP.
AND THAT THIRTEEN THOUSAND.
HOUSING IN THE PROJECT WENT
AWAY. SO WAS ANYBODY ON THE
WRONG SIDE OF THE CHOICE HERE
NOW WHO WOULDN'T WANT TO PAY
MORE WHO WOULD WANT TO THERE'S
SO MANY THINGS THAT MATCH OUR
VALUES BUT WHEN IT ALL CAME
TOGETHER THAT PROJECT
COMPLETELY COLLAPSED. SO IT
GOES BACK TO THE REAL WORLD
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE STREET
THE DECISIONS WE MAKE HERE DO
THEY REALLY EVEN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. AND THAT'S THE CASA
THAT I PUT UP. ON THIS BILL AND
ON OTHERS IS THAT. IS IT REALLY
GOING TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
THE MARKETPLACE. IF ARE
ADMIRABLE AND ARE WORTHY OF
GREAT SUPPORT. IF THERE'S A
PROBLEM RESOLVE IT QUICKLY. SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE PROGRESS AND
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL
IN ONE HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY. SENATOR NIELSEN. MATTER
PRESIDENT IF I MAY- QUESTION
FOR THE AUTHOR OF THIS COMMENT
ON MY OWN TIME. SENATOR YES
REALLY CHAIR QUESTION. SENATE
OR NIELSEN PLEASE PROCEED. THIS
BILL HAS AN ATTRACTION BECAUSE
IT IS AT LEAST ADDRESSING
MOVING SEQUEL ALONG A LITTLE
BIT IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME BANE.
THE QUESTION IS THIS IS A
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR OF
FIGURE. CAN THERE BE
ACCOMMODATIONS HERE FOR RURAL
COUNTIES OR ANOTHER
CLASSIFICATION OF COUNTIES THAT
I FIND ON MY OWN. IT'S CALLED
NOT THIS URBAN SUBURBAN RURAL
TEN YEARS AGO I COINED THE TERM
SUBURBAN ISAAC THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY ABOUT
FIFTY YEARS AGO SOLANO ABOUT
FORTY AND THIRTY YEARS NOW IT'S
IN THE PROCESS OF TRANSITIONING
FROM RURAL. TO SUBURBAN. WOULD
COUNTIES LIKE THAT THE
SUBURBANITES AND COUNTY THAT'S
GROWING. FOR THE RURAL COUNTY
WOULD THERE BE ANY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM TO
BENEFIT IN THIS SCHEME. SENATOR
ABSOLUTELY I MEAN I THINK THE-
EIGHTY NINE HUNDRED STRUCTURE
OF A HUNDRED MILLION- FOR MEGA
PROJECTS PART OF THE DISCUSSION
OF THE SENATORS ENGAGED IN THIS
WAS. ODD WE NEED TO LOWER THAT
THRESHOLD- AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IT IS ABSOLUTELY A SIZE
THAT CAN FIT MANY COMMUNITIES-
RURAL SMALLER COMMUNITIES ARE
SO THAT WAS THE WHOLE POINT.
THAT WE LOWER IT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT OPPORTUNITY
SPECIFICALLY AS IT RELATES AND
INCLUDES HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
ALONG WITH THAT. SO IT WOULD
ABSOLUTELY. BE AVAILABLE TO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT. I THANK YOU TO THE
PROGRAM AND I WOULD ENDORSE THE
BILL AND VOTE FOR THE BILL
BECAUSE IT IS INDEED THAT
SUSTAINING SOME OPPORTUNITIES
THAT KIND OF A BEEN THWARTED IN
THE PAST. AND WE HAVE SOME
GROWTH WE'VE GOT COUNTIES THAT
ARE DECLINING AND IN AND IN
POPULATIONS AND MANY DIFFERENT
FACTORS AND DYNAMICS IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THIS DOES AT
LEAST AFFORD SOME HOPE. FOR
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN A
LITTLE BIT AND CHANGE THAT FOR
VERY LONG TIME AND I THANK YOU
FOR ALTERING THE BILL EITHER
TONIGHT. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM ANY OTHER MIKE SUB THAT I
HAVE NOT SEEN. SEEING ALL
DEBATE HAVING SEIZE SENATOR
ATKINS YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I WILL THANK
MY COLLEAGUES AND- PARTICULARLY
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS ON
THE SKILLED AND TRAINED WORK
FORCE. FROM THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM SANTA CLARITA- YOU KNOW
HOUSING IN PARTICULAR IS
DIFFICULT IT IS DIFFICULT
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
ISSUES OF FINANCE. COMMUNITY
SUPPORT AND CHARACTER
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES YOU HAVE
TO DEAL WITH ISSUES OF FINANCE-
YOU KNOW WE HAVE STRUGGLED FOR
DECADES- TO FIGURE OUT HOW. TO
DEVELOP HOUSING I'VE SPENT
TWENTY FIVE YEARS FROM MY
EARLIEST DAYS AS A STAFF MEMBER
AND A CITY COUNCIL MEMBER.
GOING BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN
THE BUILDING INDUSTRY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADVOCATES
ENVIRONMENTALIST. LABOR ON AND
ON AND ON- AND IT'S JUST NOT
EASY IT'S JUST NOT EASY TO FIND
A COMMON GROUND THAT MEETS
EVERYBODY'S CONCERNS- I THINK
WE ARE DOING THE BEST WE CAN.
CLEARLY THERE ARE ISSUES AROUND
IF WE GO TO THAT FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS THRESHOLD WHAT
IS THAT GOING TO DO WITH THE
COURTS WERE VERY. MUCH AWARE OF
THAT CONCERN BUT WE'RE ALSO
TRYING TO HELP EVERY PART OF
CALIFORNIA. EVERY PART OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE ACCESS TO TOOLS
THAT CAN HELP. DEAL WITH THIS
ISSUE. OF A CRISIS WE HAVE A OF
THE LACK OF HOUSING. YOU KNOW I
KNOW THERE'S LL KINDS OF
ISSUES THAT CAN BE RAISED BUT I
WOULD JUST SAY TO MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY
YOU KNOW OUR EXPERIENCE ON PEEL
LACES ALL OVER THE PLACE WE'VE
HAD A NUMBER IN SAN DIEGO THAT
CAME IN ON TIME UNDER BUDGET SO
I THINK IT IT JUST IT'S ABOUT
THE PROJECT IN THE DEAL THAT'S
PUT TOGETHER WHICH DOESN'T MEAN
YOU DON'T CALL THOSE IN THE
QUESTION AND EVALUATE- THE
THING I LIKE ABOUT- INCLUDING-
PARTICULARLY THE SKILLED TRADES
WORKFORCE WHICH OBVIOUSLY THE
COLLEAGUES. A SANTA CLARITA
COMMENTED ON. IS THIS IS ALSO
ABOUT JOBS AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY AND THE NEED FOR
HOUSING. AND THE NEED TO MAKE
IT POSSIBLE FOR COMMUNITIES TO
HAVE ACCESS. TO TOOLS THAT
GOVERNMENT PUTS IN PLACE FOR
THAT VERY REASON. WE NEED TO BE
FOCUSED ON THE ECONOMY AS WELL
AS THE NEED FOR HOUSING AS WELL
AS THE NEED UNDER THE ECONOMY
FOR GOOD JOBS. THIS CREATES AND
HELPS PEOPLE MOVE INTO THE
MIDDLE CLASS AND IT FOCUSES THE
JOBS PIECE FOCUSES ON
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
TRADITIONALLY BEEN
DISADVANTAGED. AND HELPS WOMEN
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THAT
HAVE TRADITIONALLY NOT HAD
ACCESS TO THE IS PRINT THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. IT'S A
FOCUSED EFFORT TO INCLUDE THEM.
INTHAT PROCESS SO I THINK
WE'VE WORKED LONG AND HARD. TO
TRY TO COME TOGETHER WILL
EVALUATE THIS TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM AROUND HE IS TOTALLY RIGHT
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE A
LOOK. BACK WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO WATCH AS THIS PROCEEDS AND
HE'S PACKAGE- THE PACKAGE OF
DIFFERENT BILLS TO TRY TO. GET
THE DEVELOPMENT ACTUALLY DONE
NOT JUST PERMITTED. AND I THINK
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO STAY
FOCUSED AND EVALUATE WILL THIS
BE HELPFUL WILL WE BE ABLE TO
DO THAT- BECAUSE WE'VE SPENT
DECADES ARGUING OVER WHETHER IT
IS. OUR RED TAPE AND SEE WHAT.
ARE THE LACK OF FUNDING. WELL
IT'S ALL OF THESE THINGS AND SO
I THINK THIS BILL IN LINE WITH
THE PACKAGE OF BILLS IS TRYING
TO GET US CLOSER ON ALL OF
THESE ISSUES HOLDS ALL
ACCOUNTABLE. AND SAY IT'S ALL
OF OUR RESPONSIBILITIES TO KIND
OF FOCUS ON THIS AND DETERMINE
IF MAKING THESE CHANGES THAT WE
HAVE FINALLY BEEN PUSHED TO DO.
IN THE MIDST OF A REAL CRISIS.
THIS IS THE ROAD MAP AND I
THINK THAT IT IS A GOOD START I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB
NINE NINE FIVE. ALL DEBATE
HAVING SEIZED MADAM SECRETARY.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES.
YEAH BATES THE BELL HI GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD I HAVE A YELLOW I
CHIANG I DALLY. DODD FIVE
TERRAZZO HI GALGIANI. I GLAZER
FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI HILL I HUESO. I
TADO. HI JACKSON HI I JONES NO
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S.
MITCHELL I MONNING. I MORE LOCK
NO MORRELL. NO NIELSEN. NIELSEN
AYE PAN. HI PORTANTINO. I ROTH
I RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN. HI
AMBER I WHITE HOUSE SKI. I
WIENER I WILK HI THESE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
BATES GORGEOUS. DALLY GROWTH.
MELENDEZ. SIZE THIRTY TWO KNOWS
THREE THE MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR HEARD SUPPORT FOR WHAT
PURPOSE ARE QUITE PROCESS SANDY
KOUFAX- COUPLE OF THINGS FIRST
JOB JUST TO REPORT TO THE
MEMBERSHIP WE HAVE PASSED
TWENTY ONE MEASURES TODAY AND
IT'S FIVE NINETEEN WE HAVE
SEVEN ON CALL THAT'S TWENTY. WE
STILL HAVE TWENTY FIVE BILLS TO
TAKE UP. DEAD WE HAVE EIGHTEEN
TRAILER BILLS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE BUDGET. ARM SO WE'RE GONNA
HAVE DINNER NOW. DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUSES MEMBERS IT'LL BE
TELEPHONICALLY AT FIVE FORTY
FIVE FIVE FORTY FIVE
TELEPHONIC. DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS
AND WILL BE BACK ON THE FLOOR
AT SIX PM SIX SIX MAYBE SIX OH
FIVE BUT THAT'S IT SO DINNER
NOW. DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS AT FIVE
FORTY FIVE BACK ON THE FLOOR AT
SIX PM. THANK YOU EVERYBODY WE
GET A LOT OF WORK TO DO A
COMING BACK AND WILL BE DOING
THE- EIGHTEEN BUDGET TRAILER
BILLS AND WE CAN'T TAKE THE
BUDGET UP UNTIL EIGHT FORTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
SENATOR HERTZBERG SENATOR GROW
FOR WHAT PURPOSE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I HAVE TO
ACTUALLY I HAVE A PARLIAMENTARY
ENQUIRING. PLEASE PROCEED WITH
THAT INQUIRY UNDER THE REVISED
LEGISLATIVE SCHEDULE IN THE
JOINT RULES TOMORROW IS THE
LAST STATE TO HE HAVE BILLS
HEARD- FROM THIS SIDE OF THE OF
THIS THE HOUSE THE SENATE
HOUSE- CAN THE PRESIDING
OFFICER OR THE INFORM THE BODY
WHAT TYPES IF ANY BILLS ARE
EXCLUDED FROM THIS DEADLINE.
AND THAT DO NOT NEED IT WILL BE
A REAL WAITER. THE ARE THE ONLY
ITEMS THAT ARE EXEMPT OUR
BUDGET BILLS. URGENCY CLAUSES
AND- ACTUALLY TAX LEVIES
ELECTIONS. AND CURRENT EXPENSES
OF THE STATE. SO JUST TO BE
CLEAR- ALL OTHER BILLS WOULD
NEED A RULE WAIVER. THAT IS
CORRECT THANK YOU MA'AM.
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS MEMBERS
PLEASE GRAB YOUR DINNER WE WILL
BE CAUCUSING IN MY OFFICE ROOM
THREE OH FIVE. THERE IS A
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN SENATOR
GROVES OFFICE.
CARCASSES HAVE
CONCLUDED WE ARE READY TO
PROCEED WITH. WHAT ALL SENATORS
PLEASE COME DOWN TO THE SENATE
FLOOR.
COLLEAGUES WE'RE BACK
OUR FIRST FILE ITEM IT IS FILE
ITEM.
BUT WE'RE ON FILE ITEM
EIGHTY SEVEN COLLEAGUES FILE
ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN THESE ARE THE
BUDGET TRAILER BILLS. SENATOR
MITCHELL ARE YOU READY TO
PROCEED MA'AM I AM MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ FILE ITEM
EIGHTY SEVEN. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY EIGHT BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN ACT
RELATING TO ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND A MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES AB EIGHTY
SEVEN IS THE INFRASTRUCTURE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT BANK
TRAILER BILL SO FIT WITH THE
BUDGET ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY.
THIS BILL MAKES TECHNICAL AND
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL
ESTABLISHES THE CLIMATE CALLAS
REVOLVING LOAN FUND ACTIVE
TWENTY TWENTY. WHICH MAKES
MONIES IN THE FUNDS AVAILABLE
FOR EXPENDITURE UPON
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE FOR PURPOSES OF
FUNDING. CLIMATE CATALYST
PROJECTS TO FURTHER THE STATE'S
CLIMATE GOALS ACTIVITIES THAT
REDUCE CRIME AT RISK AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF LOW CARBON
TECHNOLOGY AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT COMBINES THE LIMITS OF RATE
REDUCTION BONDS AND BONDS
ISSUED TO FINANCE PUBLIC
DEVELOPMENT FACILITIES THAT MAY
BE OUTSTANDING AT ANY ONE TIME.
IT MAKES CHANGES TO PROVIDE THE
I. BANK WITH FLEXIBILITY TO SET
UP A PROGRAM TO PROMOTE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION TO EXPAND
UNDERSERVED SMALL BUSINESSES.
BUSINESS LENDING IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FRANCE FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL IS THERE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE BEN SCHECTER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BATES NO
BELL. GORGEOUS NO BRADFORD.
CABALLERO HI CHIANG. DALLY NO
DODD. I TORONTO. I GALGIANI. I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL I HUESO HIGH
TADO. JACKSON HI I JONES NO
LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE. I MELINDA'S
NO MITCHELL I MONNING. I MORE
LOCK NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO
HAN HI PORTANTINO I ROTH. I
RUBIO I SKINNER HI STERN I AM
VERY HI MY CASKEY AYE WIENER HI
WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS I FELL I
BRADFORD. CHIANG. NO GROWTH. NO
TADO AS WE- BRADFORD WELL.
SENATOR MITCHELL MOVES A CALL
MOVING ON TO A FILE ITEM EIGHTY
EIGHT. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. YEAH ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY NINE BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
ACTUALLY AND HUMAN SERVICES IN
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. SENATOR MITCHELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES AB SEVENTY NINE- IS
THE HUMAN SERVICES BUDGET
TRAILER BILL THE BILL DOES THE
FOLLOWING IT INCREASES THE
LIFETIME LIMIT TO RECEIVE CAL
WORKS EIGHT FROM FORTY EIGHT
MONTHS TO SIXTY MONTHS AFFECTED
MAY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE
BILL ALSO ELIMINATES THE TWENTY
FOUR MONTH LIMITATION ON
SPECIFIED WELFARE TO WORK
ACTIVITIES WHICH IS ALSO
AFFECTED MAY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. BEGINNING JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND INCREASES
THE AMOUNT OF CHILD SUPPORT
PASSED THROUGH TO CAL WORKS
RECIPIENTS DIRECTLY THE AMOUNT
OF CHILD SUPPORT PASSED TO THE
FAMILY WITH ONE CHILD WITH
INCREASED BY FIFTY BUCKS AND
SUPPORT FOR FAMILIES WITH TWO
OR MORE CHILDREN WOULD
INCREASED BY A HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS MAKES SEVERAL
SIMPLIFICATIONS OF THE CALPERS
PROGRAM TO HELP THOSE AND
ROLLED RETAIN BENEFITS AND
HELPFUL FOR ELIGIBLE ACCESS THE
PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE THE BILL
REQUIRES COUNTIES TO ATTEMPT TO
MAKE PERSONAL CONTACT VIA
TELEPHONE OR OTHER ELECTRONIC
MEANS. PRIOR TO TERMINATING
BENEFITS. VIED SUPPLEMENTAL
RATE INCREASES FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING PROGRAMS IN THE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS. AN EARLY
START SPECIALIZED THERAPEUTIC
SERVICES EFFECTIVE JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL IS THERE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS TRAILER BILL.
SENATOR NIELSEN MADAM PRESIDENT
I JUST IN ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION. SITTING AND
HEARING NONE SENATOR MITCHELL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. JUST
WOULD LIKE TO CLARIFY THAT THE
HUMAN SERVICES ON THIS BUDGET
TRAILER BILL MAKES NUMEROUS
POLICY CHANGES TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE SUPPORTING THE
LEAST AMONG US DURING THIS CALL
THE CRISIS THOSE LIVING WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES-
THOSE IN THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM
I'D ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR MITCHELL ALL DEBATE
HAVING SEIZED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA BY ATKINS. AYE BATES.
NO BELL HI GORGEOUS NO BRADFORD.
CUT BY ADAM I CHIANG. NO DALLY
NO DODD. HI THE RHIZOME HI
GALGIANI I GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG. HI HILL
I HUESO. TADO FIVE JACKSON HI I
JONES NO LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I
MELENDEZ NO MITCHELL. AYE
MONNING FIVE MORE LOCK NO
MORALE NO NIELSEN. NO HAN HI
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO. I
SKINNER I STERN I NUMBER NINE
HI MY COUNTY HI WIENER I WILL.
NOW PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS I'D HEARD I WAS SO. HI
ALL EYES TWENTY NINE KNOWS
ELEVEN. ONE MOMENT PLEASE THE
PHARMACY SO WE'RE MISSING. OKAY
WE ARE ICE TWENTY NINE KNOWS
ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK AND
LEAVE THE CALL ON FILE ITEM
EIGHTY SEVEN. FILE ITEM EIGHTY
SEVEN. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE
TIME THROUGH. BRADFORD. THE
CITY OF. HI TADO. WILK. TATO NO.
LET'S CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME PLEASE. WILK.
YEAH. WELCOME NO. TAKE A MOMENT
HERE IF WE COULD.
THE VICE
TWENTY EIGHT. KNOWS TWELVE THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON NOW TO
FILE ITEM NINETY WHICH IS AB AT
ONE FOR ANYONE KEEPING SCORE I
AM FILE ITEM NINETY. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTY ONE BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET SENATOR MITCHELL MADAM
PRESIDENT AB AT ONE IS THE LONG
TERM CARE AND MENTAL HEALTH
TRAILER BILL. THE BILL DOES THE
FOLLOWING UNDER THE CATEGORY OF
LONG TERM CARE IT EXTENDS THE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
QUALITY ASSURANCE FEE. WITH A
DROP DOWN FEDERAL FUNDING TO
IMPROVE FACILITY REIMBURSEMENT
RATES UNTIL DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO. IT
CONTINUES THE QUALITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT SYSTEM WHICH CONDITIONS
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS AND
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
MEETING CERTAIN QUALITY
MEASURES. IT ADDS AUDITING
REQUIREMENTS FOR INCREASED
FEDERAL FUNDING RELATED TO COAL
BUT NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY TO ENSURE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES ADEQUATELY.
AND APPROPRIATELY UTILIZE
INCREASE FUNDING. WITH REGARD
TO MENTAL HEALTH DUE TO THE
COLD NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. IT PROVIDES COUNTIES
WITH FLEXIBILITY IN REPORTING
AND EXPENDITURES OF THEIR
MENTAL HEATH SERVICES ACT PROP
SIXTY THREE FUNDING FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES INCLUDING IT
EXTENDS THE TIME FRAME FOR
REPORTING ON THREE YEAR PROP
SIXTY THREE EXPENDITURE PLANS
BY UP TO ONE YEAR. IN A LAS
ACCESS TO COUNTY PROVEN
RESERVES FOR PROP SIXTY THREE
FUNDS THE FUND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. IT ALSO AUTHORIZES
COUNTIES FLEXIBILITY TO
DETERMINE ALLOCATIONS OF PROP
FIFTY THREE FUNDS WITHIN
REQUIRED EXPENDITURE CATEGORIES
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FISCAL YEAR ONLY. THIS IS
SPENCER VERSION OF UNSPENT
INMATES AT SAY FUNDS FROM
COUNTIES BY ONE YEAR AGAIN AND
MAKES A M. H. S. A. FUNDS OR
PROP SIXTY THREE FUNDS
COLLEAGUES. I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SENATOR
NIELSEN. THAT PRESENT LADIES
GEMS AND WHEN WE GET TO THE
BUDGET BILL I HAVE A FEW MORE
COMMENTS BUT JUST OF PRACTICING
REMARK OR TWO. I'VE GOT SOME
PROBLEMS WITH HOW THIS BUDGET
IS PRECEDED UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES MAY BE THE BEST
IT COULD HAVE BEEN DONE BUT I
WILL NOTE AT THIS PARTICULAR
POINT THAT MANY OF THESE BILLS
HAVE MAJOR POLICY. IN THEM. AND
THEY ARGUABLY AND IN ONE CASE
IN ARGUABLY IT SHOULD NOT EVEN
BE CALLED TRAILER BILLS THERE
ARE POLICY BILL SHOULD HAVE
BEEN HEARD POLICY COMMITTEES
AND WE HAVE NOT HAD ANY IN
DEPTH ON THE POLICY HEARING ON
ANYTHING. IN THIS BUDGET. THAT
SAID THAT I WHAT I'M GONNA DO
IS JUST RIGHT UP ON BILL AFTER
BILL AND MAKE A RECOMMENDATION.
TO MY CAUCUS AND THEN DEATH IF
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT ALL DEBATED BUT OTHER
THAN THAT IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME WE'LL JUST SAY. THE
REQUEST WHATEVER THE VOTE WOULD
BE THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
NIELSEN IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION. THING IN
HEARING ON SENATOR MITCHELL YOU
MAY CLOSE WITH REGARD TO AB AT
ONE MADAM PRESIDENTE MANY OF US
ARE READING ABOUT SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES IN THE PRESS
RIGHT NOW AS A RESULT OF COAL
BUT NINETEEN AND THIS TRAILER
B. L. CONTAINS IMPORTANT. WE
FUNDS AND OVERSIGHT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE STATE TO
REALLY STEP IN TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ARE PLACES WE WOULD
WANT OUR OWN FAMILY MEMBERS TO
BE AND I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL ALL
DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM NINETY. ALAN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
NO BELL FIVE FORGES NO BRADFORD
HI COME BY ADAM I CHIANG. NO
DALLY NO DODD. I TORONTO I
GALGIANI HI GLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE. NO
HERTZBERG HI HILL I LISTEN. HI
TADO HI JACKSON WHY I JONES NO
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S
NO MITCHELL. I MONNING HI
WARLOCK NO MORALE NO NIELSEN NO
PAN FIVE PORTANTINO. I ROTH I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN HI
I'M BURKE. WHY CASKEY AYE
WIENER I WILK NO PLEASE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. I'M
BURKE. I TWENTY EIGHT NOS
ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING NOW TO FILE ITEM. EIGHTY
NINE. AB AT M. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY BY
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES AB AT IS
THE HEALTH ON THE BEST TRAILER
BILL IT DOES THE FOLLOWING.
THAT ESTABLISHES THE HEALTH
CARE PAYMENTS DATA PROGRAM TO
COLLECT DAA ON HEALTHCARE
EXPENDITURES. IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY ABOUT A HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM AN INFORMED PUBLIC
POLICY DECISIONS. THE
PRIORITIZE FOR INCLUSION IN
NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET THE
EXPANSION OF FULL SCOPE MEDI
CAL COVERAGE. THE UNDOCUMENTED
SENIORS IF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DETERMINE SUFFICIENT
FUNDING IS AVAILABLE. IT
IMPLEMENTS SEVERAL PROPOSALS TO
LOWER PRESCRIPTION DRUG COSTS
AND MEDI CAL INCLUDING THE GO
SHOOTING BASED ON THE BEST
INTERNATIONAL PRICE AND
ELIMINATING PRESCRIPTION LIMITS
AND COPAYS FOR FEE FOR SERVICE
BENEFICIARIES. AS WELL AS A
LINE MEDI CAL TO UTILIZE HIS
BARGAINING POWER TO NEGOTIATE
PRESCRIPTION DRUG REBATES FOR
NON MEDICARE POPULATIONS. IN
AUTHORIZES DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF FEDERAL WAIVERS AND
FLEXIBILITY. AS WELL AS
ENHANCED FEDERAL MATCHING FUNDS
PROVIDED IN THE FEDERAL RELIEF
PACKAGES AND OTHER FEDERAL
REGULATORY ACTIONS DUE TO THE
COLD BUT NINETEEN. PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. IT REMOVES
STATUTORY SUSPENSION LANGUAGE
FOR HIV HEPATITIS C. AND
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED INFECTION
PREVENTION PROGRAMS MAKING
THESE PROGRAMS ON GOING. AND
ESTABLISHES A SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT TOOL FOR COMMUNITY
CLINICS PARTICIPATING IN THE
FEDERAL. THREE FORTY B. DRUG
REBATE PROGRAM WHAT THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO
DETERMINE THE ALLOCATION OF
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS THE
CLINICS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL DEBATER DISCUSSION
SENATOR GROWTH. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB I'M AT THE BUDGET TRAILER
HEALTH BILL. AB AT ALLOWS A
SUSPENSION OF ALMOST ALL
MEDICARE PROVIDER SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS AT THAT ARE FUNDED BY
PROP FIFTY SIX. THAT INCLUDES
PHYSICIAN SERVICES DENTAL
SERVICES IMMEDIATE CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE DEVELOPING A
JUST DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED.
FACILITIES PROVIDING CONTINUOUS
SKILLED NURSING CARE TO
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS HIV AIDS WAIVER
PROVIDERS. PEDIATRIC HEALTH
CARE FOR THE AND MEDI CAL FOR
SYSTEM STRONG SCREENINGS FOR
CHILDREN AND ADULTS.
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENING FOR
CHILDREN PROVIDER TRAINING FOR
THOMAS- SCREENS. STANDALONE
PEDIATRIC SUB ACUTE FACILITIES
COMMUNITY BASED ADULT SERVICES
NON EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION. IT DOES HOWEVER
INCLUDE ALL ABORTIONS YOU KNOW
WE WOULD I'M SAD AND SICKENED
BY THAT BUT YOU KNOW THIS IS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT POOR
COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES THAT
RELY ON MEDI CAL SERVICES AND
DOCTORS AND DENTISTS TREATING
MEDI CAL PATIENTS LIKE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. IN KERN IN
FRESNO IN KEAN'S IN DEL ECL
AREAS THESE DOCTORS ARE NOT
GOING TO PROVIDE THESE SERVICES
BECAUSE THEY WILL GO BROKE IF
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
SUPPLEMENTAL- PAYMENTS THAT
COME FROM THE PROP FIFTY SIX
MONIES. SO THERE WILL BE LIT
LESS MEDICAL CARE FOR THOSE IN
IMPOVERISHED FOR SOCIO ECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IF
THIS BUDGET TRAILER BILL PASSES
SO I DESPERATELY URGENT NO VOTE.
THANK YOU- SENATOR GROW SENATOR
DOLLY FOLLOWED BY SENATOR PAM.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I ALSO RISE IN
OPPOSITION- PROP FIFTY SIX WAS
PASSED TO LEVERAGE MONEY AND
WAS SOLD TO THE VOTERS TO.
BRING MORE FOR HEALTH AND THAT
REGION TO DO ALL THE THINGS
THAT MY CENTER FROM BAKERSFIELD
JUST TALKED ABOUT SO FOR THOSE
REASONS- I WILL BE OPPOSING
THIS BILL AND IT'S ALSO PUTTING
MONEY INTO THE GENERAL FUND
WHICH I THINK IS IN A PROPER
THIS TIME WE NEED THE- WE TALK
ABOUT. TOBACCO AND IN THOSE-
ISSUES TODAY AND THAT'S WHAT
THESE BONDS THE VOTERS VOTED
FOR WAS TO DO HEALTH. AND
LEVERAGING SO FOR THOSE REASONS
IALSO OPPOSES A TRAILER BILL.
THANK YOU CENTER DOLLY CENTER
PAN. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENTS
AND- SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY-
FOUGHT FOR AND- ENDORSED PROP
FIFTY SIX- I'M HERE TO SAY THAT
I SUPPORT THIS TRAILER BILL AND
I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE AND-
WELCOME MY GOOD FRIENDS. YES
I'LL IN THEIR- DESIRE TO
CONTINUE TO PROTECT PROFIT THE
SIX- THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
AS A SENATE DID. FROM THE
BEGINNING IT'S SOMETHING THAT-
WE HAVE FOUGHT FOR IN OUR OWN
BUDGET PROPOSAL AND ACTUALLY IF
YOU REALLY LOOK AT THE TRAILER
BILL WE WILL PROTECT ALL THOSE
THINGS AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
GOOD FRIENDS OF BAKERSFIELD
LISTING OFF THE VARIOUS THINGS
PROPERTY SIX FUNDS. IN THIS
COMING BUDGET YEAR SO YES THERE
IS A PROVISION WHICH THE
GOVERNOR WANTED TO BASICALLY RE
VISIT THE- AT THE NEXT BUDGET
YEAR. AND I THINK I WILL BE
HAPPY TO SAY THAT- WHEN THAT
BUDGET COMES FORWARD. I WILL BE
FIGHTING TO CONTINUE TO PROP
FIFTY SIX AND I MY GUESS IS
THAT MANY OF MY- GOOD FRIENDS
IN THE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS WILL
BE DOING THE SAME BUT THAT'S
FOR NEXT YEAR. AND THIS YEAR I
THINK REST ASSURED I DON'T
THERE'D BE ANY CONFUSION FROM
THE PUBLIC. THAT WE ARE PASSING
A BUDGET THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
PROTECT THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS FOR PROP FIFTY SIX-
FOR THIS COMING BUDGET YEAR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
BANISTER ANY FURTHER DEBATEOR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
MITCHELL YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'D LIKE TO
CORRECT THE RECORD IT WAS THE
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY NINE THE
HUMAN SERVICES TRAILER BILL
THAT WE JUST VOTED ON I THINK
ON A- PARTISAN SPLIT. THAT IS
WHERE THE SUPPLEMENTAL RATE
INCREASES FOR PROVIDERS WITHIN
THE D. D. S. COMMUNITY. THAT
WAS THE TREE IN THE BILL WHERE
WE TALK ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
INDEPENDENT LIVING PROGRAMS THE
INFANT DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS AND
EARLY START SPECIALIZED.
THERAPEUTIC SERVICES ARE ALL
PAID FOR ALSO REMIND MY
COLLEAGUES THAT IT WAS IN THE
BUDGET BILL WE VOTED ON SEVERAL
WEEKS AGO. WHERE WE PROTECTED
ALL OF THE- MEDI CAL SERVICES
THE OPTIONAL BENEFITS THAT WERE
AT RISK. EVERYTHING FROM
INCONTINENCE CREAMS AND WASHES
STIR OPTOMETRY THE OPTICAL ALL
THOSE CRITICAL SERVICES THAT WE
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR. AS
DOCTOR PM STATED IN THE PROP
FIFTY SIX- QUESTION COMES UP
EVERY YEAR IN THE BUDGET SINCE
THE PASSAGE OF THE INITIATIVE.
AND WE HAVE STOOD AS THE
LEGISLATURE IN PROTECTED THAT
INVESTMENT FOR PROVIDER
REIMBURSEMENT EVERY YEAR AND I
DON'T EXPECT THAT THIS HOUSE
WILL. STOP DOING SO FOR THOSE
REASONS AND MANY MORE I ASKED
WHEN I VOTED AB AT. THE THANK
YOU SENATOR MITCHELL. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES NO BELL. I FORGES NO
BRADFORD HI COME BY OTHER HI
CHIANG. NO DALLY NO DODD. I
DORADO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG
AYE HILL I HUESO I TADO I
JACKSON BY I JONES NO LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ NO MITCHELL.
I MONEY. I MORE LOCK NO MORRELL.
NO NIELSEN NO HAN HI PORTANTINO
I ROTH. I RUBIO HI SKINNER. I
STERN I NUMBER HI MY COUNTY I
WIENER HI WILK NO LIES TWENTY
NINE KNOWS ELEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON NOW TO FILE
ITEM NINETY ONE A. B. EIGHTY
TWO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY TWO BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN
ACT RELATING TO STATE
GOVERNMENT AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET SENATOR MITCHELL
MADAM PRESIDENT I THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN A. B. EIGHTY TWO IS
THE GENERAL GOVERNMENT BUDGET
TRAILER BILL THE BILL MAKES
TECHNICAL STATUTORY CHANGES. TO
IMPLEMENT THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT FOR GENERAL
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS THE STATE
ADMINISTRATION THE BILL DOES
THE FOLLOWING IT ESTABLISHES
THE SOCIAL ENTREPRENEURS FOR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OR SEED
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
ENTREPRENEURIAL TRAINING MICRO
GRANTS TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
SUPPORT NOT REGION EDUCATION
INDIVIDUALS WITH LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY. OR WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED TO ESTABLISH AND
MAINTAIN A SMALL BUSINESS IN
THE STATE AND INCLUDES CLEAN IT
LANGUAGE FOR THE USED CAR
DEALER TAX PROPOSAL THAT WAS
PASSED EARLIER THIS MONTH IN AB
EIGHTY FIVE TRAILER BILL IT
REMOVES PROVISIONS THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY PUNISHED CONSUMERS
OF A CARD READER FAILED TO
REMIT TAXES. AMONG OTHER CLEAR
FINE CHANGES IN FINALLY
PROVIDES RELIEF TO LICENSEES OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES CONTROL DEPARTMENT BY
DELAYING THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE RESPONSIBLE BEVERAGE ACT BY
ONE YEAR. ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL DEBATER DISCUSSION
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I DURING THE BUDGET
HEARING LAST NIGHT I ASKED-
WHAT THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS
WOULD BE- AVE HOW IT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE WHAT STATE AGENCY
WOULD ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT- THE
C. PROGRAM AND SO I JUST WANTED
TO SHARE WITH THE MEMBERS THAT
WERE ON THE COMMITTEE AND ALSO
THE MEMBERS THE BOARD THE
LEGISLATURE HERE THEY ATUALLY
SENT ME RESPONSE- IN TIME AND I
WANT TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU
ALL. THE SERVICES WILL BE
PROVIDED THROUGH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ORGANIZATIONS CBO'S HOWEVER WE
CANNOT PROVIDE THE LISTA CBO'S
BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
DETERMINED YET THE WORST THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
WILL ENTER INTO AN INTER AGENCY
INTER AGENCY AGREEMENT WITH
UCLA LABOR CENTER TO CONTRACT
WITH THE CBO'S THAT HAVE A
DEMONSTRATED TRACK RECORD OF
PROVIDING CULTURAL AND LOOT
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE
SERVICES TO SEE. TARGETED
POPULATIONS THE LABOR CENTER
WILL EVALUATE CBO'S THAT APPLY
TO PARTICIPATE IN TE SEED TO
DETERMINE IF THEY HAVE THE
DEMONSTRATE TRACK RECORD ONE OF
THE GOALS TO MAKE SURE SEAT
PROGRAM. COMPONENTS LIKE
TRAINING AND OUTRAGE ARE
ACCESSIBLE THROUGH THE STATE SO
I DID GET I JUST WANTED TO
SHARE WITH YOU I WAS EXCITED
THAT THEY ACTUALLY- BUT THEY
DIDN'T GIVE ME. WHAT SEE
PROGRAM- WHERE WHERE THAT CBO
WOULD BE. IN MY DISTRICT AND I
WANT TO SHARE I WILL BE
OPPOSING THIS A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION I LIKE. THE PART OF
THIS BILL WHERE WE TALK ABOUT
THE CAST OF FUNDS. AND
LEVERAGING THE FEDERAL GRANTS
BUT- YOU DON'T A TIMER WE HAVE
COBIT. AND WE ARE BUSINESSES.
THAT ARE LEGITIMATE BUSINESSES
NOT. BUSINESS THAT ARE TRYING
TO START. A AND THESE MANY OF
THESE ARE- ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ARE STARTING THESE BUSINESS AND
THAT'S OUR TAX DOLLARS. THAT
ARE GOING TO. START THESE
THROUGH THESE- CBO'S WHICH I
BELIEVE ARE- NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS SO OUR TAX
DOLLARS ARE GOING TO A-
NONPROFIT. CHOSEN BY. THE UCLA-
AND THEN- HELPING PEOPLE START
BUSINESSES- YOU KNOW THAT TIME
WILL BE SEEING. MANY BUSINESSES
IN CALIFORNIA DEVASTATED BY THE
CODE KOBE DEAD NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. I WE SHOULD BE
HELPING THOSE BUSINESSES THAT
ARE LEGITIMATELY UP LAID OFF.
LITERALLY MILLIONS OF EMPLOYEES
GET BACK ON THEIR FEET AND SO I
THINK THIS- THESE TAX DOLLARS
WOULD BE SPENT A LOT BETTER IN
HELPING LEGITIMATE BUSINESSES
IN CALIFORNIA. THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED WHO HAVE BEEN HERE
FOR GENERATIONS OR AT LEAST
DECADES- GET BACK ON THE PEACE
SO FOR THOSE REASONS I WILL BE
OPPOSING THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU SIR
DAHLE ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION CHING IN HEARING
NONE SENATOR MITCHELL YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MADAM PRESIDENT I I'M I'M
THRILLED THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION- WAS VISIONARY
ENOUGH TO UNDERSTAND. THAT THE
MILLIONS OF UNDOCUMENTED
WORKING CALIFORNIANS. WHO ARE
UNABLE TO BENEFIT FROM ANY. OF
THE FEDERALLY FUNDED CALL THAT
NINETEEN RESPITE. I WILL BE
ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM THIS
PROGRAM TO CONTINUE. TO RECEIVE
TRAINING IN MICROGRAMS TO START
SMALL BUSINESSES. I'M NOT SURE
WHAT LEGITIMIZES A BUSINESS.
ONE OVER ANOTHER- BUT I'M
CERTAINLY PLEASED THAT WE HAVE
STEPPED UP RECOGNIZING THE
NEEDS OF OUR UNDOCUMENTED
BROTHER AND- TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
CARE OF THEIR FAMILIES TO AND
PROVIDE BUSINESSES THAT WE
COULD ALL BENEFIT FROM I'M
ASKING FOR I VOTED MAYBE EIGHTY
TWO. THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
HALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES NO BELL I FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD HI CABRERA I CHIANG NO
DALLY. NO DODD I DRAWS OWN I
GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG I HILL I
HUESO. HI TADO FIVE JACKSON AYE
AYE JONES NO LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL HI I
MONNING I MORE LOCK NO MORAL.
NO NIELSEN. NO PAN I PORTANTINO.
HI ROSS I RUBIO I SKINNER. HI
STERN. I NUMBER NINE HI MY
COUNTY I WIENER I WILL. NOW
WEISS TWENTY NINE KNOWS ELEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON
NOW TO FILE ITEM NINETY FOUR A.
B. EIGHTY EIGHT BEDROOM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTY EIGHT BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC SAFETY
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATE
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET SENATOR MITCHELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT AB EIGHTY EIGHT IS
THE PUBLIC SAFETY TRAILER BILL
THIS BILL INCLUDES VARIOUS
CRIMINAL JUSTICE. REFORMS THAT
REFLECT THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE DATA AND EVIDENCE
BASED PROPOSALS FOR REDUCING
OUR STATES THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLAR PRISON BUDGET PROTECTING
PUBLIC SAFETY AND ACHIEVING
OVERALL BUDGET SAVINGS. THE
BILL PROVIDES SPECIFICITY ON
THE PLANT THE CALLS THE STATE
OWNED AND OPERATED PRISON BY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND A SECOND
BY TWENTY TWENTY TWO IN
DETERMINING WHICH FACILITIES
THE CLOSE THIS BILL REQUIRES
FACTORS SUCH AS OPERATIONAL
COSTS FACILITY CONDITION AND
SYSTEM WIDE OPERATIONAL NEEDS
TO BE WEIGHED HEAVILY. THE BILL
ALSO INCLUDES REFORMS TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM FOR EXAMPLE IT CALL
BANDS THE BOX ON MOST COLLEGE
ADMISSION APPLICATIONS AND
UPDATES THE STATE'S PAROLE
SYSTEM BY CREATING INCENTIVES
LIKE BURNED EARLY DISCHARGE.
THE BILL ALSO INCLUDES SEVERAL
STATUTORY CHANGES TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS HOUSE OF THE
STATE'S PRISON IN LIGHT OF THE
ONGOING COLBERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL DEBATER DISCUSSION
SENATOR NIELSEN. THAT PRESENT
LEGEND THE SENATE I ASK A NO
VOTE ON THIS IT SOME MORE. SO
CALLED REFORM OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM REFORM THAT
THERE'S NOT GOING TO NAY IN
YOUR TO THE BENEFIT OF THE
AVERAGE CITIZEN. WHAT WILL MAKE
THEM MORE VULNERABLE TO
VICTIMIZATION AND COMPROMISES
JUSTICE IN PART BY SHORTENING
THE PAROLE PERIODS. WHICH IS A
PART OF THE SENTENCE WE'LL GET
INTO THAT AND SOME OTHER
MATTERS BUT IT IS A PART OF THE
SENTENCE. WHEN YOU ARE RELEASED
FROM PRISON THAT'S NOT IT YOU
HAVE NOT EXTINGUISH
EXTINGUISHER DID DEBT TO
SOCIETY AND THIS IS A PART OF
THE REFORMS NOW TO. DO LESS.
THE MOST ONEROUS PART OF THIS
IS AN INTEGRAL PART OF THE SO
CALLED REALIGNED. OR VICE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED STATE
INMATES IN CUSTODY AND IN
TREATMENT AND STATE FACILITIES
HAVE BEEN DUMPED INTO OUR
COUNTIES. INTO OUR COUNTY JAILS
ARE JUST INTO OUR COUNTIES AND
ON THE STREETS. THE
REHABILITATED RESOURCES ARE NOT
THERE FOR THEM. AND WE HAVE
PLENTY OF PROBLEMS BECAUSE OF
IT THIS IS WHERE THEY HAVE NO
LOW. THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN
SENATOR GROW FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB EIGHTY EIGHT THIS COMMIT
BUDGET TRAILER BILL- IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE A PUBLIC SAFETY
BUDGET TRAILER BILL BUT I DOUBT
THAT IT IS CALIFORNIA'S SOFT ON
CRIME POLICIES ALREADY PRETTY
MORE CRIMINALS BACK ON THE
STREET- DEBT RISK OF PUBLIC
SAFETY EARLIER THIS YEAR THE
CALIFORNIA CHIEF JUSTICE SET
BAIL AT ZERO DOLLARS AND WE SAW
REPEAT OFFENDERS RELEASED BACK
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES.
COMMITTING CRIME AFTER CRIME
AGAIN IN APRIL SEVEN HIGH RISK
OFFENDERS ARE RELEASED EARLY IN
ORANGE COUNTY THESE WERE
SERIOUS VIOLENT OFFENDERS
RELEASED IN A TIME OF CHILD
USING WAY CASES CHILD ABUSE
CASES WERE ALREADY INCREASING
ALL SEVEN OF THESE SEX
OFFENDERS WERE WERE RELEASED
EARLY AFTER COMMITTING CRIMES
AGAINST CHILDREN. INTO LARRY
COUNTY THIS YEAR MAN WAS
RELEASED AFTER PLEADING NO
CONTEST TO CHARGES INCLUDING
HIT RUN CAUSING ANY INJURIES
EVADING A PEACE OFFICER OVER
THE PLEASE THE DESPERATE PLEAS
A PROSECUTOR'S THAT MAN OUT OF
HIS OWN REQUIREMENTS IS
MURDERED TO A TULARE COUNTIES
CONSTITUENTS IN JUNE INVOICE
DALY AYE HE INVITES SO HE
BRUTALLY MURDERED HEATHER SLOAN
WITH WITH A BARBECUE FORK. AT
HER HOME WHILE HE WAS
COMMITTING A ROBBERY AND THREE
DAYS LATER DURING THE CHASE HE
LOST CONTROL OF HIS CAR HIDDEN
KILL THE WOMAN AND TULARE
RIDING A BIKE HEATHER MUST CO.
AB EIGHTY EIGHT FURTHER PUSHING
SOFT ON CRIME NARRATIVE THE ONE
THAT RESULTED IN THE MURDER OF
THESE TWO BEAUTIFUL WOMEN THAT
WERE JUST MINDING THEIR OWN
BUSINESS AND HAVE FAMILIES TO
RAISE. THIS HAS GOT TO END WE
CANNOT CONTINUE TO RELEASE MORE
CRIMINALS THAT PROMOTE SOFT ON
CRIME POLICIES IN PLACE WHERE
LAWMAKERS- OVER CRIME VICTIMS
AND SAFETY WE'VE GOT TO START
PROTECTING VICTIMS WE STAND ON
THIS FLOOR AND WE FIGHT AND WE
ARGUE AND I HEAR NOTHING BUT-
COMMENTS ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE THAT SAY WE HAVE TO
PROTECT WOMEN WOMEN THAT ARE
VIOLENTLY RATE. THIS GUY
STABBED THIS WOMAN WITH A FORK
IN HE IS SOMEBODY THAT WOULD
GET OFF ON THIS PARTICULAR
THING SO YOU GUYS TO CLOSE DOWN
THESE PRISONS AND MAKES
SOFTBANK I'M POLICIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IS
COMPLETELY UP IT AND IT. IN
HIXSON ACCOUNT. FOR THE VICTIMS
ARE PUNITIVE. MURDERED GROSSLY
MURDERED IN GREAT UNDER THESE
POLICIES LIKE THIS BILL IT'S
GETTING READY TO BE PASSED BY
NOTHING BUT THE MAJORITY PARTY
I ASK FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR JONES THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- THIS IS ONE OF THE
BILLS THAT ARE- FIND CALL THE
FROM TO AIM AT MENTIONED IS-
NOT JUST A BUDGET BILL BUT ALSO
A POLICY BILL THERE'S ACTUALLY
MEMBERS- I HEAVY HEAVY AMOUNT
OF POLICY IN THIS BILL AND
ACTUALLY AN ITEM THAT SHOULD
HAVE GONE THROUGH A PUBLIC
SAFETY AT LEAST PUBLIC SAFETY
IF MAYBE NOT EVEN
APPROPRIATIONS AND THAT IS
DEALING WITH- CAN CONTINUING TO
OUTLAW. A PARTICULAR TYPE OF
FIREARM AND- I TRIED TO DO SOME
RESEARCH ON THIS AND I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THAT WITH THE
TYPE OF FIREARM IT'S DESCRIBED
HERE IN THE LANGUAGE I READ THE
LANGUAGE WATCHED A VIDEO READ A
NEWSPAPER ARTICLE AND STILL
CAN'T FIGURE OUT. OF WHAT
THEY'RE TOOK WHAT THE LANGUAGE
IS TALKING ABOUT SO MADAM
PRESIDENT I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THE AUTHOR A QUESTION IF YOU
WOULD BE WILLING TO. ADDRESSES
THANK YOU SIR JONES WOULD YOU
BE WILLING TO ACCEPT A QUESTION
SENATOR MITCH HAPPILY THANK
THANK YOU AND BASICALLY KIND OF
SET UP ALREADY. CAN YOU
DESCRIBE. THE TYPE OF FIREARM
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. IN
THIS BUDGET BILL. THAT'S RIGHT
YOU'RE NOT ON BUDGET COMMITTEE
BECAUSE WE HAD A LENGTHY
DISCUSSION. CLARIFICATION ON IT
YESTERDAY. I'M GOING TO HAVE-
ACTUALLY MYSELF FIVE CHAIR I'VE
GOT NOTES HERE BUT I'M GONNA
ASSET MYSELF FIVE TWO YEARS
STAND UP AND TAKE THE QUESTION.
ON AND IF THERE'S ANYTHING I
NEED TO ADD WITH REGARD TO
FRANKLIN ARMORY. AND THIS BILLS
EFFORTS TO PRECLUDE THEM FROM
CONTINUING TO MANUFACTURE PARTS
THAT CAN BE ASSEMBLED ASSAULT
WEAPONS. I'M GOING TO ASK US
SENATE IS GOING TO RESPOND.
WITH BERMAN WITHOUT OBJECTION
STARTING OFFICER THANK YOU-
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG STANDING
HAD IN A BAN ON ASSAULT WEAPONS
WHICH WE HAVE. BY EXPANDED
THROUGH VARIOUS- STATUTE
AMENDMENTS THAT INCLUDE
LIMITATIONS ON- CONVERSION KITS
THAT WOULD ALLOW FIREARMS
STREET TO HAVE. AMMUNITION
DEVICES THAT ALLOW THEM TO
SHOOT GOT MORE THAN TEN BULLETS
AT A TIME A WHOLE VARIETY OF
THINGS EACH AT EACH POINT. THAT
WE HAVE FACED WHERE A
MANUFACTURER HAS TRIED TO
DESIGN A WEAPON IN ORDER TO
CIRCUMVENT CALIFORNIA'S LAWS.
WE HAVE COME BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND- AMENDED THOSE
LAWS TO MAKE SURE THAT WEHAD
STATUTES THAT PROTECTED.
CALIFORNIANS FROM ASSAULT
WEAPONS WE NOW HAVE AT LEAST
ONE MANUFACTURER WHO IS
GLEEFULLY ADVERTISING THEIR
TYPE ONE. FIREALARM HAS
CALIFORNIA ASSAULT WEAPONSSAFE
BANNED THE MANUFACTURE EVEN
REFERS TO THE FAR OR AS AN
ASSAULT WEAPON WHAT THIS DOES
IS ENABLES US TO. KEEP CATCHING
UP WITH THESE MANUFACTURERS WHO
ARE CONSTANTLY TRYING TO
CIRCUMVENT CALIFORNIA'S LAW SO
THAT IS THE PURPOSE OF THIS
LANGUAGE AND I WOULD ONLY SAY
THAT EVERY SINGLE VOTE IN A
BUDGET WHETHER IT IS DOLLARS
FOR WORDS IS A POLICY ACT.
THANK YOU- THAT ON YOUR OWN
TIME SENATOR JONES OR YOU DON'T
KNOW YEAH I DID VIçT THANK
YOU I DON'T THINK I'LL BE LONG-
I APPRECIATE THAT AND- LOOK
WE'VE HAD SOME VERY ROBUST
DEBATE ON THIS FLOOR AND IN
POLICY COMMITTEES- REGARDING
THE SECOND AMENDMENT. AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE ACTUALLY IN
THE POLICY COMMITTEES. THE
LEVEL OF DEBATE THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO HAVE. BUT I THINK AS
THE ANSWER THE QUESTION WAS
ANSWERED PROVES MY POINT. THAT
THIS IS HEAVY POLICY. AND YOU
KNOW NORMALLY WHAT ON THE
SECOND AMENDMENT DEBATE AND A
FIREARM DEBATE THERE IS A
LEGITIMATE CONVERSATION THAT
TAKES PLACE INTHAT POLICY
COMMITTEE THAT GIVES THE PUBLIC
THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOICE THEIR
OPINION- ON THIS TYPE OF ISSUE.
AND SO WHILE I BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S MANY. ITEMS SUPPORTABLE
IN AB EIGHTY EIGHT ARE THERE
HAS BEEN- NOTICE OF THINGS THAT
ARE NOT SUPPORTABLE IN EIGHTY
EIGHTY EIGHT. BUT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE. THIS
IS. A STEP TOO FAR IN A BUDGET
BILL- AS FAR AS POLICY IS
CONCERNED. AND I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO PUT ON NOTICE FOR ALL
OF US. AND FOR THE PUBLIC. THAT
THIS COULD BE A SLIPPER IT IS A
SLIPPERY SLOPE. AND WE HAVE
MADE OTICE OF THESE TYPE OF
THINGS BEFORE ON THE ON THIS
FLOOR REGARDING BUDGET BILLS.
AND. THIS JUST GOES TOO FAR AS
FAR AS POLICIES CONCERN SO I
ALSO WOULD ASK FOR A NO VOTE
THANK YOU. AND IF I MAY OF
THROUGH THE PRESIDENT- SINCE I
WAS ASKING A QUESTION JUST ADD
AN ADDITIONAL A RESPONSE TO THE
INQUIRY MADE. ON. AGAIN AS THE
CHAIR OF BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
SAID THERE'S NOTHING URRENT
LAW PREVENTING THE SALE OF THIS
TITLE ONCE HOT STYLE OF GUNS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. FOR
PROVIDING THESE FIREARMS AND
HAVE AN ASSAULT WEAPON STYLE
FEATURES. OF WITH REGARD TO THE
ARGUMENT THAT IS NOT PURE
POLICY THERE IS AN ALLOCATION
THE BUDGET ALLOCATION A HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLAR
DEALERS RECORD OF SALE SPECIAL
ACCOUNT IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND A- EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY TWO
THOUSAND ALLOCATION TWENTY
TWENTY ONE APPROPRIATE TO
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SO THEY
CAN. REVIEW APPLICATIONS AND
IMPLEMENT THE ABOVE CHANGES SO
WITH REGARD I'M CLEAR THAT
YOU'D LIKE MORE OPPORTUNITY AND
I'M ALSO CLEAR THAT I SENATE
TODAY OF LAST NIGHT WITHOUT
MOVING. TO HEAR HUNDREDS OF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS FULL TIME
ON THE ASSEMBLY BILL THE WHILE
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE IT MAY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN POLICY.
HUNDREDS OF MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WERE ABLE TO CALL IN AND
EXPRESS THEIR CONCERN. THE
MEMBERS TO STATEN OF FLOORING
HEARD THEM RABAL TO PARTICIPATE
IN THAT BUT I DID WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT THERE IS A
ALLOCATION- ASSOCIATE WITH THE
LANGUAGE OF THE TRAILER BILL.
AND THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
ANYTHING FURTHER SENATOR JONES
SAWYER. THANK YOU AND SO TWO
THINGS- FIRST OF ALL AND I
MEANT TO STAND UP AND
RECOGNIZE- BEGINNING MY
CONVERSATION THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE THAT WAS HERE TILL
MIDNIGHT LAST NIGHT I DO
APPRECIATE. THE SERVICE- EVERY
BUDGET COMMITTEE MEMBER
BECAUSE- THAT CAN GET-
LABORIOUS. AND SO I APPRECIATE
THAT THE SECOND THING I WASN'T
UNNECESSARY SHARE THE STORY BUT
I SURE- AND- QUICKLY AGAIN. I
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY ON A-
SATURDAY- TO SPEND A COUPLE
HOURS IN A IN A GUN SHOP-
BUYING THE APPROPRIATE.
CALIFORNIA COMPLAINT PARTS TO
BUILD A ARE FIFTEEN. AND SO ON
FATHER'S DAY. I HAD THE GREAT
OPPORTUNITY WITH A FRIEND OF
MINE AND- ONE OF MY SONS TO.
ASSEMBLE AND- CALIFORNIA
COMPLAINT A. R. FIFTEEN IT WAS
ACTUALLY. A GREAT EXPERIENCE
I'D NEVER DONE THAT BEFORE-
ASSEMBLED MY OWN FIREARM. AND
I'VE HAD OPPORTUNITY TO FIRE IT
YET BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY- I'M KIND
OF. GOT A **** SHOULDER RIGHT
NOW. SO IT WAS- EDUCATIONAL TO
ME. HOW MUCH THESE FAR ARM
DEALERS HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
ABOUT THE LAW. AND AS AS THE
FARM DEALER WAS WALKING ME
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF WHICH
PARTS I CAN BUY AND WHICH PARTS
I CAN'T BUY. IT WAS IT WAS
INSTRUCTIVE AND THEY HAVE TO
KNOW THE DETAIL. I MEAN MY NEW
DETAILS OF WHAT'S LEGAL AND
WHAT'S NOT LEGAL SO THAT THEY
DON'T GET IN TROUBLE AND BY
EXTENSION I DON'T GET IN
TROUBLE AND SO AGAIN I JUST
CLOSE WITH THAT'S WHY THESE
THINGS ARE SO IMPORTANT TO GO
TO POLICY COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR
JOHN SENATOR GLAZERS. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS- SINCE
THIS MAY BE THE ONLY- BUDGET
BILL I SPEAK TO- ME FIRST
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION FOR THE
BUDGET CHAIR AT HER- COMMITTEE.
THE LEADERSHIP. FOR ALL THEIR
WORK ON THIS BUDGET CERTAINLY
THE STAFF I DON'T THINK THERE'S
BEEN A MORE DIFFICULT TIME- IN
ANY IN OUR RECENT HISTORY FOR A
BUDGET TO BE PUT TOGETHER UNDER
THE CIRCUMSTANCES WITH THE-
CHALLENGES THAT. FISCAL
CHALLENGES THAT WE ARE
CERTAINLY FACING- AND THAT
CERTAINLY. A MOMENT TO EXPRESS
GREAT PRAISE- TO THE LEADERSHIP.
AND EVERYONE THAT'S BEEN
INVOLVED IN AN. I'M NOT
SPEAKING ON THIS BILL BECAUSE-
THERE'S A LOT IN IT TOO TO
LIGHT BUT THERE ARE A FEW
THINGS IN IT THAT CAUSED ME
GREAT I NEEDS. I HEAR THE-
SUGGESTION THAT EVERYTHING IN
THE BUDGET HAS POLICY BUT WHAT
WE DO ASK IS THAT THAT THERE BE
A GERMANE NECESSARY IT'S REMAIN
AS TO FISCAL IN FACT FOR
MEASURES TO BE INCLUDED IN
BUDGET TRAILER BILLS. AND I
THINK THAT- WHILE THE EFFORTS
THAT HAVE BEEN ONGOING HAD BEEN
DONE MOSTLY VERY VERY WELL IN
THIS CASE I THINK THAT- THERE
ARE A FEW PLACES WHERE IT FALLS
SHORT. AND CERTAINLY FOR ME
IT'S IN THE SENTENCING CHANGES
IN THIS BILL. IF THE IDEA IS
THAT IT HAS A SIGNIFICANT.
BUDGET IMPACT. THAT SPEAKS TO
THE SERIOUSNESS IN WHICH THE
SENTENCING CHANGES. MAY HAVE A
FAX AND I THINK THAT WOULD
SPEAK TO THE NEED FOR FULL
POLICY REVIEW. AND DELIBERATION
SO WE CAN ALL MAKE A COLLECTIVE
CHOICE. AGAIN THE BUDGET COMING
AT THE HOUSE OF LORDS AND
DEADLINE PROBABLY NEVER
HAPPENED BEFORE. THE PRESSURES
ON ALL OF US THE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF THE MOST DIFFICULT- THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS FACED AND
THAT'S WHY IT MAKES IT EVEN
HARDER TO. GET ALL THIS
INFORMATION SO LATE AND NOT
REALLY HAVE THE TIME TO HEAR
FROM STAKEHOLDERS. IRRESPECTIVE
OF THE GRACIOUSNESS OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE TO WORK LATE
INTO THE NIGHT LAST NIGHT. WE
KNOW THAT THAT IS NOT THE
DELIVER TO PROCESS THAT IS
REALLY EXPECTED OF US SO ONCE
AGAIN MY APPRECIATION TO THE
BUDGET TEAM I'M A VOTE FOR THE
TRAILER BILL TODAY THAT'S
BEFORE US BUT ONE TO EXPRESS
THOSE THOUGHTS THANK YOU.
SENATOR MORLOCK. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I WANT TO ALSO
AFFIRMED THE JOB THAT THE CHAIR
OF THE BUDGET DISTRIBUTE
COMMITTEE DID LAST NIGHT DOES
SHE GRACIOUSLY HANDLED AT LEAST
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS
THE PREDOMINANT. FEELS THAT THE
CALLERS WERE ASKING EVER OR
TALKING TO WERE AB EIGHTY EIGHT
THIS ONE. AB SEVENTY SEVEN AND
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE I JUST
WANTED TO- THINKER FOR HOW TO
HOW WELL SHE HANDLED OF
BIGELOW. OUT TWO THINGS MADAM
PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IS INFORMED US THAT THEY WOULD-
STRONGLY URGE THAT WE NOT TAKE
UP- AB EIGHTY EIGHT. THE
BELIEVE THAT THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL REPRESENT A SEA
CHANGE IN PUBLIC SAFETY POLICY
AND SHOULD NOT BE APPROVED
WITHOUT FULL CONSIDERATION. OF
THEIR SWEEPING IMPACT IN TWO
SPECIFICALLY THEY WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT SECTION
FOURTEEN WHICH ALLOWS FOR
DIVERSION IN ALL MISDEMEANOR
CASES WITHOUT EXCEPTION AND SO
THERE'S A LOT HERE THAT WE
SHOULD BE REAL CONCERNED ABOUT
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
WE DEFERRED AB- EIGHTY EIGHT.
TO ANOTHER TIME THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. SENATOR NEAL.
PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF THE SENATE.
AND THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
WHO I AM DRESSING AS MUCH AS I
AM MY COLLEAGUES. THIS IS ABOUT
YOU THIS AFFECTS YOU. AND HUGE
WHITE. NOW THIS HAS BEEN A
DESTROYED NEARLY UNUSUAL YEAR.
BUT WOULD BE A YEAR WHERE WE
SHOULD EXERCISE. OPTIMAL
RESTRAINT. BECAUSE VERY BAD
THINGS HAPPEN WHEN THEY ARE
RUSHED TO. AS A SOMETIMES ARE
DONE IN THIS INSTITUTION. THIS
IS A MAJOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
POLICY IT'S NOT JUST LIKE STUFF
IT'S BIG STEP. WARRANTING IN
DEPTH HEARINGS. AND POLICY
COMMITTEE OR COMMITTEES IN BOTH
HOUSES. THIS CALL OMMITTEES
SCRUTINY ON THE FLOOR EXTENSIVE
DEBATE. THAT WAS VERY DIFFICULT
TO EVEN COME CLOSE TO ACHIEVING.
I UNDERSTAND THAT. BUT ALL THE
MORE REASON TO BE MORE
RESTRAINT AND RESERVE ABOUT
TRYING TO JAM MAJOR POLICY. IN
SUCH A YEAR AND I WOULD ARGUE
SOME OF THESE POLICIES. COULD
HAVE WAITED. BUT I THINK SOME
AND I DO NOT COME TO CONDEMN
ANYBODY IN THE LEGISLATURE OF
ADMINISTRATION FOR THIS BUT I
CALL OTHER PORTIONS AND POWERS
OUT THERE THIS IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO EXPLOIT.
PURSUE THEIR AGENDA NO IT'S
BEEN A LONG AGENDA. OVER A
WHOLE PERIOD OF TIME. AND THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM BY
VIRTUE OF THIS PIECE BY PIECE
IS BEING TURNED INSIDE OUT. AND
I WILL ARGUE VOCIFEROUSLY THAT
WE THE CITIZENS. AND OUR
FAMILIES ARE NOT SAFER AS A
PRODUCT OF THIS. OVER THE YEARS
AND NOW YET AGAIN IN AN
ACCELERATED WAY BECAUSE THIS
OPENS THE DOOR TO CALL. CLOSING
TO MORE PRESENTS. ANDREA
MILITATED. FORMALLY IN CUSTODY
IN TREATMENT AND SOME KIND OF
SUPERVISION. AND SERVING A
SENTENCE JUST DESSERTS THE
PUBLIC AND THEIR VICTIMS
DESERVE SATISFACTION FOR NOW
ARE GOING TO BE OUT. IN THE
COMMUNITY. THERE IS NO QUESTION
THERE'S MORE CRIME. NOW ONE OF
THE WAYS UNDER REALIGNMENT IT
WAS HANDLED IS A REDEFINED
RECIDIVISM. A BOARD OF THE
STATE RE DEFINED. DUMB THAT
DOWN IF YOU WILL. THAT'S ALL
MAJOR POLICY STUFF. THAT KIND
OF THING HAPPENED NOT IN THE
LEGISLATURE NOT AND COMMITTEES.
BUT IN AN OUTSIDE ENTITY. AN
AGENCY OR DEPARTMENT. I WANT TO
NAME. THAT HAPPENED. WHAT'S
LEFT IN OUR PRISONS NOW. WOULD
BE EVEN TO THE LOCATION
ADVOCATES TO. CLOSE PRISONS.
IT'S THE WORST OF THE WORST OF
SLAPPED. ALL THE COOL LOW LEVEL
OFFENDERS ARE LONG GONE. AND
WE'VE TRANSITION IN THE PRISONS
FROM THE HIGHER LEVELS OF
SECURITY TO THE MAIN LINE. THE
VERY MOST DANGEROUS INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE STILL IN CUSTODY. DO
YOU THINK SOME OF THEM ARE NOT
GOING TO SLIP OUT ON THE NATION
YES THEY ARE. MY POINT IN THAT
REGARD. IS HOW IMPORTANT IT IS.
TO HAVE SOME LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT. AN IN DEPTH POLICY
COMMITTEE HEARINGS AND
DISCUSSIONS ON THIS. AND WE'RE
IN THE PUBLIC CAN CALM AND
COMMENT NOW. THIS NEW REGIME
THAT WE HAVE EXPECTED. I LIKE
ONE PART OF IT MORE
CALIFORNIANS BECAUSE OF THE
CONVENIENCE ARE ABLE COULD
EXPRESS THEIR OPINIONS TO THE
CALL IN. BUT WE AND WE EVEN DO
IT IN OUR POLICY COMMITTEES
HERE THEN I THINK IT'S VERY
UNSATISFACTORY IN THE
DETERIORATION THE INTEGRITY
INSTITUTION. IN FORMER TIMES
POLICY COMMITTEE HEARINGS HAVE.
LONG LONG TIME YEAH MAYBE TOO
LONG MAYBE WE ALL TALKED TOO
LONG WE DO. BUT THERE WERE IN
DEPTH HEARINGS IN NOW WE GET
THREE. TWO PEOPLE THREE MINUTES.
EVERYBODY ELSE ONE MINUTE HI
I'M SOLD SO I'M FOR ON AGAINST.
NOW I DO NOT CONSIDER THAT.
PROPER A THOROUGH PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION THAT'S THE SHORT
SHRIFT IN THE LEGISLATURE OUGHT
NOT DO THAT. WE ARE TO DEVOTE
OUR TIME TO GIVE THE PUBLIC THE
MAXIMUM OPPORTUNITY IN OUR
SALES THE MAXIMO A COMMITTEE.
TO REVIEW TO COMMENT TO ASK
QUESTIONS. THE LAST NIGHT IN
ONE PARTICULAR AND ONE
PARTICULAR BILL. THE MEMBERS
WERE MARVELOUS. AN ENQUIRING OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ABOUT SOME POLICIES. THAT THEY
DID NOT HAVE ADEQUATE ANSWERS
TO YET WE ARE EXPECTED TO BOTH
PUT THIS INTO EFFECT AND FORCE
IT UPON THE PEOPLE. AND EVEN
THE FOLKS WHO CAN FEED. AND
ARTICULATED THE POLICY COULDN'T
TELL US WHAT WAS GOING ON. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER TRIED
MIGHTILY. TO GET SOME
INFORMATION AS YET ANOTHER
MEMBER. THE OTHER PARTY. THAT'S
NOT GOOD BUSINESS. NOW IN OUR
CASE HOWEVER COLLEGE CAMPUSES
JUST FOR A MINUTE. WE DO HAVE
MORE PROBLEM INDIVIDUALS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES NOW. WE HAVE A SH
STIRRED UP POPULATION. AND THEY
ARE ENCROACHING ON OUR
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS. NOT
JUST THE HIGHER EDUCATION ONCE.
BUT PART OF THIS BILL. WOULD
ALLOW THE UNIVERSITIES CANNOT
INQUIRE OF APPLICANTS OF THEIR
CRIMINAL HISTORY. NOT I ARGUE
THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT. THE
PLACES WHERE OUR STUDENTS. ARE
SPENDING THEIR TIME DAY AND
NIGHT. AND HAVING THE
INSTITUTION KNOW ABOUT IT I
THINK WOULD BE IMPORTANT FACT I
KNOW IT WOULD BE IMPORTANT HAND.
ON TOP OF THAT. WE'RE GETTING
READY OF THE CAMPUS POLICE
DEPARTMENTS. AS WELL AS SOME
ARE TRYING TO GET RID OF OUR
LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENT. LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN THAT IS NOT. THE
FORMULA FOR IN ORDER TO.
PEACEFUL INFORMED AND INVOLVED
SOCIETY. FOR THAT AND MANY
OTHER REASONS. I WOULD ASK FOR
A NO VOTE. SENATOR ALAN I'M
JUST BE SURE MY FRIEND TO HIM I
HEARD TODAY THE CAMPUS TO WERE
HAD BEEN ON THE TO IN THIS BUT
THAT IS BEEN CHANGED TO SOME
SORT OF STAY MAYBE WE CAN GET
FOR THE- AUTHOR AS THIS DOESN'T
PARTICULAR. MAN MADE TO THE.
OKAY I'M SO COULD I HAD FOR
HEARING THE SENATOR ALLEN WE
YOU WOULD YOU. THE FEDERAL
RESPONSE. SHE QUESTION FOR
SKINNER. YEAH AND MY FRIENDS
AND HIM MENTION TO THETHAT THE
TIME SCHOOL. SKINNER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO RESPOND TO THIS S.
THANK YOU THERE IS NO
ELIMINATION OF SCHOOL POLICE IN
THE BILL. THANK YOU. A CENTER
ALLEN ANYTHING FURTHER I MEAN
DID YOU CAN YOU JUST CLARIFY-
WHAT IS IN HERE ON THAT TOPIC.
TIMES GLAD TO PULL THE HI I IT
I DO REMEMBER THE X. LANGUAGE
SO. OKAY IT'S A GREAT. TURN MY
CALL VERY GOOD THANK YOU. A
CENTER NIELSEN ON THAT POINT.
IF I STILL BLIGHTED MEAN TO
THAT THE BILL REQUIRED I WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE GENERAL
MOVEMENT IN SOCIETY TODAY AND I
WILL CLARIFY THAT POINT HOWEVER
I DO BELIEVE THERE WILL BE
PRESSURES ON OUR CAMPUSES
TOWARDS THAT END AND I'M TAKING
IT IN THAT CONTEXT IT BY
ALLOWED MYSELF TO THIS
MISUNDERSTOOD MY APOLOGIES
THANK YOU AND IF I COULD REMIND
EVERYONE PLEASE DIRECT YOUR
COMMENTS TO THE ACTUAL BILLS
THAT WE ARE. DEBATING THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR- BRADFORD
FORTUNER SKINNER DID YOU WANT
TO ELABORATE ON THAT. PLEASE
AND THEN SENATOR BRADFORD
CHEDDAR SKINNER- BUT NOW I'M
JUST A GUIDE. GENERAL POINT IN
TERMS THE DISCUSS SO FOR. A
THAT IS THAT HI. THE LARGEST
FOR DIRECTOR IN A BUDGET
TRAILER THE TO A PLAN FOR
SINGLE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. YEAH
THAT BUDGET SIGNED THE ADMIN OF
COURSE CHANGE WE HAVE A NEW
GOVERNOR BUT IN THAT PROCESS
THEY'VE BEEN DEVELOPING THE
PLAN. AND AS A RESULT IN THIS
BUDGET AND THE GOVERNOR MADE IT
CLEAR FROM BOTH JANUARY AND NOW.
HE IS SET GOALS FOR CERTAIN
DATES FOR PRISON CLOSURE
WITHIN. A INITIAL DATE AND THEN
THE SECOND ONE FOLLOWING. IN
ORDER TO DO THAT THERE HAS TO
BE POPULATION REDUCTION NOW. AS
MOST PEOPLE I THINK WOULD AGREE
THAT TO ACHIEVE POPULATION AND
WE'RE JUST MEANT JUST BY
RANDOMLY SAYING X. NUMBER OF
PEOPLE SHOULD JUST BE RELEASED.
WOULD PROBABLY NOT BE WISEST
DECISION REGARDING PUBLIC
SAFETY SO INSTEAD THERE ARE A
VARIETY OF MEASURES THAT ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE WHOLE SET
OF BOTH RECIDIVISM REDUCTION
MEASURES CREDIT- FIFTY SEVEN
CREDIT ISSUES THINGS LIKE THAT.
THAT ARE IN THIS PARTICULAR
TRAILER BILL THAT WILL ASSIST
ACHIEVING. IN IN A WAY THAT
PROTECTS PUBLIC SAFETY THE TYPE
OF POPULATION REDUCTION THAT
WOULD BE NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE
THE PRISON CLOSURES WHICH THE
LEGISLATURE ITSELF FIRST
DIRECTED. BACK IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. AND SO OF THESE ARE.
ARE FOR THAT PURPOSE AND SO
THEY DO HAVE A BUDGETARY
CONNECTION BECAUSE WE WOULD
FACE A CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE WE
WOULD HAVE TO IF WE WANTED TO
MEET THESE GOALS OF THE PERSIAN
CLOSURE BY A CERTAIN DATE. AND
WE HAD NOT HAD THE APPROPRIATE
POPULATION REDUCTIONS WHICH I
WILL NOTE THAT CRIME IS DOWN
AND THERE ARE NATURAL
POPULATION REDUCTIONS AS WE'VE
SEEN OVER TIME. BY TO ENSURE
THAT WE DO NOT INCREASE
POPULATION THROUGH RECIDIVISM
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF MEASURES
IN HERE AROUND THEIR CREDITS
AND VARIOUS THINGS LIKE THAT.
THANK YOU SO SKINNER SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MAY CHAIR
AND I WANT TO THIS MEASURE HERE
AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM TEAM CAME UP
BECAUSE I THINK HE'S JUSTIFY
WHY THIS IS IMPORTANT WE DID
FORTY YEARS OF TOUGH ON CRIME
ANY MAKES ARGUMENT THAT CRIME
IS UP EVEN THOUGH IT'S NOT. IF
CRIME IS UP AND WE'VE HAD FORTY
YEARS OF TOUGH TOUGH ON CRIME
THE WAY WE'VE BEEN DOING IT FOR
THE LAST FOUR YEARS HAS BEEN A
DISMAL FAILURE I WOULD THINK WE
WOULD ALL AGREE SO I THINK IT'S
TIME FOR RESET WE HAVE BUILT
MORE PRISONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE HAVE BUILT.
UNIVERSITIES AGAIN WE
INCARCERATE MORE PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA MORE PEOPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES IN ANY OTHER
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD YET YOU
SAY WERE NO SAFER SO WHY WOULD
WE WANT TO REASSESS HOW IT IS
THAT WE ADDRESS CRIMINAL
JUSTICE HERE IN THE STATE HOW
DO WE DRESS CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN
THIS NATION. THE CLOSURE
PRISONS IT SHOULD BE A PRIORITY
FOR EACH AND EVERYONE OF US
INCARCERATING PEOPLE DOES NOT
REDUCE CRIME ESPECIALLY WHEN
THE MAJORITY OF FOLKS WHO'VE
BEEN INCARCERATED ARE BLACK
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE AGAIN
WHO HAVE BEEN OVER CHARGE MANY
TIMES FALSELY ACCUSED. AND
FALSELY PROSECUTE. AND REALITY.
SO I THINK YOU MADE A GREAT
ARGUMENT WHY WE SHOULD TAKE
ANOTHER APPROACH I THINK THIS
BILL IS THE RIGHT MEASURE AT
THE RIGHT TIME AND I US RIVAL.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DEBATER
DISCUSSION CHINGAND HEARING
NONE SENATOR MITCHELL YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT AND I I'M I'M GOING
APOLOGIZE TO YOU UP FRONT
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT YOU- FAST
AT LEAST FOCUS OUR COMMENTS ON
THE BILL AT HAND BUT I. FEEL AN
OBLIGATION TO RESPOND TO MY
BUDGET COMMITTEE VICE CHAIR.
CAN I RESPOND BY SAYING THIS. I
APPRECIATE THE VICE CHAIR
STANDING WITH ME HE'S ALWAYS
THERE FOR THE LONG HOURS WE
HAVE THESE COMMITTEES AND NEVER
WAVERS I APPRECIATE THE
PARTNERSHIP AND I WILL HAVE TO
SAY THAT OUR COLLEAGUE FOR TO
HAMMER A FEW IF NOTHING ELSE
HE'S CONSISTENT. AND
CONSISTENTLY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
TO HIM EVERY YEAR WHETHER WE
HAVE ONE MONTH OF THE
DELIBERATE THE BUDGET OR SIX
MONTHS. HE'S CONSISTENT. I HAVE
TO REMIND US ALL. WE MAKE UP
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
AND SO PEOPLE ARE FEELING YOU
KNOW AS THE KIDS SAY SOME KIND
OF WAY ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
NO LONGER ENGAGE IN A
DELIBERATE TO PROCESS THEN WE
SHOULD DELIBERATE. IT'S UP TO
US. I HAPPEN TO SERVE ON BOTH
PUBLIC SAFETY ENSURE THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND SPEND HOURS UPON
HOURS NOT ONLY IN COMMITTEE.
PREPARING MYSELF FOR
DELIBERATION THESE BUDGET
TRAILER BILLS HAVE BEEN
AVAILABLE ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WEBSITE SINCE MAY WITH
KNOWLEDGE THAT LAST NIGHT WITH
MY COMMITTEE MEMBER SAID WELL
YOU KNOW HE DIDN'T SPEND HIS
LEISURE TIME PERUSING THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A WEBSITE
SO HE WASN'T AWARE WILL OF THE
YOU'RE GOING TO BE A BUDGET
COMMITTEE MEMBER THAT'S ERHAPS
WHAT WE SHOULD DO. THIS WAS A
INTER NATIONAL PANDEMIC. AND WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE LUXURY TO SAY
WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO READ IT
ALL AND CATCH UP TO EFFECTUATE
A BUDGET WE DON'T HAVE THAT
LUXURY. FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ARE COUNTING ON US
TO FIGURE IT OUT. TO DO
WHATEVER YOU NEED TO DO TO READ
AND PREPARE AND CAST VOTES THAT
YOU BELIEVE ARE IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THE RESIDENTS YOU.
REPRESENT SO THAT SHOULD BE THE
FOCUS OF OUR DELIBERATION AND
IF THERE IS A- REAL BELIEVE.
THAT THE DELIBERATIONS OF THIS
BODY ENGAGES IN AREN'T ADEQUATE
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE SPENT SOME
TIME DURING IN A ROOM. HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEIR
RESPECTIVE LEADERSHIP ABOUT
WHAT WE'RE WILLING TO DO AS
INDIVIDUALS TO PUT OUR SHOULDER
TO THE TO THE CORNERSTONE TO DO
BETTER. I'LL BE THE FIRST ONE
IN LINE TO STAND UP TO SAY I
STAND WITH YOU. AND I THINK I
EXIT BUT THAT EVERY DAY AS MY
CHAIR WOMAN SHOULD WITH THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE I SERVE ON. AND I
BELIEVE ALL THOSE OTHERS. I CAN
DO THE SAME. WITH THAT MADAM
PRESIDENT. I WE CLEAR FIVE BUT
IT IS NOT IN THIS TRAILER BILL
ANY REFERENCE TO SCHOOL POLICE-
THAT WAS NOT ACCURATE- I
APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS
MADE BY MEMBERS OF THE
CLARIFICATION BY OUR SUB CHAIR
ABOUT THE NUMBER OF YEARS THAT
THE ISSUE OF A PRISON CULTURES
HAS BEEN DISCUSSED. THE NUMBER
OF YEARS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF THE
PRISON EXPERIENCE THE NUMBER OF
YEARS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT ARE
THE RIGHT PEOPLE IN PRISON THAT
SHOULD BE. NO ONE ON THIS FLOOR
WOULD QUESTION WHETHER NOT
SOMEONE WHO STAB SOMEBODY WITH
A FORK. NEEDS TO SERVE TIME
NOBODY WOULD QUESTION THAT THEY
OBVIOUS THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE
WHO ARE SERVING TIME- BASED ON.
HISTORIC PERCEPTIONS OF WHAT
WAS APPROPRIATE IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE THE FIELD OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE HAS CHANGED BASED ON
EXPERIENCE AND RESEARCH. AND
THE POLICIES BUT BEFORE THIS
BODY HAVE KEPT UP WITH THAT.
THAT'S WHAT A DELIBERATE OF
LEGISLATIVE BODY IS SUPPOSED TO
DO I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
WELL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
BATES NO WELL I FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM. I
CHIANG NO DALLY. NO DODD. HI
THE RAZA HI GALGIANI. HI GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG I HILL HI HUESO TANTO.
NO JACKSON HI HI JONES NO LEYVA
FIVE MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ NO
MITCHELL. I MONEY FIVE MORE
LOCK NO MORALE NO NIELSEN NO
HAN. I PORTANTINO HI ROTH I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN I
NUMBER NINE I LIKE HOW SKI I
WIENER BY WILK NOW PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. HUESO HI
VICE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS TWELVE
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ALONG
NOW TO FILE ITEM NINETY SIX AB
NINETY. SENATOR MITCHELL. I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE THREE ASSEMBLY
BILL NINETY BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN ACT
RELATING TO TRANSPORTATION AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFOR TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET SENATOR MITCHELL THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- THIS IS
THE TRANSPORTATION TRAILER BILL
WHICH CONTAINS STATUTORY
CHANGES NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
THE BILL DOES THE FOLLOWING THE
PROVIDE STATUTORY RELIEF TO
GIVE TRANSIT AGENCIES THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY COLD BUT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC CERTAIN.
CERTAINTY ABOUT FORMULA DRIVEN
STATE FUNDING LEVELS IT
REQUIRES REPORTING OF
INFORMATION ABOUT THE SALE AND
TAXATION OF AIRCRAFT JET FUEL
CONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL POLICY.
IT DELAYS THE DELIVERY OF THE
FINAL TWENTY TWENTY HIGH SPEED
RAIL BUSINESS PLAN TO DECEMBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY GIVEN THE
LEGISLATURE MORE TIME TO REVIEW
AND WEIGHING IN. AT
APPROPRIATES FUNDS TO ALLOW THE
DMB TO PARTNER WITH THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD FOR HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE INSPECTIONS AND
ENFORCEMENT AS REQUIRED IN
EXISTING LAW. ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL DEBATER DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM SENATOR NIELSEN. BOTH
CENTER NIELSEN IS REQUESTING AN
OVAL ANYONE ELSE WISH TO RAISE
THEIR MIKE XIN DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SEEING AND HEARING
NOT SENATOR DOLLY BACK THERE IN
THE MOONIES THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I JUST WANTED TO- I ASK
THIS QUESTION LAST NIGHT WAS
ANOTHER ONE THAT I ASKED ABOUT
THE HIGH SPEED TRAIN AUTHORITY.
AND THE BUSINESS PLAN I JUST
WANTED TO LET THE MEMBERS KNOW
THAT- THERE IS A PLAN TAT IS
NOT GONNA BE FORD UNTIL MARCH
OF NEXT YEAR. AND THEIR THIRTY
YEAR CONTRACTS OR COME DO I
THINK THAT- I NEVER GOT BUT
THEY NEVER GOT BACK TO ME I ASK
IF THEY WOULD GET BACK TO ME.
ON IF THE PLAN THE CONTRACT
WOULD NOT BE THAT TELL THE PLAN
WAS OUT AND SO. I JUST WANT TO
LET THE MEMBERS KNOW THAT WE
SHOULD BE WATCHING THAT. THIS
IS A LONG TERM CONTRACT. IN MY
MIND. AN EIGHTY BILLION DOLLAR
PROJECT THAT WILL NEVER
COMPLETELY BE FUNDED. AND SO
WHAT WE NEED TO HAVE THAT PLAN
BEFORE WE- LET THOSE THIRTY
YEAR CONTRACTS FOR THOSE
REASONS I WILL BE. VOTING NO ON
THIS BILL. SENATOR GROW. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT COMING FROM
THE CENTRAL VALLEY I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL IT
ACTUALLY HOW ALLOWS A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY TO
GO BACK TO THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
IF WE WERE REALLY SERIOUS ABOUT
CUTTING THE BUDGET IN MEETING
THESE BUDGET DEADLINES WE WOULD
REMOVE ALL FUNDING FROM THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY. THAT
TO PROCESS THAT WAS STARTED
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
WE WERE ALSO SB RIGHT NOW HIGH
SPEED TRAIN TO KNOW WHERE AT
THIS TIME IN OUR LIFE AND IT
DOES NOT EXIST THE MATTER OF
FACT THERE ARE HUGE GAPS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHERE THEY
HAVING THEM BUILD SECURE THE
LAND YET SO I'M ASSUMING THAT
FOR THOSE OUR PREDECESSORS OUR
OUR OUR THINGS THAT CAN. US IN
THIS BODY TWENTY YEARS FROM NOW
THEY WILL. BE FUNDING. THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL. TO KNOW WHERE
THAT'S MY PREDICTION. AND THIS
IS A VERY COSTLY AN EXPENSIVE
PROJECT. IT IS NOT SUCCESSFUL
IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR FORM IT HAS
NOT MET ANY OF THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE ORIGINAL PROP UP
ROPOSITION ONE IN TWO THOUSAND
AND- EIGHT. AND SO I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER GROVE ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING ND HEARING
NONE SENATOR MITCHELL YOU MAY
CLOSE I DON'T PLEASE. ALL
DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES NO BELL FIVE GORGEOUS NO
BRADFORD HI CABRERA I CHIANG NO
DALLY. NO DODD HI THERE ARE SO.
I GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ
I GROWTH NO HERTZBERG. I HILL
AYE HUESO. HI TADO I JACKSON HI
I JONES NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL. I
MONNING. I MORE LOCK NO MORALE
NO NIELSEN NO HAN HI PORTANTINO
HI ROSS. I RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN I NUMBER HI MY CAO SKI
AYE WIENER. HI WILK NOW PRICE
TWENTY NINE KNOWS ELEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ALONG NOW
FILE ITEM NINETY SEVEN AB
NINETY TWO SENATOR MITCHELL
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY TWO BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND ACTUALLY IN THE PUBLIC
RESOURCES AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET SENATOR MITCHELL
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT OF
COLLEAGUES THIS IS THE
RESOURCES TRAILER BILL OF THE
BILL DOES THE FOLLOWING IT
ESTABLISHES THE GOOD NEIGHBOR
AUTHORITY FUND TO FACILITATE
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF FOREST
MANAGEMENT PROJECTS.ON FEDERAL
LANDS THAT ESTABLISHES A NEW
FEE OF THIRTY TO SUPPORT
ASSOCIATED PROGRAM COSTS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION IMPLEMENTATION
AND ENFORCEMENT OF PROP TWELVE
WHICH IMPOSES MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS ON FARMERS TO
PROVIDE MORE SPACE FOR
LIVESTOCK CONFINEMENT. IT
EXTINGUISHES ALL GENERAL
OBLIGATION BONDS THAT ARE NO
LONGER NEEDED IN ORDER TO SAVE
ON ON GOOD ADMINISTRATION OF
MINIMAL REMAINING BALANCES THAT
ARE NOT ENOUGH TO SUPPORT
ANOTHER PROJECT THAT AUTHORIZES
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD TO ISSUE A SORT
OF CERTIFICATE OF STICK OR
STATEMENT WHICH IS REQUIRED
UNDER FEDERAL WATER QUALITY
CONTROL LOS BEFORE COMPLETION
OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROCESS AND IT INCLUDES OTHER
CHANGES TO IMPLEMENT THE BUDGET
ACT ASKING FOR NOT. THANK
MITCHELL BETA. SENATOR GROW
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR NELSON
THANK YOU MADAM HIGHER IS IN
OFFICE OF HAD NINE TWO OR AB
TWO- BOTH I GUESS BOTH BILL
NUMBERS WOULD APPLY THIS
INCLUDES A PROPOSAL TO ALLOW
THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
CURTAIL FEDERAL REGULATIONS
RELATED TO THE CLEAN WATER ACT.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER ASSAULT ON
OUR WATER SO FOR. CAL IS
BLESSED TO BE ABLE HAVE THE TOP
THREE FOOD PRODUCING COUNTIES
IN THE NATION. WHEN I SAY IN
THE NATION THERE IS NO JOKE IN
FACT OVER THAT IN THIS NATION
OVER A THIRD OF THE VEGETABLES
PRODUCED IN THE ENTIRE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. ARE PRODUCED
IN FRESNO KERN AND TULARE
COUNTIES. WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
NATION'S BEST STONE FRUIT
CITRUS FRUITS CUTIES HALOS-
PEACHES ANY TYPE OF STONE FRUIT
OR CITRUS FRUIT AND NETS GROWN
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
ACTUALLY PRODUCE 99% OF THOSE
PRODUCTS ARE COMMODITIES. 99%
SO WHEN YOU THINK OF THE IMPACT
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS ON FOOD
SECURITY AND THE WORLD'S FOOD
SUPPLY. IT'S VERY VERY
IMPACTFUL WE'RE THE SOLE
PRODUCER OF THE COUNTIES FOODS
AT THE COUNTRY'S FOODS LIKE
ALMONDS ARTICHOKES ALL IS WELL
LET'S PISTACHIOS RICE GARLIC IN
MORE. WE PRODUCE 99% OF THE
NATION'S SUPPLY OF THOSE FOOD
PRODUCTS THAT I JUST IN-
MENTIONED. FOOD SECURITY FOR
FAMILIES DEPENDS ON THE ABILITY
FOR CALIFORNIA FARMERS TO
CONTINUE TO PRODUCE FOOD. THIS
IS NOT JUST ABOUT JOBS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THAT IS DEBATED
ALL THE TIME WHEN THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY ESPECIALLY THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE ATTACKS
ARE FOOD PRODUCTION FARMERS.
THIS IS ABOUT FOOD SECURITY FOR
THE NATION AND PARTS OF THE
WORLD. WELL THE PRINT WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION HAVE
PRIORITIZING FOOD SECURITY IN
THE LONG RUN STATE LEADERSHIP
IN CURRENT IN RECENT PASSED IN
THIS BODY HAS CONTINUALLY.
ATTACKED FARMERS AND FOOD
SECURITY FOR OUR NATION AND
PART OF THE WORLD. AN ATTACK ON
FARMERS IS AN ATTACK ON OUR
FOOD SUPPLY. THE ASSAULT ON OUR
FARMERS HAS GOT TO STOP AGAIN
THIS IS MORE THAN JOBS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. THIS IS ABOUT
PRODUCING A TREMENDOUS NUMBER
OF PRODUCTS OR COMMODITIES IN
THE FARMING WORLD COMMODITIES
THAT ARE PRODUCED IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WITH THE TOP
THREE FOOD PRODUCING COUNTIES
IN THE NATION. THIS BODY THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE HAS THE
ABILITY TO DISTRACT THE
NATION'S FOOD SUPPLY WITH BILLS
LIKE THIS. THE CREE TAIL WATER
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AND
IT'S BEYOND ME WHY THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT STEPPED
IN TO STOP. THIS BODY FOR
STRICTLYIN THE NATION'S FOOD
SUPPLY FROM PEOPLE AND CREATING
FOOD AND SECURITY ESPECIALLY
FOR THE COLBERT SITUATION WHICH
WE FIND OURSELVES IN WHERE
PEOPLE WERE WORRIED ABOUT GOING
TO THE GROCERY STORES. TO MAKE
SURE THEY AND FOOD FOR THEIR
FAMILY. CALIFORNIA PRODUCES THE
FOOD THAT CREATES FOOD SECURITY
AND BILLS LIKE THIS WILL STOP
THAT FOOD SECURITY FROM GOING
TO OUR GROCERY STORES AND I
DESPERATELY URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR KNEELS. MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND OF THE
CENTER I DO URGE THE NO VOTE ON
THIS AGAIN. IT'S A PART OF A
CONTINUING TREND. WHERE IN THE
END MINISTRATIONS FOR ALL IN
THE LEGISLATURE'S PEARL HAVE
ACCORDED MORE AND MORE POWER
AND AUTHORITY TO AGENCIES OF
STATE GOVERNMENT IN THIS CASE
AN EXAMPLE BEING THE WATER
BOARD. MORE POWER. TO CONTROL
OUR LIVES MORE POWER TO IN
EFFECT TAX THROUGH LEVYING FEES
AND BROADENING THE APPLICATION
OF THOSE FEES. TIME AND AGAIN
WE HAVE FOUND OUT WHEN WE
CHALLENGE. THE AGENCIES PEARL
DIXIE THEIR STATUTORY AUTHORITY.
AND THE FACT THROUGH FIAT OR
MEMO OR DEAL LAND DEPARTMENT
OPERATIONAL MEMEL. DAVE AFFECT
POLICY WHICH IN EFFECT
LEGISLATION. UNLESS IT IS
LITIGATED THEN IT STANDS.
SOMETHING WAS CREATED HERE MANY
YEARS AGO I WAS A PART OF THAT
WITH THE SPEAKER AT THE TIME
LEO MCCARTHY THE ADMINISTRATORS
PROCEDURES ACT. WHICH ENSURED
THAT AGENCIES COULDN'T JUST
**** NILLY IMPOSE OUR WILL UPON
THE PEOPLE THAT THERE HAD TO BE
A PROCESS PROMULGATING POLICY
IN IMPLEMENTING POLICY. THROUGH
THE ADMINISTRATIVE FOR TO
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES.
WHICH DID ALLOW PUBLIC INPUT.
VERY LITTLE PUBLIC INPUT. THESE
AGENCIES THESE DAYS. ARGUE WHAT
YOU WILL ABOUT THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION. IN THESE MANY
AREAS THAT MY COLLEAGUE
BAKERSFIELD AS MENTIONED. HAS
TAKEN THE LEAD IN ASSERTING
FEDERAL AUTHORITY. OVER THE
EXCEEDING OF STORY L. STATE
AGENCIES. THAT'S A GENERAL
OBSERVATION BUT IT IS
ABSOLUTELY APPLICABLE. TO THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE AT HAND. THE
PART OF THIS DOES RELATE TO
SOMETHING THAT PASSED YOUR
SEVERAL YEARS AGO THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT LEGISLATION. NOW
THAT SEVERAL LAW AND I'M NOT
ARGUING ABOUT THAT NOW. EXCEPT
THAT IT'S IMPOSED CERTAIN
CONDITIONS. ON A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND OUR OWN
ABILITIES. THAT HAVE AFFECTED
NOT ONLY AGRICULTURAL PUMPING
OF GROUNDWATER. BUT INDUSTRIAL
AND MUNICIPAL AS WELL. AND THE
AUTHORITY THAT EVEN THERE'S
EXPANDED HERE TO THE WATER
BOARD. MORE. ONLY GIVES THOSE
AGENCIES MORE POWER. AND WHO
KNOWS REALLY WHAT GOES ON
WITHIN THEM EVEN SOMEONE WHO IS
PRETTY FOR STUDIOUSLY WATCHING
WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND PUTTING
THEM AND HAVING SOME
OPPORTUNITY FRANKLY AT WHICH I
APPRECIATE TO IMPORT THOSE
BOARDS. BUT THE AVERAGE CITIZEN
DOES NOT. THEY HAVE TO. DEAL
WITH THE AGENCIES. AND THE
STRONG ARM TACTICS THAT
SOMETIMES ATTEND THOSE. I WOULD
URGE A NO VOTE. BECAUSE THIS IS
ANOTHER. INCREMENTAL STEPS IN
ACCORDING MORE AUTHORITY AND
POWER. THE WATER BOARD. SENATOR
KIRBY ERROL FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
WAY CASKEY. THANK YOU MADAM.
PRESIDENT WE COULD SPEND ALL
NIGHT HERE ARGUING ABOUT WATER.
THERE'S SO MUCH TO FIND OUT
ABOUT WATER BUT I WON'T DO THAT
LET ME BE REALLY BRIEF FIRST I
WANT TO THANK. THE CHAIR THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE FOR DOING AN
EXEMPLARY JOB OF GETTING US
THROUGH THIS BUDGET. IN THE
SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME THAT WE
HAD SHE'S DONE A TREMENDOUS
JOB. BUT THIS PARTICULAR-
TRAILER BILL. HAS ADDITION THAT
IS GOING TO DEEPLY IMPACT. THE
MERCED IRRIGATION DISTRICT AND
IT'S INTERESTING AND I WILL BE
VOTING NO ON THIS TRAILER BILL
BECAUSE WHAT THIS. PROVISION IN
THE BILL DOES IS IT AUTHORIZES
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOAR. TO ISSUE A
CERTIFICATE. THAT IS REQUIRED
UNDER FEDERAL LAW. BEFORE THE
COMPLETION OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
REPORT AND I WANT TO SAY THAT
AGAIN BECAUSE WHAT IT DOES IS
IT GIVES THEM THE ABILITY TO
VIOLATE THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT. AND
TO ISSUE A CERTIFICATE BEFORE
THAT THAT- REVIEW IS FINISHED
AND- AND THAT ACT. TREMENDOUSLY
IMPACTS WHAT THE MERCED
IRRIGATION DISTRICT IS WORKING
TOWARDS WHICH IS A FEDERAL THE
FEDERAL RELICENSING. OF THEIR
POWER SYSTEM A HYDRO ENERGY
POWER SYSTEM THAT THEY HAVE
OPERATED FOR OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS SO. TO TAKE THIS KIND OF
ACTION THAT. IS HAS IT DID
DELETERIOUS IMPACT ON A MAJOR
ENERGY PER. IN MY REGION-
FORCES ME TO VOTE NO ON THIS SO
I IT'S WITH DEEP REGRET THAT I
DO THAT I THINK THERE IS THE
ABILITY FOR US TO WORK OUT OUR
WATER ISSUES INVOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS BUT IT'S GOING TO
IT'S GOING TO TAKE EVERYBODY
COMING TO THE TABLE AND WORKING
IT OUT. SENATOR Y. CASKEY THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I WILL TRY
TO BE HELPFUL HERE ON FEDERAL
AUTHORITY AND HOW THIS FOR OVER
FOUR OH ONE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS WORKS. THE LANGUAGE IS
IN THIS TRAILER BILL SIMPLY
PRESERVES THE STATE'S RIGHT TO
REQUIRE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW OF
HYDRO ELECTRIC PROJECTS PRIOR
TO THESE PROJECTS BEING LICENSE
OR RE LICENSE FOR FORTY TO
FIFTY YEARS. THIS BILL DOES NOT
CREATE ANY NEW MANDATES IT'S
SIMPLY PRESERVES THE STATE
CALIFORNIA'S WRITES THAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
ATTEMPTING TO TAKE AWAY AT THIS
MOMENT. THE FEDERAL ENERGY
REGULATORY COMMISSION WHICH
FOR. HAS THE AUTHORITY UNDER
THE FEDERAL POWER ACT TO LEASE.
HYDROELECTRIC POWER PROJECTS
LOCATED ON NAVIGABLE WATERWAYS
OR FEDERAL LANDS WERE CONNECTED
TO THE INTERSTATE ELECTRIC GRID
THESE STAMPS GREATLYIMPACT
CALIFORNIA'S RIVERS AND
WATERWAYS. SECTION FOR A ONE OF
THE CLEAN WATER ACT PROVIDES
THE MECHANISM TO REQUIRE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW OF THE
STADIUMS TO COMPLY WITH THE
STATE'S WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD'S PROTECTIVE WATER
QUALITY REQUIREMENTS MANY FOR
LICENSES MADAM PRESIDENT. NOW
IN EFFECT FOR HYDROELECTRIC
DAMS IN CALIFORNIA WILL GRANTED
PRIOR TO THE ADOPTION OF THE
CLEAN WATER ACT IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO SECTION FOR A ONE
WATER QUALITY CERTIFICATIONS
OFFERS A ONCE IN A GENERATION
OPPORTUNITY. TO REVIEW THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT OF THESE
PROJECTS SINCE PERKS LICENSES
RUN THIRTY TO FIFTY YEARS.
TODAY THERE ARE MULTIPLE NEW
FOR LICENSES PENDING IN
CALIFORNIA AGENCIES OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ARE
ATTACKING CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY
TO ISSUE OR DENY SECTION FOR A
ONE WATER CALL THE
CERTIFICATIONS IF THESE FEDERAL
EFFORTS ARE SUCCESSFUL
CALIFORNIA WILL BE EXCLUDED
FROM ENSURING THAT DAMS WITH
WIDE REACHING IMPACTS AND RIVER
HEALTH. MEET STATE WATER
QUALITY STANDARDS WHEN THEY'RE
READ LICENSE IN THE PAST YEARS.
FOR HAVING COURAGE IN THE FACT
THAT THE PRACTICE OF WHICH
ROWING AND RE SUBMITTING
APPLICATIONS FOR CERTIFICATION
PRIOR TO THE EXPIRATION OF THE
ONE YEAR DEADLINE. THIS
PREVENTED THE SITUATION WITH
THE STATES WITH HAVE TO DENY
CERTIFICATION FOR LACK OF
INFORMATION AND SUPPORTING
DOCUMENTATION THE STROKE THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HOWEVER
HAS PROPOSED NEW RULES REQUIRE
REGARDING THE CLEAN WATER ACT
SECTION FOUR ONE THAT WOULD
DRASTICALLY RULE BACK TO
SCHOOL. OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
WATER BOARDS. OF FORTY. THREE
WAVING. AT THE WERE TO OVERSEE
AND WATER CALLED FOR THESE THE
IS NO LONGER IN FEAR. IT REAL
AND IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
LAST WEEK FOR FOUND THE STATE
HAD WAVE WATER CERTIFICATION
AUTHORITY FOR THE- OR SAID
PROJECT LIKE MY COLLEAGUE HAS
INDICATED THE STATE WATER BOARD
HAS BEEN UNABLE TO PROCESS THE
APPLICATION BECAUSE MERCED
IRRIGATION DISTRICT HAD NOT
PREPARED. OR YOU CAN COMMENCE
THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT REVIEW AS THE
SEQUEL LEAD AGENCY OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS THERE'S
GOING TO BE SEVEN. OTHER
PROJECTS IN A SIMILAR SITUATION
AN EXTRA EUROPE OR P. JEANNIE
PROJECTS. THAT IS THE TYPE OF
PROBLEM THIS TRAILER BILL
ADDRESSES ITS SPECIFICALLY THE
TRAILER BILL WOULD ENSURE THE
STATE CAN CONTINUE TO REQUIRE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AND
CONDITIONS TO PROTECT THEIR OWN
WHAT DOWNSTREAM WATER USES
INCLUDING AGRICULTURAL IN
MUNICIPAL SUPPLIES RECREATIONAL
BOATERS. AND EVEN NATIVE
FISHERIES AND OTHERS AS A STATE
WE HAVE FOUGHT AGAINST
EGREGIOUS ROLL BACKS OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S ASSAULT
ON STATE PROTECTIONS IF WE FAIL
TO ADDRESS THIS ROLLBACK THE
STATE WILL LOSE ITS AUTHORITY
OVER THESE PROJECTS FOR THE
NEXT. FORTY OR FIFTY YEARS.
MADAM PRESIDENT. I'D LIKE TO
TURN OUR ATTENTION TO SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT IN AB ARE NINETY TWO
WHICH IS ON THE FLOOR. THE
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PROPOSAL THE
SO CALLED TWO WAY DEAL
ORIGINALLY INCLUDED A
REQUIREMENT THAT THE AIR
RESOURCE BOARDS TO RULE MAKING
TO CONSIDER CHANGES TO THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM. THAT
PROPOSED RULE MAKING HAS BEEN
WITHDRAWN. INSTEAD THE NEW SOME
ADMINISTRATION AND CAL EPA
SECRETARY HAVE MADE A
COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH THIS
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE LEADERSHIP
THRIVES DURING THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES AND BEYOND.
ON THE FLOOR TODAY I WOULD LIKE
TO FORMALLY RECOGNIZE A LETTER
AND COMMITMENTS MADE BY THE
NEWSMEN MINISTRATION AND THE
TELL THE PA SECRETARY THE NEW
SOME ADMINISTRATION AND- KILL
THE PECE SECRETARY HAS MADE
THE COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH THE
AIR. RESOURCE BOARD TO EXAMINE
THE PROGRAMS ROLE IN
CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY THIRTY
CLIMATE STRATEGIES IS PART OF
THE BROADER TWENTY TWENTY TWO
SCOPING PLAN PROCESS. THE CAL
THE P. SECRETARY HAS MADE A
COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH THE
INDEPENDENT AIR RESOURCE BOARD
LEADERSHIP TO ENSURE A
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW AND
CONSIDERATION OF THE FOLLOWING.
THE EXTENT TO WHICH THE
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE STRATEGY
YOU SHOULD RELY ON THE CAP AND
TRADE RELATIVE TO OTHER
APPROACHES TO REDUCING
EMISSIONS AND VALUE EVALUATION
OF POTENTIAL CHANGES TO THE CAP
ENTRY PROGRAM THAT MAY BE
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS OUR LONG
TERM ECONOMIC. IN THE MISSION A
PROJECTIONS AS WELL AS AN
IDENTIFICATION OF AREAS WERE
NEW LEGISLATION COULD FURTHER A
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION. OF
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE STRATEGY.
WE THAT WITH THIS COMMITMENT
FROM THE NEWS MINISTRATION AND
KILL PEOPLE EPA I WOULD URGE
EVERYONE SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE SENATOR MITCHELL YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU- ARE ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR MITCH
CLOSE WITH A REQUEST FOR AN HI.
MADAM CHECKER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THANK YOU MISTER. ALLEN HI
HI ARCHULETA. I ATKINS I BATES
NO WELL. I FORGES NO BRADFORD I
HAVE A YELLOW. NO CHIANG. NO
DALLY. NO DODD. I RAZA HI
GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ HI
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG. HELLO. HI
HUESO ARE HI- TADO. NO JACKSON
I JONES NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL AYE AYE
MONNING I MORE LOCK. NO MORALE
NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH I RUBIO. I
SKINNER HI STERN HI AMBER HI MY
CASTING AYE WIENER I WILK NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
HERTZBERG I. ALL EYES TWENTY
SEVEN KNOWS THIRTEEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON NOW TO
FILE ITEM NINETY EIGHT. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL NINETY THREE BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN
ACT RELATING TO TAXATION AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
DID YOU SEE MAKE SURE YOU SPEAK
INTO THE MIKE GUY WAS STALLING
YES I HAD TO GET MY PAPER- THE
BINDER AND- VERY GOOD.
COLLEAGUES A. B. NINETY THREE
IS THE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
TRAILER BILL ASSOCIATED WITH
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
THIS BILL MAKES TECHNICAL AND
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES.
SPECIFICALLY IT EXPANDS THE I.
T. C. AND THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT ELIGIBILITY. TO
INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER FILERS
WITH AT LEAST ONE CHILD UNDER
THE AGE OF SIX. AND SPECIFY THE
CHILDREN SIX AND OVER WOULD
COUNT AS A QUALIFYING CHILDREN
AS LONG AS THE FAMILY HAS AT
LEAST ONE CHILD UNDER SIX. THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT STEP IN
ENSURING THAT ALL WORKING
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
ELIGIBLE. FOR THE E. I. T. C.
IN THAT CHILDREN ARE NOT
TREATED DIFFERENTLY. BASED ON
THE FILING STATUS OF THEIR
PARENTS. I ASKED FOR AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
DEBATER DISCUSSION SENATOR
KNEELS. MADAM PRESIDENT LATER
DOWN THE SENATE ARGENEAU VOTE
ON THIS. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DEBATE DISCUSS. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE SENATOR MITCHELL
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I THINK THERE WAS SOME
DISCUSSION ON THE FLOOR TODAY
WHETHER WE STILL HAVE THE
DUBIOUS HONOR OF BEING THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD WHETHER WE ARE ARE AREN'T
WE HAVE FAR TOO MANY OF
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN LIVING IN
POVERTY AND LIVING IN DEEP
POVERTY AND EXPANDING THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT ALLOWS
FAMILIES TO CARE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN IN A MEANINGFUL WAY.
I'M ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL
DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
BATES NO WELL I FORGES NO
BRADFORD. HI CAN I CHIANG.
SALLY NO DODD. BY THE RISING.
HI GALGIANI. I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO HERTZBERG
I HILL HI WITH SO. HI TADO. I
JACKSON AYE JONES NO LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL
HI I MONNING I MORE LOOK NO
MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO HAN HI
PORTANTINO. HI ROSS HI RUBIO. I
SKINNER I STERN. HI I'M BURKE
HI MY CAO SKI ON AYE WIENER. HI
WILL. NO OVER THERE HE'S CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BEING TEST
CHIANG. OUR EYES TWENTY NINE
PEOPLE CLOSE TEN THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON NOW TO FILE
ITEM ONE HUNDRED AB ONE HUNDRED.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE HUNDRED BY
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AN ACT RELATING TO STATE
GOVERNMENT AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET SENATOR MITCH I'M
READY THIS TIME IN A PRESIDENT
AB ONE HUNDRED IS THE GENERAL
GOVERNMENT BUDGET TRAILER BILL
THE BILL MAKES TECHNICAL
STATUTORY CHANGES TO IMPLEMENT
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
FOR GENERAL GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS THE STATE
ADMINISTRATION. THE BILL ALLOWS
LEFTOVER FUNDS FOR COUNTIES TO
REPLACE VOTING SYSTEMS TO BE
USED FOR THE NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ELECTION IT MAKES
STATUTORY CHANGES TO TRANSFER
THE SEISMIC SAFETY COMMISSION
TO THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES I'M ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. YEAH THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL DEBATER DISCUSS ON THE
ITEM SHE AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES I TELL FIVE FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I HAVE A OTHER HI
CHIANG I VALLEY FIVE DODD. I
DORADO HI GALGIANI I GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I HERTZBERG
I HILL I WISH SO. I TADO HI
JACKSON WHILE I JONES I LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S HI
MITCHELL HI I MONNING I MORE
LOCK I MERLE. I NIELSEN AYE PAN
I PORTANTINO HI ROSS I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN HI I'M BURKE I
WAY CASKEY I WIENER HI WILK. HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GORGEOUS AYE AYES FORTY KNOWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ALONG NOW TO FILE ITEM ONE NO
ONE AB ONE OH TWO. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE OH TWO BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN ACT
RELATING TO RETIREMENT SAVINGS
IN MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET SENATOR MITCHELL THANK
YOU AB ONE ALL TO IS THE CAL
SAVERS TRAILER BILL ASSOCIATE
WITH THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY THIS BILL MAKES
TECHNICAL AND SUBSTANTIVE
CHANGES IT WILL TRANSITION
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY FOR THE
CALIPHATE WHICH PROGRAM FROM
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT TO THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD. IT ALSO ALLOWS CANNABIS
REGULATORY AGENCIES TO SHARE
DATA WITH CAL SABRES FOR
PURPOSES OF ADMINISTERING THE
CALIPHATE WAS PROGRAM THAT
MAKES OTHER TECHNICAL AND CLEAN
UP CHANGES ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. DEBATE OR DISCUSSION IS
THERE ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES NO
BELL I BORDERS NO BRADFORD I
HAVE A OTHER. I CHIANG NO DALLY
NO DODD. I DRAWS OVER I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG I HILL.
HI HUESO I TADO FIVE JACKSON HI
I JONES NO LEYVA. I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL HI I
MONEY HI MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN NO HAN FIVE
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO. I
SKINNER I STERN HI I'M BURKE HI
LAKE COUNTY AYE WIENER HI WILK.
NOW ALL EYES TWENTY NINE KNOWS
ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK NOW TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY
THREE. WHICH IS AB SEVENTY FIVE
ALSO A TRAILER BILL FILE ITEM
EIGHTY THREE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY FIVE BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
ACTUALLY INTO THE STATE BUDGET
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. BUDGET BELL
SENATOR MITCHELL THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AB SEVENTY FIVE IS
THE CURRENT YEAR SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROPRIATIONS BILL. THIS BILL
APPROPRIATE A HUNDRED NINETEEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND TO UNDRESS
UNANTICIPATED COSTS INCURRED BY
NUMBER STATE DEPARTMENTS IN THE
CURRENT BUDGET YEAR.
SPECIFICALLY THERE IS FOUR
POINT EIGHT MILLION FOR
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT BETWEEN
CAL FIRE AND BARGAINING UNIT
EIGHT FOR OVERTIME
COMPENSATION. NINE POINT SEVEN
MILLION WILL REIMBURSE CDC ARE
FOR THE COSTS OF REMEDIATED AN
OUTBREAK OF LEGIONNAIRE'S
DISEASE AT THE HEALTH CARE
FACILITY IN STOCKTON. TO
ADDRESS COVERT NINETEEN BECAUSE
REVENUE SHORTFALL THAT STATE
AFFILIATE FAIRS THERE IS FORTY
POINT THREE MILLION TO COVER
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION WHILE THE
FARES UPDATE THEIR FINANCIAL
PLANS AND CONDUCT NECESSARY
LAYOFFS. THIS FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION TO COVER THE COSTS OF
ACTIVATED IN SUPPORT OF THE
NATIONAL GUARD WHICH ASSISTED
LOCAL AGENCIES IN RESPONDING.
TO CIVIL UNREST EARLIER THIS
MONTH. FINALLY SIXTY POINT SIX
MILLION COVERS EXPENSES
INCURRED Y NUMBER OF
DEPARTMENTS THAT HAD TO RESPOND
TO WILDFIRES AND PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFFS I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE. DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM SENATOR NIELSEN.
MADAM COLLEAGUES I URGE AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS THIS IS A NORMAL
AND TRADITIONAL AND WELL
REVIEWED PROVISION THAT WE PASS
EVERY YEAR. TO COVER OUR
OBLIGATIONS OF ORIGIN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR JONES AS A I
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT AND JUST
WANT TO GIVE A QUICK THANKS A
PUBLIC THANKS TO THE NATIONAL
GUARD WHO WAS I CALLED OUT- FOR
SHORT TIME INTO MY DISTRICT TO
HANDLE SOME THE CIVIL UNREST
AND THEY DID A GREAT JOB AND I-
WILL BE SUPPORTING AB SEVENTY
FIVE. SENATOR GROWTH. MADAM
PRESIDENT I TO HAS STAND TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I
APPRECIATE THE- FUNDING OF THE
NATIONAL GUARD THAT CAME OUT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE ALL
SAFE- IT WAS PRETTY SCARY
DRIVING AWAY FROM THE CAPITOL
IN C. IN TRUCKLOADS OF AMEND
LOAD BUT I APPRECIATE THEM
BEING HERE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WERE SAFE HERE AT THE CAPITOL I
ALSO WANT TO THINK THE- BUDGET
CHAIR FOR MAKING SURE THAT THE
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS-
ADVOCATED BY A FAITH IN THE IN
A SEIZE IN AC THE NATIONAL
ASIAN AMERICAN COALITION- FOR
THE HOUSING ISSUE THAT WAS
ADDRESSED IN A COURT CASE- I'D
LIKE TO THINK THE BUDGET YOU'RE
FOR MAKING SURE THAT THAT MAN.
WAS OF INTO INFRASTRUCTURE
PROCESS SO THAT THAT MONEY
COULD BE RIGHTFULLY RETURN TO
THE HOMEOWNERS AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT HAPPENS AND SO I REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS BUDGET
TRAILER BILL IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM. SITTING IN HERE NONE
SENATOR MITCHELL YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO THE
LOOKS LIKE WE'RE HAVING A LOVE
FEST ON THIS ONE ANY OBJECTION
TO SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL THE NATIONAL GUARD
SEEING AND HEARING NONE AYE
AYES FORTY NO ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSAGE. MOVING RIGHT ALONG.
FILE ITEM NINETY THREE OUR
PERHAPS SINCE THE LATE HOUR OR
MAYBE WE ARE ALL NO NO I MEAN
TOGETHER BUT IT'S A THANK YOU
ALL FOR THAT TOTALLY LIKE HAVE
NOW FILED NINETY THREE AB
EIGHTY FOUR. MADAM US CHECK
PLEASE RE. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY
FOUR BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUT RELATED
TO THEBUDGET. SENATOR MITCHELL.
MADAM PRESIDENT AB AT FOR THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT
TRAILER BILL AND CONTAIN
STATUTORY CHANGES TO IMPLEMENT
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT.
IT RE PURPOSES THE TWO POINT
THREE BILLION SUPPLEMENTAL
PENSION PAYMENT THAT WAS
PROVIDED IN THE NINETEEN
BUDGET. BACK TO MAKE A
SUPPLANTING PAYMENT ON BEHALF
OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CONTRIBUTION RATES FOR CAL
STARS IN CALPERS. IT RE
PURPOSES THE TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION CALPERS SUPPLEMENTAL
PENSION PAYMENT PROVIDED IN THE
TWENTY NINETY BUDGET ACT. TO
SUPPLANT THE STATE'S TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE AND
TWENTY TWO CALPERS
CONTRIBUTIONS. IT'S THE SPINS
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
SALARY ADJUSTMENTS FOR ONE
YEAR. AND LASTLY THE BILL
ESTABLISHES THE PERSONALLY
PROGRAM TWENTY TWENTY AS
REQUIRED BY APPLICABLE
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING TO
PROVIDE LEAVE CREDITS
ASSOCIATED WITH STATE EMPLOYEE
PAY REDUCTIONS. ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO MITCH
CENTER DRAW WE GONNA GET
ANOTHER UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IN
THIS NOT ON YOUR LIFE MADAM
PRESIDENT. I CAN ALWAYS TRY GO
AHEAD THAT'S OKAY MA'AM. SO
AGAIN I URGE EVERY ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES BUT I REQUEST A VERY
STRONGLY THAT NO REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUE SUPPORT THIS BILL. AB
EIGHTY FOUR REQUIRES A HIGHWAY
PATROL SUBJECT TO PAY
REDUCTIONS THIS IS ANOTHER
CLEAR CASE OF THE POOR
PRIVATIZATION OF THIS CAPITAL.
INSTEAD IS FOURTEEN ARE INSTEAD
OF SUPPORTING OUR INCREDIBLE
HIGHWAY PATROL OFFICERS THE ONE
TO PROTECT THIS BUILDING
PROTECT US PROTECT THE
GOVERNOR. IN BEING SPENT ON
WHILE THEY STOOD ON THIS LINE
OUTSIDE THIS CAPITAL WITH C.
MEANT WATER BOTTLES THROWN AT
THEM. BEING HOSPITALIZED IN
SOME CASES AND TOOK THE
BRUTALITY THAT THEY STUDENT
PROTECTED THIS BUILDING AND ALL
OF US FOR OVER THE PAST FEW
WEEKS BECAUSE OF THE RIOTS IN
THE INDIVIDUALS TRYING TO CAUSE
HARM. AND LITERALLY MAKING
COMMENTS ABOUT COMING IN TO
BURN THIS BUILDING DOWN. THESE
GUYS STOOD ON THAT LINE OUT
THERE AND THEY PROTECTED EACH
ONE OF US. THEY DRIVE AROUND IN
THE PROTECT THE GOVERNOR OF
THIS STATE AND THEY DO
EVERYTHING THAT THEY CAN TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE SAFE HERE
IN THIS CAPITAL AND LAW AND
ORDER IS INSTILLED ON THESE
GROUNDS. THIS BUDGET GETS AWAY
WITH TWO POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR HIGH SPEED. RAIL
WHICH IS GOING NO WHERE. TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR EIGHT FIVE
TO STAY PEOPLE FROM WORK IS IT
THE CARD. FIGHTING DOLLARS FOR
HIS PARK AND POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR BUT SERRA TO SUE%
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION. WE
CAN GET RID OF ALL THAT OTHER
NONSENSE AND MAKE SURE THOSE
MEN AND WOMEN IN BLUE THAT
STAND TO PROTECT THIS BUILDING.
HAVE THEIR PAY RAISES AND THE
PAID THEY ARE ENTITLED TO
INSTEAD OF CUTTING THEIR WAGES
AND SO AGAIN. I KNOW THAT OUR
COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE ARE GOING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE MEN AND WOMEN IN
BLUE THAT PROTECT THIS BUILDING
WILL TAKE THAT PAY CUT. BUT I
AM TELLING EVERYONE OF MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES THIS IS A
NO VOTE BILL. SORRY I MENTIONED
IT SENATOR GROVE. SENATOR
NIELSEN. ALLOW ME LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE NOT A
PRESENT TO FOLLOW UP ON THIS
PARTICULAR ONE. MY OBJECTION IS
SIMILAR TO OUR REPUBLICAN
LEADERS CONCERNED ABOUT THE
RIVER HIGHWAY PATROL. GENERATE
LAWYERS CRITICISMS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THERE'S PETITIONS
AND THE HIGHWAY PATROL DIRECTLY
F YOU SEE A RED LIGHT BEHIND
YOU. BUT I'VE BEEN CLOSE ENOUGH.
TO THE FRONT LINES WITH THESE
INDIVIDUALS. TO KNOW WHAT THEIR
LIVES ARE LIKE. AND HOW
DIFFICULT THEY ARE. AS YOU
DRIVE AROUND CALIFORNIA. HE
REGULARLY WAS SEE SCIENCE WHO
NAMING PORTIONS OF OUR HIGHWAYS.
THE LOST PATROLMAN. BEFORE I
WAS EVEN SWORN IN. TWO HIGHWAY
PATROLMEN. IN THE DISTRICT I
REPRESENTED RIGHT ACROSS THIS
RIVER. WERE MURDERED. THE
DOCTOR NIGHT. BY AN INDIVIDUAL.
TWO YEARS AGO. I GOT UP UNTIL
THE NIGHT AND RED BLUFF AND I'M
LOOKING OUT OVER THE RIVER. I
SEE NO. LIGHTS COMING SOUTH
DOWN ON I FIVE NO EVEN AT TWO
IN THE MORNING THAT'S RATHER
UNUSUAL. THEY WENT BACK TO BED
FORGOT ABOUT IT. UNTIL SEVEN
O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING. WHAT I
FOUND OUT. THE HIGHWAY
PATROLMAN STATIONED IN THIS. BE.
WHOSE HUSBAND OF ONE OF OUR
NATION'S. PULL THE CAR OVER
JUST NORTH OF US. HE GOES TO
THE DRIVER'S SIDE. HERE'S IN.
CHOOSE A WEAPON. HE ASKS. THE
MAN TO GET OUT OF THE CAR WHICH
SHE DOES DUTIFULLY BUT IS IT
DOES SHOW THE DRIVER WHEELS
AROUND. THE CHIU C. OFFICER.
NOW HE BACKS UP AS HE IS
TRAINED TO DO. TO GO BACK TO
HIS CAR. NEXT CALL. THE BACK
WINDOW OF THIS VEHICLE IS
BLACKED OUT. WE CAN'T SEE
ANYTHING. BUT HE KNOWS THE
DRIVERS GOT A GUN AND HE'S
SHOOTING WITH IT. SO HE- SHOOTS
INTO THAT BACK WINDOW. AND THAT
INDIVIDUAL MET JUSTICE VERY
QUICKLY THE OTHER PERPETRATOR
THOUGH IS STILL BUSY.
FORTUNATELY TO RESPONDING
OFFICERS COME UPON THE SCENE
NOW WHY DO I BORE YOU WITH SUCH
DRAMA. IT IS FAR MORE THAN
DRAMA. KILL OUR FAMILY TO THAT
FAMILY. THAT Y. FROM THEIR
CHILDREN. THAT'S THE REAL DEAL.
NOW WHAT ARE THOSE FOLKS DO IF
THEY CAN RECOVER AND HE DID.
THEY GO RIGHT BACK ON THE JOB.
I MEAN HE DID RIGHT BACK ON THE
JOB. DOING PAPERWORK FOR AWHILE
AND HE'LL. AND THEN WE HAD
SHOULD MENTION HERE ABOUT THREE
WEEKS AGO I WENT DOWN. THE END
OF THE DAY. CERTAINLY THERE WAS
A LOT OF ACTIVITY AROUND OUR
CAPITAL. THERE SIXTEEN FOR A
HIGHWAY PATROL OFFICERS IN OUR
BASEMENT WHERE WE PARK. DRIVE
OUT. MOST OF TIME WE DO KNOW
ABOUT THAT. BUT IT IS A
SACRIFICE THAT THEY MAKE. AND I
FEEL THAT WE OUGHT NOT ASK THEM
TO MAKE MANY MORE SACRIFICES
FOR US CERTAINLY IN TERMS OF
THEIR FUTURE AND THEIR INCOMES.
SIR ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SEEING
AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
MITCHELL YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ON I WAS TRYING
TO PULL UP. ARMS AND THAT I
JUST READ RECENTLY THAT SHOWED.
THE AMOUNT OF OVERTIME THAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S PAYING
THE HIGHWAY PATROL FOR THEIR
SERVICE TO PROTECT AND SERVE
AND SELLTHOSE MEN AND WOMEN
WERE DULY COMPENSATED FOR DOING
THAT JOB AND WE ALL CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THEM I'LL BE ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE IN AB EIGHTY
FOUR. ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I BATES NO BELL I FORGES
NO BRADFORD HI I HAVE A YELLOW.
I CHIANG NO DALLY. DODD. HI
THERE EITHER. HI GALGIANI HI
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG. HI HILL HI HUESO HI
TANTO. HI JACKSON ALRIGHT I
JONES NO LEYVA. I MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL. I MONEY
I MORE LOCK. ZERO MORALE. NO
NIELSEN. I PAN. I PORTANTINO I
ROTH. FIVE RUBIO. I SKINNER. HI
STERN AYE UMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI.
I WIENER I WILK. NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE TIME.
DALLY NO MORE LOCK. VICE THIRTY
KNOWS NINE. THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE OH
THREE COLLEAGUES ONE OLD THREE.
AB ONE OH FIVE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
OH FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
AN ACT RELATING TO TAXATION TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX
LEVY. SENATOR MITCHELL THANK
YOU AB ONE OH FIVE PERTAINS TO
THE NON RESIDENTIAL ACTIVE
SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEM TAX
EXEMPTION MOST SIGNIFICANTLY
THE BILL DOES THE FOLLOWING IT
SEEKS TO PREEMPTIVELY CORRECTLY
UNINTENDED IMPACT OF THE
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES FIRST
INITIATIVE IN THE UPCOMING
NOVEMBER BALLOT. ON NON
RESIDENTIAL SOLAR ENERGY
SYSTEMS IN THE STATE IT ENSURE
THAT NON RESIDENTIAL ACTIVE
SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEMS IN THE
STATE CONSTRUCTED OR INSTALL
PRIOR TO JANUARY ONE POINT
TWENTY FIVE. CONTINUE TO BE
EXEMPTED FROM TAXATION BY
RECLASSIFYING THEM AS PERSONAL
PROPERTY. COMES AN OPERATIVE IN
THE EVENT THE BALLOT INITIATIVE
IS NOT APPROVED AT THE STATE
WIDE SELECTION PRESERVING THE
EXISTING LAW EXEMPTION FOR NON
RESIDENTIAL SOLAR ENERGY
GENERATION SYSTEMS. THE BILL
DOES NOT INTRODUCE ANY NEW TAX
EXEMPTION TO THE SOLAR ENERGY
INDUSTRY. VOTERS INITIALLY
APPROVED THE EXCLUSION OF ACT
OF SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEMS AND
TAXATION IN NINETEEN EIGHTY. AN
EXISTING LAW PROVIDES THAT THIS
EXCLUSION WILL SUNSET ON
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. THE BILL ONLY SERVES TO
PRESERVE THE EXISTING EXCLUSION
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. DEBATER
DISCUSSIONS SENATOR DOLLY THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
SPOKE ABOUT THIS LAST NIGHT
THIS IS ABSURD. WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT PRIVATE A PROPERTY TAX
AND WE'RE THAT PROPERTY TAX
GOES A GOES TO LOCAL COUNTIES.
AND THE SOLAR INDUSTRY HAS DONE
HAS BEEN IF YOU LATE AT THE
LEGISLATURE FOUR YEARS ON THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE NOT PAY
THEIR PROPERTY TAX WHICH FUNDS.
YOUR CAN ONLY SWITCH FUNDS.
DEPUTIES THEY HAVE A STRUCTURE
YOUR COUNTIES ALL THE THINGS-THAT THE COUNTY SERVICES AS
MENTIONED EARLIER TODAY PROVIDE
AND THEY HAVE NO ABILITY BILL
RAZOR TAX NOW LOOK YES WE DO
INCENTIVIZE- DIFFERENT TYPES OF
ENERGY WHEN IT'S CLEAN TO.
OBVIOUSLY OTIS BUT WE HAVE
PLENTY OF SOLAR BACK WE HAVE
MORE SOLAR WE CAN POSSIBLY
USING CALIFORNIA. WE ARE OUR
RATE PAYERS ARE PAYING. TO OFF
LOAD OUR POWER TO OTHER STATES
BECAUSE WHEN THE SUN SHINING
WE'RE CREATING TOO MUCH POWER
AND UNTIL STORAGE EITHER
BATTERY OR SOME OTHER TYPE OF
TECHNOLOGY IS ABLE TO STORE.
THOSE ELECTRONS WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE AS CALIFORNIANS AS
RATE PAYERS TO PAY OTHER STATES
TO TAKE OUR ENERGY WHEN WE'RE
OVER PRODUCING. THIS BILL IS X.
IS IT IS EXPECTING TO SEE THIS
BUT ROLE COMING AFFECTING HIS
HEDGING THAT THEY'LL STILL GET.
THE TAX INCENTIVE WHY IN THE
WORLD WE INCENTIVIZE OF THE WE
HAVE TOO MUCH UP IS BECAUSE THE
LOBBY IS VERY POWERFUL IN THIS
AREA. THE RATE PAYERS OF
CALIFORNIA ARE GETTING THE
SHORT END OF THE DEAL. AT THE
SAME TIME WE SHOULD BE TALKING
ABOUT STORAGE THE ONLY WAY
WE'RE EVER GOING TO REALLY DO A
GOOD JOB OF GOING GREEN AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE A
BALANCE IS UNTIL WE HAVE
STORAGE. IS SO FOR THOSE
REASONS I OPPOSE THIS PIECE
LEGISLATION SECONDLY IT IS NOT
FITTING BE IN THIS BUDGET
PROCESS THIS SHOULD BE A POLICY
DRIVEN BILL. GO TO THE POLICY
SHOP AND IT'S JUST A HEDGING
THE BET FOR. THE ELITE PEOPLE
WHO GET THE TAX CREDITS FROM
THIS SO FOR THOSE REASONS I
URGE A NO VOTE IN ON THE BEHALF
OF THE RATE PAYERS OF
CALIFORNIA I URGE. FOR NOVA.
SENATOR BOARD JUST THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- QUESTION WILL
NOT CERTAIN TO WHOM MUCH
OPPOSES QUESTION PERHAPS. IT
WOULD BE THE PUBLIC BUDGET DIRE
TO TRY TO POSTED TO THE AUTHOR
SENATOR MITCHELL AND I THAT
HERSCHEL I JUST I WANT TO KNOW
IF THROUGH THE CHAIR IF I MAY
UM INITIALLY EXCEPT. MY
QUESTION IS IN THE DRAFTING OF
THIS WHEN IT WENT THROUGH LEDGE
COUNCIL WAS THERE EVER REVIEW
ON THE LEGALITY. OF OFFERING AN
EXEMPTION FROM A REASSESSMENT.
FROM A LEGAL STANDPOINT HAS
THIS BEEN VETTED AND FOUND TO
BE LEGALLY SOUND TO MOVE
FORWARD AS A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. SENATOR MITCHELL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND. I'M
NOT WHERE OF LEDGE COUNCIL
DRAFTING LANGUAGE THAT THEY
WOULD DEEM UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
MAYBE AS A FOLLOW UP. YOU MAY
NOT BE AWARE BUT IT FORTY
REPRESENTATIONS MADE BY STATE
DEPARTMENT OR THE LEGAL COUNSEL
THAT POSED ANY CONCERNS ABOUT
THE LEGALITY OF THIS. HI IT
WOULDN'T BE A TRAILER BILL
BEFORE IF THEY DID SIR. ON YOUR
OWN TIME TO CENTER. ALL OF ALL
CONCLUDE HERE I APPRECIATE-
THOSE ARE VERY CRYPTIC IN-
NONRESPONSIVE. TO MY INQUIRY
BUT MIGHT MY CONCERN REALLY IS
I THINK THIS IS BEING SET UP
FOR A LEGAL CHALLENGE AND I
THINK MY COLLEAGUE BEFORE HAD
INDICATED THAT. THIS IS
DEFINITELY A POLICY DRIVEN
DISCUSSION FINDING ITS WAY INTO
THIS- INTO THIS BUDGET I THINK
IS INAPPROPRIATE BUT I'M I'M
CONCERNED AND I HOPE I'M NOT A
CANARY IN THE COAL MINE HERE
BUT I THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE
CHALLENGE OF THIS MOVES FORWARD
AND NOT FOUND TO BE. LEGALLY
SUPPORT. AND LET ME BE LESS
CRYPTIC IN MY RESPONSE TO YOU
SIR. I DON'T KNOW THAT LEADS
COUNCIL. WILLINGLY KNOWINGLY
DRAFT LEGISLATION THAT THEY
THINK IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL. A
COURT CAN CHALLENGE WHATEVER
THEY CHOOSE TO CHALLENGES UP TO
INTERPRETATION AS A CITY MEMBER
THE BAR YOU ARE WELL AWARE OF
THAT BUT I DON'T BELIEVE LET'S
COUNCIL WE CAN COLLEGE COUNSEL
HERE IF THEY COULD ANSWER IT IN
A LESS CRYPTIC FORM THAT I AM
BUT IT IS NOT MY EXPERIENCE
THAT LETS COUNCIL WOULD PUT
FORWARD LANGUAGE THAT THEY
BELIEVE IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
CORRECT THANK YOU. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE PERHAPS WE COULD CALL
PLEDGE COUNSEL IF THEY.
MAJORITY LEADER SAYS NO OF. I
BELIEVE MANY OF US WHO'VE BEEN
HERE A LONG TIME AGREED THAT
LEDGE COUNCIL IF THEY BELIEVE
SOMETHING IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL
WILL SO ADVICE YOU. IN ADVANCE
OF THE PREPARATION F ANY
DOCUMENT- THAT THEY BELIEVE
THIS ON CONSTITUTIONAL COURSE
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE A COURT
SYSTEM IF THERE'S A CONCERN.
YOU CAN FEEL FREE TO CHALLENGE
IT AND WILL HAVE HER DRESS SAID
IN HER CLOTHES BUT I THINK WE
DO HAVE SENATOR NIELSEN- WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK CENTER
NIELSEN THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES YOU DOWN
THE SENATE THAT I WILL BE
URGING A NO VOTE ON THIS ONE AS
WELL WE HAD AN EARLIER MEASURE
THAT WAS. PROPAGATED ON
RESPONSE TO. POTENTIAL VICTORY
A BALLOT PROPOSITION COMING
DOWN THE PIKE HERE'S ANOTHER
ONE. ELECTED US AND THE
CONCERNS OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE SOLAR INDUSTRY IS WELL
ESTABLISHED IN CALIFORNIA
LITERALLY FOR DECADES. AND I
SUPPORT THE- HOWEVER IT'S
WEARING A LITTLE THIN. THE THEY
HAVE HAD THE PRIVILEGE TO
ADVANTAGE FOR DECADES OTHER
OTHER SOURCES OF ENERGY THAT WE
NEED IN OUR ENERGY BASKET AND
CALIFORNIA. AND ARGUE THAT WE
SHOULD ATTEND OURSELVES AND DID
THAT DEVOTE ATTENTION TO THOSE
OTHER ENERGY SOURCES. A
DIVERSIFICATION. INSTEAD OF
HAVING SOLAR BEING THE NEARLY
ONLY GAME IN TOWN. AND AS
BEFORE IN THIS LEGISLATURE THIS
INDUSTRY. BEFORE THE AXES EVEN
FALLEN ON THE LAST BENEFIT ARE
EXTENDING IT. OR IN THIS CASE
PREPARING FOR EVENTUALITIES.
THAT DOES NOT SERVE US. THE
ABILITY TO FOCUS AS WE SHOULD.
ON OVERALL ENERGY POLICIES. AND
AGAIN I ARGUE THAT THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL. AND NO
FAULT TO THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
AND CERTAINLY NOT TO THE CHAIR.
BUT SPECIAL INTEREST EXPLOIT
THE OPPORTUNITY. AND THAT IN
ITSELF IS WORTHY OF A NO LOW.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN MAY I
PLEASE REMIND EVERYONE THAT WE
ARE SUPPOSED TO TRY TO PRACTICE
SOCIAL DISTANCING. AYE
RELATIONSHIP IT'S DIFFICULT-
BUT- PLEASE TRY TO KEEP THAT IN
MIND. SENATOR WIENER AND
SENATOR BELL. CHAIRMAN. SOME
SOCIAL DISTANCING PLEASE. I
RECOGNIZE IT'S NOT EASY TO DO
BUT IT'S STARTING TO BECOME
VERY OBVIOUS THAT WE'RE NOT SO
WITH THAT. SENATOR BATES. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT JUST A CLARIFICATION
ON THE QUESTION ABOUT THE
LEGALITY OF THIS PARTICULAR
MEASURE I DO YOU REMEMBER WHEN
WE HAD TO. THE RECALL ISSUE IN
A TRAILER BILL AND IT DID PASS
OFF THIS FLOOR AND THEN HOW TO
BE. A WAS FOUND IN A COURT
CHALLENGE TO BE ILLEGAL AND
THEY HAD TO REDO IT OVER IN A
POLICY BILL. SO WE WERE ALERTED
IN THAT PARTICULAR MOMENT THAT
FRIENDLY TO COUNSEL THAT THAT
POTENTIALLY COULD BE HONEST
CONSTITUTIONAL SO I'D LIKE TO
ASK THE AUTHOR JUST A
CLARIFICATION. WERE YOU EVER
ALERTED BY LEAD COUNSEL THAT
THERE MIGHT BE A CONSTITUTIONAL
ISSUE WITH THIS PARTICULAR
MEASURE NO MA'AM THANK YOU
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN SOMETHING THAT WE GOT
ON THE ON THE RECALL MEASURE.
GIVEN THE EXAMPLE YOU GAVE IN
THE PAST WE HAD BEEN ALERTED
YES AND SO I THINK THAT WAS A
DIFFERENT SITUATION EXACTLY WE
WERE NOT ALERTED. INSTEAD POINT
OF CLARIFICATION LITTLE
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE THAT
THANKS IT IT WORKS EVERY TIME.
THANK YOU HI IS A FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ISSUE SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
SENATOR MITCHELL WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I JUST RESTATE THAT
THIS AGAIN IS IN CURRENT LAW IN
THIS A MEASURE IS JUST
PRESERVING THE CURRENT
EXEMPTION THIS PROPOSAL IS NOT
A NEW BENEFIT FOR THE SOLAR
INDUSTRY AGAIN THAT ONLY
PRESERVES CURRENT LAW OF AN
EXEMPTION AT SUNSET. IN TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE SHOULD THE SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITIES FIRST
INITIATIVE PASS. ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU- AND AGAIN
SENATORS PLEASE SIX FEET.
SENATOR SIX FEET PLEASE. IT'S A
IT'S NOT EASY BUT I WOULD
REQUEST AND IF WE CAN'T GET
PEOPLE TO DO SIX FEET I'M GOING
TO ASK YOU ALL TO SIT DOWN WE
WILL CONTINUE UNTIL WE'VE DONE
THAT. ALRIGHT WITH THAT. ALL
DEBATE HAVING CEASED. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
ATKINS I BATES NO BELL I
BORDERS. BRADFORD. CUT BY ADAM
I CHIANG. NO DALLY. NO DODD I
DORADO HI GALGIANI I GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG
AYE HILL. HI HUESO. I TADO I
JACKSON AYE JONES NO LEYVA FIVE
MCGUIRE. I MELINDA'S NO
MITCHELL. FIVE MONNING I MORE
LOCK NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN. NO
HAN HI PORTANTINO I ROTH. I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN I AM
VERY HI MY CASKEY I WIENER. HI
WILK NOW PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FOR JUST. NOW BRADFORD.
I TWENTY EIGHT NOS ELEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON NOW TO
FILE ITEM ONE OLD TO. FILE ITEM
ONE OR TWO A. B. ONE OH THREE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH THREE BY
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND ACTUALLY INTO
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AB ONE ALL THREE-
PROVIDES A FEDERAL CONFORMITY
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ASSESSING
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL UNEMPLOYMENT
ADMINISTRATION GRANTS AND TO
PROVIDE UP TO TWENTY WEEKS AN
ADDITIONAL UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BENEFITS. FUNDED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL PROVIDES
FOR THE NON CHARGE OF EMPLOYERS
UP FOR UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
ISSUE DURING THE CALL BUT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC OF SPECIFIED.
THE BILL ALSO AUTHORIZES THE
USE OF THE TOTAL UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE FOR THE PURPOSES OF
TRIGGERING ON THE DAY ALL THEIR
BENEFITS. WELL LAST NIGHT
DURING BUDGET COMMITTEE SEVERAL
QUESTIONS WERE ASKED- OF THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND I THINK I
JUST WANT TO COVER A COUPLE OF
THEM. A MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE
ASKED WHAT WAS THE TOTAL AMOUNT
OF UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS PAID
OUT WHAT WAS THE PROPORTION
BETWEEN STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDS
IN NINETEEN TWENTY. THERE BEEN
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY SIX POINT
FOUR BILLION IN U. I. BENEFITS
PAID OUT TO JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY. APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
THREE POINT SEVEN BILLION IN
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS ARE TIED
TO THE VERY FEDERAL PROGRAMS F.
P. YOU SEE THE P. WAY AND THE
P. E. YOU SEE. AND TWELVE POINT
SEVEN BILLION IS FOR REGULAR
YOU WHY. AFTER YOU SEE THE
ADDITIONAL SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER WEEK P. WAY AS THE PANDEMIC
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. AND P. E. YOU SEE IS
THE THIRD THIRTEEN WEEK
PANDEMIC EMERGENCY UNEMPLOYMENT
COMPENSATION EXTENSION. ANOTHER
QUESTION WAS POSED BY COMMITTEE
MEMBER WHICH WAS HOW MUCH HOW
MANY HOW MUCH FUNDS HAVE BEEN
BORROWED FROM THE FED SO FAR
AND WHAT IS THE REPAYMENT PLAN
AND IMPACT ON BUSINESSES. AS OF
JUNE TWENTY THIRD TWENTY TWENTY
CALIFORNIA HAS ADVANCE A TOTAL
OF FOUR BILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. IT
SHOULD BE NOTED THAT DUE TO
SEVERAL LARGE EMPLOYER TAX
RECEIPTS TOWARDS THE BEGINNING
OF MAY APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION HAS BEEN REPAID
TODAY. LEAVING THE OUTSTANDING
LOAN VALUE OF THE TWO POINT SIX
BILLION I THINK THAT HITS ALL
OF THE QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ASK. ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. YOU'RE WELCOME SENATOR
BREAUX FOLLOW BY SENATOR
NIELSEN AND THEN YOU CAN ADAM
TO RUSSIA THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT CAN I HAVE SEE AUTHOR
IF SHE WOULD JUST EXPAND ON
THAT QUESTION- THE FIRST PART
OF THE QUESTION WAS- HOW MUCH
MONEY IS OUTSTANDING ON THE
LOAN BALANCE WHICH YOU
ARTICULATED VERY WELL FOR
BILLION DOLLARS ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION REPEAT TWO POINT SIX
BILLION BUT WHAT'S THE IMPACT
ON THE TWO POINT SIX BILLION
FOR EMPLOYERS IN THE FUTURE
THAT WAS A SET HALF OF THAT
QUESTION HOW IT'S GONNA BE. A
MINUTE PLEASE THANK YOU. WOULD
YOU BE PREPARED TO ACCEPT THAT
QUESTION YES. ABSENT CHANGES TO
THE STATE'S FINANCING STRUCTURE
FOR YOU I IT IS ANTICIPATED
THAT ANY OUTSTANDING BALANCE
WILL BE REPAID THE A FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT TAX RECEIPTS
SIMILAR TO WHAT OCCURRED DURING
THE INSOLVENCY PERIOD FOLLOWING
THE GREAT RECESSION THE FULL F.
U. T. A TAX RATE IS 6% ON THE
FIRST SEVEN THOUSAND AND
EARNINGS PER EMPLOYEE. PAID ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS AND COLLECTED
BY THE IRS HOWEVER EMPLOYERS
RECEIVE SIGNIFICANT TAX CREDIT
A FIVE POINT 4% WHICH LOWERED
THEIR FEDERAL TAX LIABILITY TO
JUST POINT 6% ON THE FIRST
SEVEN THOUSAND OR FORTY TWO
DOLLARS PER EMPLOYEE.
CALIFORNIAN PLAYERS EXPERIENCE
THEY POINT 3% LOSS EACH YEAR ON
THE F. U. T. TAX CREDIT FROM
TAX YEARS TWENTY ELEVEN TO
TWENTY SEVENTEEN FOLLOWING THE
GREAT RECESSION PICKING OUT A
TWO POINT 1% TAX CREDIT
REDUCTION IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
OR ONE HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN
DOLLARS PER EMPLOYEE IT'S
ANTICIPATED AT THIS TIME THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS WILL
PROBABLY EXPERIENCED MULTIPLE
YEARS OF F. UT A TAX CREDIT
REDUCTIONS. BEGINNING WITH TAX
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO. TERRY
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH.
COLLEAGUES I REALIZE THAT WE
HAD A SUPPORT ON THIS BILL-
PENDING THAT QUESTION BUT
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THAT
QUESTION WAS ANSWERED WHICH I
ANTICIPATED- AGAIN WE HAD A
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL BUT BASED
ON THE WAY THE QUESTION WAS
ANSWERED. BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BORROWED AGAINST THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND- FOR
THE- UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
FUND WHICH IS 1100% FUNDED. BY
EMPLOYERS BASED ON THE FOR
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT
EACH EMPLOYEE MAKES. THAT LONE
THAT AS NOT REPEAT TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT REQUIRED
EMPLOYERS NOT TO GET A FOODIE
TAX REDUCTION CREDIT. THE
TIMES- BECAUSE WE ARE A STATE
THAT HAS TO PAY STATE
UNEMPLOYMENT TAX AND FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT TAX VERY FEW
STATES. HAVE TO PAY BOTH A
TAXES. SO CALIFORNIA'S ALLOWED
OF FOOD A TAX REDUCTION CREDIT
FROM THE FEDERAL SIDE. THIS
PARTICULAR BORROWING OR THIS
MANY THAT IS OWED NOW AT NO
FAULT OF THE EMPLOYER. THIS WAS
A GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN OF COVE
IT THIS REQUIRED FOUR POINT
EIGHT MILLION POSSIBLY MORE
CALIFORNIANS TO LOSE THEIR JOB.
AND NOW EMPLOYERS WILL BE
PAYING THIS ADDITIONAL- PAY
BACK THE LOAN. THAT WAS IT
MINISTERED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON THIS SET DOWN.
YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND THAT
EMPLOYERS RESPONSIBLE FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND WE
LAY SOMEBODY OFF OR WE HAVE TO
TERMINATE SOMEBODY. THERE'S
ALWAYS THE ISSUE OF MAKING SURE
THAT THAT EMPLOYEE GETS- THE
PROPER YOU I DIDN'T FIT. BUT
THIS AGAIN WAS AT NO FAULT THE
EMPLOYERS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BUSINESSES ARE
BARELY SURVIVING DISCO WITH THE
TUITION AND TO HIT THEM WITH
THE IMPACT OF NOT BEING ABLE TO
RECEIVE THE FOOD TAX REDUCTION
CREDIT IN PAIN BACK. TO
GOVERNMENT. IN SOME CASES THIS
TOTALS HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS- PER YEAR. AND I KNOW
THAT FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE-
FOR THREE YEARS DURING THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT I SIX. MIGHT MOM
BUSINESS AT THE BORROW MONEY TO
PAY THAT LOW. BACK AND THEN.
USE THE PROP WE GET EVERY. TO
PAY BACK LONG. AND IT'S JUST
RIGHT. WE OR THE SMALL OWNER
AND BUSINESS OWNERS IN GENERAL
IS. CAL WILL BE SUBJECT TO PAY
BACK THAT LOAN THAT WAS CREATED.
BY THE UNEMPLOYMENT- INSURANCE
THAT WAS PAID OUT TO EMPLOYEES
BUT ONLY BASED ON THE COLBERT
SHUT DOWN. SO I APPRECIATE- THE
BUDGET CHAIR WOMAN'S- ANSWER IN
THAT. I REALIZE IT HAS A
SUPPORT TO RECOMMENDATION ON IT
FROM THE OUR SITE PENDING THE
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION. AND
BECAUSE EMPLOYERS ARE GOING TO
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE EVEN THOUGH
THEY HAD NO. A FAULT AT
CREATING THIS AND EMPLOYMENT
CATASTROPHE I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU NOT SUPPORT THIS BILL LET'S
COME UP WITH A BETTER SOLUTION-
SO THAT- EMPLOYERS AREN'T HIT
WITH THIS DRASTIC COST WHILE
THEY'RE TRYING TO REBUILD. OUR
ECONOMY TO MAKE UP THE FORTIES-
ARE FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
BUDGET BUDGET DEFICIT. AS I
SAID AND A COUPLE OF. WEEKS AGO
OR LAST WEEK. WE HAVE TO RELY
ON THE IT SECTOR TO PROVIDE
JOBS. TO PROVIDE DOT. SIX
REVENUE. SPENT IN THE BUILDING
KANSEN PERSON INCOME TAX. AND
SO THE PRIVATE SECTOR HAS TO BE
ABLE TO SURVIVE THAT. BARELY
SURVIVING THE CODE SITUACIóN
THINK ABOUT YOUR SMALL
RESTAURANT. THE BARELY SURVIVED
ON CURBSIDE TO GO THAT IS
BARELY- MAKING IT OR IS NOT RE
OPENING THEY'RE STILL GOING TO
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THOSE
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS PAID OUT
BECAUSE OF COVERT NINETEEN. AND
IT'S GOING TO BE A HUGE IMPACT
ON AND THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
TO BE ABLE TO COME UP WITH
THOSE ADDITIONAL DOLLARS TO
MEET THIS- LOAN REQUIREMENTS.
THE CALIFORNIA IS NOT GOING TO
PAY BACK- THEY'RE GONNA LEAVE
IT ON THE BACKS OF THE- JOB
CREATORS IN OUR STATE AND I
WOULD AB RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
NO VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
DRAWS SO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- I'D GREATLY APPRECIATE
THE- THE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT IS BEING
DISTRIBUTED THROUGH
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BILL AT
THE STATE LEVEL AND THE FEDERAL
LEVEL I THINK IT'S TREMENDOUS-
ARE AGENCIES NEVER SAW THIS
COMING SO I KNOW THAT THE
PRESSURE IS TREMENDOUS. HOWEVER
I THINK AS A BODY WE SHOULD
COMMUNICATE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT MUCH MORE
NEEDS TO BE DONE TO BE ABLE TO
DISTRIBUTE THESE MONIES TO THE
UNEMPLOYED IN A MUCH MORE
EFFICIENT WAY. THAN WHAT'S
BEING DONE NOW- I THINK WE'VE
ALL BEEN VERY PATIENT. ABOUT
HOW OF THE PACE WITH WHICH THIS
IS BEING DONE. BUT I MUST SAY I
SAID THIS YESTERDAY IN THE
COMMITTEE. THAT THE PRESSURE
THAT- I KNOW JUST AS AN EXAMPLE
OUR STAFF IS GOING THROUGH
EVERY SINGLE DAY. HEARING THE
ANGER THE FRUSTRATION- THE
PASSION WITH WHICH THE CALLS
ARE COMING IN. IS SOMETHING
THAT EIGHT YOU KNOW IS BECOMING
VERY UNBEARABLE SO I KNOW THE
PRESSURE IS ON THE AGENCIES BUT
MORE HAS TO BE DONE SOMETHING
DIFFERENT HAS TO BE DONE
BECAUSE WE'RE SO MANY MONTHS
AFTER THIS- AFTER THEY ALL
STARTED LOSING THEIR JOB SO
THAT'S MY ONLY COMMENT OF ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT WE DO
SOMETHING. REALLY DIFFERENT
FROM WHAT IS GOING ON RIGHT NOW
THANK YOU. SENATOR MORLOCK
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FOR
YEAH I HAD A LONG DISCUSSION ON
THIS LAST NIGHT AT THE BUDGET
IS TO REVIEW COMMITTEE AND-
GOING BACK TO MY EARLY CAREER I
DID PREPARE A LOT OF PAYROLL
TAX RETURNS- THERE ARE TWO-
UNEMPLOYMENT TAX. CATEGORIES
SAID EMPLOYERS ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR ONE IS STATE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE THE OTHERS VIEW THE-
AND THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE WAS ACCURATE AND HOW
CUTE IS CALCULATED TO FORTY TWO
DOLLARS PER EMPLOYEE. IF THEY
ARE AND SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
OR MORE YEAR. WE WERE
INSTRUCTED LAST NIGHT. THAT THE
S. YOU WHY THE STATE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE WOULD
THE RATES WOULD NOT BE IMPACTED
BECAUSE- THE LAYOFFS WERE DUE
TO CO OF IT AND NOT. BECAUSE OF
OTHER. CIRCUMSTANCES SO
EMPLOYERS WOULD. NOT BE
PENALIZED AND TO- SHOULD THIS
STATE. TAKE THE SAME ROAD. AS
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
WHICH DID NOT PAY OFF THE
FEUDAL LOANS RIGHT AWAY SO
EMPLOYERS HAD TO PAY THE
HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN PER
EMPLOYEE THAT WOULD NOT. TAKE
AFFECT UNTIL TWO YEARS AFTER WE
HAD ESTABLISHED A LOAN BALANCE
THAT WAS ON PAID SO WE STILL
HAVE SOME BREATHING ROOM HERE
AND CORRECT ME IF I DIDN'T GET
THAT IT CORRECTLY MADAM CHAIR
BUT I THINK THAT I'M
COMFORTABLE AND SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TONIGHT. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU- SENATOR
MORE LOCK. AND THE CENTER YOU
MENTION THAT NEW CLOTHES
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FOR THEIR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. I THINK OF CALLING
FROM BAKERSFIELD CONFUSED THE
ISSUE A LITTLE BIT AND I WANT
TO SET THE RECORD STRAIGHT I
ASK OUR STAFF AND I WENT TO THE
BUDGETARY WHO I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO SAY. I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
KEEP TRACK OF ALL THE THINGS
YOU KEEP TRACK OF WHICH DO AN
EXCELLENT JOB. AND I WANT TO
COMMEND YOU FOR THAT. IN MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT. THIS
WILL BE PICKED UP BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE WILL NOT
BE LIKE IT WAS. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT. FOR AND I WAS I'M AN
EMPLOYER SAW THIS HAPPEN TO ME
AS WELL AS IT DID. THE MEMBER
FROM BAKERSFIELD THAT WE HAD TO
PAY. LITERALLY UNTIL TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
WE JUST FINISHED PAYING OFF.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT DEBT. THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BORROWED.
AGAINST THE LITTLE LONG LONG
TERM OF UNEMPLOYMENT THE PEOPLE
WERE ABLE TO CLASS SO. I
BELIEVE UNDER THIS SCENARIO. IT
WILL BE BACK FILLED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND ONE
OTHER ONE OTHER THING I WANT TO
ADD. WHICH I TALK WHICH I ASKED
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LAST
NIGHT WHICH IS VERY CRUCIAL TO
BUSINESS OWNERS. WHO ARE TRYING
TO HIRE THEIR EMPLOYEES. WHEN
THEY'RE GETTING FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS A WEEK NOT ONLY
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BUT SIX HUNDRED. FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THERE'S
REALLY NO REASON FOR THEM IN
SOME CASES TO GO BACK TO WORK
BECAUSE THEY'RE ACTUALLY MAKING
MORE MONEY- ON UNEMPLOYMENT
THAN THEY WOULD BE. IF THEY
WERE WORKING. IF YOU OFFER YOUR
JOB BACK AS AN EMPLOYER.
THEY'RE REQUIRED TO TAKE THAT
JOB AND IF THEY DON'T. THEN
THEY ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR THOSE
UNEMPLOYED. SKEWS ME
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS WHICH IS
CRUCIAL WE WANT TO GET THEM
BACK TO WORK. OBVIOUSLY THEY
MAY BE TAKING A PAY CUT BUT
THAT'S TAX DOLLARS THAT ARE
PAYING THAT UNEMPLOYMENT AND
IT'S ALSO EMPLOYERS THAT ARE
PAYING IT. SO I ENCOURAGE THOSE
BUSINESS OWNERS WHO ARE TRYING
TO GET BACK STARTED. TO GET IN
<c.green>ONTACT WITH THOSE EMPLOYEES</c>
AND IF THEY DON'T TAKE THEIR
JOB BACK REPORT INTO THE
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS BECAUSE
IT'S ALL OF US THAT ARE PAYING-
THOSE FEES. SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE LEGISLATION I
BELIEVE WE HAVE IT IRONED OUT
RIGHT AND THIS IS CRITICAL FOR
CALIFORNIA TO GET MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR GREAT JOB AND I
DON'T KNOW HOW YOU KEEP IT ALL
STRAIGHT. THANK YOU SENATOR
GROVE AGAIN. YES MADAM
PRESIDENT I AM I GUESS I
MISUNDERSTOOD THE RESPONSE FROM
THE CHAIR WOMAN THE BUDGET
HERE- I UNDERSTOOD HER TO SAY
THAT WOULD BE PAID BACK SIMILAR
TO THE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT.
A CRISIS THAT WE HAD THAT WAS
MY UNDERSTANDING. AND I JUST
GOT CORRECTED BY THE CONSULTANT
THAT IT IS NOT THAT IS NOT
THAT'S THE WAY I UNDERSTOOD IT
I DON'T. THINK THAT SO I-APOLOGIZE FOR THAT. SO THE
CONSULTING CORRECTING ME HAT
IT IS NOT GOING TO BE DONE LIKE
THAT THAT WE WOULD NOT HAVE THE
REPAYMENT FROM THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT SIMILAR TO THAT. SO THERE
WOULD BE A- NO PREPAYMENT FOR
THE FEDERALLY- GUARANTEE
FRIENDS. THAT WERE PROVIDED FOR
EMPLOYMENT SO I APOLOGIZE FOR
MISUNDERSTANDING THE BUDGET
CHAIR- AND I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. HI THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION. SEEING
HEARING NONE SENATOR MITCHELL
YOU MAY CLOSE. WOULD YOU WOULD
YOU SPEAK PUT MORE INTO THE
MIKE PLEASE. FORGET I GOT
PLEASE IN WITH THE SHOWER CAP
CAN GET CLOSER OKAY. LOAN
REPAYMENT AND THE NON AND NON
CHARGING ARE TWO DIFFERENT
ISSUES NON CHARGING IS NOT. IS
TO NOT PENALIZE EMPLOYERS FOR
THEIR WORKERS ASSESSING
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS THIS BILL
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE LOAN
REPAYMENT THIS BILL PROVIDES
FOR THE NON CHARGING OF
EMPLOYERS FOR THE PURPOSES OF
THE EMPLOYER EXPERIENCE RATING
BECAUSE OF COLD IT. WE'RE ALL
ON THE SAME PAGE ASKING FOR
NOVEL. HE ALL DEBATE HAVING
SEIZE IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
ICE FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ALONG NOW TO
FILE ITEM WONDERFUL FOR. WHICH
IS AB ONE ONE NINE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE NINETEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TANG AND
ACTUALLY INTO STATE EMPLOYMENT
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK
YOU AB ONE NINETEEN- PROVIDES
LEGISLATIVE RATIFICATION OF THE
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
BETWEEN THE STATE. AND SEIU
LOCAL ONE THOUSAND THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS OF
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS. THE
BILL SUSPENDS THE EMPLOYEE
MONTHLY CONTRIBUTION. TO PRE
FUND OTHER POST EMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FOR
THESE BARGAINING UNITS WHILE
MAINTAINING THE STATE EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTION. IN GENERAL THESE
THEM ALL USE INCLUDE
ADJUSTMENTS IN EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION THAT IS EQUIVALENT
TO UP TO TWO DAYS OF LEAVE.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL PROVIDES
LEGISLATIVE RATIFICATION IMHO
USE OR ADDENDA BUT AGREED TO BY
JUNE THIRTY TWENTY TWENTY. IF
THESE AGREEMENTS INCLUDE
SAVINGS MEASURES THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO MEETING THE
BUDGET REDUCTION SPECIFIED IN
THE BUDGET THAT. THIS BILL
APPROPRIATES TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION TO IMPLEMENT
THE PROVISIONS OF THESE MO YOU
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM
SENATOR MORLOCK. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- I WANT TO
COMMEND THE BARGAINING UNITS
FOR THEIR WILLINGNESS TO
DISCUSS. MODIFICATIONS TO THEIR
COMPENSATION- THEY'RE TAKING OR
LEAST THERE'S NEGOTIATIONS TO.
DISCUSS TAKING TO FOR LATE DAYS
WHICH WOULD BE TEN PERCENT
SALARY CUT. BUT THEY'RE ALSO-
SUSPENDING THE WITHHOLDING OF
THEIR- RETIREE MEDICAL
CONTRIBUTION OF 4% SO THEY'LL
BE TAKING A NAP. REDUCTION OF
6% SO WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE THAT WILL MORE
ACCURATELY MOVING FORWARD
SHOULD THE EMPLOYEES VOTE TO
ACCEPT THE MEET AND CONFER. OF
THE NEGOTIATIONS BUT IT WE
SHOULD ENCOURAGE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO TAKE A HARD
LOOK AT THE RETIREE MEDICAL.
PLAN IT'S NOW. HAS AN EIGHTY
SIX BILLION DOLLAR UNFUNDED
ACTUARIAL ACCRUED LIABILITIES.
AND BY SUSPENDING THE WITH
HOLDINGS FOR YEAR THAT WE'RE
ADDING ANOTHER ONE POINT TWO
BILLION TO THAT AMOUNT- WHICH
IS NOT A PLEASANT THING TO PASS
ALONG TO OUR KIDS AND GRAND
CHILDREN- WE MADE SOME. RATHER
PRODUCTIVE MODIFICATIONS TO THE
RETIREE MEDICAL PLAN AT THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX MAKING
MODIFICATIONS TO THE COST OF
LIVING MAKING MODIFICATION TO
WHO PAYS AND- STATE. SPENDING
WOULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
STATE TO NOW START PAYING IT
HITS 4% SAID OF HAVING
EMPLOYEES DO IT. IN MAKING
CHANGES TO. INTEGRATING WITH
MEDICARE AND A FEW OTHER
CHANGES THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
REDUCE OUR UNFUNDED LIABILITY
BY 71% WHICH WAS ONE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE RATHER SUBSTANTIAL IF WE
COULD REDUCE THE UNFUNDED
LIABILITY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BY 71% WE'RE TALKING
SIXTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS SO WE
HAVE A REAL OPPORTUNITY HERE TO
MAKE SOME SUBSTANTIAL CHANGES
FOR A SYSTEMIC ISSUE THAT WILL
COME BACKTO US IN IN A IN.
HIGHER COSTS AS THE YEARS
PROGRESSED SO WITH THAT- MADAM
PRESIDENT I THINK WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE- AND HI I
THINK THE GOVERNOR SHOULD
SHOULD WORK ON THAT IT'S AN
ABILITY TO CHANGE THE SYSTEM
MAKE LONG TERM PROBLEM AND- I-
WHEN I THINK FOR THE TIME.
THANK YOU ARE SENATOR MORLOCK
ANY FURTHER DEBATER DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
MITCHELL YOU MAY CLOSE ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA OR AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES NO FELL I FORGES NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A YELLOW. I
CHIANG NO DALLY NO DODD I
DORADO HI GALGIANI. HI GLAZER
HI GONZALEZ HI GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL. I WISH SO.
I TADO HI JACKSON HI I JONES NO
LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE AYE
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL. I
MONNING I MORE LOCK. MORRELL NO
NIELSEN NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH. I RUBIO. I SKINNER I
STERN AYE AMBERG HI MY COUNTY
HI WIENER AYE WILK. NOW. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MORE
LOCK. VICE TWENTY NINE KNOWS
TEN THE MEASURE PASSAGE
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON NOW TO FILE ITEM NINETY NINE.
AB NINETY FOUR. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE THREE. ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETY FOUR BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
ACTUALLY IN THE POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION AND MAKING AN
APPRPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR
MITCHELL. AB NINETY FOUR AS THE
HIGHER EDUCATION TRAILER BILL
AND CONTAIN STATUTORY CHANGES
TO IMPLEMENT THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET THAT. THE BILL DOES THE
FOLLOWING IT DIFFERS ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION IN PROP NINETY
GENERAL FUND FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. FROM THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEAR TO THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FISCAL
YEAR. COMMUNITY COLLEGES WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE FOR A HARDSHIP
WAIVER OF THIRTY MILLION TOTAL
FOR EACH DEFERRAL MONTH. VIED
SIXTY SIX POINT THREE MILLION
IN PROP NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
<c.cyan>UND ONE TIME FOR THE COMMUNITY</c>
COLLEGE COLBERT NINETEEN
RESPONSE BLOCK GRANT. WHICH
WOULD FUND ACTIVITIES THAT
SUPPORT STUDENT LEARNING AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
MAINTAINS THE CAL GROUNDWORK
FOR STUDENTS ATTENDING PRIVATE
NONPROFIT COLLEGES AT NINE
THOUSAND EIGHTY FOUR DOLLARS
PROVIDES EMERGENCY FINANCIAL
AID FOR A. B. FIVE FORTY
STUDENTS AT UCCISSUE AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND
FINANCIAL AID FOR STUDENTS
ATTENDING SUMMER SESSION AT UC
AND CSU. LASTLY AB NINETY FOUR
REQUIRES THE UC SAN FRANCISCO.
NARCISSUS HEIGHTS PROJECT TO
USE SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE AND A PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS TO PERFORM ALL WORK
ON THE PROJECT THE BILL ALSO
PROVIDES FOR AN A. B. NINE
HUNDRED EXPEDITED JUDICIAL
REVIEW PROCESS ON THE GRANTING
OF PROJECT APPROVALS FOR THE UC
S. F. PROJECT. ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE. DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR NIELSEN. I
ASK A NO VOTE MADDEN. ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING ON SENATOR
MITCHELL ANY RESPONSES- FINAL
COMMENT ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. I BATES I TELL FIVE
BORDERS NO BRADFORD I HAVE A
YELLOW HI CHIANG. HI KELLY TAKE
CARE NO DODD. I THE RHIZOME I
GALGIANI. I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG. I HILL
I HUESO. I TADO I JACKSON
ALRIGHT I JONES NO LEYVA I
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S. NO
MITCHELL FIVE MONNING. I MORE
LOOK NO MORRELL. NO NIELSEN NO
HAN HI PORTANTINO HI ROTH. I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN. I AM
VERY HI WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WIENER I WILL KNOW. I THE.
BATES I DON'T KNOW. OUR EYES
THIRTY KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE
PASSES COLLEAGUES WE HAVE TWO
ITEMS TO BUDGET ITEMS LEFT. WE
ARE ABOUT AVAILABLE TO DO THE
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR BUT BEFORE
WE DO THAT WE HAVE- ONE THE
FINAL. TAYLOR BILL THIS IS AB
AT THREE FILE ITEM NINETY TWO
THIS IS THE HOUSING MEASURE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY THREE BY
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON THE
BUDGET AN ACT RELATING TO
HOUSING AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL FLOOR SHORES.
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU A. B.
EIGHTY THREE IS A HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS TRAILER BILL WHICH
CONTAINS STATUTORY CHANGES.
NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY IT
CONTAINS SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS AS WELL AS A MAJOR
POLICY CHANGES. TO ADDRESS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY THE BILL PROVIDES
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
TO ASSIST CITIES. COUNTIES AND
CONTINUUM'S OF CARE IN
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS. AND
ALLOWS FOR THE USE OF FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IN
FEDERAL- COLD IT NINETEEN
RELIEF FUNDS AND FIFTY MILLION
IN GENERAL FUND FOR THE
ACQUISITION CONVERGE IN A
REHABILITATION OF. HOTELS
MOTELS AND OTHER PROPERTIES FOR
USE AS AFFORDABLE HOUSING AS
WELL AS FOR THE OPERATIONS OF
THOSE HOUSING UNITS. IT ALSO
PROVIDES SIGNIFICANT REGULATORY
STREAMLINING FOR PROJECTS
FUNDED THROUGH THIS PROGRAM
PROVIDED CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS
ARE MET. IT MAKES CERTAIN
CHANGES TO RULES AND
REGULATIONS TO STREAMLINE THE
ALLOCATION OF AN ADDITIONAL
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION IN STATE
LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDITS.
IT MAKES A VARIETY OF TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO HOUSING AND LAND USE
LAW TO ENCOURAGE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE BILL
TO MAKE EXCESS PROFIT A
PROPERTY AVAILABLE FOR HOUSING.
AND TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO USE EMERGENCY
TRAILERS PROVIDED TO COMBAT THE
CALL THAT NINETEEN PANDEMIC. IT
ALSO EXTENDS A NUMBER OF
ENCUMBRANCE AN EXPENDITURE
DATES TO ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO BEEN IMPACTED BY
COOL BUT NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THE
SPIN FUNDS THAT HAVE PREVIOUSLY
BEEN APPROPRIATED FOR HOUSING
AND PLANNING PROGRAMS. THIS IS
A VERY TIMELY IN A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL AND I'M HOPING
THAT. ALL MEMBERS WILL VOTE I.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM IS THERE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. I BATES I
FELL HI GORGEOUS. GOOD FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T. I
CHIANG. HI DOLLY. DODD I DORADO.
I GALGIANI. HI GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO. I TADO. I
JACKSON HI I JONES NO LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S. MITCHELL I
MONNING I MORE LOCK. MORALE
NIELSEN. PAN I PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER. I
STERN HI I'M BURKE I LIKE HUSKY
AYE WIENER. I WILL. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME. FOR JUST. TALLY NO GROWTH.
MELENDEZ MORE LOCK. MORRELL. NO
NIELSEN. WILK ONE MORE TIME
PLEASE. GORGEOUS GROWTH.
MELENDEZ MORE LOCK. NIELSEN
WILK AYE AYES THIRTY ONE KNOWS
THREE THE MEASURE PASSES
COLLEAGUES IT IS EIGHT FORTY
SIX WE ARE ABLE TO TAKE UP THE
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR AS IT'S
CALLED AT EIGHT FORTY FIVE SO
WE ARE RIGHT ON TIME. WITH THAT
WE WILL GO TO FILE ITEM NINETY
FIVE A. B. EIGHTY NINE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING AND ACTUALLY INTO
THE STATE BUDGET AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BELL.
SENATOR MITCHELL FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT AB EIGHTY NINE IS A
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR ASSOCIATE
WITH THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY. THIS BILL MAKES
TECHNICAL AND SUBSTANTIVE
CHANGES TO THE BUDGET. ON JUNE
FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED SENATE BILL
SEVENTY FOUR WHICH REPRESENTED
THE LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET
AGREEMENT THIS BILL MAKES
AMENDMENTS BASED OFF OF SB
SEVENTY FOUR. THAT REPRESENT
THE BUDGET AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. SOME OF THE KEY
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET AGREEMENT
AND DISAGREEMENT WITH THE
GOVERNOR INCLUDE. THIS
AGREEMENT DOES NOT RELY ON
ADDITIONAL RAINY DAY FUNDS
SAFETY NET RESERVE FUNDS OR THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT
SYSTEM DEFERRAL IF ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS DO NOT
MATERIALIZE. INSTEAD THIS
AGREEMENT RELIES UPON UPDATED
BASELINE FORECAST ADJUSTMENTS
TO REVENUES AND EXPENDITURES
AND AN INCREASE PROP NINETY
EIGHT DEFERRAL. THIS AGREEMENT
ALSO TAKES A TRIGGER APPROACH
IN TERMS OF ARCHITECTURE
SIMILAR TO THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION WHERE CERTAIN FUNDING
WILL ONLY BE AUGMENTED OR
RESTORED IF ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDS ARE RECEIVED. HOWEVER THE
TRIGGER CONTINUES TO FOLLOW THE
LEGISLATURE'S AGREEMENT TO NOT
INCLUDE CUTS THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS. THIS
BUDGET AGREEMENT INCLUDES TOTAL
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE FISCAL
YEAR OF ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THREE POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS AND WOULD MAINTAIN A
RESERVE ELEVEN POINT FOUR
BILLION TO HELP ADDRESS THE
POTENTIAL ON GOING SHORTFALL.
THIS BILL MAKES NUMEROUS
ADJUSTMENTS THE BUDGET ACT
ITEMS OF APPROPRIATION TO
REFLECT THE AGREEMENT WITH THE
GOVERNOR SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS
INCLUDE PROVIDES AN INCREASE OF
TWO POINT THREE MILLION AND I'M
GOING GENERAL FUND FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
TO REFLECT THE TRANSITION OF
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. IT
PROVIDES SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION TO COUNTIES TO BACK
FILL FOR LOST REALIGNMENT
REVENUES. PRIORITIZE IN SUPPORT
FOR HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAMS AND
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. AN ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION WILL BE
PROVIDED TO COUNTIES IS
SUFFICIENT FEDERAL FUNDING IS
RECEIVED. BY OCTOBER FIFTEENTH
OF TWENTY TWENTY. INCLUDES
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT BANK TO EXPAND
UNDERSERVED SMALL BUSINESS
LENDING IN THE STATE. IT
PROVIDES THREE HUNDRED MILLION
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
CONTINUE ONES OF CARE TO
CONTINUE EFFORTS TO COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS. THEIR PROVIDE TO
THE ALLOCATION OF NINE POINT
FIVE BILLION IN FUNDS FROM THE
CORONA VIRUS RELIEF FUND IN THE
CARE EXACT INCLUDING ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THIS BILL ALSO INCLUDES SOME
TOUGH PRODUCTIONS INCLUDING THE
STATE EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION
HOWEVER THIS REDUCTION AND
OTHERS WILL BE RESTORED. UNDER
THE TRIGER IF ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS MATERIALIZE.
MEMBERS THIS BILL REPRESENTS A
THOUGHTFUL AND RESPONSIBLE
BUDGET AGREEMENT. AND I'M
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR MITCHELL DEBATER
DISCUSSIONS SENATOR NIELSEN.
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE. THE
PROJECT WE ARE BUDGET CHAIR WHO
ARE SO HIGHLY RESPECT. THIS IS
WHERE I WILL. INDICATE BY A NO
VOTE MY OWN FRUSTRATION. WITH
THE YEAR THE PROCESS THE
PRODUCT. THIS WAS A BUDGET THAT
STARTED OUT WITH GREAT HOPE. I
WAS VERY PLEASED WITH SOME
ELEMENTS AS I SPOKE THAT DAY
WHEN HE ANNOUNCED HIS BUDGET OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PARTICULAR IS TOWED AWAY CHOSE
TO DEAL AND SUCH A CONSTRUCTIVE
AND PROBLEM SOLVING AND LONG
TERM AWAY WITH HOMELESSNESS.
WELL ALL OF OUR HOPES ALONG THE
WAY OF KIND OF. WERE DERAILED.
OF GREAT MAGNITUDE UNDERSTOOD.
BUT THE DIFFICULTY THAT I'VE
HAD AND I DO NOT COMPLAIN ABOUT
THE- SHORTENING UP OF THE
BUDGET PROCESS. I'D BE MULLIN
RIGHT. AND I DO ARGUE THAT IT'S
DONE A DISSERVICE BECAUSE WE
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO IN DEPTH
SCRUTINIZE THE BUDGET INPUT THE
BUDGET AS WE NORMALLY COULD.
AND THE SUBCOMMITTEES IS THE
ONE PLACE FOR. THE MINORITY
PARTY COULD HAVE SOME GOOD
FAITH DISCUSSIONS NEGOTIATIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS AND AGREEMENTS.
AS I'VE SAID HERE BEFORE QUITE
FRANKLY AND HAVING SAID ON
SUBCOMMITTEES FOR MANY YEARS AS
WE VOTE ITEM BY ITEM IN OUR
SUBCOMMITTEES. MORE OFTEN THAN
NOT. THE MAJORITY IN THE
MINORITY PARTY MEMBERS ARE IN
AGREEMENT. THAT HAS ALWAYS FELT
GOOD. THEY'RE ALWAYS FELT GOOD.
IN YEARS PAST ONE. I BECAME A
MEMBER OF THE BIG FIVE. NOW I
HAVE TO TELL YOU A LITTLE FUNNY
STORY ABOUT THAT THOUGH. WHEN I
CAME HERE. I FIGURED THAT. YOU
KNOW IF YOU'RE GOING TO BE
AFFECTED YOU HAD TO GET ON. THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE. THE END SO I
GOT ON THE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
AND I DIDN'T FEEL VERY
EFFECTIVE. SO IN A BECAME A
MEMBER OF THE BIG FIVE. AND
THEN I THOUGHT BOY I'M REALLY
GOING TO BE AFFECTED NOW. WELL
I FOUND OUT IT WASN'T QUITE AS
BIG A DEAL BUT ON THE OTHER
HAND THAT WAS A- CONSTRUCT.
UNDER GOVERNOR NATION AT THE
TIME. OR BY THE BIG FIVE
CONVENE ONLY ON THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUES. NOT AS ONE
YEAR WE HAD THE WHOLE BUDGET
DONE. THEN THE BIG FIVE BUT
THEN FINALLY HAD TO CONCLUDE.
AT THE END WHEN ASKED WHAT WORD
IS A BUDGET FINALLY GET DONE. I
SAID WELL IT'S A MATTER OF
FATIGUE. WHEN NOBODY GETS TIRED
ENOUGH. NOW THAT'S KIND OF A
FACETIOUS WAY TO PUT IT. BUT
SOMETIMES THE EXHAUSTION WEARS
YOU DOWN. WHEN YOU REACH A DEAL.
SO THIS YEAR FOR SPOKE WELL AND
EVEN LAST YEAR TO IT'S SORT OF
BECOME A PARTY OF THE BIG THREE.
AND MINORITY PARTY. I STILL
FELT LAST YEAR THAT I HAD
PLENTY OF SAY THE INPUT AT
LEAST AN OPPORTUNITY EXPRESS
MYSELF THIS YEAR. ALMOST NONE.
WHERE WE YOU'D NORMALLY SPENT
MUCH. MANY WEEKS IN OUR
SUBCOMMITTEE SHOULD LABORIOUS
WORK EVERY THURSDAY AFTERNOON
THREE FOUR HOURS. AND THEN WE'D
HAVE A LABORIOUS CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE. EXHAUSTING BUT
FRUITFUL AND PRODUCTIVE AND A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY. TO NEGOTIATE.
AND GIVE A LITTLE SMILE THAT'S
ONE OF MY DEAREST MOMENTS. ONE
NIGHT AND THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE THEN SHARED. BY GOOD
FRIEND SENATOR MARK LENO SAN
FRANCISCO. I A. B. E. OFFERED A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF FUNDING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
NEITHER THE GOOD TO DEVOTE QUE
TO THEIR ARTS COUNCIL IN. SO I
WROTE ASK FOR TWO MILLION MORE.
INSTEAD OF FIVE I WAS GOING TO
GO SEVEN. ANY SAID AND LAUGHED
OUT LOUD HE SAID YES ONLY TIME
TO. JIM NIELSEN EVER OUTBID ME
TO SPEND MONEY. WELL I'M PROUD
TO SAY. TO HAVE SOME INPUT NOW
THE SAYS CITY THIS YEAR WE DID
NOT HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE THESE DISCUSSIONS IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S. I FEEL BAD
ABOUT THAT. AND SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT I FOUND OF GREAT
MERIT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
ORIGINAL BUDGET. FELL BY THE
WAYSIDE TOO AND I GUESS I CAN
UNDERSTAND WHY. AND INDEED
THESE ARE HARD TIMES. BUT I
WANT TO COMPLIMENT ALL OF US IN
PARTICULAR THOSE OF YOU WHO
SERVED IN THE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
AND LABORED THROUGH THIS TRENCH.
I WILL BE A NOBLE AND ASK FOR A
NO VOTE. BUT MAYBE I COULD
CHARACTERIZE IT AS A SOFT NOBLE.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN
SENATOR BORCHERS. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. I TO- WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS MY CONCERN.
THESE ARE IN PERFECT TIMES OF
THIS IS NAMED PERFECT BUDGET
PROCESS AND WE'RE DOING OUR
BEST EVEN WHEN WE HAVE STRONG
PHILOSOPHICAL ARGUMENTS BUT I
WOULD THINK THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT IS TRULY BIPARTISAN.
AND ULTIMATELY BICAMERAL IS ALL
OF US APPRECIATE THE IMPORTANCE
OF EDUCATION. AND IN THIS
PARTICULAR INSTANCE HIGHER
EDUCATION. AND I KNOW THAT WE
WENT FROM- TWENTY TWENTY TWO
BILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS- YEAR
AND A HALF AGO- IN NOW WE'RE
DOWN TO FIFTY FOUR- BEFORE THE
BUDGET CONSIDERATIONS BUT ONE
THING THAT I'M REALLY HOPEFUL
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO RE
VISIT. OUR THE CUTS TO SEE
ISSUE UC AND CSU IN PARTICULAR.
I THINK THESE INSTITUTIONS.
PART TAKING SUCH ADDRESS
DRAMATIC HIT BECAUSE THEY DON'T
KNOW THE FULL COST OF GOING
REMOTE THEY DON'T KNOW THE FULL
ATTRITION RATE OF STUDENTS WHO
MAY NOT RETURN IN RE
MATRICULATED ARE AND WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE INDEBTEDNESS- IN
THE CAPITAL NEEDS OF THE
SCHOOLS I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT AT SOME POINT WHETHER BE A
TRAILER- IN IN- THE COMING
MONTHS THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT
FINDING WAYS BECAUSE- WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT THE FEDS COME IN.
AND ALLOW US DOLLARS THAT WOULD
TO OFFSET THESE LOSSES OR THESE
REDUCTIONS IN THE BUDGET. BUT
LET'S ASSUME THAT THEY DON'T
HAPPEN. I THINK WE NEED TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT AS WE APPRECIATE
HIGHER EDUCATION AS ONE THE
GREAT ECONOMIC ENGINES. OF OUR
STATE. CREATING ALL THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR VERTICAL
ADVANCEMENT FOR MINORITY
PARTIES ASSUME ON MINORITIES
AND- IN THOSE THAT WE TALK
ABOUT AS BEING DISENFRANCHISED
I THINK THIS NEEDS TO REMAIN
TOP OF MIND. MOVING FORWARD IF
WE DO NOT GET FEDERAL FUNDING I
WOULD STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THAT
WE RE VISIT THE BUDGET TO SEE
ISSUE SYSTEM BECAUSE THEY ARE.
GOING TO BE IN DESPERATE NEED.
THANK YOU SENATOR BORCHERS BUT
VETERAN PRO TâM. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES THIS
IS CERTAINLY BEEN A LONG DAY-
BUT IT'S ALSO BEEN A
TREMENDOUSLY STRESSFUL AND
UNPRECEDENTED AND TRULY UNIQUE
YEAR WE KNOW THAT BUT WE ARE
PERSEVERING DESPITE THE IMMENSE
CHALLENGES ACCOMPLISHING OUR
WORK ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA.
WE PRESERVED- WE PERSEVERED AND
PROTECTING ALL THOSE WHO LIVE
HERE THROUGH OUR SWIFT ACTIONS
TO INCREASE SUPPLIES AND FUN
LIFESAVING CARE AN ACTING
PROGRAMS AND RESOURCES TO HELP
OUR COMMUNITIES. THAT
PERSEVERANCE CONTINUES THROUGH
TODAY AND FOR TONIGHT AS WE
VOTE ON THIS BUDGET. WHICH
BALANCES THE BUDGET WHILE ALSO
UPHOLDING OUR COMMITMENT TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
STARTED TWENTY TWENTY AT AN
ECONOMIC HIGH. AND PIVOTED
SWIFTLY OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS TO ARRIVE AT A BUDGET
PLAN. THAT IS RESPONSIBLE. AND
IS RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS THAT WAS NOT A
SIMPLE TASK IT HAS NOT BEEN
EASY TO BALANCE ALL OF THOSE
ISSUES AS EVIDENCED BY THE
CONVERSATION HERE TODAY. THIS
BUDGET REFLECTS COMPROMISE ON
ALL SIDES WE HAD TO GIVE UP
SOME OF OUR PRIORITIES. JUST
THE STATE EMPLOYEES ARE GIVING
UP PAY INCREASES. WE'VE HAD TO
EXERT RESTRAINT AND REDUCTIONS
IN SPENDING. THAT WE DON'T FEEL
GREAT ABOUT. AND THERE IS MORE
BUDGET WORK THAT LIES AHEAD WE
KNOW THAT. BUT WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO ARRIVE AT AN AGREEMENT
THAT IS PRAGMATIC AND BALANCED
THANKS IN LARGE PART NOT TO
DECISIONS WE ARE MAKING RIGHT
NOW. BUT THE RESPONSIBLE BUDGET
DID BUDGETING DECISIONS THAT
WE'VE MADE OVER THE PAST DECADE
AND MANY OF US HAVE BEEN HERE.
FOR THAT ENTIRE DECADE WHEN WE
HAD TO FIGHT OUR WAY BACK. FROM
A TWENTY SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT AND BEFORE THAT A FEW
OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE HERE THAT
HAD TO ADDRESS A FORTY BILLION
DOLLAR DEFICIT. BECAUSE OF OUR
RESPONSIBLE APPROACH TO
BUILDING RESERVES AND PAYING
DOWN DEBTS IN GOOD TIMES. WERE
ABLE TO PASS THIS BUDGET TODAY
THE DOES NOT SLASH SCHOOL AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS. WE SHOULD APPLAUD
OURSELVES FOR BEING ABLE TO DO
THAT. IN ADDITION TO PROTECTING
EDUCATION AND PROGRAMS WE ARE
MAINTAINING SIGNIFICANT
RESERVES AND OTHER SOLUTION
TOOLS IN OUR TOOLBOX TO ASSIST
THE STATE IN MAKING IT THROUGH
THE EXPECTED BUDGET CHALLENGES
OF THE COMING MONTHS AND THE
UPCOMING YEARS. WE WOULD NOT
HAVE HAD THE LUXURY OF VOTING
ON WHAT WE ARE TODAY DURING
THAT LAST RECESSION. WE
WOULDN'T OF HAD THE LUXURY. THE
FACT THAT WE COULD BALANCE THIS
BUDGET WHILE MAINTAINING
SIGNIFICANT RESERVES IS
SIGNIFICANT. AND WE DID SO
WITHOUT HAVING TO USE COST
DEFERRALS LIKE WE DID DURING
THE PAST RECESSION UNDER OTHER
GOVERNORS INCLUDING. REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS I WANT TO THANK EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THIS BUDGET
PROCESS OVER NINE HOURS
YESTERDAY AFTER. AFTER OTHER
WORK ON THIS FLOOR OUR BUDGET
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MET. IT WAS A
PROCESS AIDED BY THE
COLLABORATION OF EVERYONE IN
THIS ROOM. SPEAKER RENDON AND
OUR PARTNERS IN THE ASSEMBLY
AND GOVERNOR NEWSOME IN HIS
TEAM. I HAVE TO SAY THANK YOU
TO OUR BUDGET CHAIR AND OUR
VICE CHAIR SENATOR MITCHELL
SENATOR NIELSEN OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET STAFF.
THE LEGISLATIVE DATA CENTER WHO
IN MADE IT POSSIBLE FOR US TO
DO THIS WORK. INCLUDING A ALSO
THE ENTIRE BUDGET STAFF OUR
STAFFS. AND LET ME JUST ALSO AT
THE DEAD TO WORK FOR FATHER'S
DAY TO DELIVER THIS AGREEMENT
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT IT TOOK. I
WANT TO THANK YOU TO ALL THE
DEPUTIES THAT LEDGE COUNCIL
FURTHER SUPPORTED DRAFTING OR
LEGISLATIVE LANGUAGE. SO MANY
PEOPLE HAD TO BE PART OF MAKING
IT POSSBLE FOR US TO DO THIS
WORK. EVERYONE HAS BEEN WORKING
HARD AND FAST TO DELIVER A
BALANCED BUDGET UNDER INTENSE
CRISIS CONDITIONS. AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU TO THOSE WHO FOR
YEARS AGREED TO BUDGETS THAT
MAY HAVE NOT GONE AS FAR AS WE
WOULD HAVE LIKED. DUE TO OUR
COMMITMENT TO BUILD THOSE
RESERVES AND PAY DOWN THOSE
DEBTS. THAT DISCIPLINE HELPED
US CRAFT THIS BUDGET WITHOUT
OPPRESSIVE CUTS. WHEN ECONOMIC
RECOVERY HAPPENS AND IT WILL WE
MUST REMEMBER HOW IMPORTANT IT
HAS BEEN TO HAVE RESERVES
AVAILABLE FOR THIS VERY MOMENT.
COLLEAGUES I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COLLABORATION IN YOUR
WORK IN THIS UNPRECEDENTED HERE.
AND WITH THAT I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK. AND I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK YOU
SENATOR ATKINS SEEING NO
FURTHER DEBATE SENATOR MITCHELL
FLETCHER OF OUR BUDGET
COMMITTEE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE VERY BRIEFLY MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE PRO TEM FOR THE HONOREE THE
HONOR OF CONTINUING TO SERVE AS
CHAIR OF THE SENATE BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE. I'D
LIKE TO THANK SENATE LEADERSHIP
THE DESK AND THE SECRETARY OF
THE SENATE FOR ALL. THEIR
VISION AND HARD WORK AND
ALLOWING US TO SEEMLY TRANS
SEAMLESSLY TRANSITION INTO THE
USE OF TECHNOLOGY OUR VERY
FIRST- INFORMATIONAL HEARING
WHERE WE WERE THE FIRST HOUSE
IN THE FIRST COMMITTEE TO TRY
OUR HAND ALLOWING FINANCE IN
THE ALLEY TO PARTICIPATE AND
MEMBERS TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
IS A HOME. LAST NIGHT TO HAVE
MEMBERS COMPLAIN ABOUT HAVING
TO WAIT ON THE PHONE WHO WERE
CALLING IN FROM SAMBAR DINO AND
PLACES FAR AND WIDE AND I HAD
TO STOP AT ONE POINT SAY
ACTUALLY YOU'RE WELCOME.
BECAUSE OF THE WEATHER FOR THE
VISION OF THE SENATE YOU ARE AT
THE COMFORT OF YOUR OWN HOME
BEING ABLE TO PARTICIPATE. IN
IN THE FOR MAY AND EXPRESS YOUR
PURSE WITH LIBERTY STATE BUT IT
FOR WHAT THANK YOU FOR GIVING
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
OPPORTUNITY. MY MOTHER TO HAVE
THIS IN THAT WHEN I WAS YOUNG I
DIDN'T QUITE UNDERSTAND AND SHE
WOULD SAY YOU KNOW A WISE
PERSON KNOWS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHAT IS. VERSUS WHAT
OUGHT TO BE. AND WHAT OUGHT TO
BE IS WHAT WE SAW IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET WHAT WE ALL HOPE
TO BE ABLE TO INVEST. IN OUR
DISTRICTS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
FOR THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WELL WHAT IS. HIS
COLBERT NINETEEN AND WHAT IS
OUR ABILITY TO PASS A VIABLE
DEFENSIBLE BUDGET BASED ON OUR
DECADE OF STRATEGIC BUDGETING
AND SAVING THAT'S GOING TO
ALLOW US TO HELP GUIDE THIS
STATE TO THIS HISTORIC PUBLIC
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC PANDEMIC.
WITH THAT I PROBABLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE OF A. B. EIGHTY
NINE. ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I BATES. NO WELL I FOR
JUST NO BRADFORD I HAVE A OUT
OF. I CHIANG NO DALLY. NO DODD
I TORONTO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG I HILL I LISTEN. I
TADO. HI JACKSON HI I JONES NO
LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S
NO MITCHELL I MONEY HI MORE
LOCK. NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO
HAN. HI PORTANTINO HI ROSS. HI
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN I
NUMBER HI MY COUNTY I WIENER HI
WILK NO. VICE TWENTY NINE KNOWS
ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES. AND
WITH THAT OF SENATOR MITCHELL
THE MIKE BACK TO YOU PLEASE FOR
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
PLAY WITHOUT OBJECTION. I'D
LIKE TO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RECONSIDER THE VOTE
ON EIGHTY B. EIGHTY FOUR ITEM
NINETY THREE. THIS WILL ALLOW-
ONE OF OUR MEMBERS TO CHANGE
THEIR VOTE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THAT WILL BE THE ORDER. VICE
FORTY NO ZERO ON THE ITEM HIGHS
FORTY NO ZERO. I'M SORRY WE
HAVE TO. THAT IS ON
RECONSIDERATION AND MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THIS SIDE OF. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES NO
BELL FIVE GORGEOUS NO BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CHIANG NO DALLY.
NO DODD. I DORADO. HI GALGIANI.
I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI GROWTH
NO HERTZBERG AYE HILL. HI HUESO
I TADO I JACKSON WHY I JONES.
NO LEYVA. I MCGUIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL. I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK. MORRELL NO NIELSEN
NO HAN HI PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN I AM
BURKE I LIKE HOW SKI. I WIENER
HI WILK NO. FIVE TWENTY NINE
DOES TEN MEASURE PASSES. PLEASE
I'M NOT A BUDGET YEAR YES WAS
THE PRESIDENT LIKE TO ASK FOR
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL OF ALL
THE BUDGET BILLS. MEDIA
TRANSFER KNOWS FOR GRANTED. THE
DEATH IS GONNA BE WORKING ON
THAT NOW WE ARE OFFICIALLY
CALLING YOU PS TO BE ABLE TO
GET OVER THE WHOLE. I
APPRECIATE THAT. ALSO KNOWN AS
S. ID. SO THERE WE GO. MISTER
MAJORITY LEADER FOR WHAT
PURPOSE YOU RIGHTS ON OTHER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS MISTER A
PRESIDENT- MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
WAS MAJORITY LEADER THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU SO MUCH
THERE'S A RESOLUTION OF THE
DESK. REQUESTING PERMISSION TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ALLOWING
SENATE BILL ONE THREE EIGHT
THREE. SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE WE TAKE IT UP ON
THE SENATE FLOOR THESE
REQUESTED THIS REQUEST HAS BEEN
APPROVED. BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ASTRONAUT VOTE. THE
MAJORITY LEADER IS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE. CONSIDER JONES FOR
PURPOSE YOU RISE THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I RISE IN
OBJECTION TO THE SUSPEND THE
RULES AND ASK FOR ROLL CALL
VOTE AND- A NO VOTE PLEASE
THANK YOU SO MUCH THE MAJORITY
LEADER IS REQUESTING AN AYE
VOTE DID SENATOR JONES HAS
REQUESTED A NO VOTE. MINUTES
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
RESOLUTION IN THE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. RESOLVED THAT JOINT
RULE SIXTY ONE BE DISPENSED
WITH. SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
NO BELL I FOR JUST. FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD. I HAVE A- I CHIANG NO
DALLY NO DODD. I ASSUME I
GALGIANI. I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG. I HILL
AYE HUESO. HI TADO. HI JACKSON.
YEAH HI JONES NO LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NO
MITCHELL. I MONNING I MORE LOCK
NO MORALE NO NIELSEN. NO HAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN HI I'M BURKE I
LIKE HOW TO SKI I WIENER. I
WILK. NO. HI TWENTY NINE KNOWS
ELEVEN THE JOINT RULES ARE
SUSPENDED THANK YOU SO MUCH
MEMBERS. I BELIEVE THE MAJORITY
LEADER HAS ONE ADDITIONAL ITEM.
ONE ADDITIONAL. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR. PLEASE REMOVE A.
B. SIXTEEN FIFTY TO SIXTEEN
FIFTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WICKS. FROM THE INACTIVE FILE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SUGGESTS
WILL MAKE NOTE THAT HIS
MAJORITY LEADER. LAZY
JOURNALISTS AND IT JUST GIVE US
A FEW MOMENTS- TAKE CARE OF
SOME HOUSEKEEPING WILL BE RIGHT
BACK WITH YOU.
I JUST. I MEAN.
BECAUSE. CENTER STERN FOR A
PURPOSE TO RISE- REQUESTING
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO ROOM TO
REMOVE ITEM EIGHT TEN THAT'S AB
SEVEN FORTY BURKE FROM THE
INACTIVE FILE MOTIONS
RESOLUTION SUGGEST GOING OUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SOONER OR
LATER FOR WHAT PURPOSE YOU RISE.
MISTER PRESIDENT. IS IT WE GET
AN UPDATE OR WAITING FOR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH SENATOR LABOR WE
ARE LEADING ON INQUIRE RE BY
SENATOR GLAZERS. OKAY DO HAVE
AN ANTICIPATED TIME FRAME ON
THAT IT'S NINE SEVENTEEN AND WE
FINISHED ALL OF OUR TRAILER
BILLS. WE DO NOT CURRENTLY
HAVE. A TIME WE WILL GET BACK
WITH YOU IN THE MEMBERS THAT WE
WILL NEED TO BE ABLE TO BRING
UP ADDITIONAL BILLS ADDITIONAL
BILLS THAT ARE CURRENTLY ON
CALL IS WELL. WE APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE. AND WE'LL
BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU. DO WE
KNOW WHERE HE IS. WE WILL GET
BACK WITH YOU MOMENTARILY OKAY
THING THANK YOU SO MUCH. PRO
LEADER GROW FOR WHAT PURPOSE HE
WRITES. QUESTION PART OF I JUST
HAVE A QUESTION SIR YES PLEASE
PERCENT WHILE WE'RE WAITING WE
STILL HAVE TWENTY FIVE BILLS
THAT NEED TO BE DISPENSED WITH
CAN WE TAKE UP THOSE BILLS TO
LIMIT THE BILL LOW TOMORROW AS
WE SIT HERE AND WAIT AND DO
NOTHING THAT WOULD BE A GOOD
OCCUPIER OF OUR TIME. THANK YOU
SO MUCH LEADER GROWTH WILL BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU. THANK YOU.
WE APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
PATIENCE FOR JUST ANYWAY IN A
FEW MORE MOMENTS ON CHOIR READ
BY SENATOR GLAZER. IF YOU CAN
JUST. GIVE US A FEW MORE
MOMENTS AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE SENATE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
SENATOR JACKSON'S PLEASE
PROCEED TO THE ROSTRUM SENATOR
JACKSON'S YOU COULD PLEASE
PROCEED TO THE RESTAURANT. WE
HAVE SEVEN BILLS ON CALL.
SENATE JACKSON WILL BE TAKEN AS
HOME TONIGHT.
THANK YOU ALL
THIS IS BEEN A LONG DAY
EVERYONE HAS BEEN ON THEIR BEST
BEHAVIOR I KNOW THERE'S A LOT
OF CONCERN AND FRUSTRATION THAT
WE ARE HERE AT THIS POINT IN
TIME BUT I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR THEIR INDULGENCE-
THE COLLEGIALITY THAT WE'VE HAD
TODAY BEFORE WE GO AND A LIFT
THE CALL IN THE SEVEN ITEMS I'D
LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE TO THANK THE
EXTRAORDINARY WORK DONE BY THE
DESK. IN EVERYTHING RUNS
SMOOTHLY HERE LIKE THERE'S NO
PROBLEM FOR BERNIE AND STAFF
YOU GUYS. REALLY ROCKING. AND
WITH THAT- COLLEAGUES WE'RE
GOING TO WE'RE WE'RE GONNA DO
IS GOING TO LIFT THE CALLS ON
THE SEVEN ITEMS. THEN WE ARE
GOING TO OR ASK THE PRO TEM TO
CLOSE US OUT AND INDICATE WHEN
WE WILL BE BACK IN THE MORNING
TO FINISH UP I THINK WE GET
ABOUT TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
BILLS LEFT SO. WITH THAT. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE LIFT THE CALL
ON FILE ITEM FORTY ONE FILE
ITEM FORTY ONE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GORGEOUS.
CHIANG DALLY. NO MELENDEZ.
MITCHELL I MORE LOCK. ZERO NO
NIELSEN. HI IS THIRTY KNOWS
FIVE THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM FORTY TWO THE
CURRENT VOTE IS THIRTY FOUR TWO
ZERO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD I DALLY. HI HERTZBERG
AYE HUESO. MITCHELL I
PORTANTINO HI ONE MORE TIME
PLEASE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS HUESO. ICE THIRTY NINE
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM FORTY THREE. THE CURRENT
VOTE CARD IS TWENTY SIX OUR
EYES FOR KNOWS PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES. GORGEOUS
CABALLERO. CHIANG DALLY. GROWTH
HERTZBERG HI MITCHELL I MORE
LOCK HI WILK. HI IS TWENTY NINE
KNOWS FOR THE MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR. BILLS THE
CURRENT VOTE CARD IS THIRTY
SEVEN TWO ZERO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ROVE NEAR.
HERTZBERG AYE MITCHELL. HI.
THIRTY NINE ZERO ON THE URGENCY
THIRTY NINE ZERO ON THE BILL
ITSELF UP NEXT IS FILE ITEM
FORTY FIVE LABOR THE VOTE
COUNTY IS TWENTY SIX TO EIGHT
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BATES. BRADFORD. I HERTZBERG HI
BELINDA'S. MITCHELL I MORALE
THE- OUR EYES TWENTY NINE ONE
MORE TIME PLEASE ONE MORE TIME
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BATES. NO NO. MELENDEZ NO
MORRELL. NO ICE TWENTY NINE
KNOWS ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN THE VOTE
COUNT IS TWENTY FIVE TWO NINE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD. I CHIANG. GLAZER. I
HERTZBERG I MITCHELL. HI WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME CHIANG. WILK VICE
TWENTY NINE KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES IN THE LAST ITEM
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT THE VOTE
COUNT IS CURRENTLY THIRTY FIVE
TO ONE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BRADFORD I GALGIANI.
GROWTH MITCHELL. OUR EYES
THIRTY FIVE EXCUSE ME ICE
THIRTY SIX KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES. MADAM PRO TEM
LOOKS LIKE THE DESK IS CLEAN.
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH OBVIOUSLY WE HAD
INCREDIBLY HIGH ASPIRATIONS
THAT WE WOULD COMPLETE ALL OF
OUR BUDGET BILLS AND ARE
LEGISLATIVE BILLS ALAS THAT DID
NOT HAPPEN BUT LET IT NOT BE
SAID THAT THE SENATE DOES NOT
DEBATE THE ISSUES AND REFLECT
EVERY OPINION OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS FROM NORTH TO
SOUTH EAST TO WEST. SO WITH
THAT I. WE WILL BE RETURNING
TOMORROW FRIDAY JUNE TWENTY
SIXTH AT NINE AM WE HAVE TWENTY
FIVE BILLS TO GO AND I WOULD
IMPLORE MY COLLEAGUES. THAT IT
WILL BE WITHIN OUR CONTROL HOW
QUICKLY WE ARE ABLE TO GET THAT
WORK DONE AND STILL MEET THE
INTENT OF WHAT WE NEED TO DO
WITH OUR LEGISLATION AND SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF OUR- CONSTITUENTS
SO I WOULD IMPLORE YOU TO THINK
ABOUT THAT TONIGHT. BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES HAVE TO BE HOME IN
THEIR DISTRICTS TO DO OTHER
WORK RELATED THINGS AND OTHER
OBLIGATIONS SO MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE
WORK PRESIDING TODAY. WE WILL
SEE YOU TOMORROW MORNING FRIDAY
JUNE TWENTY SIXTH AT NINE AM
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM
COLLEAGUES WE ARE IN RECESS
UNTIL NINE AM TOMORROW MORNING.